ALL RIGHT, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING. WE'RE HOLDING THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING IN ROOM 112 OF
THE, CAPITOL BUILDING. I ASK
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE IN ROOM 112, SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE. BEFORE
WE BEGIN PRESENTATION ON TODAY'S
BILLS, I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE
GROUND RULES AS WELL AS THE
BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT. SO
THE GROUND RULES FOR ALL BILLS
TODAY EXCEPT ONE. AND I'LL SPEAK
TO THAT IN JUST A SECOND, ARE
THAT EACH SIDE WILL HAVE FOUR
MINUTES. THEY'LL HAVE TWO
WITNESSES DIVIDED TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS. SO FIRST WE'LL
TAKE THE SUPPORT. THE TWO
SUPPORT WITNESSES. IF THERE ARE
TWO SUPPORT WITNESSES, EACH WILL
BE GIVEN TWO MINUTES. AND THEN
WE'LL HAVE THE. ME TOO
PRESENTATIONS. IN OTHER WORDS,
FOLKS CAN APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, TELL US WHAT THEIR
NAME IS, THEIR POSITION, AND
THEIR AFFILIATION. THEN WE'LL
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. THE
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE EXACTLY THE
SAME TIME, TWO MINUTES FOR EACH
WITNESS, A TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES. AND THEN ME TWO
TESTIMONY. NAME. POSITION
AFFILIATION. SO, THERE'S ONE
EXCEPTION. AT 130 TODAY. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS ON AB 886 ON AB 886.
THE RULES ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
, ON AB 886, THERE WILL BE SIX
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE, IT MAY BE
DIVIDED BETWEEN 2 AND 3
WITNESSES, NO MORE THAN THREE
WITNESSES. AND THEN WE'LL TURN
TO SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION, LET
ME ANNOUNCE THE BILLS THAT ARE
ON CONSENT TODAY. THEY ARE AS
FOLLOWS. FILE NUMBER TWO, AB
1861 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADDIS,
FILE NUMBER 13, AB 2929 BY
SENATOR JUAN CARRILLO, WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER 15, AB
2908 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN.
FILE NUMBER 20, AB 2867 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER 27, AB
672 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON,
FILE NUMBER 31, AB 3100 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LO. FILE NUMBER
34, AB 3013 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. FILE NUMBER 35 AB
960 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHES,
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER 36,
AB 2988 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. FILE NUMBER 38 EIGHT.
AB 2283 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO, FILE NUMBER 40, AB 2859
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER 42,
AB 1505 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. AND FINALLY FILE
NUMBER 47, AB 1170 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VALENCIA. ALL RIGHT, I
SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
HERE. DOCTOR ROMULO. WE HAVE IS,
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 2543. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS, WE'RE GOING TO
BE PROCEEDING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE,
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE PRESENTING
WILL BE A SUBCOMMITTEE. SO I
SUSPECT THAT BILLS THAT, WILL BE
MOVED WILL BE MOVED TO THE POINT
IN TIME WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. ALL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. WHEN SMALL
BUSINESSES THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA THRIVES. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2543 ENSURES THAT ELIGIBLE
BUSINESS OWNERS, INCLUDING DACA
ENTREPRENEURS, ARE ABLE TO
REGISTER THEIR BUSINESSES WITH
THE STATE AS A CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
SMALL BUSINESS, CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISHED A CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESS PROGRAM. A SMALL
BUSINESS WHICH IS CERTIFIED
UNDER THIS PROGRAM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A NUMBER OF BENEFITS SUCH AS
BIDDING PREFERENCES, PROMPT
PAYMENT OF STATE CONTRACTS, AS
WELL AS SMALL BUSINESS
QUALIFIERS FOR PRIME
CONTRACTORS, WHICH ARE REQUIRED
TO SUBCONTRACT WITH A SPECIFIED
PERCENTAGE OF SMALL BUSINESSES.
DESPITE THEIR IMPORTANCE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE, MANY SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
UNABLE TO ACCESS THESE BENEFITS
OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. THESE
BUSINESSES OFFER THE SAME
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES AS OTHER
CERTIFIED BUSINESSES. HOWEVER,
SOME SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS MAY
NOT HAVE PROOF OF LAWFUL STATUS
IN THIS COUNTRY EVEN WHEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS ISSUED
THEM AN EMPLOYER IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER. THIS PREVENTS THEM FROM
ACCESSING THE BENEFITS OF SMALL
BUSINESS CERTIFICATION AND
RESTRICTS THEIR ABILITY TO
EXPAND AND TO CONTINUE TO HELP
THE STATE'S ECONOMY GROW.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2543 SIMPLY STATES
THAT ELIGIBLE SMALL BUSINESSES
MAY BE CERTIFIED REGARDLESS OF
THEIR CITIZENSHIP OR IMMIGRATION
STATUS OF ITS OWNER. FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW ALREADY AUTHORIZED
THESE BUSINESS OWNERS TO BE IN
BUSINESS. IT IS TIME FOR US TO
ENSURE THAT THESE BUSINESS
OWNERS CAN THRIVE AND EXPAND.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 2543 IS ALEJANDRO
GUILLEN. WITH IMMIGRANTS RISING,
AND JEANETTE ESPARZA, WHO'S A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU. FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
ALEJANDRA GUILLEN. I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT IMMIGRANTS
RISING, AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
IMMIGRANTS RISING. WHOLE HEARTED
SUPPORT OF BILL 25 AB 2543.
IMMIGRANTS RISING WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 2006 AND HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO EMPOWERING
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE TO ACHIEVE
THEIR EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
ASPIRATIONS. WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS, EVERYONE HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO THRIVE THROUGH
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. OVER THE PAST
DECADE, WE'VE DEVELOPED PROGRAMS
AND RESOURCES TO EDUCATE AND
EMPOWER IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
ABOUT ENTREPRENEURSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. OUR EFFORTS HAVE
YIELDED TANGIBLE RESULTS. WE
WERE HONORED TO HAVE RECEIVED
$7.4 MILLION THROUGH THE STATE'S
SEED INITIATIVE, WHICH WE
DISTRIBUTED TO NEARLY 1000
IMMIGRANT ENTREPRENEURS
STATEWIDE. THIS INVESTMENT HAS
ENABLED INDIVIDUALS TO CLIMB THE
ECONOMIC LADDER AND CONTRIBUTE
SIGNIFICANTLY TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. RESEARCH UNDERSCORES
THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE MORE
INCLINED TOWARDS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP, AND THROUGH
OUR WORK, WE'VE WITNESSED
FIRSTHAND HOW ENTREPRENEURSHIP
IS SERVES AS A LIFELINE,
PARTICULARLY FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. FOR WHOM FACE
EMPLOYMENT LIMITATIONS
POST-GRADUATION. AB 2543 ALIGNS
WITH OUR MISSION AND VALUES, AND
BY EXPANDING BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUPPORT, THIS
BILL NOT ONLY FOSTERS ECONOMIC
GROWTH, BUT ALSO PROMOTES
INCLUSIVITY AND EQUITY WITHIN
OUR STATE. SO IN CONCLUSION, WE
ARE Dð TO SUPPORT AB 2543 AND
LET'S ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS,
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS, ARE ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE
TO CALIFORNIA'S, PROSPERITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JEANETTE
ESPARZA, AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE PASSING OF AB
2543. I AM THE PROUD OWNER OF
THE RESIDENTIAL CLEANING
BUSINESS, WHICH I ESTABLISHED
TWO YEARS AGO. THROUGH
DEDICATION, MY BUSINESS HAS
FLOURISHED, NOW SERVING A TOTAL
OF 60 REGULAR CLIENTS AND
ACCOMMODATING ANOTHER 70 CLIENTS
MONTHLY, THIS SUCCESS HAS
EMPOWERED ME TO PROVIDE FOR THE
FAMILY AND CONTRIBUTE TO MY
COMMUNITY. DURING THE PANDEMIC,
I FOUND MYSELF LAID OFF FROM A
STABLE JOB AFTER DEDICATING 13
YEARS OF MY LIFE. THAT DIDN'T
STOP ME. I SEIZED THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I STARTED MY
BUSINESS. THAT SEAT GRANT
PROVIDED BY IMMIGRANTS RACING
WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING ME
WITH THE NECESSARY RESOURCES AND
KNOWLEDGE TO NAVIGATE THE
DIFFICULTIES OF STARTING A
BUSINESS WITH THE NEW SKILLS IN
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT, I
TRANSFORMED MY BUSINESS INTO A
THRIVING SOURCE OF INCOME FOR MY
FAMILY AND MYSELF. TODAY, I
PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OTHERS WITHIN MY COMMUNITY.
I ALSO ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
EXPANDING MY BUSINESS OPERATION
TO INCLUDE COMMERCIAL CLEANING
SERVICES. I AM EXCITED TO OFFER
MY SERVICES TO GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCIES. THIS HELPS CREATE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT BENEFITS
EVERYONE AND MAKE OUR SOCIETY
BETTER. AB 2543 IS NOT JUST A
BILL, IT'S A PATHWAY TO
INCLUSIVITY AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS LIKE
MYSELF WHO MAY BE UNDOCUMENTED
BY GRANTING THIS ACCESS TO STATE
CERTIFICATION FOR ALL DESERVING
ENTREPRENEURS, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRANT STATUS, THIS BILL
LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD AND
OPENS DOORS TO AN OPPORTUNITY.
IN CONCLUSION, I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 2543. IT WILL HELP
PEOPLE LIKE ME TO TRY AND ENSURE
WE CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA
PROSPERITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. GOOD
MORNING, DANIEL SANCHEZ,
CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
CHIRLA AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MARTINEZ,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE. WE
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTING IMMIGRANT
ENTREPRENEURS SINCE 2020 WITH A
NEW PROGRAM THAT WE ESTABLISHED,
HELPING IMMIGRANTS ESTABLISH THE
BUSINESS AND GROW IT, WHERE ARE
YOU IN SUPPORT? YES, I'M IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, ON BEHALF
OF FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2543, PLEASE
APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE, LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BY THE WAY, WE HAVE 50.
ONCE MORE. WE HAVE 50% OF THE
REPUBLICAN COMPONENT OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, AND
WE HAVE ABOUT 10% OF THE
DEMOCRATIC COMPONENT. SO, IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED, PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING
SENATOR NIKAIDO, I'D JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT I UNDERSTAND
THE POSITIVE NATURE OF THIS
PROPOSAL, BUT EACH CONTRACT IS A
SUM ZERO GAME. YOU EITHER GET IT
OR YOU DON'T. AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE ADVANTAGE, IMMIGRANT
BUSINESSES AND AN IMMIGRANT
BUSINESS GETS A CONTRACT, A
DOMESTICALLY OWNED BUSINESS DOES
NOT. IT'S A SUM ZERO GAME. AND
THAT'S THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE.
IT'S A FURTHER ENCOURAGEMENT FOR
IMMIGRATION. WHEN I'M NOT SURE
THAT ENCOURAGING IMMIGRATION
SERVES US WELL AND IT TAKES AWAY
FROM BUSINESSES OWNED BY THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. SO I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE SUM ZERO
GAME ASPECT OF THIS. RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, DOCTOR ARAMBULA, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY. IMMIGRANTS
PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN OUR GREAT
STATE AND THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO
OUR ECONOMY, THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE AND ENSURE
THAT THEIR BUSINESSES ARE
THRIVING IS SOMETHING THAT WE AS
A STATE, SHOULD CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE AND PUSH FORWARD. I'M
EXCITED THAT THIS BILL HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CERTIFY
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH THE STATE
THAT WILL ALLOW THEIR SMALL
BUSINESSES TO THRIVE. ALL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS, SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITY IN OUR STATE THAT
ULTIMATELY WILL BENEFIT OUR
STATE AND OUR ECONOMY. AND WITH
THAT, WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, WE
ARE A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH
APPROPRIATE TIME. I EXPECT
THERE'LL BE A MOTION. ALL RIGHT,
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
SENATOR DODD FOR FILM NUMBER 50,
SB 1524, AFTER SENATOR DODD.
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 2586 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO I
SEE IS PRESENT. SENATOR DODD.
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS SB 1524 ADDRESSES
QUESTIONS AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SURROUNDING SB 478
LEGISLATION I AUTHORED TO
ADDRESS THE DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISING PRACTICE OF DRIP
PRICING OR HIDDEN FEES. SB 1524
WOULD REQUIRE CLEAR AND
CONSPICUOUS DISCLOSURE OF ALL
MANDATORY FEES FOR FOOD OR
BEVERAGE SOLD DIRECTLY TO A
CONSUMER IN A RESTAURANT, FOOD
BAR, FOOD CONCESSION CATERER,
GROCERY STORE BY GROCERY
DELIVERY SERVICE. THIS CLEAR AND
UPFRONT DISCLOSURE OF ANY FEE
AND A DESCRIPTION OF ITS PURPOSE
WOULD BE REQUIRED ON ALL
ADVERTISEMENTS, MENUS AND OTHER
DISPLAYS THAT CONTAIN THE PRICE
OF THE FOOD OR BEVERAGE ITEM.
THIS MEASURE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
AND RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE
DIRECTLY RESPONSIVE TO THE
CONCERNS FROM CONSUMER GROUPS.
BY NARROWING APPLICABILITY AND
STRENGTHENING TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS IN
ADVERTISING AND THE FOOD AND
SERVICE INDUSTRY. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE TODAY. JOHN ROSS,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION, AND
SHANE GUZMAN ON BEHALF OF UNITE
HERE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, SHANE GUZMAN ON
BEHALF OF UNITE HERE, I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF, OUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS, CRITICAL BECAUSE, AS
SENATOR DODD SAID, THERE WERE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WITH SB 478, WE NEGOTIATE.
VARIOUS SERVICE CHARGES WITH OUR
EMPLOYERS THAT PROVIDE BENEFITS
LIKE, OBVIOUSLY HIGHER WAGES,
BUT HEALTH CARE SUPPLEMENTS AND,
PENSION SUPPLEMENTS. SO WITHOUT
THIS BILL ON JULY 1ST, THOSE
THINGS BECOME ILLEGAL AND OUR
MEMBERS TAKE IMMEDIATE CUTS TO
PAY AND BENEFITS. SO THIS BILL
IS VERY NECESSARY. AND CRITICAL.
AND WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, MR. GUZMAN. MR. ROSS, GOOD
MORNING, JOHN ROSS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION, OUR THANKS TO
SENATOR DODD FOR CARRYING THIS
MEASURE AND FOR THIS COMMITTEE
TAKING US ON SHORT ORDER. IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THIS GETS DONE BY
JULY 1ST. THERE'S NO MAJOR
DISRUPTIONS TO RESTAURANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
BEING AVOIDED BY PASSING THIS
MEASURE. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. AS FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1524?
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, DON GILBERT
FOR SAN FRANCISCO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. GENESIS GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS, AS A PROUD
SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF FRANKEL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
BEVERLY, YOU, ON BEHALF OF OPEN
TABLE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
MR. CHAIR MEMBERS, CHRIS WALKER,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S TURN NOW TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO SB, WE HAVE ONE MORE.
THEY HAVE TO GO OVER. OKAY. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO OPPOSITION IN
JUST A SECOND. HI, LETICIA REYES
FOR SAN JOSE AIRPORT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHES THE
MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT EXCEPT FOR
ONE MORE PERSON. GO AHEAD. SO
SORRY, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS,
ROBERT MURRAY, CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. NOW, SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO SB 1524,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, I'M GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR DODD, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR HIGH VOTE PARTY? THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AT IT WAS AN
EXCELLENT CLOSE, SO AT SUCH TIME
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM, I EXPECT
THERE'LL BE A MOTION AND A VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
DODD. VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. ALL RIGHT. NEXT,
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO FILM
NUMBER THREE, AB 2586, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING AB 2586 TO
YOU. FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION, I
WANT TO START OFF BY, SHARING
WITH YOU HOW I GOT TO THIS BILL
AND WHY THIS IS SO SIGNIFICANT
FOR ME AND MANY INDIVIDUALS, IN
THE STATE, LIKE ME, AS A SON OF
IMMIGRANT PARENTS WHO CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY AND TO THIS STATE
TO FIND BETTER OPPORTUNITIES,
THE PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY WERE THE
FIRST DREAMERS THAT I EVER KNEW.
I KNOW THE STRUGGLES THAT MANY
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES AND
NON-CITIZENS GO THROUGH. IT'S
NOT EASY. EVEN WHEN YOU ARE
WORKING AS HARD AS YOU CAN.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENTS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION MEANS THAT WE
HAVE INVESTED IN ACCESS,
OPPORTUNITY, AFFORDABILITY,
EQUITY AND SUCCESS OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS, ALL OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. YET THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS FACE UNJUST BARRIERS,
UNABLE TO SECURE ON CAMPUS JOBS
DUE TO THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS,
WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS
THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE PAYMENTS
TOWARDS THEIR TUITION, SUPPLIES,
HOUSING AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CONGRESS, TIME
AFTER TIME, HAS FAILED OUR
DREAMERS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
ABOUT 83,000 UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. HOWEVER, THE NUMBER OF
DACA ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUSES HAS CONSISTENTLY
DECREASED AS COURT RESTRICTIONS
AND ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA HAS
NARROWED. THE ACCESS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THAT IS WHY THE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT LED
NETWORKS BRAVERY TO FIGHT FOR
CHANGE INSPIRED ME TO INTRODUCE
THIS TRUE, STUDENT LED
LEGISLATION, AB 2586 IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL BILL, WHICH
PROVIDES EQUAL ACCESS TO CAMPUS
EMPLOYMENT FOR ALL STUDENTS
WHILE THEY'RE EARNING THEIR
DEGREES, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS, ON THE
CAMPUS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS BILL
ALLOWS STUDENTS TO BE THE IN THE
APPLICANT POOL AND LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES HAVE
THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO AUTHORIZE
THE HIRING OF ALL OF ITS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES. TODAY LEGAL EXPERTS
AT THE CENTER FOR IMMIGRATION
LAW, POLICY AND THE UCLA LAW
SCHOOL OF LAW HAVE IDENTIFIED
THAT THE FEDERAL PROHIBITION ON
HIRING UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE DOES
NOT INCLUDE STATE ENTITIES LIKE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IT IS AN ARGUMENT THAT
IS SUPPORTED BY DOZENS OF THE
NATION'S LEADING LEGAL SCHOLARS
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, THE CSU, AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE ARMS OF
THE STATE, THEY FACE NO LEGAL
RESTRICTION ON HIRING
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. IF YOU
REFERENCE THE 1986 FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION REFORM AND CONTROL
ACT, UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS PAY
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL TAXES
WITHOUT GETTING MUCH OF THE
BENEFITS OF SOCIAL PROGRAMS THAT
THEY ARE HELPING TO FUND WITH
THEIR HARD EARNED DOLLARS. WHEN
MORE PEOPLE CAN WORK AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE ECONOMY,
WE ALL BENEFIT. TODAY, WE ARE
GOING TO BE HEARING FROM TWO
WITNESSES WHO ARE STUDENTS THAT
ARE GOING TO SHARE THEIR STORY
WITH YOU OF WHY THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT. THESE STUDENTS ARE
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
VETTED BY OUR ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS, WHO DID THE WORK
TO GET ACCEPTED INTO THESE
INSTITUTIONS. THESE ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN PROMISED
THAT IF THEY WORK HARD, THEY
WILL HAVE A FUTURE. WE HAVE
WITNESSED IN THEM, AND NOW WE
NEED TO ALLOW THEM THE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES. FELLOW
FELLOW COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA HAS
PASSED LAWS ADVANCING THE RIGHTS
OF IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, INCLUDING PROVIDING
IDENTIFICATIONS FOR ALL
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS AND
ALLOWING FARM WORKERS TO VOTE IN
UNION ELECTIONS. OUR STATE, OUR
STATE HAS CHAMPIONED THESE
ISSUES. THESE STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO ENTER OUR
COLLEGES. CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED IN THEM, AND THEY'VE
DONE WHAT WE'VE ASKED OF THEM.
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR US TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AND
COMPETE WITH EVERYBODY BY
REMOVING EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS,
CALIFORNIA ONLY ENSURES EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY, BUT ALSO
STRENGTHENS OUR ECONOMY AND
MAKES US A BETTER STATE. IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO EMPOWER
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND
UNFORTUNATELY, FIX WHAT CONGRESS
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO FIX, WHICH
IS TO PROVIDE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH THE OPPORTUNITIES TO THRIVE
AFTER THEY'VE COMMITTED AND DONE
THE WORK, THE HARD WORK THAT
WE'VE ASKED OF THEM. SO NOW I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER. IT'S
REALLY A PLEASURE AND HOPE YOU
HAVE THE SAME SENTIMENT AFTER
YOU HEAR FROM OUR TWO WITNESSES.
FIRST, WE'LL HEAR FROM JEFFREY
MUNOZ, RECENT UCLA GRADUATE AND
ENTERING CSU STUDENT AT THE
GRADUATE LEVEL, AND ALICIA
QUIROZ, A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT. JEFFREY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, SENATOR UMBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, MY
NAME IS JEFFREY MUNOZ, AND I AM
AN UNDOCUMENTED RISING GRADUATE
STUDENT AT CAL STATE LOS ANGELES
FROM SAN BERNARDINO, CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO HERE TODAY, JOINED BY A
COALITION OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPELLING FORWARD ASSEMBLY BILL
2586, THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
ACT. JUST TWO WEEKS AGO, I
GRADUATED WITH TWO BACHELORS OF
ARTS DEGREES FROM UCLA. AND
WHILE I AM HUMBLED TO JOIN MY
FELLOW UNDOCUMENTED SCHOLARS WHO
HAVE ACHIEVED HIGHER EDUCATION,
I AM CONCERNED THAT INCOMING
GENERATIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WILL FACE THE SAME GRIM
REALITY I ENCOUNTERED AT THE UC,
AND NOW BRACING TO FACE AGAIN AT
CAL STATE LA. DESPITE RIGHTFULLY
EARNING MY ADMISSION AND PAYING
TUITION LIKE THE REST OF MY
PEERS, UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF ARE UNJUSTLY BARRED
FROM FULLY ACCESSING THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
PROMISED TO US UPON ADMISSION
AND ENROLLMENT. EVERY YEAR AT
UCLA. DESPITE MEETING ALL OTHER
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA, THE
UNIVERSITY OPENLY PROHIBITED ME
FROM ACCESSING ON CAMPUS
EMPLOYMENT AS AN UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT STUDENT WITH LIMITED
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID AND
SCHOLARSHIPS. THIS MEANT THAT
EACH YEAR, PURSUING MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION WAS MARKED BY
EXPERIENCES OF HOUSING
INSECURITY, FOOD INSECURITY,
FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY, AND THE
LOOMING POSSIBILITY OF DROPPING
OUT. BEYOND THESE MATERIAL
DEPRIVATIONS, THE CURRENT POLICY
AT UC, CSU AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO DENY EQUAL
ACCESS TO ON CAMPUS EMPLOYMENT
FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
FURTHER, OSTRACIZES AND
MARGINALIZES US. DESPITE THE
STATE'S CLAIM TO EMBRACE AND
EMPOWER ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS. I WAS TOLD I COULD NOT
WORK IN THE BOOKSTORE, COULD NOT
SERVE ON A STUDENT GOVERNMENT
BOARD OR CONTRIBUTE TO THE
UNIVERSITY SCHOLARSHIP AS A
RESEARCH OR TEACHING ASSISTANT,
EVEN WHEN FACULTY OR STAFF
MEMBERS WANTED TO SUPPORT ME
WITH EMPLOYMENT, I WAS MET WITH
COLD, UNJUST REJECTION. IN THE
WEEKS BEFORE YOU REGISTER A
UNIVERSITY'S PROMISE,
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO SUCCEED
ACADEMICALLY AND CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER, AS I
AND THOUSANDS OF OTHERS CAN
ATTEST TO, THIS PROMISE
DISAPPEARS, LEAVING US TO SCRAPE
TOGETHER COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND
WAGES FROM UNSAFE AND UNDERPAID
JOBS TO STAY IN SCHOOL AND
SUPPORT OUR FAMILIES. FOR MANY
OF US, THIS WILL COST US OUR
DREAMS OF COLLEGE EDUCATION.
ALTOGETHER, FOR OVER TWO
DECADES, CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE
NATION IN PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I ASSUME
YOU'RE CHEN I VOTE YES. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS ALYSSA QUIROZ, AND I
REPRESENT THE KHN AS WELL AS
I'M A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
STUDYING TO BE A COGNITIVE
SCIENCE. AND I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT AB 2586, OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL. GROWING UP, MY MOTHER
TAUGHT ME TO GIVE EVERYBODY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW ME WHO THEY
ARE. AND UNFORTUNATELY, I'M
BEING JUDGED BASED ON MY
IMMIGRATION STATUS INSTEAD OF MY
SKILLS AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS. A
YEAR AGO, THERE WAS A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO SHATTER
A NEUROLOGIST IN MY INSTITUTION.
IT WAS A PAID POSITION, AND I
QUALIFIED. I WAS ONE OF THE MOST
COMPETITIVE APPLICANTS FOR THAT
POSITION, AND THEY HAD EXTENDED
AN OFFER FOR ME TO TAKE ON THE
ROLE AS A STUDENT OF THE YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN IT CAME TO
PROCESS THE APPLICATION FOR THE
FINANCIAL PART, I WAS ASKED TO
PROVIDE A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
. INITIALLY, I WAS TOLD THAT MY
TAXPAYER IDENTIFYING NUMBER WAS
A CORRECT SUBSTITUTE FOR THE
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER, BUT IT
WASN'T. SO EVEN THOUGH I HAD
IMAGINED ALL OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WOULD COME
ALONG FROM THE INTERNSHIP, ALL
OF THE DOORS THAT WOULD COME
OPEN, ALL OF THE CONNECTIONS
THAT I WOULD BUILD, AND ALL OF
THE SKILLS THAT I WOULD OBTAIN,
ALL OF THOSE DOORS WERE SHUT IN
MY FACE ONLY BECAUSE OF MY
STATUS, DACA RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF
US DON'T QUALIFY FOR IT, AND THE
FUTURE OF IT IS UNCERTAIN, SO
THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK IN THESE HIGHER
EDUCATIONAL JOBS THAT ARE,
ACCORDING TO OUR EDUCATION IS AB
2586 TODAY, YOU HAVE THE POWER
TO SHOW THAT CALIFORNIA TRULY IS
THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY BY
PASSING THE BILL. AB 2586 THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB 2586,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING. KEISHA HUNT HERE
WITH NOSSAMAN ON BEHALF OF
CITRUS COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, DOLORES
HUERTA. DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO.
MY NAME IS DAVID AND I AM A
STUDENT AT FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
PASSING OF AB 2586. THANK YOU,
TIFFANY MOCK, ON BEHALF OF CFT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. HELLO EVERYONE. MY NAME IS
ANGELICA PEREZ MARTINEZ FROM
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS SHARON. I AM A SENIOR AT CAL
POLY POMONA. I HAVE BEEN
UNDOCUMENTED AND WITHOUT A PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP SINCE I FIRST
THANK YOU. I ASSUME YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. I AM IN SUPPORT. YES.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. MY NAME.
MY NAME IS SILVIA ROMERO, AND I
AM A STUDENT ENROLLED AT MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE. AND IN FAVOR OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THANK YOU,
KENT WONG. I'M A UCLA FACULTY
MEMBER. I'VE BEEN THERE FOR 30
YEARS, AND I RISE TO SUPPORT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR BELINDA LUM, THREE OF US
COLLEGE FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
AND SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
PROFESSOR STAND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, JANET, STAFF MEMBER
OF CHIRLA AND ORGANIZER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK. CN AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
KARLA RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CASEY
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF RANCHO
SANTIAGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD, ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBER SARA
FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI. GOOD MORNING,
CAROL GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. CHRIS MYERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FATIMA ZEFERINO,
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
LONG BEACH. I'M HERE TO URGE
STATE LEADERS TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB 2586. I STILL
REMEMBER HOW HEARTBROKEN I WAS
WHEN THE èC FELL VERY MUCH. I
ASSUME YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS ANA
LUNA. REPRESENTING BAKERSFIELD
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I SUPPORT
THANK YOU, DANIELA DE LA CRUZ,
SACRAMENTO STATE ALUMNI AND I
SUPPORT OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
THANK YOU, LILLIAN JUAREZ
ARMENTA, FOOTHILL COLLEGE AND UC
BERKELEY ALUMNI IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MONSERRATT
DIAZ, UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MARIA REZA. I'M REPRESENTING UC
MERCED AND THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
NETWORK, AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
VICTOR HERNANDEZ. I AM AN ALUMNI
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, NORTHRIDGE, AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL ALREADY. THANK
YOU. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2543, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. IN A MOMENT, WE'LL
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS. MY NAME IS
RYAN MANRIQUEZ. I SERVE AS
PRESIDENT FOR THE UC GRADUATE
AND PROFESSIONAL COUNCIL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I MAY
HAVE MISSPOKEN 2586 OKAY, NOW
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2586, WE
STILL HAVE MORE SUPPORT. OH
OKAY. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE. PLEASE LINE UP. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. HI,
I'M DIANA ORTIZ AND I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT WITHOUT
DACA. AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB
2586. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO. MY NAME IS LEO RODRIGUEZ.
I AM A ALUMNI OF UC BERKELEY AND
PRESIDENT OF IDEAS AT UC
BERKELEY. AS WELL AS MEMBER OF
THE UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY
COUNCIL UNDER UC BERKELEY
DIVISION OF EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI, MY NAME IS
BEATRICE BASURTO REYES. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF IN SUPPORT FOR AB TWO
586. I'M A RECENT GRADUATE OF
UCLA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. HELLO.
MY NAME IS RONALD SANTIAGO. I'M
THE STATEWIDE ORGANIZER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK, AND I
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND HOW THESE
STUDENTS HAVE NEED OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL AB 520 THANK YOU. SO
JUST JUST SO THAT WE'RE CLEAR
WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
WE'RE DOING WHAT'S CALLED ME TO
TESTIMONY. SO IF YOU GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION, I ASSUME THOSE
THAT ARE LINED UP RIGHT NOW ARE
IN SUPPORT, AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. HI,
I'M CARLY AMAYA RIOS. I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT STUDYING
PUBLIC POLICY AT UCLA, AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE IT
WOULD CHANGE MY LIFE. ALL RIGHT.
SO JUST JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR,
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION,
YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU. HI. MY
NAME IS BRIAN. I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT, AND I'M IN
FULL SUPPORT. PLEASE PASS THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
ANTHONY WONG. I'M SUPPORTING AB
2586 BECAUSE I HAVE
UNDOCUMENTED. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE IT.
HI. MY NAME IS ABRAHAM. I'VE
BEEN AN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AT
UCLA AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS. THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M ANA
I'M AN UNDOCUMENTED
MATHEMATICIAN AND I SUPPORT
OVERALL. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY
NAME IS KAREN REYES DÍAS AND I
AM AN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AT
UCLA. AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
EDDIE CAMPOS GONZALEZ. I'M A
STUDENT AND GRADUATE AT UCLA,
MSW, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY NAME
IS BEATRICE TORRES AND I WORK
FOR LAUSD AS A TEACHER, AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS ANDY REYES
RAMOS AND I'M AN ALUMNI FROM
UCI. AND I SUPPORT AB 2586.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS JOSE
MENDEZ. I'M A PHD STUDENT AT UC
IRVINE. I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB 2586. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS NELSON GUARDADO. I'M AN ALLY
FROM UC IRVINE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
BETSAIDA, STUDENT AT UC IRVINE,
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO 586. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ANGEL VALDEZ AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 256. HELLO, MY
NAME IS LUIS. I'M FROM UC IRVINE
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2566. TIME IS UP. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS JEFFERSON HERRERA AND
I'M A STUDENT AT UCI. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS ALAN PERALTA. I'M A
STUDENT WORKER AT UC IRVINE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
RICARDO GARCIA AND I'M A STUDENT
AT UCI AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS CINDY
GUZMAN AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC
SANTA BARBARA. AND I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB TWO 586. THANK YOU
. HI. MY NAME IS DIANE, A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HELLO. MY
NAME IS BLANCA MPP STUDENT AT
UCLA AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO. MY NAME IS SYLVIA AND I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO 586.
THANK YOU. HELLO, I'M VICTOR
HERNANDEZ AND I'M A RECENT
GRADUATE FROM UC IRVINE. I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI
I'M GIANCARLO PEREZ HERNANDEZ,
RECENT GRADUATE FROM UCI. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. VIVA
PALESTINA THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS DELYLAH. I'M A RECENT UCI
GRAD AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
VIRIDIANA. I AM AN UNDERGRAD
STUDENT AT UC MERCED. I'M
REPRESENTING UNDOCU PRIDE UNITED
WE DREAM AND UNITED WE DREAM
ACTION AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. HELLO, MY NAME
IS JASMINE. I'M A CURRENT
STUDENT AT UC IRVINE. I'M IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2586 BECAUSE WE'RE
UNDOCUMENTED AND WE'RE HERE TO
STAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO. MY NAME IS JANETH AND I'M
A I'M A RECENT GRAD FROM UC
MERCED, AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THEM. AB 2586 NOT ONLY FOR
MYSELF, BUT MY YOUNGER SIBLINGS
ARE ALSO. ALRIGHTY, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. HI THERE. GOOD
MORNING, ALEJANDRO GUILLEN,
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS, AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
AUBREY RODRIGUEZ. ON BEHALF OF
ACLU, ACLU COLLECTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. MORNING. MY
NAME IS FAITH LEE WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. EVA JIMENEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO. I'M GLORIA ALLEN, CSU
STANISLAUS ALUMNI, AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE EXCEPT
FOR ONE, IN A MOMENT, WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO THE OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS ALMA. PALOMA IS A
STUDENT AT UC SANTA CRUZ AND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY, WE DON'T REQUIRE YOU TO
RUN, SO YOU'RE OKAY. SO. ALL
RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, NOW LET'S TURN
TO THE OPPOSITION. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO SIT DOWN OR SPEAK
FROM THE MICROPHONE. I'LL SPEAK
FROM HERE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIRST, WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION. MARIO GUERRERO, ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, WE'RE PROUD TO HAVE
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS. I CAN SAY
THAT THERE IS REALLY NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE INTENT
THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE STUDENTS
HAVE. AND WE'RE PROUD TO SEE OUR
STUDENTS HERE ADVOCATING FOR AND
USING THEIR VOICES FOR SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WE ALL BELIEVE IN,
HOWEVER, WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS. THOSE
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE LETTER.
I'VE SHARED THEM IN COMMITTEE
PRIOR, SO I WON'T REITERATE THEM
HERE, WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THIS. ALSO,
I WILL MENTION THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AN ALTERNATIVE
EXPERIENTIAL FELLOWSHIP THAT IS
EXPANDING ACROSS ALL CAMPUSES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
OUR STUDENTS TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES THAT WE BELIEVE,
ARE WORKABLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
WHO'S OPPOSED TO AB, 2586,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. WE'RE GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS, QUESTIONS. SENATOR
NHIÀU. A QUICK COMMENT. THIS
BILL REALLY SCREAMS OUT FOR
REFORM OF OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
IN WASHINGTON, DC. AND BECAUSE
IT'S NOT HAPPENING IS THE REASON
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ
INTRODUCES THIS. BUT, IF WE
LISTEN TO èC NOW, WE HAD
SUPPORT FROM SOME COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND MAYBE THEY LOOK AT
IT DIFFERENTLY, BUT IN CSU'S
SILENCE, I KIND OF HAVE TO
INTERPRET THAT THEY ARE OF LIKE
MIND OF èC AND THAT IS THAT
THEY, ASSEMBLYMAN ALVAREZ, YOUR
YOUR INTERPRETATION OF THE
FEDERAL LAW NOTWITHSTANDING, THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BELIEVES THAT THEY CANNOT AND SO
IN ABSENCE OF THAT SCREAMING
NEED TO REFORM OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, AND GIVEN THE POSITION
OF èC, THAT I THINK PROBABLY
WOULD PERSUADE, PERSUADE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS ALSO GIVEN THE
CONSEQUENCES, IF WE PASS THIS
BILL, IT WON'T ACCOMPLISH
ANYTHING BECAUSE NOBODY WILL BE
HIRED. THEY FEEL THEY CAN'T.
YOUR INTERPRETATION OF LAW
NOTWITHSTANDING. SO, I WISH THAT
OUR FEDERAL REPRESENTATIVES
WOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS,
BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THAT.
THANK YOU. SENATOR YELLOW.
SENATOR RUSSELL, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF, MAYBE MORE
THAN A COUPLE QUESTIONS. I
THINK, AS I UNDERSTAND IT, THERE
ARE SOME PROGRAMS, THAT ARE PART
OF THE REQUIREMENTS TO GRADUATE
WHERE YOU WORK. COULD YOU, COULD
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU
DON'T PUT IN WORK HOURS, IT
TAKES AWAY FROM YOUR GRADUATION
OR YOUR REQUIREMENTS? I WOULD I
WOULD SAY, SENATOR, THAT I,
DON'T HAVE A 100% CERTAINTY IN
THAT. AND SO I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK OUT OF TURN, I DID WANT TO
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY, THOUGH,
TO. YEAH, TO, SOMEONE FROM THE
UCLA, CENTER FOR IMMIGRATION AND
LAW POLICY WHO WAS PART OF THE
AUTHORSHIP GROUP OF THIS OF THIS
ILLEGAL, ASSESSMENT, IF AHILAN,
PROFESSOR FROM PRACTICE AND
CO-DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER CAN
COME FORWARD, MAYBE HE HAS MORE,
MORE ANSWERS FOR THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION. I DID, IF I MAY WANT
TO RESPOND JUST BRIEFLY,
RESPECTFULLY TO, TO SENATOR
NIELLO ABOUT, THE CONCERNS,
WHICH HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS IS A FEDERAL, THIS WOULD
ALL BE SOLVED IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID THEIR JOB AND
THEY, YOU KNOW, PASSED
IMMIGRATION REFORM. AND THAT
WOULD BE IDEAL. BUT THE FACT IS
THAT THEY HAVEN'T DONE SO IN
ALMOST 40 YEARS. NOW, THE LAST
TIME THEY DID WAS IN 1986. AND
SPECIFICALLY, SENATOR ASKED
ABOUT THE CONCERNS FROM èC,
WHICH ARE OUTLINED IN THE LETTER
THAT I THINK WE ALL RECEIVED,
JUNE 13TH OF 2024, AND IT'S FOUR
POINTS, OF WHICH, THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY SAY THEY CAN'T
IMPLEMENT THIS. WHAT THEY SAY IS
THEY'RE CONCERNED WITH WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED. AND I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, IF WE GO
LINE ITEM BY LINE ITEM NOT TO
TAKE TIME FROM YOUR QUESTIONS,
BUT I THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY A
RESPONSE WE CAN PROVIDE FOR ALL
OF THOSE, INCLUDING THE FIRST
ONE, WHICH IS REALLY I WOULD I
WOULD URGE THE èC TO, REFRAIN
FROM USING THIS AS A REASON
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY, A SOMEWHAT
INSENSITIVE TO THE GROUP OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE TESTIFYING
BEFORE AND WHO WOULD BE
BENEFITING. AND THEY TALK ABOUT
THE EXPOSURE. SO ONE OF THEIR
CONCERNS, SENATOR NEAL, IS THE
EXPOSURE OF OUR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
THE POSSIBILITY OF CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AND DEPORTATION.
ANYBODY WHO HAS EVER LIVED OR
KNOWS AS I DID AND MY FAMILY
HAVE AN UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUAL.
THEY LIVE WITH THAT FEAR ON A
DAILY BASIS. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
UNDER THE CURRENT DYNAMICS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, AND CERTAINLY
IN PARTICULAR WITH PAST
ADMINISTRATIONS, THAT THAT FEAR
CONTINUES TO EXIST AND WOULD NOT
BE RESOLVED WITH OR WITHOUT THIS
BILL. AND SO THAT IS ONE
SPECIFICALLY THAT I WOULD, YOU
KNOW, SUGGEST TO èC,
RESPECTFULLY THAT THEY REFRAIN
FROM FROM USING THAT. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT INSULTING, TO BE
HONEST, TO TALK ABOUT THESE
STUDENTS, POTENTIALLY BEING
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED OR
DEPORTED. THEY LIVE WITH THAT
FEAR AND THOSE FAMILIES LIVE
WITH THAT FEAR ON A DAILY BASIS.
ALREADY ON THE OTHER ISSUES,
SENATOR, WE CAN GET INTO, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF, PROFESSOR HAS
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD ON THE
ISSUE OF EMPLOYMENT, AS YOU
ASKED. YES. THANK YOU. SENATOR
THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZZO. I'M
AHILAN ARULANANTHAM FROM THE
CENTER FOR IMMIGRATION LAW AND
POLICY AND A LAW PROFESSOR AT
UCLA, YES. IS THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION. THERE ARE DEGREE
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH, EMPLOYMENT
IS A REQUIREMENT TO COMPLETE IT.
I MEAN, THE OBVIOUS ONE MANY
PEOPLE WILL KNOW IS MEDICAL
RESIDENCY, RIGHT? YOU YOU HAVE
TO WORK AS A RESIDENT IN ORDER
TO BECOME QUALIFIED TO BE A
DOCTOR. BUT THERE ARE OTHERS.
WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES OF STUDENTS
ACTUALLY OFFERED PHD POSITIONS,
PLACEMENTS. AND THEN WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SORT OF PEOPLE
FIGURE OUT THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER, KIND
OF LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU,
THEY WITHDRAW THEM, THEY
WITHDRAW THE OFFER, AND THE
PERSON DOESN'T GET TO COMPLETE
THAT DEGREE. AND THEN, OF
COURSE, FOR MANY STUDENTS IN
THEIR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE,
THERE'S A PORTION WHICH INCLUDES
WORK. SO YOU HAVE TO WORK AS
PART OF THE WHOLE PACKAGE TO GET
THE TUITION, YOU KNOW, ALL OF IT
TO, TO, TO AFFORD COLLEGE. AND
THIS IS TRUE FOR UNDERGRADUATES
AS WELL. BUT THEY CAN'T WORK
LAWFULLY, AND SO THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO GET A JOB ON CAMPUS,
BUT UNDER THE CURRENT RULES,
THEY'RE, THEY'RE ACTUALLY UNABLE
THEY'RE BARRED FROM DOING THAT.
THANK YOU. AND THERE WAS MENTION
OF DACA. THERE'S SORT OF THIS I
THINK, PUBLIC PERCEPTION THAT,
WELL, WE HAVE DACA. AND SO AND
IT'S FOR YOUNG YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
SO ISN'T THAT GOOD ENOUGH RIGHT
NOW. DOESN'T THAT FULFILL THE
NEEDS OF, OF PEOPLE. SO AS YOU
ARE PROBABLY WELL AWARE OF AND
OTHERS HOPEFULLY ARE, IS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE PREVIOUS
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION THAT
PROGRAM WAS CHALLENGED AND WAS
STOPPED AND CURRENTLY SINCE THE
YEAR 2017, STUDENTS ARE NO
LONGER YOUNG, PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE DACA.
AND SO NOW WE'RE GOING ON SEVEN
YEARS OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE
KNOWN NO OTHER COUNTRY BUT THE
UNITED STATES. AND THEY HAVE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE ACCESS TO
THE BENEFITS AND THE RIGHTS THAT
ARE COME WITH THE PRIVILEGE OF
BEING DACA OR DOCUMENT
DOCUMENTED. YEAH. AND THERE WAS,
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THE ISSUE OF
BEING UNDOCUMENTED IS TAKING A
BIG PUBLIC, NARRATIVE, RIGHT
NOW, A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH.
AND I JUST WONDER IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING THAT
WOULD IMPACT THIS LEGISLATION OR
ANYTHING ELSE THAT THAT YOU
THINK IS IMPORTANT? YES. I MEAN,
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
SIGNALED THAT IT GENERALLY
SUPPORTS, TRYING TO LET MORE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES. YOU KNOW, WE SAW
THAT WITH THE PROPOSAL RECENTLY
FOR THE SPOUSES, UNDOCUMENTED,
YOU KNOW, SPOUSES OF U.S.
CITIZENS. BUT FROM WHAT WE CAN
TELL SO FAR, THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE NEW PROPOSALS. EITHER THAT
PROPOSAL OR THE ONE, WHAT'S
CALLED THE D THREE WAIVER, WHICH
HASN'T BEEN EXPLAINED VERY WELL,
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY NOTHING
THAT WOULD AFFECT UNDERGRADUATES
AND NOTHING THAT WOULD SOLVE THE
BASIC PROBLEM HERE, YOU KNOW.
YEAH THE THEIR PROPOSALS, I
THINK, ARE, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
GOOD. THEY EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR, FOR DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY. BUT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT APPEARS TO, BENEFIT THE
DOZENS OF STUDENTS YOU SAW
TODAY. AND, YOU KNOW, HUNDREDS,
PROBABLY THOUSANDS MORE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. THANK YOU. I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ELSE THAT WE HAVE MISSED HERE
THAT YOU THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONSIDER, IN
OUR DELIBERATIONS HERE. AND JUST
JUST ONE OTHER THING IN
PARTICULAR. I SPENT MANY MONTHS
TALKING WITH PEOPLE IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, TRYING
TO GET THEM TO DO THIS WITHOUT,
YOU KNOW, LEGISLATION. AND THERE
WAS A WHOLE MOVEMENT OF STUDENTS
THAT STARTED THERE, AND THEY
WERE CONCERNED THAT THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO GO OUT ON A LIMB. THAT
WAS HOW I UNDERSTOOD THEIR
CONCERNS. AND IT SEEMED TO ME
THAT IF YOU WHEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALVAREZ THEN HAD THE IDEA TO
HAVE THIS BILL, IT WOULD SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM, BECAUSE NOW YOU
SEE, AND CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD BE REQUIRED BY
STATE LAW TO HIRE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THE BEST QUALIFIED CANDIDATE FOR
THE JOB, REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. RIGHT? FOR
STUDENTS IN THAT POSITION, THEIR
OBJECTION NOW THAT THIS WOULD
PUT THE UNIVERSITY'S FINANCES AT
RISK, OR THAT IT WOULD PUT HR
STAFF AT RISK, SEEMS VERY, VERY
MUCH MISGUIDED TO ME BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T TAKE ACCOUNT OF THE FACT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO DO THESE THINGS. I'VE
NEVER SEEN A PERSON CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTED FOR DOING WHAT STATE
LAW REQUIRES. WE'VE NEVER SEEN
IT. WE'VE LOOKED. WE'VE LOOKED
IN THE MARIJUANA LAWS. WE'VE
LOOKED ALL KINDS. WE'VE LOOKED
WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT. SO I THINK
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY, AS YOU
HAD SUGGESTED, SENATOR NIELLO,
THAT THERE COULD BE A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THIS LAW IF IT PASSES,
YOU KNOW, AND I THINK WE HAVE
BETTER LEGAL ARGUMENTS. I THINK
WE COULD WIN THAT LAWSUIT. BUT,
YOU KNOW, NOBODY CAN PREDICT
WHAT WILL HAPPEN. MAYBE IT WON'T
COME OUT THAT WAY. BUT WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IF THAT LAWSUIT
PREVAILS IS THAT THE LAW WILL BE
STOPPED. IT'S NOT GOING TO CAUSE
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS FOR PEOPLE
OR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BE
TAKEN AWAY. AND MONEY, THEY
WOULD JUST SAY THE LAW'S, YOU
KNOW, PREEMPTED OR IT'S, YOU
KNOW, VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW. AND
SO YOU CAN'T DO IT. AND SO
THERE'S ALSO A POSSIBILITY THAT
WE WOULD WIN THAT LAWSUIT.
IT WOULDN'T GET SUED AT ALL
BECAUSE MAYBE THE GOVERNMENT
WON'T WANT TO ATTACK ALL OF
THESE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS,
PEOPLE LIKE YOU. SO THAT'S WHY
WE THINK THIS IS A BILL THAT'S
WORTH PASSING, AND WHY WE'RE SO
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALVAREZ FOR HAVING TAKEN IT UP,
EVEN THOUGH, YES, THERE IS SOME
POSSIBILITY THAT IT COULD GET
STRUCK DOWN IN THE COURTS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR RUSSELL NÓ. AND I JUST
WANT TO REACH OUT AND THANK ALL
OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO CAME UP
TODAY, AND EVERYBODY WHO CAME IN
SUPPORT. I THINK THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO HELP OUR YOUTH WHO WORK SO
HARD, WHO HAVE SACRIFICED SO
MUCH, AND NOW THEY'RE GETTING
THIS DOOR CLOSED TO THEM. AND I
WANT TO GIVE A VERY SPECIAL
SHOUT OUT TO OUR ICONIC LEADER,
DOLORES HUERTA, FOR BEING HERE
AND JOINING THE STUDENTS. SO
THANK YOU ALL. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR. ALSO,
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALVAREZ, FOR ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY, THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION, I DON'T THINK IS
FRIVOLOUS. I THINK THAT THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE RESOLVED, AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE LEGAL OPINIONS ON
MANY SIDES OF THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. AND I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
WHETHER IT GETS ENFORCED OR NOT
MAY BE DEPENDENT UPON WHO'S IN
THE EXECUTIVE MANSION IN
WASHINGTON, D.C, AND WE CAN'T
PREDICT EXACTLY HOW THAT'S GOING
TO GO AND WHO MIGHT ENFORCE WHAT
. BUT THE WAY I VIEW MY JOB, AT
LEAST HERE, IS TO LOOK AT POLICY
AND TRY TO AFFECT AND CREATE
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY. AND THIS
APPEARS TO BE AN UNFAIRNESS, AN
UNJUSTIFIED SITUATION THAT
REQUIRES US, AS A MATTER OF
POLICY MAKERS, TO MAKE OUR
VOICES KNOWN AND SET LAW AS WE
THINK THE LAW SHOULD BE SET. AND
FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I BELIEVE
IT'S GOING TO BE SUPPORTED BY
THE MAJORITY OF THIS COMMITTEE.
SO HAVING SAID THAT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH THANK YOU,
SENATOR, I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT OUT
PUBLICLY AND INTO THE OPEN WHAT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS ARE, AND WE
ACCEPT WHAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
MAY BE, BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE, AS
YOU JUST STATED, MR. CHAIR, THAT
IN CALIFORNIA, WE'VE DONE WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR OUR, OUR, OUR
COMMUNITIES AND FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. AND IN THIS CASE, I
AM AND I HOPE YOU ARE AS
EMBOLDENED BY THE BRAVERY OF THE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME
BEFORE US, WHO HAVE TESTIFIED,
WHO HAVE PUT THEMSELVES ON THE
LINE NOT JUST TODAY, BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING SO FOR QUITE
SOME TIME TO GET US TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY AND, AND THAT WE
SUPPORT THEM AS THEY SEEK THESE
OPPORTUNITIES GOING FORWARD. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE RIGHT MOMENT. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU. THIS
MIGHT BE THE RIGHT MOMENT. I
THINK WE MAY HAVE THE EVER
ELUSIVE QUORUM. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. UMBERG HERE. UMBERG HERE
. WILK. ALLEN. ALLEN HERE.
ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO HERE
. DURAZZO. HERE. GROSSO. HERE.
LAIRD NILO. HERE. NILO. HERE.
ROTH STERN. STERN. HERE. WILL
HOP. YOU'VE A QUORUM. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. IS THERE A
MOTION ON SENATOR RUSSO? MOVES A
BE, 25, 86. IT'S BEEN MOVED,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 2586. THE MOTION IS
DUE. PASS THE SENATE EDUCATION
UMBERG. I UMBERG. AYE. WILK
ALLEN A ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE LAIRD.
MILO. NO. MILO. NO ROTH. STERN.
A STERN. AYE. WAHAB 5 TO 1. 5 TO
1. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL, THANK YOU. SO,
MEMBER ALVAREZ. ALL RIGHT, I'M
GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL. OH,
OKAY. LET'S LET'S DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SENATOR
CABALLERO MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND THEN I'M GOING TO TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO, SENATOR NIHILO,
YOU SHOULD DO THE DODD BILL
FIRST. OKAY OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THEN WE'RE GOING TO DO
ALL RIGHT. GO GO AHEAD. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN MOVED BY, SENATOR CABALLERO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WILK. ALLEN
SENATOR ALLEN ON CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALAN AYE. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE LAIRD.
MILO MILO. AYE. ROTH STERN.
STERN. AYE WAHAB. 6 TO 0. ON
CONSENT SIX ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THAT BACK ON CALL. AND THEN
ONE OTHER MATTER BEFORE I HAVE
TO GO TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY,
FILE NUMBER 50, SB 1524, THAT'S
BEEN HEARD AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. IS
THERE A MOTION ON SB 1524?
SENATOR CABALLERO MOVES IT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
50. SB 1524. THE MOTION IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN UMBERG A UMBERG.
AYE WILK ALLEN. HI. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
BROUGH RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD.
NHIÀU NUMBER 50. YES MELO. AYE.
ROTH. STERN STERN. AYE. WAHAB 6
TO 0 SIX ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT.
ALL RIGHT. SO, OUR CHAIR HAS,
DEPARTED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE HOUSE, AND HE HAS CAST, FATE
COMPLETELY TO THE WIND AND LEFT
ME IN CHARGE. AND, NEXT UP IS
ASSEMBLYMAN CHEN, AB 2677. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR YOUR TIME
AND ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
2677. FIRST OFF, I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ON THIS BILL. MANY
BUSINESSES AND PROFESSIONALS ARE
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN SURETY
LICENSE BONDS AS A CONDITION OF
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA. THEIR
PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE AGGRIEVED
CONSUMERS WILL HAVE RECOURSE
AVAILABLE TO RECOVER THEIR
LOSSES UP TO A SET AMOUNT DUE TO
THE ACTIONS OR INACTIONS OF A
BUSINESS OR PROFESSIONAL THEY'VE
ENGAGED. EXAMPLES OF PROFESSIONS
REQUIRED TO MAINTAIN A LICENSE
BOND INCLUDE MOTOR VEHICLE
DEALERS, NOTARIES, INSURANCE
BROKERS, AND COLLECTION AGENCIES
WITH OVER 285,000 LICENSED
CONTRACTORS IN CALIFORNIA,
CONTRACTORS COMPRISE THE LARGEST
GROUP OF LICENSED BOND HOLDERS,
WHILE THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
11,500 NEW AND USED DEALER BONDS
, THE CURRENT STATUTORY LICENSE
BOND LIMIT OF LIABILITY FOR
CONTRACTORS IS NOW $25,000, AND
$50,000 FOR AUTO DEALER BONDS. A
RECENT CALIFORNIA APPELLATE
COURT OPINION HELD THAT A SURETY
UNDER A CONTRACTOR LICENSE BOND
WAS LIABLE FOR THE FULL AMOUNT
OF A 90,000 ATTORNEY FEE AWARD
ENTERED AGAINST THE CONTRACTOR,
EVEN THOUGH THE BOND LIMIT WAS
ONLY 12,500 AT THE TIME. MORE
RECENTLY, IN AN UNREPORTED
FEBRUARY 2024 DECISION, ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA APPELLATE COURT,
RELYING ON THE PRECEDENT SET
FORTH IN KHN, HELD THAT A
SURETY WAS LIABLE FOR THE FULL
AMOUNT OF A 26 2264 440,000
ATTORNEY FEE AWARD, EVEN THOUGH
THE BOND LIMIT WAS ONLY $50,000.
THE PURPOSE OF AB 2677 IS A
LIMITED LICENSE BOND. SURETY'S
LIABILITY TO THE PENAL SYSTEM OF
THE BOND. THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL, PARTICULARLY SINCE THE
LICENSE SEE IDENTIFIES THE
SURETY FOR ANY AND ALL COSTS
THAT THE SURETY PAYS OUT TO AN
AGGRIEVED CUSTOMER OF THE
LICENSEE, HENCE THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB 2677. APPROVAL OF THIS
MEASURE WILL ENSURE THAT SURETY
LICENSE BONDS, INCLUDING
CONTRACTOR AND CAR DEALER
LICENSE BONDS, REMAIN AFFORDABLE
AND WIDELY AVAILABLE TO MAINTAIN
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS INTENDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE UP TO THE
LICENSE BONDS. PENAL SUM WILL
ALSO PREVENT AN UNLICENSED BLACK
MARKET FROM EMERGING. FOR THOSE
BUSINESSES AND PROFESSIONALS
UNABLE TO MEET THE FAR MORE
STRINGENT UNDERWRITING CRITERIA
THAT WILL BECOME AN ASSISTANT
NECESSITY FOR SURETIES. IF THIS
ISSUE IS NOT RECTIFIED. WITH ME
TODAY IS PHIL VERMILLION,
REPRESENTATIVE SPONSOR THE
FLASHER BARRICADE ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. I'M PHIL VERMILLION,
REPRESENTING THE FLASHER
BARRICADE ASSOCIATION, WHAT YOU
HEAR ALL THE TIME ABOUT
EXISTENTIAL THREATS? THIS IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT. IF WE DON'T
PUT THE GENIE BACK IN THE BOTTLE
WITH REGARD TO THIS, MEASURE.
THUS FAR, WE HAVE TWO SURETY
COMPANIES THAT HAVE ALREADY
PULLED OUT OF THE MARKETPLACE.
SURE. TECH, WHICH WAS THE SECOND
LARGEST SURETY COMPANY IN THE
STATE. AND WE JUST LEARNED LAST
WEEK GREAT AMERICAN HAS PULLED
OUT OF THE DEALER BOND,
MARKETPLACE AS WELL. THIS IS
GOING TO SNOWBALL IF WE DON'T
CORRECT THIS PROBLEM. THE WHOLE
IDEA OF A BOND THAT, FOR
EXAMPLE, WITH CONTRACTORS, THE
BONDS HAVE BEEN AROUND SINCE
1939. IT DOESN'T REQUIRE AN
ATTORNEY. ALL IT DOES IS REQUIRE
THE AGGRIEVED PARTY TO FILE A
CLAIM WITH THE SURETY. THE
SURETY HAS AN OBLIGATION BY LAW
TO INVESTIGATE THAT CLAIM. IF IT
IS HELD VALID, THEN THEY PAY
OUT, I HAVE STATISTICS HERE
WHICH I'D BE HAPPY TO PASS OUT
TO EVERYONE, BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SOME OPPOSITION FROM SOME
OF THE, CAR CONSUMER GROUPS. I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE TOOK
AN AMENDMENT FROM THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS IN THE ASSEMBLY THIS
MEASURE PASSED ON CONSENT
THROUGH BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY AND ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. NOW WE'RE HERE, WE'RE
FACING THIS OPPOSITION. THERE
ARE THREE CONCERNS ARE DEALING
WITH DEALER BONDS. ONE, THE
$50,000 DEALER BOND IS
INADEQUATE. TWO, THERE IS NO
MECHANISM PREVENTING A BAD AUTO
DEALER WHO WHO'S AGGRIEVED A
CONSUMER FROM CLOSING DOWN THEIR
BUSINESS AND JUST REOPENING
AGAIN. AND THREE SURETIES DON'T
PAY OUT WELL, LET ME JUST TAKE
THE AUTO TO THE USED CAR
DEALERS, BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT. 2018
SURETIES PAID CLAIMS IN
CALIFORNIA COMPARED TO THE OTHER
STATE, 235.6% 2019 251.8% 2020
194.3% 2021 410% 2022 257. SO I
THINK THAT THAT SHOULD ALLAY THE
CONCERNS THAT THE SURETIES DON'T
PAY OUT. SENATOR, I'M SORRY, THE
CRITICAL THING IS THE ISSUES
THAT THE OPPOSITION RAISES. WE
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH. BUT
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO HAVE AN INTERIM HEARING
TO DETERMINE WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE. WE FIX THE PROBLEMS THAT
THEY'RE RAISING WITH THE
CONTRACTORS. A CONTRACTOR THAT
CREATES A PROBLEM IS BANNED FROM
GETTING A LICENSE. AGAIN, THEY
SHOULD BE DOING THE SAME THING
WITH THE DEALERS. WE RAISED THE
BOND FOR THE CONTRACTORS TO
25,002 YEARS AGO. THEY CAN RAISE
IT TO, AGAIN AN INTERIM STUDY
FOR THOSE REASONS. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
NEXT WITNESS. AND REMEMBER, WE
HAVE TWO MINUTES, MARK ZEGNA
WITH THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION,
ALONG WITH THE COMMENTS OF MR.
MUELLER MADE. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT ALTHOUGH SURETY IS NOT
A TRADITIONAL FORM OF INSURANCE,
IT IS REGULATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE. SO
SURETIES, WHICH NOW HAVE TO FACE
MUCH GREATER LIABILITIES UNDER
THE CARTAN DECISION AND
DECISIONS FLOWING FROM THAT DO
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADJUST
THEIR RATES TO REFLECT THIS FAR
GREATER LIABILITY. THEY, LIKE
ALL OTHER INSURERS, HAVE TO GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
AND FACE DELAYS IN RATE
APPROVALS FOR UP TO TWO YEARS.
WE HAVE SURETY STILL WAITING
AFTER TWO YEARS. SO I MEAN, IF
THE LEGISLATURE BELIEVES THAT A
SURETY SHOULD PAY FOR THE LEGAL
FEES, I THINK THE BEST IDEA
WOULD BE TO PASS THIS BILL FOR
THOSE SURETIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN EFFECT, THEN PASS A
BILL THAT DOES WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS AND DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION SO THE SURETY
COMPANIES HAVE THE TIME TO FIX
AND APPROPRIATE RATES. WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT SURETIES
LEAVING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A VERY COMMON THING.
INADEQUATE RATES. YOU CAN'T
CONTINUE TO WRITE AND THE ONLY
CHOICE IS TO LEAVE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU FOR THAT, DO WE HAVE
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE,
THIS IS ME. Tê TESTIMONY. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR. MEMBERS JAMIE HUFF, ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SARAH
NOCITO, ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL BUILDERS
EXCHANGE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDERS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, NAOMI PEDRO. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. MIKE GENETSKI,
CONTRACTOR, STATE LICENSE BOARD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND, SEEING
NO OTHER, FOLKS IN SUPPORT. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE OPPOSITION.
DO WE HAVE A PRINCIPAL WITNESS
FOR THE OPPOSITION. MR. VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS? MY NAME IS
WILLIAM BRADLEY. I'M A
CONSTITUENT OF SENATOR NIELLO.
ON APRIL 2ND, MY WIFE AND I
PURCHASED A VEHICLE. WE FOUNDED
AN INDEPENDENT AUTO DEALERSHIP
IN ROSEVILLE. I LOOKED IT OVER
CAREFULLY, INCLUDING TAKING A
LOOK UNDERNEATH, AND SAW NOTHING
THAT SET OFF ALARMS.
UNDERCOATING WAS PRESENT, BUT
APPEARED TO BE A PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE AGAINST RUST. I ASKED
THE SALESPERSON ABOUT THE
CONDITION OF THE CAR AND ITS
HISTORY, AND HE SAID THAT IT HAD
RECENTLY PASSED A SAFETY SAFETY
INSPECTION. HE SPECIFICALLY SAID
THAT IT HAD BEEN INSPECTED FOR
RUST SINCE IT HAD COME FROM
PENNSYLVANIA, AND THAT IT
CHECKED OUT OKAY. I TOOK HIM AT
HIS WORD. SINCE HE IS A
PROFESSIONAL AND IN A POSITION
TO KNOW ABOUT THE CAR, I PAID
$10,500 IN CASH. I TOOK IT TO AN
INDEPENDENT MECHANIC WHO HOISTED
IT ONTO A LIFT, INITIALLY
BELIEVING THAT THE CAR LOOKED
CLEAN AND WAS IMPRESSED WITH THE
LOW MILEAGE. HOWEVER, WE WERE
BOTH SHOCKED AT WHAT HE FOUND.
THE ENTIRE UNDERCARRIAGE WAS
CORRODED DUE TO RUST BRAKE
COMPONENTS. STEERING, SUSPENSION
AND THE FRAME WERE RUSTED BEYOND
REPAIR, HE SAID. THE RUST WAS
COVERED UP BY AN EXTREMELY HEAVY
LAYER OF UNDERCOATING OVER TOP
OF DUCT TAPE TO HIDE THE DAMAGE.
HE WARNED ME NOT TO DRIVE THE
CAR AT ALL, AS IT WAS GROSSLY
UNSAFE AND REFUSED TO PERFORM A
ROAD TEST. I TOOK IT TO
ROSEVILLE TOYOTA, WHO CONCURRED
WITH THE OPINION. THEY COULDN'T
EVEN PUT IT ON A HOIST AS THE
FRAME BEGAN TO BOW AND CRUMBLE,
I CONTACTED THE BUSINESS WHO
SAID I PURCHASED IT AS IS, SO I
WAS OUT OF LUCK. I ASKED THE DMV
TO INVESTIGATE, BUT THEIR SAFETY
REGULATIONS WERE WERE SCANT
UNDER THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
LAW. AUTO FRAUD LEGAL CENTER IS
WILLING TO REPRESENT ME IN THE
MATTER BECAUSE EVEN IF THE
DEALER DECLARES BANKRUPTCY TO
EVADE A LIABILITY, THEY CAN GET
MY DAMAGES AND ATTORNEY'S FEE
PAID BY THE DEALER'S SURETY
BOND. BUT IF AB 2677 BECOMES
LAW, CAR BUYERS LIKE ME WOULD BE
TOTALLY OUT OF LUCK BECAUSE
ATTORNEYS COULD NOT AFFORD TO
REPRESENT US AGAINST THE BOND
COMPANIES WHICH MAY DEFEND MAY
DENY MY CLAIM, EVEN IF IT EVEN
IF I PROVED I WAS DEFRAUDED.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB 2677. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, SENATOR NEILL.
MEMBERS I'M ROSEMARY SHANAHAN,
PRESIDENT OF CONSUMERS FOR AUTO
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY. AND WITH
YOUR PERMISSION, I'LL, SPLIT THE
TWO MINUTES WITH AN EXPERT WHO'S
HERE, WHO'S ALSO REPRESENTING
THE GENTLEMAN WHO JUST TESTIFIED
, AND WE'RE OPPOSING THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S VERY SWEEPING, AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COUNSEL'S
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THE BILL.
AND THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS WITH HOW
SWEEPING THIS BILL IS APPLYING
TO ALL DIFFERENT KINDS OF BONDS,
AND THAT IT WOULD BASICALLY
NULLIFY THE BENEFIT OF CONSUMERS
HAVING THE BOND, IF THEY CAN'T
GET LEGAL COUNSEL, WHICH USUALLY
THEY CAN'T AFFORD UNLESS THE,
ENTITY THAT DEFRAUDED THEM IS
LIABLE FOR ATTORNEY'S FEES, OR
IF THEY GO UNDER THAT, THE BOND
COMPANY, WOULD COVER THEIR
ATTORNEY'S FEES. AND WE FEEL THE
BILL WOULD BE UNFAIR TO BOTH
VICTIMS OF FRAUD AND HONEST
BUSINESSES. AND WE NOTE THAT A
LOT OF THE VICTIMS THAT WE HEAR
FROM ARE MEMBERS OF OUR ARMED
FORCES, AND THEY REALLY NEED,
THE BENEFIT OF LEGAL COUNSEL.
THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL MOVE TO THE
ME TOO TESTIMONY, NAME?
ORGANIZATION REP. I BEG YOUR
PARDON? SHE WANTED TO SHARE HER
LAST MINUTE WITH THE. OKAY.
EXCUSE ME. MISUNDERSTOOD YOU.
YOU HAVE ABOUT A MINUTE. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS, GREGORY
BABBITT. I'M A ATTORNEY. I'VE
BEEN A CONSUMER ADVOCATE,
REPRESENTING CONSUMERS LIKE MR.
BRADLEY SINCE 2002. WITH THE
AUTO FRAUD, LEGAL CENTER, I ASK
YOU TO, OPPOSE THIS BILL, I USE
THE BOND COMPANY STATUTE
REGULARLY, IN SITUATIONS WHEN
PEOPLE BUY CARS AND THEY PAY
CASH OR THEY GET THEIR OWN
FINANCING, TYPICALLY THESE ARE
LOWER INCOME INDIVIDUALS. AND
ALSO SERVICE MEMBERS. I'M IN
REGULAR CONTACT WITH THE, JAG.
PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO BECAUSE I
PROVIDE TRAINING TO THEM. THEY
TELL ME WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
SERVICE MEMBERS, USED CAR
DEALERSHIPS THAT ARE SET UP
ALONG CAMP PENDLETON, 32ND
STREET, REGULARLY CHEAT
CONSUMERS, AND THIS BILL WOULD
HURT MY ABILITY TO REPRESENT
THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE THE BOND
COMPANY STATUTE, WON'T PROVIDE
ME TO OBTAIN ATTORNEY'S FEES AND
COSTS. THE DECISIONS THAT HAVE
COME OUT RECENTLY HAVE ACTUALLY
HELPED, IN MY EXPERIENCE, HAVING
HANDLED THESE CASES SINCE 2002.
THE BOND COMPANIES ARE STARTING
TO SETTLE CASES. WRAP YOUR
TESTIMONY. THEY'RE SETTLING
CASES THAT THEY WOULDN'T SETTLE
BEFORE, SO, IN THE HARRIS
DECISION, THEY INDICATED THAT
THE VEHICLE CODE IS DOMINANT.
PURPOSE IS TO PROVIDE PROTECTION
TO CONSUMERS. I'D ASK THAT YOU
OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE IT WILL
PREVENT THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NOW, ME TOO. TESTIMONY. STATE
YOUR NAME, WHO YOU REPRESENT,
AND YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING.
DANIELLE CANDO KAISER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN OPPOSITION
. MORNING, MR. VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS ROBERT HARRELL WITH THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSITION. AND
MR. VERMUELEN KIND OF MADE OUR
POINTS FOR US AT SOME LEVEL.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE
COME FORWARD, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS? YEAH. I MEAN, MY
COMMENT IS I WASN'T AWARE OF
SOME OF THIS CONTROVERSY. SO I'M
I'M GOING TO WE HAVE UNTIL LATE
TONIGHT TO CAST A VOTE. SO I'M
GOING TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME DELVING INTO THE BILL.
THERE'S 50 BILLS ON THE AGENDA.
SO I WASN'T AS PREPARED AS I
WOULD LIKE TO BE. TYPICAL. SO
I'M I'M GOING TO LAY OFF RIGHT
NOW. BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M
NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL.
I JUST NEED TO SPEND A LITTLE
MORE TIME ON IT. I THINK WE ALL
FEEL FEEL THE SAME WAY. THE KEY
HERE IS, I THINK PROTECTING
CONSUMERS. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE PAYMENT OF ATTORNEY'S FEES.
AM I WRONG ABOUT THAT? YOU'RE
CORRECT, SENATOR. OKAY SO THE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
ATTORNEY IN REGARDS TO, THIS, I
UNDERSTOOD HIM TO SAY THAT THIS
WOULD CHANGE, THAT THAT BECAUSE
OF THE BILL, HE WOULD NOT BE
ENTITLED FOR TO ATTORNEY'S FEES.
AND I GUESS AND MY CONCERN IS
THAT, THE FULL AMOUNT OF THE
SURETY SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
PAYMENT OUT WHETHER IT'S TO
COVER COURT COSTS, DAMAGES AND
ATTORNEY'S FEES. AM I DO I HAVE
THAT WRONG? NO, SENATOR. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. SO THE
SURETY BOND WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPENSATE THE ATTORNEYS FOR
THEIR FEES. FURTHERMORE, I WOULD
SAY THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
PAYOUT, THE COMPENSATION DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
LAWSUIT. IT COMES OUT OF THE
LOGISTICAL DETAILS. I'M HAPPY TO
DEFER TO PHIL FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL
INFORMATION. SENATOR SENATOR,
THE AMENDMENT THAT WE TOOK IN
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ALLOWS ATTORNEY FEES UP TO THE
TOP OF THE BOND. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
THIS GENTLEMAN THAT WAS
AGGRIEVED FOR $10,000, HE
COLLECTS WITHOUT HAVING TO HIRE
AN ATTORNEY, GOES TO THE SURETY
COMPANY, THE SURETY COMPANY
INVESTIGATES, CONCURS, PAYS THE
10,000. THAT LEAVES $40,000 OF
THAT $50,000 BOND THAT THE
ATTORNEY COULD COLLECT ON.
BECAUSE OF THAT AMENDMENT WE
TOOK. SO WE SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEY'S CONCERN WITH THAT
AMENDMENT. AND THAT'S WHY THE
BILL PASSED ON CONSENT THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY. VERY GOOD. SIR,
YOU'RE THE ATTORNEY WHO CAN YOU
GIVE ME YOUR YOUR ANALYSIS OF
IT, PLEASE? SURE, MR. BABBITT
AGAIN, THANK YOU, SENATOR, TWO
TWO COMMENTS TO THAT NUMBER ONE,
THE VEHICLE CODE SECTION 11711
SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT ALLOW THE
RECOVERY OF ATTORNEY'S FEES FROM
THE BOND, THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE STATUTE WITH THE AMENDMENT
WOULD LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF
ATTORNEY'S FEES TO BE RECOVERED
TO THE LIMIT OF THE BOND, WHICH
IS $50,000, WHICH WOULD NOT TO
LITIGATE A CASE ALL THE WAY TO
TRIAL WOULD NOT BE FEASIBLE
UNDER THOSE RESTRICTIONS. SO
REALLY, IT'S AN AMENDMENT THAT
DOESN'T HELP US. ONE OTHER
IMPORTANT POINT THAT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE AN AGGRIEVED PARTY TO
FILE A CIVIL SUIT AGAINST THAT
AUTO DEALER. SO IN ESSENCE, THEY
COULD COLLECT 100,000, 200,000,
WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS, IF THEY
ARE SUCCESSFUL IN A CIVIL CASE
OVER AND BEYOND WHAT THE BOND IS
. SO, YOU KNOW, THE I DON'T SEE
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS. YOU'VE
YOU'VE GOT $40,000 IN MY
EXAMPLE. THERE THAT THE ATTORNEY
COULD COLLECT ON. SO, SO THE,
THE BOND DOESN'T LIMIT WHAT THE,
WHAT THE, THE COURT CAN ORDER IF
IT GOES TO TRIAL AND, AND YOU
CAN GET EXCESS AGAINST THE
COMPANY. YOU CAN FILE A SEPARATE
CIVIL LAWSUIT AGAINST WHOEVER
THE PARTY IS OVER AND BEYOND THE
BOND. THE BOND IS A SIMPLE WAY
FOR THE CONSUMER TO CLAIM ON,
AND THAT'S THE REASON IT'S BEEN
THERE FOREVER. BUT IT DOESN'T
LIMIT THE AMOUNT THAT COULD BE
OBTAINED AGAINST THE FRAUDULENT
SELLER. FOR EXAMPLE, TO THE FACE
VALUE OF THE BOND. SO AGAIN, FOR
AN AUTO DEALER IT'S A $50,000
BOND. SO IN MY SCENARIO THAT
10,000 WOULD GO TO THE AGGRIEVED
PARTY, 40,000 WOULD BE THERE FOR
THE ATTORNEY OR THE HOMEOWNER,
OR THE AGGRIEVED PARTY COULD GET
ALL 50,000. IN THAT CASE, THEN
THE ATTORNEY WOULD HAVE TO FILE
CIVILLY TO COLLECT ANYTHING ON
IT. BUT THE WHOLE IDEA OF THE
BOND IS A SIMPLE, EASY WAY NOT
TO HAVE TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY.
RIGHT? AND FOR CONTRACTORS, IT'S
A $25,000 BOND THAT WE INCREASE
THAT TWO YEARS AGO FROM 15,000.
OKAY WITH WITH RESPECT TO THE
CAR DEALERS, SINCE COVID IN MY
PRACTICE, I'VE NOTICED THAT EVEN
USED CARS NOW ARE COSTING 20,
$30,000. SO ESSENTIALLY CAPPING
AT $50,000 DOESN'T ALLOW THIS,
THIS BILL, REALLY, WHAT WILL
HELP DO IS, IS TO WEED OUT THE
UNSCRUPULOUS DEALERS AND ALLOW
THE MARKET IT'S GOING TO CORRECT
IN THE MARKET BECAUSE DEALERS
THAT ARE GOING TO CHEAT PEOPLE
ARE THE DEALERS THAT ARE GOING
TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS, AND
CONSUMERS AREN'T GOING TO HAVE
ANYBODY TO COLLECT. BUT THE
DEALERS THAT CAN PAY TO GET AN
ADEQUATE BOND, IF THERE IS AN
INCREASE IN THE PRICE, THOSE ARE
THE DEALERS THAT WE WANT IN
BUSINESS. WE WANT THOSE DEALERS
THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO IF THEY
MAKE MISTAKES, AND THE CASE LAW
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE, THESE
CASES, THE HARRIS CASE, THE
CARTON CASE, THE GONZALEZ CASE,
THOSE ARE CASES OF EGREGIOUS
FRAUD, WHICH SHOULD HAVE
SETTLED. AND THEY DIDN'T. THE
BOND COMPANIES, AS THE CASES
SAY, THE BOND COMPANIES CHOSE TO
FIGHT THESE CASES. AND THEN THEY
COMPLAIN WHEN THEY FIGHT THEM
AND THEY LOSE. IF THEY REALLY
WERE CONCERNED AND WANTED TO
PROTECT THE CONSUMERS, THEY
COULD HAVE SETTLED THESE CASES.
OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
ANY OTHER COMMENTS? SO, I HAD IN
AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION, I MUST
ABSTAIN BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN MOSTLY
ABOUT AUTOMOBILE DEALERS. AS AN
AUTOMOBILE DEALER, I AM LICENSED
AND TAKE OUT BONDS. AND IF I WAS
IN THE AUDIENCE, I COULD TAKE A
POSITION. BUT BACK HERE, I'M, AS
I SAID, IN AN ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION, I WILL ABSTAIN.
SOMEHUMAN. CHEN, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION AS WELL AS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOING FROM
THE ASSEMBLY TO THE SENATE.
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS AND TOOK ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS HAD. AND IF IT COMES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE, I ASSURE
YOU I'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION, PRIMARILY THE
MAIN FOR ME, THE FOUR REASONS
WHY WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
POLICY AND WORK ON THIS BILL IS
FOR ONE, IS TO REDUCE THE
EXPOSURE TO UNLIMITED FEES THAT
WOULD IMPACT CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS. THE SECOND,
KNOWING THAT, THE UNLIMITED FEES
COULD IMPACT CONSUMERS, THAT
THIS COULD TIGHTEN UNDERWRITING
STANDARDS IN WHICH WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO
RECEIVE A SURETY BOND. AND THE
THIRD IS QUITE FRANKLY, THAT A
SURETY LICENSE BOND COMPANIES
WOULD LEAVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THIS IS A
FINANCIAL IMPACT FOR THEM THAT
IS VERY SEVERE. WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN SOME OF THESE COMPANIES
DISCUSS THIS, AND IT'S SOMETHING
I DON'T WANT TO SEE. THE SURETY
LICENSE BOND WITHDRAW FROM THIS
MARKET. BUT YOU HAVE MY PROMISE
AS I DID GO THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR, AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEES
THAT WE WILL WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION, AS WE HAVE DONE
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY, WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS. AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AS WELL AS YOUR
CONSIDERATION MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU. I'LL MOVE IT FOR
PROCEDURAL REASONS. I WANT TO
SPEND SOME MORE TIME ON THE
BILL, AND I'M GOING TO PRESENT
THE ASSEMBLY, BUT I'M GOING TO
MOVE IT NOW. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
SO, SUCH AS IT IS, WE'LL CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 14, AB 2677. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS UMBERG WILK ALLEN
ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DURAZO LAIRD NIELLO ROTH. STERN.
WAHAB, YOU HAVE 1 TO 0. WE'LL
HOLD THAT OPEN NEXT. WE'RE
TAKING AN ITEM OUT OF ORDER.
ASSEMBLYMAN MAIENSCHEIN, ITEM
33, AB 2095. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I'D LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS. FOR MORE THAN
100 YEARS, PUBLIC NOTICES HAVE
SERVED AS VITAL CHANNELS FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN OUR LEGAL SYSTEM, INFORMING
CITIZENS ABOUT CRUCIAL EVENTS
SHAPING OUR COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC
NOTICES HAVE TRADITIONALLY BEEN
PUBLISHED IN PAPER NEWSPAPERS.
HOWEVER, AS THE DIGITAL AGE IS
HERE, IT'S CRUCIAL WE ENSURE
EQUAL ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION
FOR ALL CITIZENS, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR PREFERRED MEDIUM. AB 2095
SEEKS TO ACHIEVE THIS BY
ESTABLISHING STANDARDIZED
PUBLICATION PROTOCOLS ACROSS
PRINT AND ONLINE PLATFORMS,
ELIMINATING ANY ADDITIONAL
CHARGES FOR ACCESSING AND
PUBLISHING PUBLIC NOTICES
ONLINE. THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
LEGAL NOTICES TO BE PUBLISHED IN
PRINT, ON THE NEWSPAPER'S
WEBSITE, AND ON A STATEWIDE
WEBSITE. MAINTAINED IS THE
CLEARINGHOUSE FOR NOTICES BY
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPERS. THIS
ENSURES EVERY CITIZEN CAN STAY
INFORMED ABOUT IMPORTANT EVENTS,
WHETHER THEY RELY ON NEWSPAPERS
OR DIGITAL SOURCES. THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
VANESSA CAJINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. THIS MORNING HERE,
AS THE SPONSOR OF AB 2095, THERE
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN
TERMS OF HOW CALIFORNIANS GET
THEIR NEWS AND ALSO IN THE WAY
THAT WE DEAL WITH PUBLIC NOTICE.
WE HAVE OVER 1400 PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE THAT REQUIRE
PUBLIC NOTICE SO THAT
COMMUNITIES CAN GET ACCESS TO
INFORMATION THAT AFFECTS THEM IN
A TIMELY AND MEANINGFUL WAY.
HAVING THE THIRD ESTATE DEAL
WITH THAT, THE JOURNALISM ESTATE
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE WE ARE THE
INDEPENDENT ARBITERS OF WHAT
THAT INFORMATION IS, WHAT AB
2095 SEEKS TO DO IS TO PUT
THINGS INTO ONE MAIN CATEGORY,
TO ENSURE THAT NEWSPAPERS ARE
KEPT WHOLE, AND THAT THE PUBLIC
HAS A SINGULAR PLACE TO GET
THEIR PUBLIC NOTICE FROM. THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF ATTEMPTS
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS,
NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO BRING
PUBLIC NOTICES IN HOUSE TO THE
PURVEYORS OF THAT INFORMATION,
WHICH COULD LEAD TO THE PUBLIC
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED. SO
FOR THESE REASONS, WE HAVE
STRUCK A BALANCE WITH AB 2095.
ARE OPEN TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS, BUT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE, DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE IN
FAVOR OF THIS FOR ME TO
TESTIMONY? YOU HAVE JUST ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS. YES. AND NOW
FOR THE OPPOSITION. IS THERE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION?
THERE. ARE YOU GOOD? HOW ARE
YOU? GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
MEMBER STEVE CRUZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BLACK MEDIA
ASSOCIATION. AND WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL, RECENT
AMENDMENTS, RELATED TO THE
ENTITY THAT WOULD BE THE WOULD,
BE THE MAIN, ENTITY IN CHARGE OF
MANAGING THE PUBLIC NOTICES. AND
I'LL LET REGINA WILSON ALSO
SPEAK. WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL THAT THERE WILL BE A WAY
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS GOING
FORWARD. BUT OTHER THAN TO SAY
THAT THE PUBLIC NOTICES ARE A
PRIMARY SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
OUR MEMBERS, AND WHEN THERE ARE
POLICIES, I KNOW THEY ARE
DESIGNED TO BE BENEFICIAL. WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE DONE. IT'S DONE RIGHT, AND
IT DOESN'T ADD BURDENS TO SOME
OF OUR SMALL PUBLISHERS. AND SO
AGAIN, WE'RE OPPOSED, BUT WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR GOING FORWARD. AND
REGINA WILSON, IF SHE'S ABLE TO
YOU'RE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
CORRECT? CORRECT SEE THAT SHOULD
WORK. WELL, I THINK HE JUST SAID
EVERYTHING, BUT YES, WE ARE. I
DID GET A NOTE, THOUGH, THAT THE
AUTHOR, SPOKE TO SOMEBODY ELSE I
SPOKE TO EARLIER AND SAID THAT
HE WAS WILLING TO, LOOK AT SOME
OF THE SUGGESTIONS THAT WE PUT
FORWARD, AND SO WE'RE HOPING
THAT THAT WILL TAKE PLACE. I
DON'T KNOW IF HE COMMENTS TO
THAT, BUT ETHNIC MEDIA, FOR
INSTANCE, DOES NOT GET ITS
LION'S SHARE OF PUBLIC NOTICE.
AND SO, BEFORE WE MAKE THESE
TYPE OF CHANGES, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING MORE
BURDEN ON SMALL BUSINESSES. YOU
ALL WILL BE HEARING A BILL LATER
ON THIS AFTERNOON ON 886. AND
YOU ALL KNOW, REALLY, THE
COLLAPSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH MEDIA, WE DON'T WANT TO PUT
MORE BURDEN ON OUR MEDIA OUTLETS
AND BASICALLY THE WAY THAT THE,
PUBLIC NOTICES HAPPEN WITHIN
COMMUNITIES. STILL, THE COUNTIES
STILL EVEN REQUIRE DIFFERENT
THINGS. SOME COUNTIES STILL
REQUIRE YOU TO GO INTO THE
COUNTY CUT, PASTE. THERE'S MORE
TO THIS CONVERSATION. AND SO WE
JUST WANT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO BE ABLE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS WE HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION FOR
ME TO TESTIMONY, SEEING NO ONE
COME FORWARD, BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? YES SENATOR CABALLERO
OF THE OF THE AUTHOR. THERE WERE
SOME SUGGESTED, AMENDMENTS AND
I'M ASSUMING THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH THEM ON THOSE. YEAH. YES,
SENATOR. WE'VE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
ON THIS BILL. AND ACTUALLY WE
KIND OF GOT THIS JUST RECENT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SIT DOWN.
ABSOLUTELY. WE'LL SIT DOWN AND
MAKE SURE I MEAN, THE PREMISE
BEHIND ALL THIS, OBVIOUSLY, IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING ALL OF
US ARE GETTING OUR NEWS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS THAN WE DID JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO. AND SO THAT'S
JUST TO BE, YOU KNOW, TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S ALREADY A FACT
THAT THERE'S PEOPLE ARE GETTING
THEIR NEWS AND THEIR INFORMATION
THROUGH A WIDE VARIETY OF
SOURCES. SO IT'S ACTUALLY TO
MAKE IT MORE DEMOCRATIC, MORE
EASY, EASIER FOR PEOPLE. SO
WE'LL, WE'LL WORK WITH, REGINA.
OKAY MISS PERRY. RIGHT WE'LL
WORK WITH HER TO, TO HOPEFULLY
ALLEVIATE HER CONCERNS AS WELL.
WE'VE ACTUALLY THIS IS, YOU
KNOW, NO GOOD DEED GOES
UNPUNISHED. WE THOUGHT THIS
WOULD BE RELATIVELY SIMPLE. AND
WE HAVE WORKED WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE TO REMOVE ALL SO FAR,
NOTHING SIMPLE. NO, YOU'RE RIGHT
, THIS ONE, THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR IS A REMINDER OF THAT
. UNDERSTOOD. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I APPRECIATE IT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS? I'M PREPARED TO MOVE
THE BILL WHEN THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU, WOULD YOU CARE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIRMAN. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. EXCELLENT.
CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND, SENATOR
CABALLERO MOVES THE BILL AGAIN,
CALL THE ROLES SUCH AS IT IS AT
THIS POINT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 33, AB 2095. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, MERCK
WILK ALLEN ASHBY CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO
AYE. LAIRD. NILO. NILO. AYE
ROTH. STERN WAHAB. 3 TO 0. NOW
BACK ON FILE. ITEM ORDER.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BAUER KHN, WITH,
8 OR 10 BILLS HERE BEFORE, SIR,
ONLY FOR. AB 460. FIRST UP, AS A
FELLOW LAWYER, YOU KNOW, I LOVE
THE COURTS, SO I'D LIKE TO SPEND
TIME WITH ALL OF YOU. OKAY.
WAIT. DID WE. AB 460. IS THAT
FIRST? JUST SO I KNOW WHERE WE
WANT TO START. WHAT WAS THAT? AB
460. PERFECT. OKAY HOWEVER YOU'D
LIKE. OKAY THANK YOU. MR. VICE
CHAIR MEMBERS, I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. WITH THAT,
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB 460.
THIS BILL SIMPLY INCREASES THE
PENALTIES FOR CERTAIN VIOLATIONS
OF CEASE AND DESIST ORDERS AND
CURTAILMENT ORDERS ISSUED BY THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD. ILLEGAL OR WASTEFUL WATER
USE CAN BECOME THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ACCESS TO WATER OR DRY
TAPS IN THE FUTURE. I'M A
BELIEVER, AS I HOPE EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM IS, THAT WHEN WE HAVE
REGULATIONS AND LAWS ON THE
BOOKS, WE SHOULD HAVE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS. SEEMS
VERY SIMPLE AND THOSE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS SHOULD BE
SUFFICIENT TO DETER THE BEHAVIOR
THAT WE WANT TO NOT HAPPEN,
WHICH IS TO VIOLATE THE ORDERS
IN PLACE. AND WE HAVE SEEN
THROUGH ACTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
NORTHERN PART OF OUR STATE THAT
WHEN THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
IS WORTH VIOLATING THE ORDERS,
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS. AND SO
THIS BILL MERELY RAISES THE
FINES TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT VIOLATING CURTAILMENT
ORDERS, AND THAT THEY ARE PAYING
FINES THAT WOULD DETER SUCH
BEHAVIOR. SO WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY OF 460 IS, NOT YEAH. I'M
NOT SURE WHERE THE ON SWITCH IS.
IT'S YOUR ON I THINK. YEAH,
YEAH. GO AHEAD. YEAH. SO I AM
MATT CLIFFORD. I'M THE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR TROUT
UNLIMITED, CO-SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. AND I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS
VERY BRIEF, BECAUSE I THINK IN
ITS CURRENT FORM, THE BILL IS
FAIRLY SIMPLE, AS, MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN JUST SAID, I MEAN,
THE WATER BOARD IS CHARGED BY
LAW WITH MANAGING WATER AND
PROTECTING STREAM FLOWS WHEN
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH WATER TO GO
AROUND SITUATION, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE MORE AND MORE FREQUENTLY
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE AND
INCREASED DROUGHT AND WHATEVER
POWERS ONE THINKS THE WATER
BOARD OUGHT TO HAVE, AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S A LOT OF
DISAGREEMENT ABOUT THAT IN THE
WORLD. ONE THING WE KNOW IS THE
WATER BOARD HAS TO HAVE THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY AND THE ABILITY
TO MAKE ITS ORDERS STICK AND
MAKE SURE PEOPLE COMPLY WITH
THEM. WE SAW DIRECT EVIDENCE IN
THE LAST DROUGHT THAT THE
CURRENT LIABILITY SCHEME IS NOT
ADEQUATE TO DO THAT. AB 460
FIXES THAT, ONE POINT, I'D JUST
LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT WHEN YOU
SEE THE NUMBERS IN THIS BILL,
KEEP IN MIND THESE ARE MAXIMUM
PENALTIES, RIGHT? THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE DEFINED IN EVERY
CASE. AND AS WITH MOST AGENCIES,
THERE'S A SEPARATE STATUTE I
BELIEVE IT'S WATER CODE 1848 D
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN, WHICH
BASICALLY REQUIRES THE BOARD TO,
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS,
CONSIDER VARIOUS FACTORS,
INCLUDING THE EXTENT OF THE HARM
OR THE NATURE OF THE HARM AND
THE WRONGDOING AND JUSTIFYING IN
EVERY CASE AND NEEDS TO HAVE
THIS ABILITY. IN SOME CASES, A
DIVERSION. DEPENDING ON THE SIZE
OF A STREAM, TEN ACRE FEET OF
ILLEGAL DIVERSION MAY BE A HUGE
DEAL. IT MAY BE BASICALLY A
ROUNDING ERROR, RIGHT? SO THE
BOARD CAN AND WILL AND MUST
ADJUST THE FINES. YOU KNOW, FOR
EACH CIRCUMSTANCE. AND, THIS
BILL PROVIDES FOR THAT. SO, YOU
KNOW, IN SUMMARY, FOR THIS
REASON, I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS WE DISAGREE WITH
DIFFERENT WATER DISTRICTS AND
WATER USERS AROUND THE STATE ON.
BUT I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS JUST
RECOGNIZE THIS IS COMMON SENSE
AND SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN FOR THE WATER BOARD TO BE
ABLE TO DO ITS JOB. SO THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. THAT'S YOUR ONLY
PRIMARY WITNESS? YES. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, COME
FORWARD, STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. GOOD
MORNING ALEX, I'M HAPPY TO TRY
TO GET ON THIS. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S ON. IS THAT WHAT I'M ON?
I'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE PLENTY OF
CONSERVATION LEAGUE CLEAN WATER
ACTION, ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS AND
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DENNIS
O'CONNOR WITH THE MONO LAKE
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT LILY'S
CARILLO WITH CAL TROUT ON BEHALF
OF FRIENDS OF THE RIVER LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS, SAN FRANCISCO
BAYKEEPER AND SOUTH YUBA RIVER
CITIZENS LEAGUE, ALL IN SUPPORT.
DARRYL LIDDLE ON BEHALF OF NRDC
IN SUPPORT MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
. DON GILBERT FOR SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MEGAN
CLEVELAND WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND SUPPORT ANDREA
ABERGEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT AND ALSO FOR THE
TURLOCK IRRIGATION DISTRICT,
WHICH WAS LISTED AS OPPOSED ON
THE ANALYSIS, BUT HAS MOVED TO
NEUTRAL. I'VE WRITTEN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
GLENN FARRELL ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT. OKAY, WE WILL MOVE NOW
TO THE OPPOSITION PRIMARY
WITNESS OPPOSED TO AB 460.
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD, IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WANTS TO EXPRESS,
EXPRESS, EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL, SEEING NONE COME
FORWARD? BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
SENATOR CABALLERO OF THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. OKAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, SEEING NO
OTHER HANDS RAISED, WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I JUST WANT TO
THANK, MANY OF THE SUPPORT YOU
HEARD TODAY WERE IN OPPOSITION
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO. SO WE'VE
COME VERY FAR. I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR BEING HERE. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. I WOULD AGREE THE
OPPOSITION WAS RATHER EXTENSIVE.
NOT ANY MORE, SIR. GOOD WORK
AGAIN. WE HAVE A BILL AND, I SEE
THAT THE CHAIR HAS RETURNED, AND
I WILL HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO
HIM. BUT FIRST I GET TO CALL FOR
THE ROLL. SUCH AS IT IS. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 460.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG UMBERG. I
WILK ALLEN. ALLEN. I ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I GROSSO TO
GROSSO I LAIRD. NHIÀU I MILO I.
ROTH. STERN WAHAB. 5 TO 0. FIVE.
FIVE ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR
NILO, FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. I SEE
THERE'S STILL BILL. YOU DIDN'T
GET THEM ALL DONE, THOUGH. I SEE
I TRIED, SIR. RIGHT. I I TRIED
TO RUSH THROUGH THE AGENDA
COMPLETELY, BUT YOU JUST GOT
BACK TOO SOON. ALL RIGHT, WELL,
I'M GOING TO LEAVE AGAIN IN A
LITTLE WHILE, SO I'LL LET YOU
FINISH THE ENTIRE, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. SO, I
BELIEVE NEXT IS FILE NUMBER SIX,
AB 1846. YES THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AND FIRST, I
WANT TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON THE BILL, WHICH
CLARIFY THAT THE TRAINING IN
THIS BILL SHOULD BE INFORMED BY
RESEARCH AND EVIDENCE ON THE
IMPACTS OF ABUSE ON ASSAULT
VICTIMS AND TO LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF REQUIRED TRAININGS. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL, ALTHOUGH
PERHAPS NOT ALL. I'M PLEASED TO
BRING AB 1846 BEFORE YOU TODAY,
AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM MY
WITNESSES, WE HAVE DONE IMMENSE
WORK IN THIS LEGISLATURE TO
PROTECT SURVIVORS WHEN THEY
ENTER OUR COURTROOM. AND IT IS
THE RULE FOR ANY OF US THAT HAVE
BEEN IN A COURTROOM OF THE JUDGE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
PLAYING REFEREE TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM, TO GET
JUSTICE AND TO FEEL SAFE. AND
FAR TOO OFTEN, THE LAWS WE HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE THAT ESPECIALLY
ALLOW CHILDREN IN OUR COURTROOMS
TO BE SET UP FOR SUCCESS AND TO
NOT BE RETRAUMATIZED WHEN THEY
WALK IN, ARE NOT BEING FOLLOWED
BECAUSE JUDGES DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE
FOR INDIVIDUALS. AND SO THIS
BILL IS VERY SIMPLE. IT TRAINS
JUDGES TO ENSURE THEY KNOW HOW
AND WHY THEY SHOULD BE
PROTECTING SURVIVORS WHO WALK
INTO THEIR COURTROOM. AND AS
SOMEONE WHO PRACTICED LAW IN A
COURTROOM, I WAS ANXIOUS WHEN I
WALKED INTO A COURTROOM AND I
WAS JUST THERE TO DO MY JOB. AND
SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE FOR THE SURVIVORS WHO
SHOW UP AND ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO
SEEK JUSTICE. AND I THINK THIS
IS A SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO MAKE SURE THEIR
EXPERIENCE IS NOT RETRAUMATIZING
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
NANCY O'MALLEY, RETIRED ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY, AND
JANICE BAKER KINNEY, A SURVIVOR.
ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU. YOU NEED
A MIC? WELCOME, MISS O'MALLEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU, FIRST, I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS IS THAT THIS
IMPROPERLY IMPINGES ON JUDICIAL
INDEPENDENCE UNDER THE
SEPARATION OF POWERS DOCUMENT.
BUT IN FACT, YOUR LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED LEGISLATION THAT HAS
MANDATED CERTAIN TRAINING,
PARTICULARLY OUR REFERENCE
TRAINING AROUND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FOR JUDGES, VERY
SPECIFIC, AND THAT THAT TRAINING
INVOLVES THE VOICES OF SURVIVORS
AND VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO HELP EDUCATE THE JUDGES, THE
SECOND POINT THAT I WANT TO
REALLY BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
IS THAT THE BILL ADDRESSES THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR JUDGES TO
RECEIVE TRAINING ON THE IMPACT
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
ABUSE. IT'S NOT TELLING JUDGES
HOW TO RULE. IT'S JUST EDUCATING
JUDGES ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND THAT IMPACT
IS WELL DOCUMENTED THROUGH
RESEARCH. IT IS DOCUMENTED FOR
THE SURVIVOR. IT'S ALSO RESEARCH
THAT EVEN TALKS ABOUT LONGEVITY
IMPACTS AND THAT CARRY OVER INTO
THE CHILDREN OF SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. WE'VE SEEN TOO
MANY EXAMPLES WHERE THE COURT,
IN THEIR IGNORANCE. I GIVE THAT
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT. THE
COURT IN THEIR IGNORANCE, HAS
BEEN ALLOWED ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR BY
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY OR
DISRESPECTFUL BEHAVIOR. SO THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ENSURE THAT
JUDGES ARE TRAINED, AND THAT
JUDGES ARE RECEIVING THAT
TRAINING AND UNDERSTANDING. THEY
PROPOSAL SHOULD ALREADY HAVE
BEEN IN THE JUDICIAL COUNSEL
INDICATES THAT THEY WOULD
INCLUDE SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN
ALL TRAINING, BUT IN FACT, THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE ALREADY.
AND SO MANDATING THE SPECIFIC
TRAINING WILL ENSURE THAT IT
DOES. IN FACT OCCUR. NEWER
JUDGES WITH WHOM I'VE HAD
CONTACT HAVE TOLD ME THAT IN
THEIR NEW JUDGE COLLEGE, THERE
WAS NOT ONE SESSION, NOT ONE
SESSION ON VICTIMS OF CRIME WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS UNDER ARTICLE ONE,
SECTION 28 B, SO MANY OF WHICH
ARE BEING IGNORED AND DISCOUNTED
IN THE COURTROOM. I WILL SAY
MOSTLY OUT OF IGNORANCE OF THE
DYNAMIC. SO AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR THAT
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT NOT BE
REVICTIMIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE, AND THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JANICE BAKER
KINNEY AND I'M WITH STAND WITH
SURVIVORS. AND I STRONGLY,
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STAND WITH SURVIVORS HAVE SPENT
YEARS SUPPORTING HUNDREDS OF
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
VIOLENCE. AND I AM ALSO A
SURVIVOR. I WAS RAPED BY BILL
COSBY. JUDGES SET THE COURTROOM
STONE. YET SOME SHOW A SHOCKING
LACK OF CONCERN, WHICH IN TURN
CAN ALSO IMPACT HOW A JURY VIEWS
THE SURVIVOR. I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU SOME EXAMPLES. JUDGE ROBIN
CAMP ASKED A SURVIVOR. WHY
COULDN'T YOU JUST KEEP YOUR
KNEES TOGETHER? JUDGE TODD
BOWERS SAID OF A 14 YEAR OLD
STUDENT WHO WAS RAPED BY HER 54
YEAR OLD TEACHER THAT SHE WAS
PROBABLY IN AS MUCH CONTROL OF
THE SITUATION AS THE DEFENDANT.
JUDGE TODD BOWERS SAID, I'M
SORRY, EXCUSE ME. JUDGE DEREK
JOHNSON REMARKED ABOUT A
SURVIVOR WHO HAD BEEN BEATEN
WITH A METAL BATON. THE VICTIM,
ALTHOUGH SHE WASN'T NECESSARILY
WILLING, SHE DIDN'T PUT UP A
FIGHT. JUDGE THOMAS LO CALLED A
TWO TIME RAPIST AN
EXTRAORDINARILY GOOD MAN. BUT
GREAT MEN SOMETIMES DO BAD
THINGS, JUDGE RAYMOND DEAN SAID
AT A RAPIST SENTENCING. WHEN A
WOMAN SAYS NO, SHE DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN IT. AND JUDGE JOHN
PAUL BRAUN CLAIMED A TEENAGER
SEDUCED HER 49 YEAR OLD
ATTACKER. MAYBE SHE'S A LITTLE
OVERWEIGHT, BUT SHE HAS A PRETTY
FACE. NO, SHE WAS FLATTERED BY
HIM. MAYBE IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
HE SHOWED INTEREST IN HER. JUDGE
JAMES VOS DISMISSED A SURVIVOR'S
CLAIMS AND BLAMED HER. SHE WAS
HIGHLY INTOXICATED. SHE WAS
DANCING ON TABLES, SHE DRANK TEN
GLASSES OF WINE AND HER DRESS
WAS HIKED UP SO EVERYONE COULD
SEE. AND WE ALL KNOW ABOUT JUDGE
AARON PERSKY, WHO GAVE A
STANFORD STUDENT WHO RAPED AN
UNCONSCIOUS WOMAN BEHIND A
DUMPSTER A LIGHTER SENTENCE.
THANK YOU. EVERY SURVIVOR
DESERVES HER DAY IN COURT OR HIS
DAY IN COURT. AND I THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING. THANK YOU. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU IF YOU HAVE
THAT INFORMATION, THIS IS NOT
HOMEWORK. JUST IF YOU HAVE THAT
INFORMATION, IF YOU WOULD
COMMUNICATE THE INFORMATION AS
TO THOSE JUDGES WHO MADE THOSE
STATEMENTS AND WHETHER THEY'RE
STILL SITTING ON THE BENCH AND
WHAT DISCIPLINARY ACTION, IF
ANY, HAD BEEN TAKEN AGAINST
THEM, THANK YOU. WOULDN'T MIND.
OKAY. THANK YOU. LET'S NOW TURN
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 1846,
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. JACKIE. SIR, ON
BEHALF OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA, STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AARON. AARON TAYLOR
WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT. NOW LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 1846, PLEASE
APPROACH. YOU'RE WELCOME TO
EITHER USE THE MICROPHONE OR
COME AND SIT AT TABLE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
TRACY KENNY, ON BEHALF OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 1846, I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAD PROPOSED AND
THE AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED, AND
THEY DO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS THAT WE HAD
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED ON
PRINCIPLE TO ANY KIND OF
JUDICIAL TRAINING MANDATE IN
STATUTORY STATUTE. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT SOME OF THESE HAVE BEEN
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
PREVIOUSLY. WE DON'T THINK THIS
IS A GOOD TREND. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH, AS A
SEPARATE AND INDEPENDENT BRANCH,
IS CAPABLE OF DETERMINING THE
TRAINING PRIORITIES FOR JUDICIAL
OFFICERS. AND THE FACT IS THAT
WE DO PROVIDE INTENSIVE TRAINING
ON THIS TOPIC ALREADY. WE HAVE A
TWO DAY TRAINING ON HANDLING OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASES THAT GOES
INTO MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY. THERE ARE LIMITED HOURS
THAT JUDGES CAN SPEND IN
TRAINING, AND WE BELIEVE THE
BRANCH IS IN THE BEST POSITION
TO ALLOCATE THOSE HOURS AND
DETERMINE THE PRIORITIES FOR OUR
JUDGES. ISSUES ARISE CONSTANTLY
IN OUR LEGAL PROFESSION THAT
NEED TO BE TRAINED ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IS ONE THAT IS
CURRENTLY COMING UP. THE MORE OF
THESE MANDATES THAT ARE PUT IN
STATUTE, THE LESS FLEXIBILITY
THE BRANCH HAS TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS EMERGING ISSUES AND
ENSURE THAT OUR JUDGES ARE WELL
INFORMED AND ABLE TO TREAT THE
PUBLIC. THIS IS A VITAL AND
IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND IT
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED
IN JUDICIAL TRAINING. AS IT IS,
WE SIMPLY OBJECT TO THE
STATUTORY MANDATE AS NOT
ALLOWING INDEPENDENCE FOR THE
BRANCH AND OUR ABILITY TO MAKE
THESE DECISIONS. THE SUBSTANTIVE
LAW IS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE, BUT WE THINK THAT
TRAINING SHOULD BE WITHIN OUR
BAILIWICK AND OUR PREROGATIVE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED. WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING. YES, SENATOR
NIELLO JUST WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
THE AUTHOR'S RESPONSE TO THE
OPPOSITION. YEAH. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS. I THINK THAT WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM OUR WITNESS HERE IS
THE PROBLEM. OUR JOB AS
LEGISLATORS IS TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND I THINK TO
PROTECT SURVIVORS. AND OUR MOST
VULNERABLE TOP OF THE LIST AS IT
RELATES TO THAT. AND THAT ISN'T
HAPPENING IN OUR COURTROOMS, AND
WE'RE SEEING IT EVERY SINGLE
DAY. SO I APPRECIATE THE
JUDICIAL COUNSEL SAYING IT ISN'T
THEIR PURVIEW. HAD THEY ACTUALLY
DONE THIS. AND BY THE WAY, NONE
OF THIS IS MANDATORY. WHAT IS
SUGGESTED IS BEING PROVIDED, I
BELIEVE IT'S BEING PROVIDED. BUT
THOSE IN THE COURTROOMS, AS
SPECIFIED BY THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE IN THE ROLE OF PROTECTING
SURVIVORS, NEED THIS MANDATED.
AND I BELIEVE IT IS OUR JOB TO
ENFORCE THAT. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE, IS THERE A MOTION SENATOR
BARRASSO MOVES THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
Ó? YES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION, MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL, IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS AB 1846,
AND THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED, TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OF THE SENATE. UMBERG.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WILK. ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. GUERRERO
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE LAIRD.
NILO. NILO. AYE ROTH. STERN.
WAHAB YOU HAVE 4 TO 0. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, NEXT
FILE NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2837.
THANK YOU. MAYBE. OH, THERE WE
ARE. OKAY. THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU. AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK AND
COLLABORATION ON THIS BILL. AND
I'M ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT, I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2837. THIS
IS A MEASURE THAT PROTECTS LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO DEBT COLLECTION JUDGMENT BY
PRESERVING THEIR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS, ENSURING DUE PROCESS
AND ACCURACY, AND WAGE
GARNISHMENTS AND BANK LEVIES AND
PROVIDING THE AMOUNTS WRONGFULLY
SEIZED ARE RETUNED. RETURNED TO
THE CONSUMER TO BE 100% CLEAR.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL GETS
SOMEONE WHO IS IN DEBT OUT OF
PAYING THEIR DEBT. IT MERELY
PROTECTS THOSE FOR WHOM THEY DO
NOT GET NOTICE AND THEIR WAGES
ARE WRONGFULLY GARNISHED AND
EXPANDS THE PROTECTIONS FOR
CRITICAL SAVINGS THAT THEY HAVE.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS ALEXANDRA LONG, SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT COMMUNITY LEGAL
SERVICES OF EAST PALO ALTO AND
GHIRLANDA GIUDICI STAFF. I KNEW
I WAS GOING TO GET THAT WRONG. I
APOLOGIZE AND EVERYONE GETS MY
NAME WRONG. STAFF ATTORNEY AT
PUBLIC COUNSEL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FIRST WITNESS.
WOULD YOU WANT THE MIC? YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ALEX LONG
AND I PARTNER WITH A LEGAL AID
CLINIC THAT SERVES LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS IN SAN MATEO AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTIES. THE
POST-JUDGMENT FAIRNESS ACT
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEMS OF
CONSUMERS WHO ARE BEING OVER
LEVIED AND OVER GARNISHED
BECAUSE OF JUDGMENT COLLECTION.
THE PROBLEM STARTS WITH NOTICE.
JUST LAST WEEK, ONE CLIENT FROM
SAN MATEO FOUND OUT ABOUT A DEBT
THAT HAD DOUBLED WITH INTEREST
ONLY AFTER GARNISHMENT HAD
BEGUN. ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS WERE
BEING SENT TO A 13 YEAR OLD
ADDRESS. THE SAME ADDRESS ON THE
COMPLAINT. THE PROBLEM IS THEN
EXACERBATED AS CLIENTS SCRAMBLE
TO PAY BILLS WHILE LOSING MONEY
TO MISTAKE OR DELAYS IN THE
COURT. ONE SINGLE MOTHER OF FIVE
CHILDREN IN SAN JOSE, WHO WAS
WORKING TWO JOBS LOST HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS IN INCOME WHILE
WAITING 45 DAYS FOR A HEARING.
THE GARNISHMENT HAPPENED SO FAST
SHE HAD NO TIME TO PLAN, PUTTING
THEIR HOUSING AT RISK. HOW MANY
OF US COULD LIVE WITHOUT A FIFTH
OF OUR INCOME? WITH TWO DAYS
NOTICE? WHEN SHE FINALLY GOT THE
HEARING, THE JUDGE DETERMINED
SHE NEEDED ALL OF HER MONEY FROM
ONE JOB AND MOST OF IT FROM THE
SECOND JOB. HOWEVER, THE JUDGE
DID NOT ORDER THE RETURN OF THE
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS THAT HAD
ALREADY BEEN TAKEN, EVEN THOUGH
THE JUDGE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE
MOTHER AND HER CHILDREN COULD
NOT LIVE WITHOUT IT, EVEN THOUGH
THE CREDITOR WOULD STILL GET
$300 A MONTH UNTIL SHE HAD
FINISHED PAYING OFF THE DEBT.
PEOPLE CAN'T PAY IF THEY CAN'T
SURVIVE. THAT'S WHY FUNDS ARE
PROTECTED IN CLAIMS OF EXEMPTION
EXIST, HOWEVER, STILL ADDRESS
DILIGENCE AND THE UNENFORCED
OBLIGATION TO RETURN FUNDS LEADS
TO CONSUMERS HAVING NO TIME TO
PREPARE AND BEING PUSHED FURTHER
INTO DEBT. INTO DEBT WHEN JUDGES
SPLIT THE BABY, THE
POST-JUDGMENT FAIRNESS ACT
LOOKED TO LOOKS TO FIX THESE
PROBLEMS, AND FOR THAT REASON, I
URGE IN A VOTE ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS JILL AND I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT PUBLIC COUNSEL IN LOS
ANGELES. AS THE AUTHOR AND MY
COLLEAGUE MISS LONG SAID, AB
2837 WILL MAKE THE POST-JUDGMENT
DEBT COLLECTION PROCESS FAIRER
FOR INDIVIDUALS BY INCREASING
THE CHANCES THAT THEY ACTUALLY
GET NOTICE OF A GARNISHMENT OR
LEVY BEFORE THAT HAPPENS, AND
GIVING THEM TIME TO RESEARCH
THEIR OPTIONS. FIND COUNSEL AND
PRESENT TO THE COURT INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION
SO THAT THEY CAN PROTECT THE
ASSETS THAT THEY NEED TO
SURVIVE. I WANT TO FLAG THAT THE
AUTHORS TAKEN EXTENSIVE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS HERE, AND
THE COMPROMISES ON THIS BILL
BALANCE THE COMPETING INTERESTS
OF DUE PROCESS AND FAIRNESS FOR
DEBTORS AGAINST THE INTERESTS OF
THE $1.4 BILLION DEBT COLLECTION
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. I'LL
HIGHLIGHT QUICKLY THE FIVE MAIN
ASPECTS OF THE BILL AS I SAID,
FIRST, IT WILL MAKE SURE THAT
DEBTORS ACTUALLY GET NOTICE OF A
GARNISHMENT. BEFORE THAT BEGINS,
IT EXTENDS Ã EXPANDS THE TYPE
OF RETIREMENT SAVINGS THAT ARE
AUTOMATICALLY PROTECTED FROM
LEVY, AND HELPS COURTS DETERMINE
HOW MUCH OF THOSE RETIREMENT
SAVINGS SHOULD BE EXEMPT. THE
BILL GIVES DEBTORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY OR PAUSE A
GARNISHMENT OR LEVY WHILE,
WHILE, AS WE OFTEN SEE THE COURT
IS UNABLE TO SET A HEARING
WITHIN 30 DAYS, AS IS REQUIRED
BY LAW. FOURTH, THE COURT'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO RETURN
FUNDS THAT WERE IMPROPERLY TAKEN
AS MADE EXPLICIT AND FIFTH, THE
BILL ADDRESSES A LOOPHOLE THAT
BANKS HAVE USED TO TAKE MORE
MONEY THAN THAN THEY SHOULD FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY HAVE
MULTIPLE ACCOUNTS WITH ONE
INSTITUTION. SO I THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME. URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION. HELLO DANNY
KANDEL KAISER, ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL,
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION, AS WELL AS NATIONAL
CONSUMER LAW CENTER, BET LEGAL
SERVICES, CENTROLEGAL DE LA RAZA
, COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES OF
EAST PALO ALTO, CONTRA COSTA
SENIOR LEGAL ELDER. LAW AND
ADVOCACY. LEGAL AID OF MARIN,
LEGAL AID OF SAN BERNARDINO.
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
ELDERLY. LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR
SENIORS. OPEN DOOR LEGAL PUBLIC
COUNSEL. PUBLIC LAW CENTER,
RIVERSIDE LEGAL AID, SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY, ALEXANDER COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER, AND WATSONVILLE LAW
CENTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS ROBERT HARRELL
WITH THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2837, YOU MAY
SIT AT THE TABLE OR GO TO THE
MICROPHONE. WHATEVER YOU WOULD
LIKE TO DO. ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD.
SENATOR, I'M ACTUALLY JUST HERE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR I
REPRESENT ENCORE CAPITAL AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US. WE WERE OPPOSED, BUT
WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS AROUND
THE AFFIDAVIT OF VERIFICATION
PROCESS TO MAKE IT WORK
OPERATIONALLY FOR US, WE ARE NOW
NEUTRAL. SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE
TO CONVEY THAT TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. MR. MR.
CHAIRMAN, HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS, I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH THE OPPONENTS ON
THIS BILL. WE HAVE MOVED THE
BILL FORWARD. WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION LAST NIGHT, BUT
THERE ARE ISSUES REMAINING WITH
THE BILL, WHICH I WANT TO BRING
TO THE COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION. I
THINK THE BIGGEST ISSUE FOR US
IS WHAT WE CALL THE LOOKBACK. SO
BASICALLY CALIFORNIA LAW ALLOWS
A CONSUMER TO FILE WHAT'S KNOWN
AS A CLAIM OF EXEMPTION. WE'VE
EXPANDED THE CLAIM OF EXEMPTION
OVER THE YEARS THANKS TO SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI, WORK ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND, THIS BILL
APPARENTLY ALLOWS SOMEONE TO
COME IN AND TELL THE COURT THAT
THEY WERE ENTITLED TO A CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION. THEY DIDN'T FILE IT.
AND NOW THEY WANT THE COURT TO
ORDER THE MONEY BACK ON A WAGE
GARNISHMENT. WELL, THE BILL IS
UNCLEAR, AND WE BELIEVE
UNWORKABLE IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
PROCESS WOULD WORK, BECAUSE ONCE
THE WAGES ARE GARNISHMENT
GARNISHED, THE MONEY HAS BEEN
TAKEN BY THE EMPLOYER. IT GOES
BACK TO THE CREDITOR. IT GOES
BACK TO THE COLLECTION AGENCY.
SO THE BILL IS UNCLEAR ON WHO
EXACTLY IS SUPPOSED TO PAY BACK.
THIS WAGE GARNISHMENT
RETROACTIVELY. WE HAVE INDICATED
TO THE SPONSORS AND THE AUTHORS
THAT IF THERE'S A CHANGE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SOMEONE IS NOW
QUALIFIED FOR A CLAIM OF
EXEMPTION, THEN WE'RE FINE WITH
THAT. BUT TO BE ABLE TO
RETROACTIVELY GO BACK AFTER A
WAGE GARNISHMENT, THE MONEY IS
GONE. AND WHO'S GOING TO PAY IT?
SO WE THINK THAT PART OF THE
BILL REMAINS UNWORKABLE. I DO
WANT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT WAGE GARNISHMENT IS A
POST-JUDGMENT REMEDY, WHICH
MEANS THAT SOMEONE JUST DOESN'T
WAKE UP AND THEIR WAGE
GARNISHMENT, IT MEANS THAT THEY
OWED A BILL. IT WENT INTO
COLLECTION THE CREDITOR TRIED TO
COLLECT ON THE BILL. THE
CREDITOR DETERMINED THAT THERE
WAS AN ABILITY TO PAY. THEY WENT
TO COURT. THEY GOT NOTICE THAT
THE ITEM WAS IN COURT. THE COURT
ISSUED A JUDGMENT. THE JUDGMENT
CREDITOR THEN TRIED TO COLLECT
AGAIN, AND ONLY AFTER, THROUGH
THAT ENTIRE PROCESS. YOU ARE
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. COMMITTEE CHAIRPERSON AND
COMMITTEE GRETCHEN LICHTENBERGER
. I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
CHAIRPERSON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JUDGMENT
PROFESSIONALS, AND WE STAND
OPPOSED RESPECTFULLY AND THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
THE COMMUNICATIONS WE WOULD LIKE
IN SECTIONS ONE, FOUR, FIVE,
SIX, AND 12 TO ADD TWO LITTLE
WORDS. BECAUSE THIS WAS A RECENT
AMENDMENT AND IT REFERENCES
PERSONAL DEBT, HOW IS A COURT
GOING TO KNOW IF THE JUDGMENT IS
BASED ON PERSONAL DEBT? SO WE'D
LIKE IT TO SAY INSTEAD OF WHERE
WHERE THE JUDGMENT UPON WHICH
THE WRIT IS ISSUED IS FOR
PERSONAL DEBT, WE WANT IT ADDED
WHERE IT SAYS THAT THE JUDGMENT
WHERE THE JUDGMENT UPON WHICH
THE WRIT IS ISSUED STATES IT IS
FOR PERSONAL DEBT. IN OTHER
WORDS, THE COURT WILL LOOK TO
THE JUDGMENT TO DETERMINE IT. IT
WON'T HAVE TO BE AN ISSUE FOR
THE COURTS TO WASTE A LOT OF
THEIR TIME, AND LAST YEAR, THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AMENDED THEIR
JUDGMENT. SO THERE'S A CHECKBOX.
SO NOW IT'S BECAUSE THAT
CHECKBOX IS THERE BECAUSE OF
SENATOR SKINNER'S BILL AND
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE SIMPLE
FOR THE COURTS TO LOOK AT THE
JUDGMENT. SO WE WOULD JUST LIKE
IT CORRECTED TO SAY, AMENDING
THE JUDGMENT. I MEAN, AS IT
STATES IN THE JUDGMENT. AND I WE
CONCUR WITH THE CLAWBACK PERIOD
OF 12 MONTHS. THAT'S A VIOLATION
OF THE JUDGMENT CREDITORS DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS, BECAUSE THE
CLAIM OF EXEMPTION HEARING IS
FOR A RECENT LEVY. THE COURT
WOULD HAVE NO JURISDICTION TO
LOOK BACK 12 MONTHS, AND THERE'S
NO REASON IN SECTIONS ONE AND
FOUR FOR THE COURT TO STAY A
LEVY BECAUSE HEARING IS EXTENDED
BEYOND 30 DAYS. THE LEVY OFFICER
IS HOLDING THOSE FUNDS AS THE
MEASURE IT SAYS ITSELF IN
SECTION SIX. THE FUNDS AREN'T
GOING ANYWHERE. SO THAT WOULD BE
A WASTE OF JUDICIAL RESOURCES
FOR ANYBODY TO DO A NOTICE. AND,
THE IN SECTION THREE, THE NOTICE
TO THE JUDGMENT CREDITOR, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SHOULD BE SERVED
CONCURRENTLY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. JUST JUST A NOTE, IS THAT
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF THE
DELINEATION OF PERSONAL DEBT,
WE'VE NOT HEARD THIS SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT. I DON'T KNOW IF THE
AUTHOR HAS OR NOT, BUT I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
AUTHOR. I'LL ASK THE AUTHOR TO
COMMENT ON MR. BERG'S
SUGGESTIONS AS WELL. IN YOUR
CLOSE, IF THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
YOU. YES, IT IS GREAT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO,
AB 2837, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, CLIFF COSTA, TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CREDITORS BAR ASSOCIATION, WE'D
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THOSE MADE BY MR. BERG IN
THE CALIFORNIA COLLECTORS.
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATION. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO HAVE THEM. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MELANIE
CUEVAS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
TIM LYNCH, ON BEHALF OF THE
RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL,
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
COLLECTORS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE. IS THERE A MOTION SENATOR
DROSSOS MOVED THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. SO MOVED BY BAUER-KAHAN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT? THANK
YOU MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. OKAY, I
THINK YOU CAN HEAR ME. YES. NO,
I APPRECIATE THIS WAS ALSO THE
FIRST TIME I HEARD THIS. SO WE
WILL ABSOLUTELY TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT. AND CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
AS WE HAVE. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PROTECTING INDIVIDUALS,
BUT ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT ONE
NEEDS TO PAY THEIR DEBTS. SO
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE. AND WE'LL CONTINUE
TO THE LOOKBACK PERIOD IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE. WE HAVE HAD
MANY CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT,
BUT WE WILL CONTINUE ALL
CONVERSATIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE YOUR, AMENABILITY TO
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION SOME
OF THE COMMENTS HERE TODAY. ALL
RIGHT. MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL, IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GROSSO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL, THIS IS AB
2837, AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED, BERG, I AM BERG, I
WILK ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
LAIRD. NILO. NILO. NO. ROTH
STERN. WAHAB. YOU HAVE 3 TO 1 SO
FAR. MEMBERS MISSING 3 TO 1. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT
ON CALL. I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS HERE
BEFORE WE MOVE TO YOUR NEXT
BILL, FIRST IS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BREAK AT NOON, OR JUST BEFORE
NOON IN ORDER TO ALLOW MEMBERS
TO ATTEND CAUCUS TODAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GET AS FAR AS WE CAN
UNTIL NOON OR JUST BEFORE NOON,
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO BREAK
THAT'S ANNOUNCEMENT NUMBER ONE,
ANNOUNCEMENT NUMBER TWO IS AT
130. WE HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS, WITH SOME MEMBER WICKS
BILL CONCERNING NEWSPAPER
PRESERVATION PRESERVATION ACT
AND THEN WE WILL PROCEED WITH
OUR NORMAL AGENDA. AND THEN
ANNOUNCEMENT NUMBER THREE, THAT
I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE IS THAT
NEXT WEEK, ON JULY THE SECOND,
WE HAVE A ROBUST AGENDA AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING IN
REVERSE ORDER. WE'RE GOING TO BE
STARTING WITH THE END OF THE
ALPHABET AND MOVING TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE ALPHABET. SO,
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN, YOU MAY WANT
TO FOCUS ON THE KHN PART. SO
YEAH, OKAY. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
BILL. NUMBER EIGHT, BILL NUMBER
AB 2877. I WILL ALSO URGE MR.
ZUBER TO BE FAST NEXT WEEK,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 2877. THIS IS A MEASURE WHICH
SIMPLY RESTRICTS THE ABILITIES
OF COMPANIES TO TRAIN AI SYSTEMS
USING THE PERSONAL DATA OF OUR
KIDS WITHOUT CONSENT OF THE
PARENTS, AS YOU ALL ARE AWARE,
AI IS DEVELOPING INCREDIBLY
RAPIDLY. THIS STATE HAS PASSED
INCREDIBLY ROBUST LAWS THAT
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF CHILDREN
AND THEIR DATA ACROSS THE
INTERNET. BUT THE BILL WAS NOT
WRITTEN WITH THE ANTICIPATION OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. AND SO
THIS BILL MERELY EXPANDS THE
PROTECTIONS OF PERSONAL DATA TO
CHILDREN UNDER 16, AS IT RELATES
TO THE TRAINING OF AI TOOLS.
WITH ME TODAY IS ROBBIE TORNEY,
PROGRAM MANAGER FROM THE RATINGS
AND FAMILY TEAM AT COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. THANK YOU. AND I ASSUME
YOU'RE ACCEPTING OUR. YES.
SORRY, SENATOR. HAPPILY. ACCEPT
YOUR AMENDMENTS HAPPILY. OKAY
GREAT. THANKS. OKAY, GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR. AND THE
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ROBBIE TORNEY, AND I'M
THE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR RATINGS
AND FAMILY AT COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. I'M ALSO A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT, ACTUALLY, IN THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DISTRICT AND A
FORMER EDUCATOR OF OVER 15
YEARS. COMMON SENSE MEDIA IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2877, AND WE
ARE THANKFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. WE'RE ALSO
THANKFUL TO THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL AT
COMMON SENSE MEDIA, WE RECOGNIZE
BOTH THE BENEFITS AND THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH AI. WE SUPPORT
AB 2877 BECAUSE IT TAKES A
RESPONSIBLE APPROACH TO MANAGING
THESE RISKS BY LIMITING HOW
MINORS DATA CAN BE USED TO TRAIN
AI. THIS BILL HELPS PROTECT
VULNERABLE YOUNG PEOPLE WHILE
STILL ALLOWING FOR INNOVATION.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES A
SIGNIFICANT GAP IN OUR CURRENT
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS. WITH THE
RISE OF AI DIRECTED TO OUR KIDS
AND TEENS, AB 2877 IS A CRITICAL
STEP IN SAFEGUARDING THEIR
INFORMATION. CHILDREN'S DATA
SHOULD NOT BE USED OR EXPLOITED
WITHOUT PROPER CONSENT. AI
SYSTEMS ARE POWERFUL TOOLS THAT
LEARN FROM THE DATA THAT THEY
ARE EXPOSED TO, ALLOWING
DEVELOPERS TO USE PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM CHILDREN
WITHOUT RESTRICTIONS POSES
SIGNIFICANT RISKS, INCLUDING
MISUSE OF DATA, INVASION OF
PRIVACY, AND CREATION OF BIASED
OR HARMFUL AI MODELS. THIS BILL
ALIGNS WITH AND ENHANCES THE
PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED BY THE
CCPA. THESE PRIVACY RIGHTS WERE
ENSHRINED BY CALIFORNIA VOTERS
INTO LAW, BUT THIS OCCURRED
BEFORE WIDESPREAD USE OF AI IN
CONSUMER AND EDUCATION APPS AND
PRODUCTS. LUCKILY, THE VOTERS
MADE EXPLICITLY CLEAR THEIR
SUPPORT OF FUTURE AMENDMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN PRIVACY BY
PROHIBITING THE USE OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION FROM MINORS FOR AI
TRAINING WITHOUT EXPLICIT
CONSENT FROM A PARENT OF A MINOR
UNDER 13, OR FROM THE TÍNH
THEMSELVES. AB 2877 STRENGTHENS
OUR COMMITMENT TO PROVIDING
PROTECTING THE PRIVACY OF YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS. IN CONCLUSION, AB
2877 IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN'S PERSONAL INFORMATION
IS USED RESPONSIBLY AND
ETHICALLY IN DEVELOPING AI, AND
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO SAFEGUARD THE
PRIVACY AND WELL-BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S YOUTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR AT LEAST
THE PRIMARY SUPPORT, IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF 2877 AB, 2877,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AND GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. I
JEZIMA WITH THE TRANSPARENCY
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MIKEY HØI WITH COMMON
SENSE MEDIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE IN
SUPPORT, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE OPPOSED
TO AB 2877, YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE OR THE TABLE,
WHICHEVER YOU CHOOSE. AND THANK
YOU, CHAIR MEMBERS, AND THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR WITH CAL
CHAMBER RESPECTFULLY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB 2877, IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT ANY REGULATIONS,
IF I TAKE A RISK BASED APPROACH
AND FOCUS ON THE USES OR OUTPUTS
OF TECHNOLOGY, AS OPPOSED TO
REGULATING THE TECHNOLOGY
ITSELF. UNFORTUNATELY, BY
LIMITING INPUTS, THIS BILL DOES
THE OPPOSITE, INTERFERING WITH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF. AT ITS CORE,
THE BILL SEEMS ROOTED IN THE
ASSUMPTION THAT IT IS INHERENTLY
HARMFUL TO USE THE INFORMATION
OF A MINOR TO TRAIN AI, AND THAT
PII MUST BE BOTH DE-IDENTIFIED
AND AGGREGATED TO BE ADEQUATELY
PRIVACY PROTECTIVE. WE DISAGREE
ON BOTH PRINCIPLES AND HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS THAT THE
IMPACT OF THE BILL WILL BE THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT IS INTENDED
HARMING MINORS BY UNDERMINING
THE ABILITY OF DEVELOPERS TO
PROPERLY TRAIN AI TO AVOID
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH IN
CRITICAL AREAS SUCH AS HEALTH
CARE, EDUCATION, ONLINE SAFETY
AND MORE. ACCESS TO DATA
SPECIFIC TO CHILDREN AND TEENS
IS ESSENTIAL TO DEVELOP TOOLS TO
PROVIDE THEM THE UNIQUE SUPPORT
FOR RISKS AND CHALLENGES
SPECIFIC TO THEIR AGE GROUPS,
INDIVIDUALIZED DATA CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCE THE
PERFORMANCE. PERSONALIZATION AND
ACCURACY OF AN AI MODEL. STATED
ANOTHER WAY EFFECTIVE TOOLS TO
ADDRESS SUCH SERIOUS CONCERNS
CANNOT BE BUILT ON THE DATA
ASSOCIATED WITH ADULTS ONLY,
SUCH LIMITATIONS MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO TRAIN AI AND AMONG
OTHER TO, AMONG OTHER THINGS, BE
MORE PRIVACY PROTECTIVE OR TO
AVOID CERTAIN, OUTCOMES SUCH AS
BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION. ON THIS
POINT, WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS
AN AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION, SO WE WILL BE
REVIEWING THAT. NONETHELESS, WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT LIMITATIONS
ON TRAINING AI IS A NECESSARY
STEP FROM A PRIVACY PERSPECTIVE.
KIDS HAVE SOME OF THE STRONGEST
PROTECTIONS UNDER THE CCPA,
RIGHTFULLY SO, TO PROTECT THEIR
INTERESTS AND DATA EXCUSE ME AS
SUCH, GIVEN OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE IMPACT THAT THE BILL WILL
HAVE ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF TAKING A RISK
BASED APPROACH, WE MUST OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. JASON
SCHMELTZER, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET, ASSOCIATE, MY COMMENTS
WITH CAL CHAMBER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHERS OPPOSED TO, AB
2877 SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE, SENATOR ALLEN.
OKAY. I'M AN ENORMOUS FAN OF THE
AUTHOR, ENORMOUS FAN OF THE
SPONSOR, AND I MY CHALLENGE HERE
IS IF WE COULD SORT OF IF WE
WERE RULING THE WORLD AND WE
COULD, PASS A LAW LIKE THIS THAT
WOULD IMPACT EVERYWHERE, I'D BE
ALL FOR IT. I THINK I THINK THAT
THE GOAL OF THE BILL IS A GREAT
ONE. THE, THE CONCERN I HAVE,
YOU KNOW, I THINK SOME OF THE
BILLS WHEN WE CAN, WHEN WE HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REGULATE THE,
ACTIVITY, A BUSINESS ACTIVITY
WITHIN THE STATE, WHERE WE'LL
ACTUALLY PROVOKE A CHANGE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO DO BUSINESS
IN THE STATE. I'M MUCH MORE
AMENABLE THIS I WHAT I, WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS THAT
THIS HAS TO DO WITH WHERE THE
LEARNING TAKES PLACE. RIGHT? SO
THIS SEEMS SO EASY TO OFFSHORE.
IF WE PASS A BILL LIKE THIS, IT
JUST MEANS THAT THESE COMPANIES
CAN DO THIS. SO I'M YOU'RE
SHAKING YOUR HEAD, WHICH IS
GREAT BECAUSE I LOVE TO VOTE FOR
THE BILL. SO TELL ME MORE ABOUT
WHY I MIGHT BE WRONG. YES. SO
IT'S THE DATA. SO NO MATTER
WHERE A COMPANY IS, WHERE THE
LEARNING HAPPENS, THEY MAY NOT
USE THE DATA OF A CALIFORNIA
CHILD. SO IF IT IS A BRITISH
BASED COMPANY FOR EXAMPLE, OR A
FRENCH FRANCE HAS A VERY BIG AI
COMPANY, THEY CANNOT TAKE OUR
CHILDREN'S DATA FROM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND USE IT TO TRAIN.
YEAH, YEAH. JUST TO ADD ON TO
THAT, THIS BILL DOES NOT
ACTUALLY OPPOSE THE USE OF
INDIVIDUALIZED DATA. AND IN
FACT, IT RECOGNIZES, AS THE
CHAMBER SPOKE, THAT IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO HAVE THAT DATA
INCLUDED IN TRAINING. IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES CLEAR PERMISSION TO BE
GIVEN, CONSENT TO BE GIVEN FROM
THE PARENT OF A MINOR UNDER 13,
OR FROM THE TEEN THEMSELVES,
BEFORE THAT DATA IS USED TO
TRAIN THE MODEL. THESE MODELS
ARE COMPLICATED AND THEY'RE NOT
WELL UNDERSTOOD. THE OUTPUT DATA
IN MANY CASES CAN BE USED TO
PRODUCE INPUT DATA, SO IF THAT
DATA HAS PERSONALLY IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION ASSOCIATED WITH IT,
WE COULD BE DISCLOSING
INFORMATION ABOUT MINORS TO THE
WORLD. SO IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
TO AGGREGATE AND DE-IDENTIFY THE
INFORMATION WHEN USED FOR
TRAINING, EXCEPT IN CERTAIN
CASES AS AS AMENDED, IN ORDER TO
KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE SAFE. WE DON'T
WANT SOMETHING LIKE CHATGPT
SPITTING OUT IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT A YOUNG PERSON
AS A RESULT OF PROMPT
ENGINEERING. IF I MAY, ONE THING
TO NOTE ON THIS IS THE SALE OF
DATA. NOW FOR THE TRAINING OF AI
IS A BIG BUSINESS. PEOPLE ARE
MAKING A LOT OF MONEY SELLING
OUR DATA TO AI MODELS TO TRAIN
THESE MODELS, SO WHAT IS
HAPPENING NOW IS YOU HAVE
BROKERS SELLING CALIFORNIANS
DATA TO PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
WORLD TO TRAIN THEIR AI MODELS.
AND WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS, YOU
CAN'T DO THAT WITH KIDS DATA
UNLESS THEY HAVE CONSENT. AND
WE'VE ALREADY SAID THAT IN MANY
ARENAS. BUT I THINK IT'S CLEAR
THAT THAT IS A VALUE OF THIS
LEGISLATURE, AND IT SHOULD
EXTEND TO THE SALE OF DATA FOR
PURPOSES OF TRAINING AS WELL.
THANK YOU, MR. ALLEN. NO, IT'S
INTERESTING. I MEAN, IT RAISES
SOME INTERESTING LEGAL ARGUMENTS
ABOUT KIND OF CROSS-BORDER.
BUSINESS PRACTICE. BUT, HAVE YOU
I MEAN, I'M FLIPPING THROUGH THE
ANALYSIS. I, YOU KNOW, I WISH
I'D READ EVERYTHING WORD FOR
WORD. THIS IS THE CHALLENGE OF
50. I'D BE IMPRESSED. AGENDA
BUT, BUT OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I
MEAN, AS LONG AS IT'S NOT, I,
YOU KNOW, I, I THINK I WAS
INITIALLY JUST CONCERNED THAT BY
PROHIBITING A CERTAIN TYPE OF
LEARNING AI LEARNING THAT WOULD
HAPPEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA, ALL
IT DOES IS JUST SEND THAT
BUSINESS OUT OF STATE WITHOUT
PROVIDING A CONCOMITANT PRIVACY
BENEFIT. BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE I
WAS WASN'T THINKING ABOUT IT. I
WASN'T FULLY AWARE OF HOW THE
BILL HAD BEEN FRAMED. SO, I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE, IS THERE A MOTION?
SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE BILL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, JUST TO
CONCLUDE ON THE POINT THAT
SENATOR ALLEN MADE, YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THE SENSITIVITY OF
THE SPECIAL THE GOVERNOR HAS
AROUND PROTECTING THIS INDUSTRY
AND NOT ONLY JUST FOR THE
ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA, BUT ALSO
WE KNOW THAT THE SAFEST AI TOOLS
ARE GOING TO BE THE ONES BUILT
IN OUR COUNTRY. AND SO IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE IN
OUR STATE. AND SO IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
KEEP THOSE BUSINESSES HERE. IT'S
A VALUE I HAVE. I DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IMPEDES THAT. BUT WE'LL
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT. THANK
YOU. YEAH. THE CURRENT BUDGET
CRISIS HAS MADE ME ACUTELY AWARE
OF HOW DEPENDENT WE ARE ON THE
TECH INDUSTRY TO PAY FOR ALL THE
PROGRAMS WE LIKE AS A BAY AREA
RESIDENT, I UNDERSTAND. THANK
YOU ALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, IT'S BEEN
A MOTION BY SENATOR BARRASSO.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MRS. FILE, ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB 2877. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE. WILK. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
ASHBY. CABALLERO. GRASSO GRASSO.
AYE. LAIRD. NHIÀU. AYE MILO.
AYE. ROTH. STERN WAHAB. FOUR TO
0 OR 0. GOING TO PUT THAT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT I SEE THAT WE
ARE BLESSED WITH A PLETHORA OF
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HERE. SO
JUST JUST SO YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO NEXT TO FILE NUMBER
NINE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THEN TO FILE, NUMBER TEN
WITH A SIMILAR BURNER, AND THEN
TO IF THE AUTHOR SHOWS FILE
NUMBER 11. SO. ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL HOLD YOU TO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. THANK YOU, CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING OUR
ELECTIONS AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
WHILE OUR STATE HAS STRONG ANTI
INTIMIDATION PROTECTIONS, THERE
IS A CONCERNING TREND GROWING
ACROSS OUR NATION OF
INTIMIDATION AND THREATS AGAINST
ELECTION WORKERS. AND CALIFORNIA
IS NOT IMMUNE DUE TO THE
ALARMING RISE IN THREATS AND
ATTACKS AGAINST ELECTION AND
POLL WORKERS, THERE HAS BEEN A
NATIONWIDE EXODUS OF WORKERS
FROM THE JOB, INCLUDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN 2024. HELLO. IN
THE 2024 ELECTION, 44% OF VOTERS
IN CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE A
DIFFERENT ELECTION ADMINISTRATOR
THAN THEY HAD IN THE 2020
ELECTION. THIS BILL, AB 2642,
THE PEACE ACT, WOULD STRENGTHEN
AND SUPPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING ANTI INTIMIDATION LAWS
BY PROVIDING EXPLICIT CIVIL
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH ELECTION
WORKERS AND VOTERS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL WOULD
CREATE AN IMPORTANT PRESUMPTION
THAT PEOPLE WHO OPENLY CARRY
FIREARMS AROUND ELECTION
ACTIVITIES DO SO FOR THE PURPOSE
OF INTIMIDATION. THIS BILL HAS
ZERO REGISTERED OPPOSITION. MANY
OF MY ELECTIONS BILLS HAVE
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. THIS ONE
DOES NOT, WITH ME TODAY I'M
JOINED BY JESSE OJEDA. THE STATE
POLICY ATTORNEY WITH THE
GIFFORDS LAW CENTER, AND CATHY
DARLING ALLEN, THE COUNTY CLERK
AND REGISTRAR OF VOTERS FOR
SHASTA COUNTY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. I CONCUR WITH YOU.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY OPPOSITION.
SO GO AHEAD. I HAVE THE MIC, SO
I WILL GO. CATHY DARLING ALLEN
I'M ACTUALLY THE RECENTLY
RETIRED SHASTA COUNTY CLERK AND
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS, I WANTED TO
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY, TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL VERY STRONGLY.
I'M ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD
OF THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION, WHO ALSO SUPPORTS
THIS BILL. I SERVED MY VOTERS IN
SHASTA COUNTY FOR OVER 20 YEARS,
RETIRING RECENTLY DUE TO HEALTH
CONCERNS BROUGHT ABOUT PRIMARILY
BY THE STRESS AND PRESSURE OF A
TOXIC POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT. I'M
GRATEFUL THIS BILL IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND THAT IT HAS URGENCY,
PROVISIONS, THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT THAT ELECTION
ADMINISTRATORS ARE OPERATING IN
IS VASTLY DIFFERENT FROM THAT
JUST A DECADE AGO. AS YOU ARE
ALL AWARE, WE HAVE ENTERED INTO
A TIME WHERE THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DISPARAGE THE
PROCESS OF CONDUCTING ELECTIONS
WHEN THEY DO NOT LIKE THE
OUTCOME. THIS BEHAVIOR IS
PROFOUNDLY UN-AMERICAN AND HAS
BEEN MODELED BY CANDIDATES AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS, VALIDATING
BAD BEHAVIOR FOR FOLKS
INTERESTED IN POLITICS AT ALL
LEVELS. IN SHASTA COUNTY, WE NOW
HAVE ORGANIZED AND LOCALLY
SANCTIONED ELECTION MEDDLING. IT
IS BORDERLINE INTERFERENCE, AND
THE FOLKS WHO ARE PERPETRATING
IT ARE FROM A VARIETY OF
BACKGROUNDS AND SOCIOECONOMIC
GROUPS. THE GROUP IS SMALL BUT
LOUD, INAPPROPRIATE IN THEIR
DEPORTMENT AND CARRIAGE, AND
GENERALLY BADLY BEHAVED IN
CIVIC, PUBLIC SETTINGS. I
PERSONALLY, ALONG WITH MY PUBLIC
FACING STAFF, HAVE BEEN ON THE
RECEIVING END OF UNCOUNTABLE,
UNPLEASANT, INTENTIONALLY
INTIMIDATING CONVERSATIONS. THE
ONGOING PUBLIC HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION WILL RESULT IN
RADICALIZING OTHERS. WE HAVE
ALREADY SEEN THIS HAPPENING WITH
SOME OF OUR LOCAL VOTERS WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY PARTNERS, THOSE
FOLKS HAVE BEEN RADICALIZED AND
ARE NO LONGER WILLING TO WORK
WITH US. LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS SUBJECT TO THE SAME
ENVIRONMENT THAT I AM. NO
CHARGES HAVE BEEN FILED IN
SHASTA COUNTY, BUT THE PEACE ACT
WOULD ALLOW MY SUCCESSORS TO
HAVE THE ASSURANCE THAT THEY CAN
BRING ACTION THEMSELVES IN THE
EVENT THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOES NOT. IF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM
FAILS TO PROVIDE A DETERRENT FOR
BAD BEHAVIOR, WE CANNOT EXPECT
BEHAVIOR TO CHANGE. REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR YES
VOTE ON AB 2642. THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I HAVE OBSERVED
YOUR WORK AND YOUR COURAGE, BOTH
MORAL AND PHYSICAL, IN SHASTA
COUNTY, AND I CONGRATULATE YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN UMBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TODAY. MY NAME IS JESSE OJEDA,
AND I AM A STATE POLICY ATTORNEY
WITH GIFFORDS. AND I AM ALSO AN
ELECTION WORKER MYSELF. I'M HERE
TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
2642, THE PEACE ACT. THIS BILL
IS ESSENTIAL FOR PROTECTING
EVERY VOTER'S RIGHT TO CAST A
BALLOT AND ENSURING ELECTION
WORKERS ARE FREE FROM
INTERFERENCE AND INTIMIDATION.
RECENTLY WE HAVE SEEN A
DISTURBING INCREASE IN THREATS
AND VIOLENCE TARGETING VOTERS,
ELECTION OFFICIALS AND WORKERS.
AS MY FELLOW SPEAKER MENTIONED,
THIS ESCALATION IS DRIVEN BY AN
AGGRESSIVE PRO-GUN MOVEMENT AND
DISINFORMATION, WHICH UNDERMINES
OUR ELECTIONS INTEGRITY. MODELED
ON THE FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS
ACT, THE PEACE ACT STRENGTHENS
STATE ANTI ANTI INTIMIDATION
LAWS BY PROVIDING CIVIL
PROTECTIONS FOR VOTERS AND
ELECTION WORKERS. IMPORTANTLY,
IT ALSO CREATES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT AN INDIVIDUAL
IS DE FACTO INTIMIDATING WHEN
CARRYING A FIREARM AND
INTERACTING WITH A VOTER OR
ELECTION OFFICIAL. THIS
ULTIMATELY CREATES AN EASIER
MEANS OF RELIEFS FOR PLAINTIFFS
LIKE KATHY, WHO EXPERIENCED SUCH
UNLAWFUL INTIMIDATION, WHICH HAS
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME
INCREASINGLY PREVALENT. I WANT
TO BE CLEAR, THOUGH, THAT THE
PRESUMPTION IS NOT SUBJECT TO A
SECOND AMENDMENT ANALYSIS
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT RESTRICT A
PERSON FROM BUYING, USING, OR
CARRYING A FIREARM FOR SELF
DEFENSE. CALIFORNIA HAS LONG LED
THE NATION IN SENSIBLE GUN
REFORM AND ELECTION SECURITY,
AND GIVEN RISING POLITICAL
POLARIZATION AND GUN VIOLENCE,
WE MUST CONTINUE ENACTING LAWS
LIKE THE PEACE ACT TO ENSURE
EVERY CALIFORNIAN CAN
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
WITHOUT FEAR. FOR THESE REASONS,
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB 2642.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2642, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AND THE
SECOND WILL TURN TO OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR UMBERG AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, BRIAN
MIRAMONTEZ WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, ANNE MARIE TROUT, ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, DOCTOR
SHIRLEY WEBER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. DIANA HONIG, VOLUNTEER WITH
MOMS DEMAND ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YARD UDALL,
VOLUNTEER MOM, MOMS DEMAND
ACTION FROM SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CASSANDRA
WHETSTONE, VOLUNTEER FROM FOLSOM
WITH MOMS DEMAND ACTION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AUBREY
RODRIGUEZ, A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH ACLU COLLECTION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. KIM ALEXANDER,
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTER FOUNDATION. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY CHAU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, ANDY BIRNBAUM WITH
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, LAURA
LANE, ON BEHALF OF EVERYTOWN FOR
GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, REBECCA MARCUS, ON
BEHALF OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S NOW, SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
IN SUPPORT, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2642, PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. YES, SENATOR NHIÀU.
IT IS A FELONY OFFENSE TO
INTERFERE IN ANY MANNER WITH
ELECTION OFFICIALS ALREADY, AND
THERE'S SOME MENTION OF IT, BUT
I HAVEN'T HEARD OF A LOT OF
EXAMPLES OF THIS IN CALIFORNIA.
HEARD SOME THINGS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND BY THE WAY, I
WILL ECHO THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
ABOUT, THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU DO
UP IN SHASTA COUNTY. I'M SURE
THAT WAS DIFFICULT. AND SO HATS
OFF TO YOU FOR THAT. BUT THE
FELONY OFFENSE EXISTING, AND I
JUST DON'T SEE A PLETHORA OF
THESE SORTS OF INCIDENTS AROUND
CALIFORNIA. I'M WONDERING WHY
YOU FEEL THAT IT'S NEEDED HERE.
YEAH, I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION.
AND I'LL LET MY WITNESS, RESPOND
IF SHE WOULD LIKE. BUT JUST A
COUPLE OF INSTANCES IN
CALIFORNIA, AS WAS MENTIONED IN
SHASTA COUNTY ELECTIONS,
OFFICIALS ENCOUNTERED
ENCOUNTERED OPEN HOSTILITY AND
THREATS FROM A SMALL BUT VOCAL
GROUP OF ACTIVISTS WHO CLAIM
CONCERN ABOUT VOTER FRAUD. THESE
ACTIVISTS HAVE PHYSICALLY
CROWDED ELECTION WORKERS
PERFORMING THEIR OFFICIAL DUTIES
AND VISITED VOTER HOMES WHILE
CLAIMING TO BE PART OF A, QUOTE,
OFFICIAL TASK FORCE IN NEVADA
COUNTY. THE REGISTRAR ELECT HAD
TO TAKE OUT A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST RESIDENTS WHO HARASSED
HER, PUSHING THEIR WAY INTO HER
OFFICE AND ASSAULTING A STAFFER.
AND IN SAN LUIS OBISPO, AN ASIAN
AMERICAN COUNTY CLERK RECORDER
WAS ACCUSED OF BEING A MEMBER OF
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY FOR
REFUSING TO CONDUCT AN ILLEGAL
AUDIT OF THE 2020 ELECTION, AND
THIS THIS, COUNTY CLERK RECORDER
STATED THAT THE ACCUSATION
MONTHS OF HARASSMENT, NATIONWIDE
THREATS AGAINST ELECTION
OFFICIALS, AND INCREASE IN
ANTI-ASIAN HATE CRIMES LED HIM
TO FEEL CONCERNED FOR HIS SAFETY
AND HIS FAMILY'S SAFETY, SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
INSTANCES FROM CALIFORNIA OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS, DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPOUND. I
THINK THAT, THE BEST ANSWER I
CAN GIVE YOU IS THAT, THE ENTIRE
YEAR OF 2023, IN MY OFFICE WE
SPENT RESPONDING TO, COMPLETELY
FALSE ALLEGATIONS AND THIS
INCREASING SECURITY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THE VERY TOP OF OUR MIND.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN SPENDING OUR RESOURCES AND
TIME DOING. AND INSTEAD, WE WERE
RESPONDING TO A WHOLE HOST OF
INTIMIDATION AND HARASSMENT
TACTICS. THE MORE THE STRONGER
THAT THE LAWS ARE TO DISCOURAGE
ANY KIND OF INTERFERENCE, YOU'RE
100% CORRECT WHEN YOU SAY THAT
INTERFERING WITH ELECTION
OFFICIAL IS A FELONY. I AM
CHALLENGED TO REMEMBER THAT LAW
BEING, PROSECUTE ANY
PROSECUTIONS RESULTING FROM THAT
LAW, IN MY 20 YEARS OF SERVICE
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE, NOT JUST
IN SHASTA COUNTY. SO I THINK
THAT THE STRONGER OUR LAWS ARE,
THAT'S HOW OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
WORKS, RIGHT? THE LAWS ARE A
DETERRENT TO PREVENT PEOPLE. I'M
NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE FOLKS WHO
I KNOW IN MY COMMUNITY THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT ELECTIONS. I'M
WORRIED ABOUT THE PEOPLE THEY
ARE RADICALIZING WITH THEIR
MESSAGES THAT ARE FALSE, AND
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE I DON'T
KNOW. AND I DON'T TRUST. AND I
WANT THE STAFF WHO STILL WORKS
AT THE ELECTION DEPARTMENT TO BE
PROTECTED. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL HELP WITH THAT.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? IS THERE A MOTION?
MOTION. AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL. I THINK I DON'T THINK IT'S
JUST A MATTER ONLY OF HOW MANY
INCIDENTS, BUT IT'S THE IMPACT
THAT EACH INCIDENT HAS ON A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, YOU HEAR A
STORY, ABOUT SOMETHING GOING ON
WITH SOMEONE BEING INTIMIDATED
OR FEARFUL, AND THAT GETS OUT.
AND THAT'S THE LAST THING WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PRESERVE OUR
OUR DEMOCRACY. THERE SHOULD BE
NO FEAR, AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
BEEN TOO MANY YEARS BEFORE THAT
YOU WOULD NEVER HEAR A STORY
LIKE THAT. SO I THINK IT'S JUST
HAVING A MUCH BIGGER
REPERCUSSIONS THAN JUST THAN
JUST THE NUMBER OF INCIDENTS.
BUT RATHER THE IMPACT THAT IT
HAS BEYOND THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS. SO I PROBABLY WILL
THANK. SENATOR GRASSO HAS MOVED
THE BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, SENATOR? I MEAN, EXCUSE
ME, ASSEMBLYMEMBER, I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION. I REALLY WANT
TO THANK KATHY FOR HER HER
CAREER, AND THAT'S ALL ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS AND ELECTION WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA. THEY DON'T CARE
WHO YOU VOTE FOR. THEY JUST WANT
TO AID IN YOUR ABILITY TO VOTE.
IF YOU SHOULD BE VOTING. AND,
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WITHOUT, INTIMIDATION AND
THREATS AND COERCION. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE. RESPECTFULLY, THAT'S WHERE
I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. IT'S BEEN MOVED. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FINAL ITEM NUMBER
9AB2642. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
A UMBERG I WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. I LAIRD. NEELO. NO.
MILO. NO ROTH. STERN. 3 TO 1
ONE. WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERNER, I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
GOING TO GET WE'RE GOING TO DO
YOUR BILL TO ITS CONCLUSION. I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO ANOTHER BILL BEFORE WE HAVE
TO BREAK FOR CAUCUS, SO. WELL,
THEN I'LL TRY TO BE VERY, VERY
QUICK. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU, CHAIR, AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF, FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL. AB
2715 WOULD SIMPLY ADD THREATS TO
CYBER SECURITY TO THE LIST OF
CLOSED SESSION EXEMPTIONS IN THE
BROWN ACT. CURRENTLY, LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN ALREADY HOLD A
CLOSED SESSION TO DISCUSS
THREATS TO THE SECURITY OF
PUBLIC BUILDINGS. THE SECURITY
ESSENTIAL OF ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
SERVICES, OR THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT
OF ACCESS TO PUBLIC SERVICES OR
PUBLIC FACILITIES. HOWEVER,
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT EXPLICITLY
LIST THREATS TO CYBER SECURITY
AS A REASON TO MEET IN CLOSED
SESSION. AS A RESULT, LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE POTENTIALLY FORCED
TO DISCUSS CYBERSECURITY THREATS
AND POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS IN OPEN
SESSION. THIS COULD LEAVE LOCAL
AGENCIES OPEN TO MORE CYBER
SECURITY ATTACKS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE AND WITH MY
WITH ME. HERE IS MY WITNESS WHO
CAN ALSO BE QUITE SHORT. I'LL
HAVE DAN, DANE HUTCHINGS,
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD, THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
PLEASURES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. DANE HUTCHINGS,
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
CARLSBAD, SPONSOR OF 2715, THE
BROWN ACT WAS ENACTED IN 1953
AND ALTHOUGH IT HAS BEEN AMENDED
OVER THE YEARS, DOES NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEVEL OF
TECHNOLOGY HAS ADVANCED OVER THE
YEARS, INCLUDING CYBER SECURITY
THREATS, AS THE MEMBER STATED,
WHILE THE BROWN ACT DOES ALLOW
FOR DISCUSSION REGARDING
SPECIFIC PENDING CYBER SECURITY
THREATS TO OCCUR IN CLOSED
SESSION, IT IS SILENT ON THE
GENERAL TOPIC OF CYBER SECURITY.
AB 2715 WOULD REMEDY THAT BY
ALLOWING FOR CLOSED SESSION
BRIEFINGS WITH GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
SECURITY PERSONNEL ON CYBER
SECURITY THREATS TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTROLS OR
CRITICAL INFORMATION. THIS
MEASURE WILL HELP LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODIES BECOME MORE
INFORMED ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE
CYBERSECURITY THREATS, AS WELL
AS TO THE EXTENT OF THE AGENCY'S
VULNERABILITIES, WHILE RETAINING
THE SAFEGUARDS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED IN CURRENT LAW TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF REDUCING A
VULNERABILITY TO A SPECIFIC
CYBER ATTACK WOULD REQUIRE A
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT, SUCH AS
PROCUREMENT OF A LARGE SOFTWARE
CONTRACT, THAT WOULD HAPPEN IN
OPEN SESSION. BUT THE CLOSED
SESSION WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO LEARN ABOUT
THE VULNERABILITY AND WHY THE
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED, WITHOUT
DISCLOSING THE SPECIFIC
VULNERABILITY TO CYBER
CRIMINALS. AB 2715 IS A MODEST
AMENDMENT TO THE CLOSED SESSION
PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN ACT. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TESTIMONY FOR THE CITY
CLERK'S ASSOCIATION, THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS,
CITY OF REDWOOD CITY, RANCHO
CUCAMONGA, RANCHO PALOS VERDES,
AND EASTVALE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2715,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. JEAN HURST HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING. I'M ERIC LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION, IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2715, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHES THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SENATOR CABALLERO,
VERY MUCH. I REALLY LIKE THIS
BILL. I THINK, WE'VE BECOME MUCH
MORE AWARE OF THREATS AND, AND
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY MEET,
PARTICULARLY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS IMPORTANT. JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT, THE
OPPOSITION SITES, SOME REPORTING
OUT REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE PART
OF THE BROWN ACT. SO I'M NOT
SURE YOU ACTUALLY NEED THEM
REPEATED, BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE THAT IF
YOU'RE MEETING AND YOU MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO SPEND
MONEY AND WHO TO HIRE AND THAT
KIND OF STUFF, THAT THAT GETS
REPORTED OUT BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT WHAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING. SO
YES, SIR. SO MY BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE THE CURRENT BROWN ACT AS
IT RELATES TO CLOSED SESSION
EXEMPTIONS, AND IT DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR DECISIONS TO BE MADE
ON BUDGETING, STAFFING OR
CONTRACTING TO BE MADE IN CLOSED
SESSION AND AS THE SAME
REPORTING OUT REQUIREMENTS AS
EVERY OTHER CLOSED SESSION. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. AND MOVE THE BILL. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SORRY SENATOR
CABALLERO, MOVE THE BILL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, SB
2715. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
UMBERG UMBERG. AYE. WILK ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD. MILO. MILO. AYE. ROTH.
STERN WAHAB. FOR 2040. PUT THAT
ON CALL. I SEE THAT I HAVE
PRETTY MUCH WARNED, THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND THEY'VE NOW DEPARTED
. SO WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD, AND WE'RE GOING TO
RECONVENE AT 130. FOR A SPECIAL
ORDER OF BUSINESS. AND WITH
THAT, WE'LL BE IN RECESS TILL
130. THANK YOU.
LET'S JUST MOVE THE CLOCK. THAT
WAS THE OLD DAYS. SAN DIEGO,
THOSE DAYS HAVE NOW GONE, WE
WILL RECONVENE HERE MOMENTARILY,
THE DEMOCRATS ARE JUST FINISHING
CAUCUS. YOU MAY WANT TO WRITE
THIS DOWN. SOME OF YOU,
APPARENTLY, POLITICIANS LIKE TO
TALK. JUST JUST SAYING. SO, WE
SHOULD WE SHOULD HAVE A MORE
ROBUST COMMITTEE HERE SHORTLY,
BUT I THINK WE WILL GO AHEAD
BECAUSE WE SET THIS AS A SPECIAL
ORDER. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIX
HERE. AB 886.
LET'S GET. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO
MEMBER WIX. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
. SENATOR GLAZER IS GOING TO
SENATOR GLAZER I BELIEVE IS CO
AUTHOR COAUTHOR. SO HE'S GOING
TO PRESENT WITH ME. AND ALSO I
BELIEVE MR. STERN IS ON THE
COMMITTEE ALSO JOINED AS A
COAUTHOR RECENTLY. SO WE'LL NOTE
THAT FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU.
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBER, I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND YOUR
EXCELLENT STAFF, WHO I KNOW HAVE
PUT IN A LOT OF TIME, ENERGY,
BLOOD, SWEAT AND TEARS INTO THIS
OVER THE PAST YEAR. AND FOR
HOLDING AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
AND WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
IMPROVE THE FRAMEWORK OF THE
BILL I BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AB 886,
THE CALIFORNIA JOURNALISM
PRESERVATION ACT DIRECTS THE
VERY LARGE, LARGEST TECH
PLATFORMS OPERATING IN OUR STATE
TO COMPENSATE JOURNALISM
PUBLICATIONS FOR ACCESSING THEIR
CONTENT. PLATFORMS ARE PROVIDED
A CHOICE EITHER PAY JOURNALISM
PROVIDERS A PREDETERMINED ANNUAL
FEE OR ENTER INTO AN ARBITRATION
AND PAY AN AMOUNT DECIDED BY A
NEUTRAL PARTY. AS NEWS
COMPENSATION HAS MOVED ONLINE,
NEWS OUTLETS HAVE HAVE DOWNSIZED
AND CLOSED AT ALARMING RATES. A
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY STUDY
PUBLISHED LAST YEAR FOUND AN
AVERAGE OF TWO AND A HALF
NEWSPAPERS IN THE UNITED STATES
CLOSED EVERY WEEK, AND THAT OUR
NATION HAS LOST TWO THIRDS OF
ITS NEWSPAPER JOURNALISTS SINCE
2005. CALIFORNIA HAS LOST MORE
THAN 100 NEWSPAPERS IN THE LAST
DECADE ALONE. IT'S NOT THAT NO
ONE READS OR WATCHES NEWS
ANYMORE. IT'S THAT AS NEWS MOVED
ONLINE, POWERFUL TECHNOLOGICAL
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS HAVE
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRED
ORGANIZATIONS TO SHARE THEIR
ORIGINAL CONTENT THAT
JOURNALISTS PRODUCE, WHICH THE
PLATFORMS SELL. ADVERTISING
AGAINST WHILE PROVIDING LITTLE
TO NO COMPENSATION. IN RETURN.
PUBLICATIONS CAN'T OPT OUT OF
THIS DYNAMIC BECAUSE OF THE
SHEER REACH THESE PLATFORMS HAVE
INFORMED BY LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
IN EUROPE, AUSTRALIA, CANADA AND
IN US CONGRESS, AB 88 SIX WOULD
DISTRIBUTE FUNDING TO INDIVIDUAL
PUBLISHERS BASED ON A HEAD COUNT
OF JOURNALISTS IN THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS. TO BE COUNTED, A
JOURNALIST MUST BE EMPLOYED FOR
THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF PRODUCING
CONTENT FOR A CALIFORNIA
AUDIENCE. IN NEWSROOMS OF SIX OR
MORE, 70% OF ANY PAYOUT MUST BE
INVESTED BACK INTO JOURNALISM
JOBS. THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES
SPECIAL CONSIDERATION TO SMALL
PUBLICATIONS, EVEN THOSE WITH
ONLY ONE EMPLOYEE WHO WORK WITH
FREELANCERS. THESE PUBLISHERS
WITH FIVE OR LESS STAFF ARE
COMPENSATED RELATIVE TO THEIR
BUDGET, THEIR NEWSROOM BUDGETS.
DESPITE THIS IMPROVED FRAMEWORK,
I'M THE FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS, ACKNOWLEDGE THE BILL. ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON TODAY REMAINS A
WORK IN PROGRESS IF IT MOVES
FORWARD FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE, YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT. WE WILL CONTINUE
ENGAGING WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
ALONGSIDE THIRD PARTY
STAKEHOLDERS, REMAINING OPEN TO
GOOD IDEAS NO MATTER WHO BRINGS
THEM. SOME ARGUE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD SIT SIT BY
WHILE THE MARKETPLACE SORTS THIS
OUT. BUT ECONOMIC FACTORS WHICH
SUPPORT QUALITY JOURNALISM AND
THE TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS
THAT IMPACT ITS VITALITY HAVE
NEVER BEEN IGNORED BY OUR SYSTEM
OF GOVERNMENT. WHETHER ADAPTING
TO TELEGRAPH, RADIO, BROADCAST
TELEVISION AND NOW THE INTERNET,
OUR FOURTH ESTATE HAS ALWAYS HAD
THE HELP OF LAWMAKERS TO BOLSTER
ITS STANDING BECAUSE OUR SHARED
BELIEF THAT A FREE PRESS IS
VITAL TO DEMOCRACY, ALLOWING
RANK AND FILE JOURNALISM TO
CONTINUE TO ATROPHY HAS NEVER
BEEN OUR APPROACH. WHEN IT HAS
FACED CHALLENGES, WE'VE ALWAYS
MADE SPACE FOR THE FOURTH ESTATE
IN OUR DISCOURSE BECAUSE WITHOUT
IT, OUR CIVIC HEALTH IS GREATLY
AT RISK. PLEASE PERMIT ME TO
HAVE THE SPACE TO FIND THE BEST
WAY TO PROVIDE A LIFELINE TO
QUALITY JOURNALISM, AS IT
CONTINUES TO ADAPT IN A DYNAMIC,
CHANGING LANDSCAPE. BEFORE WE
GET TO OUR WITNESSES, I ALSO
WANT TO, ALLOW SENATOR GLAZER,
WHO'S A COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL
AND SOMEONE WHO'S WORKED IN THIS
SPACE, SOME TIME FOR SOME
OPENING REMARKS AS WELL. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. AND TO YOUR COMMITTEE,
GREAT ANALYSIS, I THOUGHT, AND
YOU PUT IN A LOT OF TIME. CHAIR,
IN THIS ISSUE SPECIAL HEARING,
WE HAD AT UCLA, IN DECEMBER THAT
I WAS, PLEASED TO PARTICIPATE
IN, LISTEN, FOLKS, WE DEAL WITH
A LOT OF ISSUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE, INTEREST GROUPS
FIGHTING AMONG THEMSELVES OR
AMONG US, BUT I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT'S ON THE LINE WITH A BILL
LIKE THIS IS DEMOCRACY ITSELF,
AS THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN HAS SAID,
THE STAKES ARE HIGH FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN OUR WORLD. YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE TODAY
WHO DON'T THINK THEY HAVE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO THE NEWS MEDIA, FREE
INDEPENDENT PRESS IN OUR STATE
AND OUR COUNTRY. AND THERE'S
REALLY NO ROOM TO FIND COMMON
GROUND. YOU WILL HEAR FROM
PEOPLE HERE TODAY WHO WANT TO
SEE SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
BILL, WHO ARE CONSTRUCTIVE AND
ENGAGED, AND I KNOW THAT THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN IS TRUE TO HER
WORD THAT IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE,
THAT SHE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO TRY TO FIND THAT
THAT BEST PATH FORWARD, TO DEAL
WITH WHAT IS A VERY FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM IN OUR WORLD TODAY. AND
THAT'S THE PROTECTING OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS AND THE
FREE MEDIA, THE INDEPENDENT
MEDIA IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
THAT. AND IT'S WHY I HOPE YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND SENATOR GLAZER.
ALL RIGHT. YOUR WITNESSES, SIX
MINUTES TOTAL. SO WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GO FIRST? I WOULD. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MARTHA DIAZ,
AND I'M THE PUBLISHER OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY SUN EL SOL, A
FREE WEEKLY COMMUNITY BILINGUAL
NEWSPAPER THAT HAS BEEN
CIRCULATING IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY SINCE 1904. I HAVE OWNED
AND PUBLISHED THE PAPER FOR OVER
20 YEARS. OUR FOCUS IS COVERING
THE ISSUES OF THE NORTHEAST
VALLEY, A COMMUNITY THAT IS
PRIMARILY BLUE COLLAR, LATINO
AND IMMIGRANT. OUR COMMUNITY
RELIES UPON OUR COVERAGE AND
SEES US AS A TRUSTED MESSENGER.
THIS LAST WEEK, WE DEDICATED IT
TO PRIDE EVERYTHING PRIDE
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITY NEEDS TO
HAVE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT COMMUNITY. AND SO WE
SHOWED PROFILES AND STORIES AND
ISSUES AND FEEL THAT IT WAS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
CELEBRATE PRIDE. BUT LIKE ALL
PAPERS, WE ARE STRUGGLING. THE
ECONOMIC LANDSCAPE FOR LOCAL
JOURNALISM HAS SHIFTED BELOW OUR
FEET. SIMPLY PUT, THE GIANT TECH
PLATFORMS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HAVE BROKEN THE MARKET.
SMALL PAPERS LIKE MINE ARE
FINDING IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
SURVIVE, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF
HOW PLATFORMS LIKE GOOGLE AND
META HAVE STACKED THE DECK
AGAINST US. THESE TECH GIANTS
EXPLOIT, EXPLOIT LOCAL
PUBLISHERS BY USING OUR CONTENT
AND PROVIDING IT TO THEIR OWN
USERS. THEY DON'T PAY OUR
TRAINED JOURNALISTS TO WRITE
ABOUT AND TAKE PHOTOS OF LOCAL
NEWS, BUT THEY PROFIT OFF OF IT
ANYWAY. IN FACT, SINCE GOOGLE
INTRODUCED AI INTO THEIR SEARCH
RESULTS THIS YEAR, I'VE SEEN A
DRAMATIC DROP IN TRAFFIC TO OUR
WEBSITE. THESE PLATFORMS TAKE
INFORMATION AND CONTENT DIRECTLY
FROM OUR SITES AND DESIGN
PRODUCTS TO KEEP CONSUMERS ON
THEIR PLATFORMS, SEVERELY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF AD
REVENUE WE CAN GET. IT'S NOT
FAIR, AND IT'S DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH OF
LOCAL NEWS ACROSS THE STATE AND
COUNTRY. IN FACT, A THIRD OF
LOCAL PAPERS THAT EXISTED IN
2005 ARE EXPECTED TO BE CLOSED
BY THE END OF THE YEAR. THUS
TURNING MANY COMMUNITIES INTO
NEWS DESERTS AND LEAVING MANY OF
OUR CONSTITUENT OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WITHOUT A TRUSTED
THIRD PARTY. FOR INFORMATION AND
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT. IF WE
DON'T FIX THIS BROKEN MARKET, IF
THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T APPLY A
COUNTERBALANCE TO GOOGLE'S
DOMINANCE, SMALL AND LOCAL
PUBLICATIONS LIKE MINE, THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY SUN EL SOL WILL
GO OUT OF BUSINESS AND EVEN
LEAVE MORE CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO ACCURATE AND
INDEPENDENT LOCAL NEWS. WE WILL
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT CLOSE OUR
DOORS. OUR DEMOCRACY RELIES ON
AN INFORMED CITIZENRY, AND WE
CANNOT ALLOW EVEN MORE LOCAL
PAPERS TO GO UNDER AS A RESULT
OF GOOGLE'S UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES, PUBLISHERS AND
NEWSROOMS DESERVE TO GET PAID
FOR THE CONTENT WE PRODUCE.
PLEASE VOTE AYE ON AB 886. LET'S
SAVE JOURNALISM AND DEMOCRACY
TOGETHER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES AND 10S
LEFT. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MATT
PIERCE AND I AM PRESIDENT OF
MEDIA GUILD OF THE WEST. WE'RE A
LOCAL UNION OF THE NEWS GUILD
CWA THAT REPRESENTS JOURNALISTS
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, I'M
HERE SHARING THE SUPPORT OF MANY
JOURNALISM UNIONS SUPPORTING
THIS BILL, WHICH INCLUDE THE
PACIFIC MEDIA WORKERS GUILD, OUR
PARENT UNION, THE NEWS GUILD,
SAG-AFTRA, NABAT, CWA, AND THE
NATIONAL WRITERS UNION, WE'RE
ALSO SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA, DISTRICT NINE, TOGETHER
WE REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF
JOURNALISTS AND MEDIA WORKERS
WHO PROVIDE NEWS AND ESSENTIAL,
ESSENTIAL INFORMATION FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS, UNTIL
A FEW MONTHS AGO, I WAS A
LONGTIME REPORTER FOR THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES. THEN OVER THE
PAST YEAR, I NEGOTIATED THE
LAYOFFS OF ABOUT 150 OF MY
COWORKERS BEFORE TAKING A BUYOUT
MYSELF. THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF
THE ENTIRE COUNTY STAFF
DISAPPEARING TWICE OVER. I'M
HERE TODAY BECAUSE MOST OF THE
LOCAL JOURNALISM JOBS THAT
DISAPPEAR IN OUR STATE EVERY
YEAR, INCLUDING MINE, ARE NEVER
COMING BACK. THAT'S BECAUSE THE
ECONOMIC FOUNDATIONS OF DIGITAL
JOURNALISM ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
BROKEN. OUR UNIONS SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL 886 BECAUSE
TRILLION DOLLAR MONOPOLY
PLATFORMS ARE STRIP MINING. OUR
CIVIC INSTITUTIONS, STEALING OUR
LABOR AND DESTROYING THE OPEN
INTERNET FOR THE SAKE OF SHORT
TERM PROFITS, IT'S NOT JUST THE
LEGACY NEWSPAPERS, AUDIENCE
NUMBERS AT NONPROFIT NEWS
OUTLETS NATIONALLY, AS THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS STATED, AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INTRODUCTION
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
SUMMARIES HAVE REPORTEDLY
DROPPED BY A THIRD ON AVERAGE
SINCE 2022, OUR PUBLIC MEDIA
COLLEAGUES AT LAIST, KPCC, KCRW,
KQED AND CAP RADIO HAVE FACED
MAJOR CUTS OVER THE PAST YEAR
ALONE. INNOVATIVE DIGITAL
OUTLETS ARE HITTING A WALL IN MY
HOME COUNTY. THE NEWS SITE LÀ,
WHICH COVERS LOCAL BUSINESSES,
SHUT DOWN LAST YEAR. THE
INDEPENDENT NEWS SITE LA TACO
RECENTLY FURLOUGHED ITS STAFF
AFTER IT COULDN'T MAKE PAYROLL.
THE LONG BEACH POST GUTTED ITS
NEWSROOM DESPITE CONVERTING FROM
FOR PROFIT TO NONPROFIT STATUS
TO ATTRACT PHILANTHROPY. IF
THESE TRENDS CONTINUE, WE ARE
HEADED TOWARD HIGH NOON FOR
VOTER APATHY AND GOVERNMENT
CORRUPTION. WHENEVER ONE OF YOU
TAKES AN UGLY VOTE, I IS NEVER
GOING TO CHASE YOU DOWN THAT
HALLWAY LIKE ASHLEY ZAVALA,
THAT'S WHY THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS LOCAL
JOURNALISM WITHOUT LOCAL
JOURNALISTS. AND THAT'S WHY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE YES
ON ASSEMBLY BILL 886. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU HAVE
ONE MINUTE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN UMBERG AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M NEIL QUINTER.
I'M WITH THE NEWS MEDIA
ALLIANCE, WHERE I'M SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR GLOBAL GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS, EARLIER IN MY CAREER, I
HELPED REPRESENT CALIFORNIA FOR
TEN YEARS AS CHIEF COUNSEL TO
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN. I'M
HOLDING THE SPOT THAT I'M
SPEAKING IN WAS ORIGINALLY
SUPPOSED TO BE RYAN. ADAM, WHO'S
VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE TORONTO STAR,
CANADA'S LEADING NEWSPAPER. A
FORMER SENIOR ADVISER TO THE
PRIME MINISTER. SO IMAGINE WHAT
I SAY FROM HERE IS WITH A
CANADIAN ACCENT. RYAN HAS SEEN
FIRSTHAND THE CHALLENGES OF THE
NEWS MEDIA INDUSTRY IN CANADA IS
FACING AS A RESULT OF RAPIDLY
CHANGING BUSINESS MODELS AND THE
DIGITAL ADVERTISING MONOPOLIES
OF GOOGLE AND META. IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT CANADA'S STRUGGLING
INDUSTRY, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OFFERED FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO
NEWS MEDIA PUBLISHERS BY WAY OF
A $500 MILLION BAILOUT. LABOR
TAX CREDIT RELIEF, AND THE
CREATION OF JOURNALISM FUND TO
SUPPORT JOURNALISTS IN
UNDERREPRESENTED AREAS. SIMILAR
TO YOUR UC BERKELEY FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM. THESE WERE ALL HELPFUL,
BUT NONE FIXED. THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM THE PLATFORM'S
DOMINANCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 886, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION, AND YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU, JOE BERRY
WITH CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING THE
THOUSAND RADIO AND TV STATIONS
SERVING CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. TODAY, I'M ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMIC LIBERTIES PROJECT, THE
ASIAN AMERICAN JOURNALISTS
ASSOCIATION, THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ASSOCIATION, THE LATINO
JOURNALISTS OF CALIFORNIA, THE
MEDIA ALLIANCE, THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
JOURNALISTS, THE NATIONAL
NEWSPAPER ASSOCIATION, NATIONAL
PRESS PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION,
ORANGE COUNTY PRESS CLUB,
SOCIETY OF PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS, AND THE RADIO AND
TELEVISION DIGITAL NEWS
DIRECTORS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALRIGHTY. MR. CHAIR,
MEMBERS OF FLOCKS, CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JEFF GLASSER FROM THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES. WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SILAS LYONS
WITH GANNETT AND THE USA TODAY
NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
REPRESENT OUR PUBLICATIONS,
MOUNT SHASTA AREA NEWSPAPERS,
THE REDDING RECORD SEARCHLIGHT,
THE STOCKTON RECORD, THE VISALIA
TIMES-DELTA, TULARE
ADVANCE-REGISTER, SALINAS
CALIFORNIAN, THE VICTORVILLE
DAILY PRESS, THE PALM SPRINGS
DESERT SUN, AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY STAR IN SUPPORT OF ABA
EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. COLLEEN MCCAIN NELSON
I'M WITH MCCLATCHY, AND THAT
INCLUDES THE SACRAMENTO BEE, THE
MODESTO BEE, THE FRESNO BEE, THE
MERCED SUN-STAR, AND THE SAN
LUIS OBISPO TRIBUNE. WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, ERIC
CUSHMAN, PUBLISHER OF MONTEREY
COUNTY WEEKLY, WHERE WE COVER
NOT JUST THE CITY OF MONTEREY
AND SEASIDE, BUT ALSO THE CITY
OF THE COUNTY SEAT OF SALINAS
AND SOLEDAD AND GREENFIELD. AND
IN OUR ABSENCE, NO ONE WOULD BE
COVERING THOSE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
IF I COULD ASK THE SERGEANTS TO
IDENTIFY ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, WHO'S
OUTSIDE OF HIM, COME INTO THE
ROOM. THAT'D BE GREAT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. BRITTANY BARSI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION, I'M
GOING TO READ OFF A NUMBER OF
OUR PUBLICATIONS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY WEREN'T ABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY. ALSO IN SUPPORT THE
BAY AREA REPORTER. THE BURBANK
LEDGER, CÁC DISPATCH, CHINO
CHAMPION, CHINO HILLS CHAMPION,
DANA POINT, TIMES, EXCELSIOR,
GLENDALE NEWS PRESS, HANFORD
SENTINEL AND LYNN VALLEY DAILY
BULLETIN, KINGSBURG RECORDER,
LOMPOC RECORD, LOS ANGELES
BLADE, LOS ANGELES DAILY NEWS,
ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER, OUTLOOK,
PASADENA OUTLOOK, VALLEY SUN,
PASADENA STAR NEWS, PATTERSON
IRRIGATOR PRESS, BANNER PRESS,
ENTERPRISE PRESS, TELEGRAM,
PICKET FENCE MEDIA, REDLANDS
DAILY FACTS, SAN BERNARDINO SUN,
SAN CLEMENTE TIMES, SAN DIEGO
UNION TRIBUNE, SAN FERNANDO, NÓ,
MARTHA'S HERE, SORRY, SAN
FRANCISCO CHRONICLE, SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY TRIBUNE, SAN MARINO
TRIBUNE, SANTA MARIA TIMES, SAN
YNEZ VALLEY NEWS, SELMA
ENTERPRISE, SOUTH PASADENA
REVIEW, TRACY PRESS, WHITTIER
DAILY NEWS, THE SONOMA INDEX,
TRIBUNE, BAY AREA BUSINESS
JOURNAL, LA PRENSA, SONOMA, AND
THE PETALUMA ARGUS COURIER.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
CAROLYN BEALL HUNTER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK MEDIA
ASSOCIATION AND ITS, 30
AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
30 PARTNERS, RATHER THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. I WANT TO SAY WE'RE
NOT ALL THE WAY IN SUPPORT, BUT
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND ESPECIALLY PLEASED TO SEE
SHE AND SENATOR GLASER WORKING
TOGETHER, BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS THAT WE
TOOK ON THE SENATE SIDE THAT HE
TOOK THAT SHE'S AGREED TO
EMBRACE HERE. SO WITH THAT, WE
HAVE A QUALIFIED SUPPORT.
QUALIFIED SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU, CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, WE'RE
NOW GOING TO TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. SAME GROUND RULES
WILL APPLY THAT THE OPPOSITION
WILL HAVE SIX MINUTES. THEY CAN
DIVIDE IT AMONG 2 OR 3 WITNESSES
IF THEY SHOULD. SO CHOOSE. SO
I'M GOING TO ASK THE SUPPORTERS
IF THEY WOULDN'T MIND RETURNING
TO THE AUDIENCE. AND THEN WE'LL
ASK THE OPPONENTS TO, IF THEY
WISH TO HAVE A SEAT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. YOU NEED
TO. WHO'S GOING TO GO FIRST?
OKAY. YOU NEED TO HAVE THE
MICROPHONE RIGHT THERE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
BURKE. I'M JEFF JARVIS. I'M THE
TOWN PROFESSOR FOR JOURNALISM
INNOVATION AT THE CITY
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK, EMERITUS
. IN A PAPER COMMISSIONED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER, I ANALYZED
AB 886 AND EXAMINE THE LONG
HISTORY OF NEWSPAPERS LOBBYING
SINCE THE ADVENT OF RADIO TO
EXTEND COPYRIGHT AND DIMINISH
FAIR USE FOR THEIR EXCLUSIVE
BENEFIT. I OPPOSE AB 886 FIRST,
BECAUSE IT WILL BENEFIT THE
HEDGE FUNDS THAT CONTROL 18 OF
THE STATE'S TOP 25 NEWSPAPERS
AND ARE PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE
FOR DESTROYING NEWSPAPERS. I
FEAR THAT NATIONAL MEDIA
CONGLOMERATES, AS WELL AS
EXTREMIST AND PROPAGANDA MEDIA,
MAY BENEFIT AS WELL. THE BILL IS
LIKELY UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IN MY
OPINION, IN THAT A GOVERNMENT
IMPOSED FEE ON ACCESSING CONTENT
IS A TAX ON READING AND THE
RETALIATION CLAUSE COMPELS
SPEECH, WHICH IS NOT FREE
SPEECH. I WAS GRATIFIED TO READ
YOUR COMMENTS IN THE LA TIMES
SAYING, AND I'LL QUOTE, WE COULD
SCREW UP SO THAT WE MAKE IT SO
EXPENSIVE THAT THE PLATFORMS
DON'T CARRY JOURNALISM CONTENT.
THAT WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC.
AMEN. THAT IS HAPPENING IN
CANADA WITH ITS BILL C-18, WHERE
EXPERIENCE SHOWS THAT NEWS WAS
OF NO VALUE TO META. BUT META'S
LINKS WERE VALUABLE TO
PUBLISHERS AND, ACCORDING TO A
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE PROGRESS,
RATHER ANALYSIS, THEY'LL LOSE
1.2 MILLION CLICKS ON AVERAGE
PER YEAR, ENDING UP WORSE THAN
BEFORE. I REACHED OUT TO META
AND WAS TOLD THAT THEY STAND BY
THEIR STATEMENT THAT IF 86
PASSES, IT WILL PULL NEWS OFF
ITS PLATFORMS IN CALIFORNIA, AS
IT DID IN CANADA. THAT WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC. MEANWHILE, GOOGLE
HAS SAID THAT IF 886 PASSES, IT
WOULD END ITS VALUABLE GOOGLE
NEWS INITIATIVE. CHRONICLE
EDITOR EMILIO GARCIA RUIZ TOLD A
RECENT JOURNALISM CONFERENCE
THAT AND I QUOTE OF THE
PARTNERS, I'D STRESS THAT GOOGLE
NEWS HAS BEEN BY FAR THE BEST
THE NEWS INDUSTRY HAS HAD. BUT
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES. GOOGLE
HAS MADE A PROMISING PROPOSAL
INVOLVING TAX CREDITS AND A
CONTRIBUTION TO A FUND. I FAVOR
AN INDEPENDENTLY ADMINISTERED
FUND THAT WOULD GRANT BASED ON
GOALS AND MERIT WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUTCOMES. IN
MY PAPER, I REPORT HOW SUCH A
FUND IS WORKING IN NEW JERSEY.
HERE IT COULD SUPPORT, FOR
EXAMPLE, BRINGING COVERAGE TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES, A NEWS
SHARING AND AD NETWORKS SUCH AS
THAT LED BY KQED, AND INNOVATIVE
STARTUPS SUCH AS LOOKOUT SANTA
CRUZ, WHICH JUST WON A PULITZER
IN MY PAPER, I EXPLORE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES, INCLUDING
TARGETING PUBLIC NOTICE
ADVERTISING NEWS, AD NETWORKS,
SUPPORT NETWORKS FOR INDEPENDENT
NEWS SUCH AS WE HAVE IN NEW
JERSEY AND ENABLING PUBLIC MEDIA
AND UNIVERSITIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO TAKE THEIR PART IN
NEWS. ONE LAST POINT AS I HOVERS
ON THE HORIZON, IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER FOR NEWS
AND TECHNOLOGY TO INNOVATE
TOGETHER. I WOULD HOPE THAT
THIS, AS THE HEADQUARTERS STATE
OF THE INTERNET, WOULD ENABLE
MORE SUCH COLLABORATION WITH
MANY MORE TECHNOLOGY LEADERS
HERE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. DO YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES AND 15
SECONDS? THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR ELLENBERG.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
SENATOR GLAZER AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY. MY
NAME IS JEFF ROSSETTI AND I'M
GOOGLE'S GLOBAL VICE PRESIDENT
FOR NEWS PARTNERSHIPS. SINCE
1998, OUR MISSION HAS BEEN TO
MAKE THE WORLD'S INFORMATION
UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE AND
USEFUL IN SERVICE TO THAT
MISSION. EVERY DAY, SEARCH
CONTINUES TO SEND BILLIONS OF
VISITS TO PUBLISHER WEBSITES,
AND THAT INCLUDES NEWS
PUBLISHERS OF ALL SIZES. TODAY,
WE'RE ALSO ONE OF THE LARGEST
SUPPORTERS OF JOURNALISM IN THE
WORLD. THAT INCLUDES PAID
LICENSING PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR
NEWS SHOWCASE PRODUCT. AS AN
EXAMPLE, AND THE GOOGLE NEWS
INITIATIVE, WHICH PROVIDES
TOOLS, TRAINING AND FUNDING
PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
LOCAL, UNDERREPRESENTED AND
COMMUNITY BASED PUBLICATIONS.
IT'S THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT OVER 200
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS BASED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE CLEAR, THE ACT
OF SURFACING LINKS TO NEWS
CONTENT IS NOT AND HAS NEVER
BEEN COMMERCIALLY LUCRATIVE FOR
GOOGLE, AS WE RARELY SHOW ANY
ADVERTISING AGAINST NEW
SEARCHES. WE MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE CONNECTING
OUR USERS TO INFORMATION AND
NEWS ABOUT THE WORLD AROUND THEM
IS CORE AND FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
MISSION, AND THAT'S WHY WE SHARE
THE GOAL OF FURTHER
STRENGTHENING LOCAL JOURNALISM
IN CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER, WHILE
WELL-INTENTIONED, WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
JOURNALISM PROTECTION ACT TAKES
THE WRONG APPROACH AND WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE DAMAGING
CONSEQUENCES. FIRST, IT'S BUILT
UPON THE FLAWED PREMISE THAT
PLATFORMS SOMEHOW APPROPRIATE
NEWS CONTENT AND PROFIT FROM IT
WITHOUT COMPENSATING NEWS
BUSINESSES. THAT IS NOT THE WAY
THAT SEARCH WORKS. ALL WEBSITE
OWNERS, INCLUDING NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS AND PUBLISHERS,
DECIDE WHETHER WE ARE ABLE TO
LINK TO THEIR SITE AND WHAT, IF
ANYTHING, CAN BE SHOWN IN
ADDITION TO THAT, THE BILL WOULD
ALSO BREAK THE FUNDAMENTAL AND
FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLES OF THE
OPEN INTERNET, FORCING PLATFORMS
TO PAY PUBLISHERS FOR SENDING
VALUABLE FREE TRAFFIC TO THEM
WHICH THEY CHOOSE TO RECEIVE. IT
THEN ESSENTIALLY COMPELS
PLATFORMS TO SHOW THAT CONTENT A
PROFOUNDLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
PROBLEMATIC NOTION. AS MANY
OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT, THE
BILL WOULD ALSO HEAVILY FUND
INTERESTS THAT RUN COUNTER TO
SUPPORTING ACTUAL LOCAL
JOURNALISM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT INCLUDES OUT OF STATE
PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS AND HEDGE
FUNDS WITH HISTORIES OF
STRIPPING NEWSROOMS FOR PARTS,
AS WELL AS GLOBAL AND NATIONAL
CONGLOMERATE PUBLISHERS AND BET
AND BROADCASTERS. IT ALSO HAS NO
WAY OF BLOCKING MISINFORMATION
ORIENTED ACTORS FROM ACCESSING
FUNDING. MEANWHILE, IT PUTS THE
FULL BURDEN OF SUPPORT ON 1 OR 2
COMPANIES WHILE SHIELDING MANY
OTHER LARGE PLATFORMS WHO ALSO
LINK TO NEWS FROM CALIFORNIA
PUBLISHERS. FRAMEWORKS LIKE THIS
AS PROFESSOR JARVIS POINTED OUT,
HAVE LED SOME PLATFORMS TO
REMOVE LINKS TO NEWS PUBLISHERS
ALTOGETHER IN OTHER MARKETS,
DELIVERING DEVASTATING BLOWS,
PARTICULARLY TO SMALLER
PUBLISHERS. THERE HAS TO BE A
BETTER PATH, AND WE HAVE SHARED
OUR OWN PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
MEANINGFULLY INCREASE OUR OWN
CONTRIBUTIONS DELIVERED THROUGH
TARGETED PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
SUPPORT FOR TRULY CALIFORNIA
BASED JOURNALISM. IT ALSO CALLS
ON A BROAD RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO CONTRIBUTE, WHICH WE BELIEVE
SHOULD BE A FUNDAMENTAL
PREREQUISITE FOR ANY SOLUTION
HERE. WE HOPE THIS CAN SERVE AS
THE BASIS FOR A WORKABLE PATH
FORWARD TOGETHER, AND WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO BEING HERE AND
CONSTRUCTIVELY WORKING TOWARDS
AN OUTCOME. I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY
EXPRESSING MY DEEP APPRECIATION
TO CHAIR UMBERG ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, SENATOR GLAZER, AND ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS TO WORK
WITH AND LISTEN TO STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ALL
RIGHT. IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB
886, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AND WHILE YOU'RE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
THANK YOU, PROFESSOR, FOR
MENTIONING THAT. MY QUOTE ABOUT
WE COULD SCREW THIS UP. THAT
COULD APPLY TO MANY THINGS. NOT
JUST THIS, BUT RIGHT, RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT. GO AHEAD. IF YOU IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED, GIVE US YOUR
NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION, YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, NAOMI PIDGEON, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. ROBERT
SINGLETON WITH CHAMBER OF
PROGRESS. ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. RON DELORME WITH CAL
CHAMBER. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON SCHMELTZER, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
BRANDON. ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION, RESPECTFULLY, IN
OPPOSITION. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
CAMERON. DIMITRI WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY IN OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
OF NETCHOICE. AUBRY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA.
ACTION IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S BRING IT BACK. IF THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION, WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS COMMENTS?
YES, SENATOR STERN, THANK YOU, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HER, HER COAUTHOR HERE FOR
LEANING IN ON THIS ISSUE AND
STICKING WITH IT, I THINK FROM
WHAT I'M HEARING, AT LEAST FROM
THE TESTIMONY, IS THAT THINGS
SOUND CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE
PLACE WHERE WE COULD ACTUALLY
LAND SOME SOME KIND OF DEAL
WHERE, WHERE WE'D BE ABLE TO
EQUALIZE THE INEQUALITIES IN
THE, THE REVENUES AND THE VALUE
THAT THAT THE NEWS MEDIA
INDUSTRY THAT JOURNALISTS ARE
RIGHTLY POINTING OUT ARE NOT
ACCRUING TO THEM RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW, I, I, MECHANICS MATTER,
OBVIOUSLY, AND NUMBERS MATTER.
THAT'S THAT SEEMS LIKE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST MISSING PIECES IN
THE CONVERSATION IS JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE OF, YOU KNOW, OF
THE FACTS. AND I GET THAT UNDER
THE BILL THAT THAT WOULD BE LEFT
TO, LACK OF A BETTER WORD, THE
ARBITER, IS THAT THE RIGHT WAY
TO PUT IT, BUT I JUST I WANTED
TO GET A SENSE FROM, FROM THE
OPPONENTS, AND SPECIFICALLY,
SINCE WE DO HAVE GOOGLE HERE AS
WELL AS PROFESSOR, LIKE, A SENSE
OF WHAT YOU ALL SEE AS THE
MISSING VALUE IN WHAT THE WHAT
THE AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS
ARE PUSHING A CHAIR, IF I, IF I
MAY, THROUGH THE CHAIR, BUT JUST
A SENSE TO GIVE US A LITTLE LIKE
HOW FAR IS THAT DELTA BETWEEN
WHAT THE AT LEAST THE FRAMEWORK
THAT THE AUTHORS HAVE PUT
FORWARD AND THE PUBLISHERS ARE
PUTTING FORWARD, WHICH WHICH I
SUPPORT, AND WHAT'S MISSING FROM
THOSE MECHANICS THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE IT MAKE IT WORK OR
MAKE IT IN YOUR MIND A FAIRER
ASSESSMENT OF SORT OF THAT, THE
NET NET EXCHANGE OR THE NET
VALUE OF SORT OF THE VALUE OF
THE PLATFORM VERSUS THE, THE,
THE LOSSES TO, TO INDUSTRY, I
DON'T KNOW. ALL RIGHT. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND? I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS AND
PROFESSOR JARVIS SHOULD WEIGH
IN, SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. LOOK, I, I AGREE,
WE'RE ACTUALLY FUNDAMENTALLY
HERE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN IN
THE SPIRIT BEHIND THIS BILL AND
THE EFFORT. WE THINK THAT LOCAL
JOURNALISM IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
OPEN DISCOURSE. AND SO WE'RE
MOTIVATED TO FIND A SOLUTION.
YOU KNOW, OUR VIEW HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THE BEST WAY. AND WE'VE
BEEN AT THIS FOR YEARS NOW, WE
WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF PUBLISHERS, LARGE,
SMALL, WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE. AND
OUR VIEW IS THIS IS NOT A
MONOLITHIC INDUSTRY NECESSARILY.
RIGHT. I THINK PUBLISHERS ARE
VERY DIVERSE, AND I THINK THAT'S
A GOOD THING. YOU HAVE LARGE
PUBLISHERS, SMALL PUBLISHERS,
NON-PROFITS FOR PROFITS. AND
WHAT YOU REALLY NEED IS A
TARGETED, PROGRAMMATIC BASED
APPROACH TO ACTUALLY DELIVERING
VALUE AND SUPPORT. AND SO I HAVE
TEAMS THAT WORK CLOSELY WITH
LARGER PUBLISHERS. THE SOLUTIONS
WE BRING FORWARD ARE VERY
DIFFERENT. I HAVE TEAMS THAT
WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITY,
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. THE
APPROACH YOU TAKE IS VERY
DIFFERENT THERE AS WELL. AND
THIS TYPE OF FRAMEWORK, AS WE'VE
OBSERVED TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
APPLIES A VERY BLUNT FORCE,
BROAD BASED APPROACH TO THE
SOLUTION AND ULTIMATELY ENSURES
JUST BY WEIGHT OF GRAVITY THAT
THE FOCUS GOES TO A VERY
SPECIFIC COHORT. AND SO OUR
VIEW, AGAIN, IS A SOLUTION THAT
INCLUDES A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS CONTRIBUTING
THROUGH TARGETED PROGRAMS THAT
ACTUALLY SUPPORT DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENTS ACROSS THE
ECOSYSTEM. IS FUNDAMENTALLY
CRITICAL. I THINK THERE'S A HOST
OF OTHER ISSUES, BUT WE'VE HAD
VERY RESPECTFUL, COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
AND OTHERS TO TRY TO TRIANGULATE
WHAT THE OUTCOME LOOKS LIKE. BUT
MECHANICS REALLY MATTER. AND
THIS TYPE OF FRAMEWORK WE'VE
SEEN HAS ALREADY DELIVERED SOME
PRETTY CATASTROPHIC EFFECTS IN
MARKETS LIKE CANADA FOR SMALLER
PUBLISHERS AND PUBLISHERS IN
PARTICULAR, THE LARGER
PUBLISHERS MIGHT HAVE AN
AMBITION FOR SOMETHING ELSE, BUT
WE SHOULD NOT LOSE SIGHT OF WHO
ACTUALLY NEEDS SOME SUPPORT HERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU. MR. IF I
MAY, COULD I GET JUST A BRIEF
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE PROFESSOR
AS WELL? YEAH. IF YOU DON'T MIND
. THANK YOU. SENATOR, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY, A
FEW QUICK POINTS. YOU TALK ABOUT
A BALANCE HERE. ONE THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT, I THINK WITH THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S GONE AROUND
THE WORLD, IS THAT PUBLISHERS
ASSUME THAT THEIR HEADLINES ARE
ALL THAT HAVE VALUE. AND IN THIS
NEGOTIATION, THE LINKS HAVE NO
VALUE. BUT WE HAVE LEARNED IN
THE MARKETPLACE IN CANADA THAT
META LOST NÓ TRAFFIC, ACCORDING
TO THREE INDEPENDENT STUDIES,
WHEN THEY TOOK NEWS OFF THEIR
PLATFORM, ERGO NEWS HAD NO VALUE
TO META, BUT THE LINKS HAD
TREMENDOUS VALUE TO THE
PUBLISHERS. AND SO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO ARGUE THAT THERE'S A
FAIR EXCHANGE OF VALUE, THEN THE
VALUE OF BOTH SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTED FOR, I THINK. BUT I
THINK THAT GETS INTO KIND OF A
TRANSACTIONAL VIEW. WHEREAS IF
THE GOAL WHICH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND SENATOR HAVE DONE
SUCH A GOOD JOB OF WORKING ON IN
THEIR IN THEIR LEGISLATION IS TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO SUPPORT NEWS,
THEN I THINK WE NEED TO ASK,
INSTEAD OF A BLANKET THING THAT
THAT COVERS, SOME PLAYERS WHO
FRANKLY DON'T DESERVE IT, IS
THERE A WAY TO GO AFTER MERIT
AND GOALS IN A FUND THAT IS
PROVIDED? IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
IN BOTH CANADA AND AUSTRALIA,
THE LEGISLATION DID NOT ACTUALLY
TAKE EFFECT BECAUSE EXEMPTIONS
WERE GRANTED IN AUSTRALIA TO
BOTH COMPANIES AND IN CANADA TO
GOOGLE. OF COURSE, LEFT NEWS, SO
I'M REALLY GRATIFIED TO HEAR YOU
SAY THAT THERE'S MORE ROOM FOR,
BUILDING THIS LEGISLATION. AND
SO MY HOPE IS THAT A DISCUSSION
CAN OCCUR HERE THAT I'VE SEEN IN
MY STATE OF NEW JERSEY. SORRY, I
LEFT CALIFORNIA YEARS AGO LIKE A
FOOL. WHERE THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WORK AROUND GRANTING
GOVERNMENT MONEY, TAX MONEY TO
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
INNOVATING IN WAYS THAT MEET
GOALS AND, IMPORTANTLY, HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. I SENATOR
CABALLERO, DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION? I THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S I
THINK THERE'S A SWEET SPOT
SOMEWHERE, LET ME JUST SAY THAT,
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE NEWS, I
LIKE RECEIVING A NEWSPAPER AND,
TOUCHING IT AND FEELING IT, AND
BEEN REALLY SAD THAT SO MANY OF
THE NEWSPAPERS THAT APPEARED
HERE TODAY WERE NEWSPAPERS THAT
I READ. I READ, RELIGIOUSLY AND
NOW ARE SHELLS OF THEMSELVES. SO
THERE'S NO REAL LOCAL NEWS. AND
IT'S NOT, IT'S NOT, THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO QUESTIONING OF FACTS,
IF YOU WILL, GOOD, GOOD
JOURNALISM IS JOURNALISM THAT
MAKES YOU THINK SO THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AT SOME POINT, RATHER
THAN JUST SAYING SOMETHING IN
ANY CASE, I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I WANT TO SEE US WORK
TOWARDS SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
CAN WORK, I THINK YOU HAVE
AUTHORS THAT ARE DEDICATED AND
COMMITTED. COMMITTED TO THAT.
WHATEVER HAPPENS, IN THIS
COMMITTEE, IT'S GOT TO GET
THROUGH AN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE, WHICH, YOU HAVE TWO
OF THE CHAIRS, ONE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND ONE IN THE SENATE.
WE'RE ALL WORK VERY HARD AT
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WHATEVER IT IS THAT WE DO. IT
WORKS BECAUSE THERE'S A REAL
COMMITMENT TO THAT. SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY,
AND I APPRECIATE THEY APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED
AND THE ANSWERS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CABALLERO. SENATOR YELLOW, THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR, MY THOUGHTS ON
THIS AREA, PARTICULARLY FROM A
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE BUT
POLITICAL TO HAVE EVOLVED MY
I'VE SPOKEN WITH SENATOR GLAZIER
ABOUT THIS QUITE A BIT. HE HAD A
BILL IN THE SENATE AND WE HAD
LOTS OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT.
MY FIRST REACTION WAS, ONE OF
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN WHERE WE
WOULD HAVE THE ENTITY THAT THE
NEWS MEDIA WAS SUPPOSED IS
SUPPOSED TO OBJECTIVELY AND
AGGRESSIVELY HOLD ACCOUNTABLE,
BEING THEIR SAVIOR, THAT'S GOT
TO CAUSE SOME CONCERN, BUT IT'S
MORE THAN THAT. THE NEWS
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN GOING THROUGH
A SIGNIFICANT CONSOLIDATION,
EVEN BEFORE, THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING CURRENTLY,
GROUPS FORMED, SMALL GROUPS
BECAME LARGE GROUPS. AND SOME OF
THOSE DECISIONS WEREN'T VERY
GOOD. AND SOME OF THE ECONOMIC
DYNAMICS OF THE RESULTING
CONSOLIDATED, ENTITIES, BEGAN TO
COLLAPSE BECAUSE OF THE WEIGHT
OF, OF DEBT AND THE LIKE THAT
THEY ACQUIRED. THEN WE HAVE THE
DYNAMIC THAT HAS COME ABOUT,
RECENTLY AND THE, THE INDUSTRY
AND EVERYTHING IS CHANGING
DRASTICALLY. AND CERTAINLY THE
INTERNET IS SOME OF IT, BUT
THAT'S NOT ALL OF IT. THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN BEHAVIOR
OF CONSUMERS AS WELL AS THE
OFFERINGS IN THE MARKETPLACE,
AND WHICH ONE IS THE CHICKEN AND
WHICH ONE IS THE EGG? I DON'T
KNOW, BUT, PEOPLE ARE GETTING
THEIR NEWS IN NONTRADITIONAL
WAYS, DEFINING NEWSPAPERS AS
TRADITIONAL OR THE TRADITIONAL
BROADCAST, ENTITIES, WHICH ARE
REALLY NOT TALKING ABOUT HERE,
BUT IN, IN, IN THE PRINT NEWS.
AND I AND I DON'T MEAN JUST
TIKTOK THAT'S SORT OF JOKED
ABOUT I DON'T DOUBT THAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT GET THEIR
NEWS FROM TIKTOK, AND I
SINCERELY FEEL SORRY FOR THOSE
PEOPLE, BUT THERE ARE THERE'S A
PLETHORA OF HIGH QUALITY
PODCASTS THAT ARE BOTH NEWS
REPORTING AS WELL AS OPINION,
AND SOME OF THEM ARE A LITTLE
CRAZY, BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
IN A MARKETPLACE WHEN YOU HAVE A
LOT OF OFFERINGS. THERE ARE VERY
QUALITY ONLINE NEWSPAPER
NEWSLETTERS, WHICH ARE
SUBSCRIPTION VEHICLES. ONE THAT
I KNOW OF IS THE DISPATCH, WHICH
IS SORT OF A RIGHT LEANING
NEWSPAPER. THERE ARE LEFT
LEANING ALSO, BUT IT IS A THEIR
EDITORIAL IS RIGHT LEANING, NOT
DRASTICALLY SO, BUT IT IS AN
OBJECTIVE REPORTING OF THE NEWS
EACH AND EVERY DAY. PLUS OTHER
PUBLICATIONS AS PART OF THAT,
THAT GIVE OTHER, TAKES ON WHAT'S
GOING ON, ECONOMIC AND
OTHERWISE, AND THEN THERE'S THE
RELATIVELY NEW MODEL OF, A
ESSENTIALLY A NEWS NEWSPAPER
ONLINE LIKE CALMATTERS, THE
FUNDING OF WHICH COMES LARGELY
FROM FOUNDATIONS, BUT FROM
INDIVIDUALS. ALSO, THAT KIND OF
MODEL DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE, AND
IT'S PRETTY SUCCESSFUL. AND THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS VERY FEW
YOUNGSTERS TO ME UNDER 50 EVEN
PICK UP A PHYSICAL NEWSPAPER
THAT'S CAUSED THAT DYNAMIC IN
AND OF ITSELF HAS CAUSED A LOT
OF TROUBLE FOR NEWSPAPERS. IT'S
NOT JUST THE LACK OF
ADVERTISING, ALTHOUGH THAT'S
CERTAINLY PART OF IT. BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE A CONSOLIDATION LIKE
THAT AND THE CONSOLIDATION, THAT
CREATES SOME SOME ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS FOR THOSE THAT MAY BE
CONSOLIDATED IN AN UNHEALTHY
WAY, YOU HAVE OTHER INVESTMENT
COMPANIES THAT SWOOP IN AND TAKE
THOSE ENTITIES OVER. NOT FOR THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE MISSION OF THE
COMPANIES. THEY'RE ACQUIRING
THAT IS REPORTING THE NEWS. BUT
TO MAKE MONEY, AND I DON'T FAULT
THAT I AM A SHAMELESS CAPITALIST
MYSELF, BUT THEY SWOOP IN FOR
THAT REASON. AND AS WAS STATED,
OVER 50% OF NEWSPAPERS, DAILY
NEWSPAPERS IN AMERICA ARE OWNED
BY HEDGE FUNDS AND INDIVIDUAL
INVESTORS. SO I HAVE JUST
PARENTHETICALLY, I SAY, WHO ARE
WE HELPING HERE, BUT BUT THAT IS
A SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE
DYNAMIC ALSO. AND I AND IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT A LOT OF SMALLER
NEIGHBORHOOD NEWSPAPERS HAVE
GONE OUT OF BUSINESS, AND MAYBE
THEY HAVE, BUT I DON'T SEE THAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. WE HAVE,
GOLD COUNTRY MEDIA, WHICH HAS
CONSOLIDATED ITSELF. IT'S BIGGER
THAN IT USED TO BE BECAUSE IT'S
ACQUIRED SOME NEWSPAPERS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY INDEPENDENT. BUT
IT'S, MY UNDERSTANDING, IS
REASONABLY HEALTHY. WE HAVE THE
MESSENGER PUBLIC PUBLISHING
GROUP OUT OF RANCHO CORDOVA,
WHICH IS A GROUP OF NEIGHBORHOOD
NEWSPAPERS. WE HAVE INSIDE
SACRAMENTO, WHICH PUBLISHES
NEIGHBORHOOD NEWS AND LAND PARK
AND ARDEN PARK AND OTHER AREAS
LIKE THAT. THEY SEEM ALSO TO BE
DOING REASONABLY WELL. THE
SACRAMENTO OBSERVER, IN FACT, I
TALKED WITH ONE OF THE OWNERS OF
THOSE GROUPS, AND HE'S ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATION.
INTERESTINGLY, BUT BEYOND THAT,
THERE'S THE OLD IF THE BILL
PASSES AS IT IS AND I REALIZE
YOU'RE WORKING ON IT, AND THAT'S
GOOD. BUT THERE'S THE OLD
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE. AND THE
THING IS, THE BILL SEEMS TO
ASSUME THAT THE PLATFORMS WILL
JUST SIMPLY COMPLY AND NOT
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR. BUT AS
WE'VE SEEN IN OTHER ATTEMPTS IN
EUROPE, AUSTRALIA, AND MORE
CLOSELY CANADA, A DYNAMIC
ANALYSIS SUGGESTS THAT THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY JUST COMPLY
AND THEIR BEHAVIOR CHANGES. AND
THEN I'M NOT, IN ENDORSING THAT
IN ANY WAY. BUT ONCE YOU PASS
LEGISLATION AND IT IMPACTS THE
MARKETPLACE, YOU CAN'T CONTROL
HOW THE MARKETPLACE REACTS TO
IT. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS I'D HAVE
ALSO. SO, IF THERE'S A QUESTION
IN THERE, I'D WELCOME REACTION.
MY COMMENTS. YEAH. WELL, HERE'S
THE QUESTION. PLEASE EXPLAIN.
RIGHT. IS THAT THE QUESTION?
YEAH. I'M SURE THERE'S REACTION
TO THE STATEMENTS THAT I'VE MADE
AND AS I SAID, SENATOR GLAZER
AND I HAVE HAD FRIENDLY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS, BUT MY
CONCERNS ARE BIG BECAUSE IT'S A
BIG MARKETPLACE WITH BIG
PROBLEMS THAT ARE NOT UNLIKE
OTHER SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY.
AND I'M NOT SURE WE CAN SOLVE
ALL THAT WITH A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. WELL, ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU. LET ME TURN TO THE
TWO AUTHORS FIRST FOR THEIR
RESPONSES. I CAN ANSWER SOME OF
THAT. MY CLOSE. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, SENATOR GLAZER. SAME
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SO LET ME, CONCLUDE
PERHAPS IS THAT, FOLLOWING ON
YOUR POINT, SENATOR NIELLO, I DO
BELIEVE THE MARKETPLACE IS THE
BEST MECHANISM TO REGULATE
INDUSTRY, THE UNIQUE SITUATION
WE FACE HERE, THOUGH, WITH THE
MARKETPLACE IS THAT THE DEMISE
OF PAGERS PROBABLY DIDN'T REALLY
IMPACT OUR DEMOCRACY. BUT THE
DEMISE OF CREDIBLE JOURNALISM, I
THINK, DOES IMPACT OUR DEMOCRACY
, AND THUS THAT WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO FIND A WAY TO
SUPPORT REASONABLE, CREDIBLE
JOURNALISM. YOU AND I. MY GUESS
IS WE WOULD PROBABLY AGREE ON
99% OF WHAT IS REASONABLE,
CREDIBLE JOURNALISM. I ALSO
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT HOW
PEOPLE ACCESS THE NEWS, HOW
YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR
ACCESS THE NEWS THAT THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE, GO ON THE NET AND THEY
DO IT IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS
THAN PERHAPS I DO IN FACT, JUST
ONE QUICK LITTLE ASIDE, I, I
ACTUALLY READ NEWSPAPERS, YOU
KNOW, THOSE PAPER THINGS WITH
PRINT ON THEM YET OLD GUYS DO.
YES. AND AS A FOLLOW ON, MY
GRANDDAUGHTER, WHO WAS THEN SIX
YEARS OLD, WHO LIVED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHEN SHE VISITED, SHE
OPENED HER SUITCASE AND PULLED
OUT A WHOLE STACK OF NEWSPAPERS
THAT WERE OVER A MONTH OLD. AND
SHE EXPLAINED TO ME THAT YOU
LIKE TO READ NEWSPAPERS. OPA! SO
I BROUGHT YOU SOME THAT SHE
APPARENTLY HAD GATHERED FROM
DRIVEWAYS AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, THINKING THAT THEY
WERE ALL ABANDONED PROPERTY, BUT
NEVERTHELESS, THAT DEMONSTRATES
A FUNDAMENTAL MISUNDERSTANDING
OF HOW NEWSPAPERS WORK, NOW, WE
SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME ON
THIS ISSUE, BUT NOT ENOUGH TIME.
WE HAVEN'T SPENT ENOUGH TIME. WE
HAD A HEARING AT UCLA, TODAY. SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING ON
THE NET SHOULD KNOW WE HAD SIX
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY ON EACH
SIDE. THAT DOESN'T DO IT
JUSTICE. BUT WE ALSO, BELIEVE IT
OR NOT, WE CAN READ. SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT INDIVIDUALS WISH TO
SUBMIT ITEMS IN WRITING, WE WILL
READ THEM. THERE'S OTHER FACTORS
AT PLAY HERE. WE KNOW THAT THAT
CREDIBLE JOURNALISM IS AT LEAST
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AND THE
ABILITY TO, INVESTIGATE IS IN
DEMISE. SADLY, NUMBER TWO, WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THIS IS A BIG AND
VERY, VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
NUMBER THREE IS THE BILL IN
PRINT HAS A BLANK SPACE FOR A
AMOUNT OF MONEY. YOU SHOULDN'T
BE MISLED. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
ZERO. THAT MEANS THAT IT IS A
SPACE THAT WE HOPE AT SOME POINT
WILL BE FILLED IN TO THE POINT
WITH RESPECT TO A FUND THAT
WOULD BE AND PERHAPS COULD BE A
VERY ELEGANT SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE. AND I KNOW THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND SENATOR GLAZER,
THEY WANT TO COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION. WE SHARE THOSE VALUES.
SOLUTION. I DON'T THINK THAT THE
COMMAS AND SEMICOLONS ARE
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
PASSIONATE ABOUT, BUT I THINK
THAT THEY ARE. THEY SHARE AND I
SHARE THEIR PASSION ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE,
THIS BILL IS CONTINUING TO
APPROVE, BUT BUT THERE'S STILL A
WAY TO GO. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT. I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE. I KNOW THAT
BOTH OF YOU ARE STILL COMMITTED
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE DO COME
UP WITH A RESOLUTION. I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE'LL EVER COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION, BUT WE'RE GOING
TO COME UP WITH A RESOLUTION
THAT THAT IS SUPPORTED. SO,
HAVING SAID THAT, LET ME TURN TO
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND
YOU, SENATOR GLAZER, FOR YOUR
CLOSE. IS THERE A MOTION, FIRST
OF ALL, SENATOR STERN, DID YOU
MAKE A MOTION? OKAY. THERE YOU
GO. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. CHAIR,
I WOULD SAY FIRST I THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR AGAIN,
PROVIDING A PLATFORM FOR A MORE
THOROUGH DISCUSSION THAN EVEN
TODAY. AND IT'S WORTH NOTING
THAT THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE. AND
THERE'S MORE TO COME. THE ONE OF
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SAID
THAT THIS BILL IS A BLUNT FORCE.
AND MY ANSWER TO THAT IS WHEN
THE PATIENT IS DYING ON THE
GROUND, YOU NEED A POWERFUL BLOW
TO RESUSCITATE IT. AND THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH JOURNALISM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT IN SACRAMENTO THAT
THERE'S STILL SOME VIBRANCY
THERE. BUT IN MOST MANY PLACES
IN CALIFORNIA, IT IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE. AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE LISTENING WHO KNOW
THAT FOR A FACT THAT NEWSPAPERS
HAVE GONE AWAY, COMPETITION HAS
GONE AWAY. WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
CUTBACKS, ENORMOUS CUTBACKS THIS
YEAR OF JOURNALISTS, 65% HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS SINCE 2005.
THAT'S NO JOB KILLER. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD BRING THAT BACK
IN AN IMPORTANT WAY. THE AUTHOR
DESERVES PRAISE FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE, AND I
HOPE YOU'LL MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR UMBERG, I KNOW YOU'VE
SPENT AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME
ON THIS BILL. YOU AND I HAVE HAD
MANY, MANY CONVERSATIONS, AND I
THINK WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THEM. AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL,
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLE. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS, EVEN
THOUGH I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
SUPPORTING THE BILL, BUT I DO
GENUINELY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED. AND, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE SOMEONE WHO IS AGGRESSIVELY
TRYING TO ENGAGE OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL. AND REALLY WANT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE,
BECAUSE IN THE END OF THE DAY, I
WANT THE BEST SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM. AND SO THE THINGS THAT
YOU RAISE, I THINK ARE VALID, WE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES. YOU KNOW, WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SMALL PUBLISHERS. I THINK
THEY'RE IT'S CRITICAL THAT THEY
ARE SUPPORTED IN THIS PROCESS.
AND THAT'S WHY I KNOW YOU SEE
MANY OF THEM SUPPORTING IT. NOT
EVERYONE, BUT MANY OF THEM WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. WE'VE HAD A LOT
OF GOOD DIALOG WITH GOOGLE OVER
THE PROCESS, ON THIS BILL, AND
THEY HAVE COME BACK TO US WITH
OTHER IDEAS THAT WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY EXPLORE AND CONTINUE
TO PUSH ON AND SEE IF WE CAN
REACH AGREEMENT ON, YOU KNOW,
SENATOR KABIRU SAID IT BEST, YOU
KNOW, NEWS MAKES YOU THINK. AND
I THINK FOR THOSE OF US IN THIS
JOB IN PARTICULAR, THAT IS
REALLY CRITICAL. AND I GET I GET
MOTIVATED TO DO POLICY IDEAS
BASED ON THE STUFF I READ OUT OF
PUBLICATIONS. AND I KNOW MANY OF
US DO, WHETHER IT'S LISTENING TO
IT ON PODCAST OR READING ABOUT
IT IN THE PAPER, YOU THINK
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, LA TIMES WAS
THE ONE WHO UNCOVERED THE USC,
SCANDAL AROUND THE GYNECOLOGIST
WHO WAS SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
WOMEN FOR DECADES THAT RESULTED
IN LEGISLATION TO OPEN UP THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS TO MAKE
THOSE WOMEN WHOLE. AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF THAT REPORTING. WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE NEW YORK
TIMES REPORTING ON METOO AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN THAT RESULTED
IN LEGISLATION TO END DNASE AND
OTHER THINGS, YOU KNOW, YOU
THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE GOOD
REPORTING THAT DRIVES A LOT OF
THE STUFF THAT WE DO HERE, AND
NOT JUST THE BIG PAPERS, THE
SMALLER PAPERS. I MEAN, I HAVE
BERKELEY SIDE AND OAKLAND SIDE
IN MY DISTRICT. THEY ARE DOING
REPORTING EVERY SINGLE DAY ON
LOCAL POLITICS, ON RESTAURANT
OPENINGS, ON SCHOOL FUNDING
CUTS, ON ALL THE IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT OUR COMMUNITIES CARE
ABOUT AND THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
AT STAKE HERE. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
WANTING TO TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM. IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD, WHICH I THINK IT WILL,
AND I HOPE IT WILL, I GIVE YOU
MY PLEDGE. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION, TO WORK
WITH THE SMALL PUBLISHERS, TO
WORK WITH MY COPILOT, SENATOR
GLAZIER FOR YOU, CHAIRMAN BERG,
FOR OUR OUR PRO TEM, WHO'S WHO
IS PUBLICLY COMMITTED TO A
POSITION ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL,
TO LAND SOMETHING HOPEFULLY ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THAT WE CAN
ALL BE PROUD OF, BUT I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
BELIEVE SENATOR STERN HAS MOVED
THE BILL JUST AS A FOLLOW ON TO
YOUR COMMENT. IN TERMS OF LOCAL
PUBLICATIONS IN OUR OWN AREA,
THE SALE OF ANAHEIM STADIUM,
WHICH WILL I THINK RESULT IN
THREE PEOPLE GOING TO FEDERAL
PRISON, WAS EXPOSED BY A SMALL,
WELL, RELATIVELY SMALL ONLINE
PLATFORM CALLED THE VOICE OF OC.
SO TO YOUR POINT. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR STERN. IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 886.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG I UMBERG
I WILK. YEAH WILK. NO. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO DURAZZO. LAIRD
MELLO. YELLO. NO ROTH. ROTH.
ROTH. I STERN. STERN. I WILL
HAVE 3 TO 2. 3 TO 2. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDWELL.
YOU'VE BEEN VERY PATIENT. JUST A
NOTE TO THE SERGEANTS. IT'S
INCREDIBLY WARM IN HERE. I DON'T
KNOW IF I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A
FUNCTION OF THE NUMBER OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WE HAVE IN THE
ROOM OR OR WHAT, BUT. RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. YES. I DO THE ONE
FIRST. ALL RIGHT. I APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE. WHICH BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DO FIRST, WHY DON'T
WE GO IN ORDER? HOW'S THAT?
THAT'S FINE. OKAY. WHICH ONE'S
THE FIRST ONE? 22. 88? YES
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS. AB 2288
WOULD MAKE SEVERAL REFORMS TO
PARGA THAT IMPROVE ITS
EFFECTIVENESS AS A VITAL TOOL TO
ENFORCE WORKERS RIGHTS, PROMOTE
MAKING WORKERS WHOLE, AND
INCENTIVIZE EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE.
SINCE 2004, PARGA HAS SERVED AS
A CRITICAL ENFORCEMENT TOOL OF
CALIFORNIA'S LABOR LAWS,
RECOGNIZING THE REALITY THAT THE
STATE'S LABOR ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES OFTEN LACK THE
RESOURCES TO INVESTIGATE AND
TAKE ACTION AGAINST EVERY
VIOLATION, PARGA CASES ARE MOST
OFTEN FILED TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
LABOR CODE VIOLATIONS AND
ENFORCE FUNDAMENTAL LABOR
RIGHTS, SUCH AS OVERTIME,
MINIMUM WAGE, AND SICK LEAVE.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA IS IN A
LABOR ENFORCEMENT CRISIS DUE TO
A COMBINATION OF LIMITED STATE
RESOURCES, THE PREVALENCE OF
FORCED ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS,
AND LITTLE INCENTIVE FOR
EMPLOYERS TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. AB 2288 ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE IN A NUMBER OF WAYS.
IN ORDER TO PRESERVE PARGA, AS
WELL AS MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE FOR THE PARTIES
INVOLVED. FIRST, IT ENCOURAGES
EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE BY REDUCING
PENALTIES FOR EMPLOYERS WHO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO QUICKLY COME
INTO COMPLIANCE, WHILE ALSO
CREATING HIGHER PENALTIES FOR
BAD ACTORS WHO ACT MALICIOUSLY.
THE BILL ALSO IMPROVES OVERALL
OUTCOMES BY ADDING INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF AS A REMEDY. UPDATING
THIS, THE SPLIT OF PAGA
PENALTIES, INCREASING WORKERS
ABILITY TO GET BACK WAGES WITH
INTEREST, AND ALLOWING JUDICIAL
DISCRETION TO INCREASE PENALTIES
OR THE OUTCOME WOULD OTHERWISE
BE UNJUST. I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PARTIES WHO CAME TOGETHER TO
NEGOTIATE THIS COMPROMISE, ALONG
WITH SB 92, BY THE CHAIR, TO
ENSURE PARGA CONTINUE TO HELP
ENFORCE CALIFORNIA LABOR LAWS
WHILE REDUCING PROLONGED
LITIGATION. I DON'T KNOW IF I'VE
EVER THOUGHT I WOULD SAY THIS,
BUT HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ARE SARAH FOX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, AND
ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT. WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST? ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. SARAH FOX,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I
FIRST JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HIS WORK ON
THIS AND OF COURSE, THE CHAIR,
FOR THE COMPANION BILL TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD, THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, WERE THE
ORIGINAL SPONSORS OF PARGA. AND
THIS WAS A RESPONSE TO A CRISIS
IN LABOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. IT WAS
DESIGNED TO SPECIFICALLY
INCREASE THE ENFORCEMENT OF
LABOR LAW FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS IN THE STATE.
IMMIGRANT WORKERS, LOW WAGE
WORKERS, FARM WORKERS. AND IT IS
STILL AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TOOL. AND SO THE TWO BILLS THAT
WE HAVE NEGOTIATED WITH THE
CHAMBER, PRESERVE PARGA AS A
UNIQUE ENFORCEMENT TOOL WHILE
UPDATING IT TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR WORKERS AND INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYER COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW, WHICH IS OUR ULTIMATE GOAL.
PARGA IS THE ONLY WAY THAT
WORKERS CAN SUE ON IMPACT ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF THEIR IMPACTED
COWORKERS, AND IT IS THE ONLY
PATH TO JUSTICE FOR WORKERS WHO
HAVE SIGNED FORCED ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS, THIS BILL UPHOLDS THE
KEY DECISIONS BY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT, THAT ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS CANNOT WAIVE A PARGA
LAWSUIT SINCE THE WORKER IS
STANDING IN THE SHOES OF THE
STATE IN ENFORCING THE LAW. WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THESE BILLS
TOGETHER ARE DOING WHAT WE THE
ORIGINAL INTENT IS IN THAT IT IS
CREATING AN INCENTIVE FOR
EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. IT IS HAVING A WAY FOR
EMPLOYERS TO ACTUALLY COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WHEN THERE ARE
VIOLATIONS, AND IT'S MAKING
WORKERS WHOLE, I'M NOT GOING TO
REPEAT WHAT THE AUTHOR SAID
ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT IS IN THE
BILL, BUT THERE ARE A FEW VERY
IMPORTANT PIECES. AND ONE IS THE
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF PIECE THAT WAS
ALSO IN THE ORIGINAL BILL. IT'S
A POWERFUL TOOL THAT ALLOWS
WORKERS TO ACTUALLY STOP ILLEGAL
PRACTICES. AND THIS IS ALSO IN
LINE WITH THE REDUCED PENALTIES
FOR SOME OF THE LESS SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS AND INCREASED
PENALTIES WHEN THERE ARE VERY
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS OR FRAUD OR
MALICE, SO TOGETHER, THIS IS, WE
THINK, MOVING FORWARD AND AN
IMPORTANT STEP AND WE THANK YOU
FOR BOTH YOUR AUTHORSHIP AND
YOUR SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
YOUR PARTNER GO AHEAD. YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ASHLEY HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 2288,
AB 2288 COMBINED WITH SB 92
PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED REFORM TO
PAGA. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
AGAIN THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION, THE ADMINISTRATION,
FOR CONVENING THE DISCUSSIONS AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND THE CHAIR, AS WELL, WE HAVE
HEARD FOR MANY YEARS FROM OUR
MEMBERS ABOUT PAGA AND HOW
UNFORTUNATELY, BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THAT PAGA IS STRUCTURED, A
LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS, NO MATTER HOW
MERITORIOUS THE CLAIM, END UP
PAYING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
PENALTIES THAT THEY SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD, REGARDLESS OF THE
SEVERITY OF ANY VIOLATION. I'M
REMINDED OF AN EXAMPLE FROM MY
OWN PRACTICE, WHERE ONE MISTAKE
BY AN HR REPRESENTATIVE ONLY
COST $80 ACROSS THE ENTIRE CLASS
, A FEW PENNIES THERE, A FEW
PENNIES THERE. BUT THAT SMALL
EMPLOYER WAS FORCED TO PAY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN PENALTIES. AND SO WHAT WAS
ONCE A WELL-INTENTIONED LAW HAS
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN MANIPULATED,
ENRICHING CERTAIN TRIAL
ATTORNEYS AT THE EXPENSE OF
WORKERS, BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS WHO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS. WHAT'S
IN THIS BILL? AND THE COMPANION
BILL REPRESENTS HISTORIC REFORMS
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT
ADDRESS EMPLOYERS CONCERNS, BUT
ALSO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS CAN FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
THERE'S ROBUST LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THE BAD
ACTORS. SOME OF THESE REFORMS
INCLUDE ADDRESSING TWO SUPREME
COURT CASES REGARDING STANDING,
AND NOW REQUIRING THAT THE
PLAINTIFF HAVE ACTUALLY
EXPERIENCED THE ALLEGED HARM
WITHIN THE STATUTE OF LIMITATION
PERIOD. AGAIN, THE PENALTY CAPS,
AS MENTIONED, WHERE EMPLOYERS
CAN SHOW THAT THEY TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO BE IN
COMPLIANCE EITHER PRIOR TO OR
AFTER RECEIVING A NOTICE, AS
WELL AS A BROADENED ABILITY TO
CURE AND PROCESSES, TO HELP MAKE
WORKERS WHOLE AND TO HELP,
ENSURE THERE'S NOT PROLONGED
LITIGATION. WE ARE ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO,
QUICKEN HIRING AT THE LABOR
AGENCY. SO WE STRONGLY URGE A
SUPPORT VOTE TODAY. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2288, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. MR. CHAIRMAN, ALBERTO
TORRICO, ON BEHALF OF AIRLINES
FOR AMERICA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN. CHRIS
MICHELI, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
. AND SHERM, THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. KEN,
STAND UP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MATT
SUTTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS, MATTHEW ALLEN WITH
WESTERN GROWERS. PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS CAMERON
DIMITRI ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
GOODWILLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
SCOTT BRANT SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS, DOUG SUBERS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TIM TAYLOR WITH THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MIKE
ROBSON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN STAFFING ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA STAFFING
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, NAOMI PIDGEON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS, TONY
GONZALEZ IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE HOME CARE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
SB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. RYAN
ELAINE, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, LAWRENCE GAYTAN. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. NICK
CHAPPIE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BILL,
ACTING WITH THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
OF ENGINEERING COMPANIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER, ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
UFCW WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GRACE COPELAND, ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND LEE AUGUSTINE, ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIKO
YOSHIHARA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SHANE GUZMAN, ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS, THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION,
THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION,
THE MACHINISTS, AND UNITE HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ABED
FRANKEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, LEANNE TROUT WITH TROUT AND
PRICE ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN. CARL
LONDON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AMBER KING WITH
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2288, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. ONE NOTE BEFORE WE
TURN TO MEMBERS IS I OBSERVED
THAT I HAD THE COMPANION BILL
TODAY, MR. CHAIR, AND YOUR
COMMITTEE IN THE NUMBER OF
SUPPORTERS TODAY FOR YOUR BILL
WAS ABOUT THREE TIMES THE NUMBER
OF SUPPORT IN MY BILL. I IT HAS
IMPACTED MY SELF-ESTEEM AND I'VE
NOTED THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED YOUR BILL BUT DID NOT
SUPPORT MY BILL. JUST A NOTE FOR
THE ADVOCATES THAT ARE HERE. ALL
RIGHT. NOW TURNING IT TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR ROTH,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
CONGRATULATIONS. IT'S BEEN A
LONG TIME CONVERSING ABOUT THIS.
LONG BEFORE I GOT TO THIS THIS
JOB. AND IT'S A GOOD EFFORT. I
JUST I HEARD A RUMOR THAT SINCE
THIS NEGOTIATION WAS ANNOUNCED,
THAT THERE WAS SORT OF A GOLD
RUSH OF CLAIMS FILING IN, IN THE
STATE. I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
TRUE. IS THAT DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY INFORMATION ABOUT THAT AS,
AS COMPARED TO WHAT THE NUMBER
OF CLAIMS FILED LAST YEAR? I, MY
UNDERSTANDING, SENATOR, IS THAT
THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET, I THINK, MOST PEOPLE THAT
THIS HAPPENED SO QUICKLY. I
THINK FROM MY AT LEAST FROM THE
MEDIA REPORTS, I'M SEEING, IS
THAT MOST PEOPLE PROBABLY MISSED
THE DEADLINE, BECAUSE AGAIN,
THESE WERE, YOU KNOW, INTERNAL
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
PARTIES. AND SO ONCE A
RESOLUTION WAS MADE, I THINK WE
ALL MOVED VERY QUICKLY WHERE
THERE ARE SOME THAT TRIED TO I
GUESS, QUOTE, BEAT THE DEADLINE.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED
TO FILE A CASE. IT'S NOT LIKE
YOU CAN NECESSARILY DO THAT
OVERNIGHT, BUT FOR THE MEDIA
REPORTS AND FOR THE ANECDOTAL
ANECDOTALLY, WHAT I'M HEARING IS
I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY FAR
MORE INDIVIDUALS THAT MISSED THE
DEADLINE THAN MADE IT BECAUSE OF
THE HOW QUICKLY WE ALL CAME
TOGETHER, YEAH. SO IF YOU LOOK
NORMALLY THERE ARE ABOUT 25 TO
40 CLAIMS FILED A DAY. AND IN
THE THREE DAYS AFTER THE
ANNOUNCEMENT, BEFORE THE BILL
WENT TO PRINT, THERE WERE
UPWARDS OF 100 OR 200 A DAY, BUT
AS AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED,
THANKFULLY, WE WERE ABLE YOU
KNOW, WE HAD THAT CONCERN. AND
SO THERE IS A PROVISION THERE
SAYING THAT YOU WOULD HAVE HAD
TO FILE PRIOR TO THE 19TH THE
DAY WAS ANNOUNCED. BECAUSE, YES,
AS YOU MENTIONED, ABOUT HALF OF
WHAT'S BEEN FILED SO FAR THIS
MONTH WAS FILED JUST IN THOSE 60
HOURS. AND THOSE WERE THOSE ARE
UNTIMELY, THEY ARE UNDER THIS
NEW LAW. YES. THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS A
PROVISION IN THE LAW THAT
DESIGNATES JUNE 19TH AS THE
STRIKE DATE. YES EXACTLY. YES.
THANK YOU. JUNE 19TH OF WHAT
YEAR? YEAH, THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION. THIS YEAR, 2024 I SEE.
YES. SO AGAIN, THE SHORT ANSWER
TO MY QUESTION IS WHILE THE NEWS
REPORTS DO REPORT A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OVER LAST YEAR, MOST OF
THOSE WERE UNTIMELY UNDER YOUR
BILL. YES AS SOON AS THE DEAL
WAS ANNOUNCED, THE NUMBER OF
NOTICES THAT WERE FILED
SKYROCKETED. BUT WE HAD
ANTICIPATED, YOU KNOW, A CONCERN
OF A RUSH TO THE COURTHOUSE. AND
SO BECAUSE OF THAT, THE
EFFECTIVE DATE IS JUNE 19TH. SO
THEY WILL BE UNDER THIS NEW LAW.
WELL, THEN, GOOD WORK. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. ALL RIGHT. JUST
TO BE CLEAR, THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT IS THAT IF YOU FILED
AFTER JUNE 19TH, YOU ARE OUTSIDE
THE TIME LIMIT. YES. UNDER.
OKAY. YES. ALL RIGHT. SINCE
WE'RE MAKING HISTORY HERE, OTHER
QUESTIONS? ANYONE ELSE HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS? ALL RIGHT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
APOLOGIZE. I WASN'T THERE FOR
THE PRESENTATION THIS MORNING,
BUT I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP. I WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION, FOR
REALLY BRINGING ALL SIDES
TOGETHER. AND, OF COURSE, I WANT
TO THANK NOT ONLY MY SPONSORS,
BUT THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WELL, AS WELL, CLEARLY, EVERYONE
CAME TO THE TABLE IN GOOD FAITH,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
LONG IN CONVERSATION. AND I
THINK THE FACT THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT THIS
YEAR, THAT I BELIEVE STRIKES
THAT RIGHT BALANCE IS HISTORIC.
AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU. AND
I WOULD JUST ADVISE THAT, MAYBE
SUGGEST THAT YOU SEEK YOUR SENSE
OF SELF-WORTH FROM WITHIN. I
THINK YOU'LL BE VERY HAPPY WITH
WHAT YOU FIND. BUT WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I'LL TRY TO
TAKE THAT TO HEART. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
ROTH, WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL? YES. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
ROTH HAS MOVED THE BILL, MADAM
SECRETARY, IF YOU GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE VOTE, THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 28, AB 2288. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG I UMBERG
AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO. HUESO LAIRD.
NIELLO. ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN
WAHAB. ASHBY. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ALL RIGHT. 4 TO 0. OKAY, 4 TO 0.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
THIS, ROMANCE. SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO, HERE'S
HERE'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED. AND I KNOW THAT THAT
I'VE CREATED SOME CONFUSION. AND
THE NEXT BILL WILL BE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARL. CHAIR CARL WAS
BILL. THEN AFTER THAT, WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO REGULAR
ORDER, WHICH WOULD MEAN FILE
ITEM NUMBER 11, THEN FILE NUMBER
12. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO HERE. AND THEN Tê.
EXCUSE ME, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
SO ALL RIGHT. SO MEMBER RECALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 2773. AS
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS, I'LL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRING THE COURT
MAKE ITS FINDINGS IN WRITING AND
CLARIFYING THE PERMISSIBLE USE
OF COURT SANCTIONS FOR
SPOLIATION. AB 2773 GIVES
ELDERLY AND DEPENDENT ADULTS
PHYSICALLY ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
IN A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY FOR
THE ELDERLY, A CHANCE AT JUSTICE
WHEN THE DEFENDANT INTENTIONALLY
DESTROYS OR CONCEALS LEGAL
EVIDENCE IN RELATION TO A CIVIL
CASE UNDER THE ELDER ABUSE AND
DEPENDENT ADULT CIVIL PROTECTION
ACT, ALSO KNOWN AS VIDAK: VÀ,
THE BILL DOES THIS DOES THIS BY
APPLYING THE PREPONDERANCE OF
THE EVIDENCE STANDARD AS THE
BURDEN OF PROOF. IF THE JUDGE
FINDS SPOLIATION OF EVIDENCE BY
A DEFENDANT, OFTEN ELDER ABUSE
VICTIMS ARE UNABLE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY DUE TO SICKNESS OR
DEATH, AND THE UNUSUALLY HIGH
BURDEN OF PROOF IN THE ACT CAN
MAKE IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
JUSTIFY A CLAIM. THIS DIFFICULTY
IS COMPOUNDED WHEN THERE'S
INTENTIONAL AND WILLFUL
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE RELEVANT
TO THE CASE. AB 2773 IS NARROWLY
FOCUSED TO ONLY APPLY WHEN A
JUDGE DETERMINES THE DEFENDANT
ENGAGED IN SPOLIATION, AND THE
EVIDENCE IS MATERIAL TO THE
CLAIM. THE ELDER ABUSE AND
DEPENDENT ADULT CIVIL PROTECTION
ACT IS OFTEN THE ONLY WAY FOR
ELDER ABUSE VICTIMS TO HOLD
NURSING HOME OPERATORS
ACCOUNTABLE AND PROVIDE
COMPENSATION FOR THE VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES ON THEIR DAMAGES. AB
2773 WILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS OF ELDER
ABUSE. IN THESE RARE CASES AND
SERVE AS A MEANINGFUL DETERRENCE
AGAINST NURSING HOME OPERATORS
THAT INTENTIONALLY DESTROY OR
CONCEAL EVIDENCE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS
TONY CHICOTEL, STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM AND TERRY
BOYER, A VICTIM'S FAMILY MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANKS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF AB 2773, I WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. AND FOR ABOUT 40
YEARS, WE'VE RUN A STATE BAR.
GIVE US YOUR NAME ALSO. Þ TONY
CHICOTEL. SORRY. WE'VE RUN A
STATE BAR CERTIFIED LAWYER
REFERRAL SERVICE TO ASSIST
VICTIMS OF ELDER AND DEPENDENT
ADULT ABUSE. WE HEAR STORIES OF
ABUSE AND NEGLECT IN LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES PRETTY MUCH
EVERY DAY. BUT WE ONLY REFER A
SMALL, VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THE CASES THAT WE HEAR ABOUT TO
ATTORNEYS BECAUSE PROVING THEM
IS SO DIFFICULT, A VICTIM HAS TO
PROVE THAT THE FACILITY IS
LIABLE BY CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT THE FACILITY'S
CONDUCT WAS RECKLESS OR WORSE,
AND THAT THE CONDUCT WAS
RATIFIED BY A MANAGING AGENT.
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY TOUGH
BURDEN FOR OBTAINING JUSTICE FAR
GREATER THAN WHAT IS REQUIRED IN
TYPICAL CIVIL CASES, WHERE
LIABILITY ONLY NEED TO BE PROVEN
BY PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE
IN ELDER ABUSE CASES AGAINST
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES, WHEN
VICTIMS ARE OFTEN DEAD OR HAVE A
COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENT, AND
EYEWITNESSES ARE FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN, MEDICAL RECORDS AND
OTHER DOCUMENTS ARE PARTICULARLY
CRUCIAL. FACILITIES CURRENTLY
HAVE VERY LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR DESTROYING, CONCEALING, OR
FRAUDULENTLY ALTERING RECORDS,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE RISE OF
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS.
SPOLIATION OF ELECTRONIC HEALTH
CARE RECORDS IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO DETECT, REQUIRING
TIME CONSUMING AND EXPENSIVE
AUDIT TRAIL AND VIEW ACCESS
REVIEWS TO EXAMINE EVERY
KEYSTROKE MADE IN A RESIDENT'S
RECORD. NEITHER THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH OR DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES HAVE THE
STAFF WHO CAN UNDERTAKE THESE
KINDS OF REVIEWS. WE SUSPECT
THAT THE PREVALENCE OF
SPOLIATION IS INCREASING DUE TO
THE DIMINISHED EFFICACY OF THE
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. BETTER
DETERRENCE IS NEEDED. THERE ARE
SANCTIONS FOR SPOLIATION, BUT
NONE OF THEM IS AUTOMATIC.
LOWERING THE BURDEN OF PROOF
FROM CLEAR AND CONVINCING TO
PREPONDERANCE OF THE EVIDENCE IN
THESE SPECIAL CASES WOULD HELP
ENSURE DEFENDANTS DON'T TIP THE
SCALES OF JUSTICE BY FALSIFYING
EVIDENCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS TERRY
BOYER. IN 2021, OUR MOTHER, MARY
HOCKEMEYER, MOVED INTO A MEMORY
CARE FACILITY. WHILE THERE, SHE
WAS GIVEN THE SEDATIVE ATIVAN
AGAINST DOCTOR'S ORDERS FOR
STAFF CONVENIENCE. SHE SUFFERED
AT LEAST NINE AVOIDABLE FALLS,
AND SHE WAS ASSAULTED MULTIPLE
TIMES BY ANOTHER RESIDENT. OUR
FAMILY THOUGHT WE WERE DOING THE
BEST THING FOR HER BY PUTTING
HER THERE, BUT IT ENDED UP BEING
HER WORST NIGHTMARE. OUR MOM
ENDED UP SUFFERING A SEVERE HEAD
INJURY, WHICH LED TO HER DECLINE
AND HER DEATH, AND TO ADD INSULT
TO INJURY, THE FACILITY THEN
LIED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND
DESTROYED RECORDS. WHEN WE WENT
TO PROVE OUR CASE WHILE SHE WAS
AT THE FACILITY, MY SISTER AND I
RELIED ON THAT FACILITY TO GIVE
HER THE CARE SHE NEEDED AND TO
PUT INTO PLACE WHATEVER
INTERVENTIONS WERE NEEDED TO
KEEP HER SAFE. LIKE ALL THE
RESIDENTS THERE, MOM HAD
DEMENTIA AND WAS AT RISK FOR
FALLS, AND SHE NEEDED HELP IN
SUPERVISION. YET DURING THE TIME
SHE WAS EXPERIENCING ALL OF
THESE ISSUES, THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH STAFF AND THERE WASN'T AN
ADMINISTRATOR THERE TO MAKE SURE
THE FACILITY WAS PROVIDING THE
CARE AND INTERVENTIONS THAT WERE
NEEDED FOR MOM AND THE OTHER
RESIDENTS OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
MOTHER'S CASE, OUR ATTORNEYS
LEARNED THAT WHAT THE FACILITY'S
OWN POLICIES SAID WERE REQUIRED
WERE NOT PROVIDED FOR OUR MOM.
THEY ALSO LEARNED THAT THE
FACILITY MADE ENTRIES INTO HER
RECORDS THAT WERE INACCURATE,
AND THAT REQUIRED TRAININGS WERE
NOT DONE BECAUSE OF HER
DEMENTIA. OUR MOTHER WAS NOT
ABLE TO TELL US ABOUT THE LACK
OF STAFF DURING THE TIMES WE
WEREN'T PRESENT, OR TO TELL US
THAT THE STAFF THAT WAS THERE
WASN'T TRAINED. SHE COULDN'T.
BUT WE FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT TO
TESTIFY HERE AND SPEAK UP ABOUT
THE CARE SHE DID NOT RECEIVE AND
THE FACT THAT WHEN WE WENT TO
PURSUE JUSTICE FOR HER AFTER HER
LAST FALL, THE FACILITY WITHHELD
KEY DOCUMENTS RELATING TO
STAFFING, TRAINING AND FINANCIAL
INFORMATION. THE CARE FACILITY
DID THESE THINGS TO TRY TO COVER
THEIR OWN TRACKS AND AVOID
RESPONSIBILITY. THIS NARROW BILL
WOULD HELP HOLD FACILITIES LIKE
THIS ACCOUNTABLE, AND THEY, WHEN
THEY DON'T MEET THEIR
OBLIGATIONS AND LATER TRY TO
INTENTIONALLY DESTROY OR CHANGE
EVIDENCE TO ESCAPE LIABILITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2773, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, NANCY PAVARINI ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA, WE ARE A
CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. DOUGLAS
ALLEN, ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY WITH THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ. I'M ACTUALLY HERE ON
A DIFFERENT BILL, BUT I DO AM
AWARE OF THIS BILL. AND VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, WHETHER
YOU CAME HERE OR NOT, IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE FOR THAT PURPOSE. ALL
RIGHT. OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2773, PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEAT AT THE TABLE OR
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AS YOU
WOULD PREFER. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GO FIRST, MR. LEVINE? GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS, SHANE LEVINE, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES, AND ALSO MY
GOOD FRIEND BILL BARNEBEY JR, ON
BEHALF OF THE DOCTORS COMPANY
WHO COULDN'T BE HERE, I'LL BEGIN
BY SAYING WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
REGRETTABLY, THEY DON'T GO QUITE
FAR ENOUGH OR ADDRESS OUR CORE
ISSUE AROUND THE LOWERING OF THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD IN THIS
BILL OR ADDRESS THAT, AND THAT'S
OUR FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN, AND LET
ME BE CLEAR. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ACTUALLY A SPOLIATION OF
EVIDENCE PROBLEM IN THE INDUSTRY
OR IN THE STATE. IT DOES SOUND
LIKE, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, AND
I HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
SYMPATHY FOR THE SPONSORS AND
THEIR WITNESSES THAT IT DOES
SOUND LIKE SPOLIATION WAS
PROVEN, REMEDIES WERE SOUGHT.
AND ULTIMATELY THERE WAS REWARD.
AND I THINK WE SEE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. I DON'T
THINK WE SEE A PROBLEM OF
PERVASIVE SPOLIATION OF
EVIDENCE, AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS SPOLIATION OF EVIDENCE,
I THINK WE THINK THAT THE
SANCTIONS THAT THE JUDGE HAS AT
THEIR DISPOSAL RIGHT NOW ARE
MORE THAN APPROPRIATE, INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO A DIRECTED
VERDICT, SO WE THINK THERE'S
PLENTY OF OPTIONS AT THE
DISPOSAL OF THE JUDGE, AND
THAT'S SIMPLY WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING, THAT THE JUDGE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT DISCRETION OVER
WHETHER OR NOT TO LOWER THE
ACTUAL STANDARD, NOT TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
BEEN SPOLIATION. BUT THE
AUTOMATIC TRIGGER HERE WITH THE
STANDARD IS OUR PRINCIPAL
CONCERN. WE'D RATHER HAVE THE
JUDGE MAKE THAT DECISION. WHAT I
THINK FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL IS
ABOUT IS, IS PULLING INTO THREAD
ULTIMATELY OF THE ELDER ABUSE
ACT. SO THIS IS STEP ONE, I
THINK, OVER WHAT WILL BE A MULTI
YEAR EFFORT TO DO THAT, CREATING
A LOWER STANDARD, WITH
ULTIMATELY THAT IS BOUND TO THE
ELDER ABUSE ACT TO SEEK ENHANCED
REMEDIES. AND, AND THIS IS ONLY
FRANKLY, GOING TO LEAD TO
INCREASED RISK FOR ALL THE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEIR VULNERABILITY AND
FINANCIAL VIABILITY, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN THE INSURANCE
MARKET, RIGHT NOW, A LOT OF OUR
FACILITIES HAVE TO GO TO THE
SURPLUS LINES ASSOCIATION TO GET
THEIR THEIR LIABILITY INSURANCE
FIRST DOLLAR. THEY'RE PAYING OUT
UP TO 500 TO $1 MILLION, AND
THAT'S WHERE THE ATTACHMENT
POINTS ARE. A NUMBER OF THEM ARE
SELF-INSURED. AND IN CLOSING,
THANK YOU. MR. IN CLOSING, IN
CLOSING, WE WOULD ASK FOR A NO
VOTE AND THAT THE JUDGES HAVE
DISCRETION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS,
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS LAURIE
FERGUSON. I'M AN ATTORNEY AT
HANSON. BRIDGETT AND I REPRESENT
OUR CDFIS IN MY PRACTICE. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED LIVING ASSOCIATION TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THIS BILL WAS
NOT NEEDED BACK IN 2017 WHEN IT
WAS FIRST PROPOSED. AND IT'S NOT
NECESSARY TODAY. NOW, DON'T GET
ME WRONG, SPOLIATION OF EVIDENCE
IS NOT, APPROPRIATE. IT IS NOT
CONDONED, SHOULD NOT BE
CONDONED. SO THAT'S NOT THE
ISSUE. THE ISSUE IS WHETHER THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THAT, THAT CONCERN. RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF EFFECTIVE
AND SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO JUDGES TO DEAL
WITH SPOLIATION OF EVIDENCE WHEN
IT'S PROVEN IN A CASE. AND THESE
ARE WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE BASED ON THE PARTICULAR
FACTS AND CIRCUMSTANCES AND
EVIDENCE. WHAT THIS BILL INTENDS
TO DO IS TO REMOVE ALL
DISCRETION FROM OUR JUDGES IN
THESE TYPES OF CASES. ELDER
ABUSE CASES AGAINST SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. THERE WOULD BE NO
DISCRETION FOR THE JUDGE TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN LOWER THE
STANDARD OF PROOF, BUT THE JUDGE
WOULD ALSO HAVE THE WAY THE BILL
IS WRITTEN, THE ABILITY TO
IMPOSE OTHER PENALTIES AS WELL.
SO IT WOULD BE A DOUBLE PENALTY,
IN THESE SITUATIONS, WHAT'S
BEHIND THIS BILL IS REALLY THE
ENHANCED REMEDY OF ATTORNEY'S
FEES. SO ATTORNEY'S FEES ARE
REALLY DRIVING THIS. AND AS MR.
LEVIN MENTIONED, I THINK THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO INCREASE THE
COSTS OF THESE CASES WITH A
LOWER BURDEN OF PROOF. A
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY WOULD BE
FOOLISH NOT TO TRY TO FIND AN
ELEMENT OF SPOLIATION IN EVERY
SINGLE CASE. THEY WOULD THEY
WOULD HAVE TO REPRESENT THEIR
CLIENT AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
WIN ON THAT CAUSE OF ACTION. AND
I'M FEAR THAT THIS IS JUST GOING
TO DRIVE UP THE COST OF THESE
CASES, DRAG THEM OUT, AND
INCREASE THE BURDEN ON OUR
COURTS AND ON ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THESE ACTIONS. AS I
MENTIONED, SPOLIATION OF
EVIDENCE IS WRONG, BUT WE
ALREADY HAVE LAWS IN PLACE TO
DEAL WITH THIS ALREADY. THANK
YOU ALREADY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, OTHERS OPPOSED
TO AB 2773, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS JAMIE HUFF, ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M WITH CAL
CHAMBER. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
NAOMI PADRONA, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS ALLIED FOR PATIENT
PROTECTION, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
. THANK YOU. I AM WORKING WITH
LEADINGAGE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. YOU KNOW,
I USED TO BE A LAWYER, AND SO I
TAKE THE EVIDENTIARY STANDARD
PRETTY SERIOUSLY. AND LIKE, I DO
A VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS,
STANDARD STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
AND ISSUES LIKE THAT, CLEAR AND
CONVINCING IS A VERY HIGH
STANDARD. OBVIOUSLY, SOMEBODY
WHOEVER SET THAT THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE IN THESE CASES OF
ELDER ABUSE. AND SO I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING, THAT SHOULD
BE THE STANDARD THAT STICKS,
HOWEVER, YOU KNOW, WHEN I READ
THE BILL, READ THE ANALYSIS, AND
WHEN, WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
A JUDGE HAVING MADE A FINDING
THAT THERE WAS INTENTIONAL, FOR
EXAMPLE, DESTRUCTION OR
CONCEALMENT, INTENTIONAL
DESTRUCTION OR CONCEALMENT OF
EVIDENCE MATERIAL TO THE ISSUES
IN THE CASE, THAT'S PRETTY DARN
SERIOUS. AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE SANCTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE, IF I REMEMBER THEM IN
THE CODE, A MONETARY SANCTION, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT DOES IN THE
CASE OF ELDER ABUSE, UNLESS IT'S
FULL COMPENSATORY DAMAGES IN THE
CASE, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT AN
INSTRUCTION TO THE JURY THAT,
YOU KNOW, TO EITHER DISREGARD OR
DO SOMETHING ELSE OR MAYBE
THERE'S AN ORDER THAT PREVENTS
THE DEFENSE FROM FROM
INTRODUCING A CERTAIN PIECE OF
EVIDENCE. I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
REALLY REMEDIES A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE, AGAIN, AN
INTENTIONAL DESTRUCTION OR
CONCEALMENT OF MATERIAL EVIDENCE
, EVIDENCE MATERIAL TO THE ISSUE
IN THE CASE. I DON'T KNOW HOW A
PLAINTIFF WOULD MEET THE VERY
HIGH STANDARD OF CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE. IF THE
DEFENDANT HAS INTENTIONALLY
DESTROYED OR CONCEALED THE
EVIDENCE THAT THE PLAINTIFF
MIGHT NEED TO PRESENT THE CASE.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON, I WOULD
THINK THAT THE ONLY OPTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS WOULD THAT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE WOULD BE
EITHER THE LOWERING OF THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD OR A
DIRECTED VERDICT. AND YOU
PROBABLY DON'T WANT A DIRECTED
VERDICT. AND SO IT WOULD SEEM TO
ME THE LESSER OPTION, THE MORE
FAVORABLE OPTION TO THOSE THAT
ENGAGED IN INTENTIONAL
DESTRUCTION OR CONCEALMENT OF
MATERIAL EVIDENCE WOULD BE THE
LESSENING OF THE STANDARD WHERE
SOMEBODY STILL HAS TO OFFER
PROOF, JUST PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE AS OPPOSED TO CLEAR AND
CONVINCING. SO THAT'S WHAT
CONVINCED ME, TO GO ALONG WITH
THE REDUCTION IN THE EVIDENTIARY
STANDARD IN THIS CASE, WHICH I
OTHERWISE WOULD PROBABLY NOT DO.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? SENATOR. SENATOR
ASHBY. YES SO, YEAH, I HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT THIS BILL ON ITS
FACE, OF COURSE, IS SEEMS VERY
SIMPLE AND DIDN'T COME TO MY
ATTENTION UNTIL REALLY RECENTLY
TO TAKE A DEEPER LOOK. AND WHILE
I SHARE, SENATOR ROTH'S PROBABLY
CONCLUSION, I HAVE STILL A
LINGERING CONCERN. I TOO,
RECENTLY WENT THROUGH THE VERY
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
SENDING MY FATHER TO A CARE
FACILITY. I'M SURE MANY OF US
HAVE. AND YOU KNOW, YOU WORRY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT IN CONTROL
OF EVERYTHING AROUND THEM. THEY
CAN'T TELL YOU ALL THE THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THERE'S AN ENTIRE
GROUP OF PEOPLE OUT THERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO CAN'T EVEN AFFORD
THAT CARE WHEN THEY NEED IT. AND
I WORRY ABOUT HOW THIS TYPE OF
EFFORT WOULD PUSH ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF AN ALREADY DIFFICULT
SITUATION. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE
HERE BETWEEN, EVIDENTIARY
STANDARDS, WHICH ASIDE FROM, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY DISBARMENT AS
WELL, BEING ONE OF THE PENALTIES
FOR, YOU KNOW, TAMPERING WITH
EVIDENCE AND VARIOUS OTHER
CRIMINAL CHARGES THAT COULD
ENSUE, WHICH I THINK CAN'T BE
IGNORED IN THIS SPACE. I WOULD
OBVIOUSLY HAPPEN. YOU AND I BOTH
KNOW THAT. BUT, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, WOULD THIS BILL HELP US
TO REDUCE USE ABUSE AND NEGLECT
ON ADULTS? I DON'T KNOW, I THINK
IT WOULD HELP PROVE THE CASE
EASIER. WHERE THERE WHERE THIS
SPECIFIC FACT SET IS IN PLAY,
BECAUSE IT WOULD REDUCE THE
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD. BUT FROM A
PREVENTATIVE STANDPOINT, I'M NOT
SURE. AND WILL IT INSTEAD CREATE
AN ADDITIONAL EXPENSE WHERE THE
COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN THIS
SPACE IS ALREADY VERY HIGH? GET
HIGHER? THAT'S MY CONCERN. SO
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC, I REALLY MY QUESTION IS
FOR YOU, SENATOR KALRA. DO YOU I
MEAN, YOU SAW THE LINE OF FOLKS,
THOSE ARE NOT THE NORMAL FOLKS
THAT WOULD I MEAN, THOSE I WOULD
THINK THOSE FOLKS WOULD HAVE
BEEN HERE IN SUPPORT. DO YOU
HAVE A PLAN TO TALK TO THEM
ABOUT SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
MOVING FORWARD? ARE THERE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU STILL CAN SEE IN
THIS BILL THAT YOU COULD WORK ON
WITH THEM TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY HAVE? WELL, THANK YOU,
SENATOR. I MEAN, THE AS THE
OPPOSITION INDICATED, YOU KNOW,
THIS THE ISSUE OF SPOLIATION IS
NOT RAMPANT. AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING. YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE,
FACILITIES THAT ARE
INTENTIONALLY CONCEALING AND
DESTROYING EVIDENCE, I DO THINK
IT IS A NARROWLY TAILORED BILL,
OBVIOUSLY, I THINK THERE IS
GOING TO BE CONCERNS GENERALLY
FROM AN INDUSTRY, JUST TO YOUR
POINT, THAT THERE COULD BE MORE
LITIGATION, WHAT HAVE YOU. BUT
THIS ONLY COMES INTO PLAY WHEN
THERE'S BEEN SOME PRETTY
EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR. I THINK
THERE COULD BE A BENEFIT FROM
THIS IN THAT THERE WILL BE
INTERNAL PROTOCOLS THAT WILL
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR HOW YOU
HANDLE RECORDS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU. AND THAT COULD VERY WELL
LEAD TO LESS LITIGATION, BECAUSE
IF EVERYTHING'S CLEAR OUT IN THE
TABLE, IT ALLOWS ALL PARTIES TO
COME TOGETHER AND SAY, OKAY,
THESE ARE THE FACTS. LET'S TRY
TO RESOLVE THIS AS OPPOSED TO A
SCENARIO LIKE THIS, WHERE IT
ALMOST INSISTS UPON, YOU KNOW,
ASKING, YOU KNOW, DIVING DEEPER
INTO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN EVIDENCE HAS
BEEN DESTROYED. ULTIMATELY, WHAT
WE WANT IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
SITUATION LIKE THIS DON'T OCCUR.
AND I THINK THAT THAT CREATES
THE LEVEL PLAYING FIELD, SO TO
SPEAK, WITH THE FACT IS, IF
SPOLIATION DOESN'T OCCUR, A
HIGHER BURDEN IS THERE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST. SO I DON'T
THINK THAT WILL NECESSARILY LEAD
TO MORE LITIGATION, BECAUSE WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IS WHEN THE RECORDS
ARE PRESERVED AND THERE ARE
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ISN'T ANY DESTRUCTION
OF EVIDENCE. FRANKLY, WHETHER
IT'S INTENTIONAL OR OTHERWISE, I
THINK THIS WOULD LEAD TO
ACTUALLY A BETTER, A SYSTEM IN
PLACE THAT WILL LIKELY LESS
LITIGATION BECAUSE THAT HIGHER
STANDARD IS GOING TO BE THERE,
BY THE PLAINTIFF. THE LOWER
STANDARD ONLY OCCURS. AND THE
FEARS THAT THERE WILL BE MORE
LITIGATION ONLY OCCURS WHEN
THERE'S INTENTIONAL, INTENTIONAL
DESTRUCTION OR CONCEALING
EVIDENCE, WHICH AGAIN, I THINK
IS A VERY RARE INSTANCE. BUT SO
TO THE POINT OF COMING TO A
BROADER CONSENSUS, ARE THERE
STILL POINTS IN THE BILL THAT
YOU CAN WORK ON WITH THE FOLKS
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED QUITE A FEW
TIMES. I ACTUALLY DO APPRECIATE
THE CHAIR'S ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. THE COMMITTEE'S
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS. I THINK
THAT INCLUDING MAKING REQUIRING
A COURT TO MAKE ITS FINDING,
FINDING AS A WRITING FINDINGS IN
WRITING, IN I THINK AT THIS
POINT, LOOK, YOU KNOW, I, I'M
SOMEONE THAT ALWAYS TRIES TO
FIND A COMMON GROUND WITH EVERY
ESPECIALLY WITH OPPOSITION
THAT'S DOING A WORK THAT'S
IMPORTANT, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT. IN
THIS CASE, I THINK THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO THERE'S JUST A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT ON THE
STANDARD BEING REDUCED IN THESE
NARROW SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
SO I THINK WE'VE GONE AS FAR AS
WE'VE GONE, ALTHOUGH MY DOOR IS
ALWAYS OPEN, MY, MY, MY TABLE IS
ALWAYS THERE FOR ANY OTHER
SUGGESTIONS THAT MIGHT BE THERE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY. OTHER
QUESTIONS? NO, SORRY. SENATOR
ROTH, JUST JUST TO TIE IN TO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID. I'M
FRANKLY NOT SURE THAT THIS BILL
MAKES IT EASIER TO PROVE THE
CASE. REMEMBER, THERE'S BEEN AN
INTENTIONAL DESTRUCTION OR
CONCEALMENT OF MATERIAL EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD HELP PROVE THE CASE.
SO IF ANYTHING ELSE, WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS LEVEL THE PLAYING.
TRY TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
GIVEN THE INTENTIONAL CONDUCT
THAT HAS BEEN ALREADY FOUND BY A
JUDGE DURING THE COURSE OF THE
PROCEEDING. SO ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ROTH. OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SO LET ME
JUST ASK, MISS FERGUSON, YOU'VE
TRIED THESE CASES BEFORE. IS
THAT RIGHT? AND WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING THE CASE, DO YOU TRY TO
PUT TOGETHER ALL THE MATERIAL
EVIDENCE THAT HELPS TO BASICALLY
ADVANCE YOUR DEFENSE? WELL, OF
COURSE, YOU KNOW, AS AN
ATTORNEY, ANY ATTORNEY WHO'S
REPRESENTING A DEFENDANT IN ONE
OF THESE CASES HAS OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE DISCOVERY ACT AND THE
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE TO
RESPOND TO DISCOVERY REQUESTS.
AND I DON'T MEAN RESPOND. I
MEAN, IN TERMS OF YOUR
AFFIRMATIVE DISCOVERY AND YOUR
AFFIRMATIVE INVESTIGATION, WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS PUT
TOGETHER ALL THE MATERIAL FACTS
THAT SUPPORT YOUR YOUR CAUSE,
YOU KNOW, AND WHEN YOU FIND THAT
SOMEONE HAS DESTROYED THAT
MATERIAL EVIDENCE, DO YOU FIND
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO PROVE THE
CASE? IF THAT EVIDENCE IS GONE?
I CAN'T SAY THAT I'VE PERSONALLY
HAD A SITUATION WHERE EVIDENCE
WAS DESTROYED, TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
SORT OF HARD TO KNOW IF THE
EVIDENCE IS NOT THERE. WHETHER
IT HELPS OR HURTS WOULD YOU
AGREE? I WOULD AGREE, AND PART
OF MY BIG CONCERN ABOUT THIS
BILL IS I THINK, CONTRARY TO
WHAT I THINK THE INTENT IS TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT ALL THE
EVIDENCE IS PRODUCED. I THINK
IT'S GOING TO CREATE A PERVERSE
INCENTIVE TO MAKE THESE CASES
MORE DRAWN OUT AND MORE
EXPENSIVE, BECAUSE THERE'S THAT
CARROT OUT THERE OF, OH, YOU
KNOW, A LOWER STANDARD OF PROOF
IN THESE CASES. AND SO I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE AND
MORE, LITIGATION AIMED AT TRYING
TO DETERMINE IF EVIDENCE IS
MISSING. WE DON'T WANT TO
ENCOURAGE DISCOVERY LITIGATION,
BUT, THIS IS AN UNUSUAL MATTER.
AND I LEARNED SOMETHING NEW
EVERY DAY. I WAS NOT AWARE THAT
YOU HAD TO PROVE BY CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE. AND AS
SENATOR ROTH POINTS OUT, BY THE
WAY, SENATOR ROTH IS STILL AN
EXCELLENT LAWYER. BY THE WAY,
SENATOR ROTH, THAT THAT'S A
HIGHER STANDARD THAN THAN
PREPONDERANCE IN NORMAL CASES,
PREPONDERANCE OF PROOF IS THE
STANDARD OF PROOF THAT'S
REQUIRED. IS THAT RIGHT, IN MOST
CIVIL CASES, YES. THERE ARE
OTHER CAUSES OF ACTION THAT DO
HAVE A CLEAR AND CONVINCING
EVIDENCE STANDARD. AND WHEN THIS
BILL WAS FIRST, YOU KNOW, CAME
ABOUT YEARS AND YEARS AGO,
BEFORE I WAS INVOLVED, I BELIEVE
THAT THERE WAS THE REASON THE
HIGHER BURDEN OF PROOF WAS
ESTABLISHED WAS IN EXCHANGE FOR
THE ENHANCED DAMAGES THAT
PROVING AN ELDER ABUSE ACTION
AFFORDS THE PLAINTIFFS. SO IT
WAS A GIVE AND TAKE. AND SO THE
EFFORTS TO TRY TO, EAT AWAY AT
THAT HIGHER STANDARD OF PROOF
ARE PROBLEMATIC. OKAY. IN CASE
IN THIS CASE, WITH THIS BILL, IT
DOESN'T REMOVE A JUDGE'S
DISCRETION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THAT JUDGE FINDS MATERIALITY OR
NOT. THE JUDGE HAS THE
DISCRETION TO FIND WHETHER
SOMETHING IS MATERIAL OR NOT. IS
THAT RIGHT? I DON'T THINK THAT
THE FINDING OF MATERIALITY IS AN
ISSUE OF DISCRETION. FOR THE
JUDGE THAT WOULD BE LOOKED AT
BASED ON THE FACTS. SO IT
DISCRETIONARY DETERMINATION BY A
JUDGE IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN,
DOING A FINDING. WHOO HOO! IN
TRYING THESE CASES, WHO WOULD
FIND MATERIALITY? WHO WOULD MAKE
THAT FINDING OF FACT? IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE JUDGE WOULD. BUT WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT'S NOT A
MATTER OF DISCRETION. THE JUDGE
WOULD HAVE TO BASE THAT DECISION
BASED ON THE FACTS. OKAY. SO THE
JUDGE WOULD ANALYZE THE FACTS
AND MAKE THE DECISION AS TO
WHETHER THAT'S MATERIAL OR NOT.
RIGHT. YOU AGREE WITH THAT. ALL
RIGHT. AND THEN IN TERMS OF
INTENTIONALITY, THE JUDGE WOULD
HAVE THE DISCRETION AS TO FIND
OUT WHETHER THAT WAS DONE BY
VIRTUE OF NEGLIGENCE OR VIRTUE
OF INTENTIONALITY. IS THAT STILL
WITHIN THE JUDGE'S DISCRETION?
NO. DISCRETION IS A IS A SPECIAL
LEGAL CONCEPT. JUDGES HAVE
DISCRETION WHEN THEY HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS. AND BASED ON,
YOU KNOW, VARIOUS INFORMATION OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THEY CAN DO
ONE THING OR ANOTHER AND IT
WOULD BE UPHELD ON APPEAL,
MAKING A FINDING OF FACT IS NOT
A MATTER OF DISCRETION FOR THE
JUDGE. SO MAKING A DETERMINATION
OF INTENTIONALITY OR
MATERIALITY, I DON'T BELIEVE,
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE JUDGE'S
DISCRETION, BUT RATHER A FINDING
OF FACT BASED ON THE EVIDENCE.
YOU'VE GOT ME VERY CONFUSED NOW,
VERY CONFUSED AS TO WHO FINDS
MATERIALITY. I THINK IT'S THE
JUDGE AND WHO FINDS
INTENTIONALITY. I THINK IT'S THE
JUDGE. RIGHT. BUT IN THE JUDGE,
YOU'RE SAYING HAS NO DISCRETION
AS TO THAT EVALUATION OF
MATERIALITY OR INTENTIONALITY.
IS THAT IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING? I THINK THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE TWO
OF US ABOUT THE MEANING OF THE
TERM DISCRETION. I SEE. OKAY,
AND SO DISCRETION AND I DON'T
SORRY, I DON'T HAVE MY LAW BOOKS
HERE TO GIVE YOU THE ACTUAL
LEGAL DEFINITION. BUT WHEN, FOR
EXAMPLE, ON APPEAL, WHEN A COURT
OF APPEALS LOOKING AT A DECISION
OR SOMETHING DONE IN THE LOWER
COURT BASED ON AN ABUSE OF
DISCRETION STANDARD, IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT STANDARD THAN LOOKING
AT IT, DE NOVO. AND I BELIEVE
THAT A DETERMINATION OF
MATERIALITY OR INTENTIONALITY
WOULD LIKELY BE LOOKED AT DE
NOVO IN THE COURT OF APPEALS. I
THINK WE PROBABLY HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. I THINK
THAT'S WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT FINDING. BUT NEVERTHELESS,
I'LL LET IT GO. SO, OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THIS HAS BEEN
HELPFUL TO ME, ALL RIGHT. HAS
THERE BEEN A MOTION? SENATOR
ROTH, DID YOU MOVE THE BILL,
SURE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR ROTH'S MOVED THE
BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CARO,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR, I THINK
ULTIMATELY, THE FEAR THAT THIS
WILL LEAD TO PLAINTIFF'S
ATTORNEYS BRINGING CLAIMS OF
SPOLIATION. THE GUARDRAIL TO
THAT IS THE JUDGE. THE JUDGE IS
THE ONE THAT MAKES THAT
DETERMINATION. AND SO I THINK,
YOU KNOW, THERE THERE'S STILL A
HIGH HURDLE THERE. BEFORE IT
WOULD EVEN GET REMOTELY CLOSE TO
A REDUCTION IN THE STANDARD OF
PROOF. SO WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. JUST JUST TO
NOTE, AND WE DID ADD THE
REQUIREMENT OF WRITTEN FINDINGS.
AND OF COURSE, JUDGES ARE NOT
LAZY AND THEY LIKE TO MAKE
WRITTEN FINDINGS. SO THIS ADDS
ANOTHER LEVEL OF DISCERNMENT. IF
YOU WILL, IN TERMS OF THOSE
FINDINGS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH.
MADAM SECRETARY, IF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL, THIS IS FOR ITEM
NUMBER 29 AB 2773. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK NØ WILK. NO. ALLEN
ASHBY. CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD
NILO. ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB
2 TO 1. 2 TO 1. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON, I THINK
YOU'RE HERE. YES, YOU ARE ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. I NOTE YOU
DIDN'T BRING YOUR ASSISTANT
TODAY. YOU'RE BRENNAN, YOU
DIDN'T BRING BRENNAN. NO, NO,
HE'S HE'S IN THE OFFICE. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, SO, MR.
CALDERON, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. SIR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2752
WOULD REQUIRE THE JUVENILE COURT
TO SET THE FREQUENCY AND
DURATION OF FAMILY VISITATION AT
THE INITIAL PETITION HEARING,
WHEN A CHILD IS FIRST PLACED IN
THE CALIFORNIA WELFARE SERVICES
SYSTEM AT SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS,
THE BILL REQUIRES THE COURT TO
ORDER UNSUPERVISED FAMILY VISITS
UNLESS THE COURT FINDS THAT
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION WILL
HARM THE PHYSICAL OR EMOTIONAL
HEALTH OF THE CHILD. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2752 IS SARAH
COOK, WHO SERVES AS THE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY AND LEGAL SERVICES FOR
DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY, ADVOCACY
CENTER, AND DAVE SCHUSTER, THE
MENTORING PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY CENTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS SARAH
COOK, AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND LEGAL SERVICES WITH
DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY CENTER IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. I HAVE
REPRESENTED PARENTS AND MINORS
IN JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT AS
COURT APPOINTED COUNSEL FOR THE
PAST 11 YEARS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
2752, WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
SAFE, HIGH QUALITY, MEANINGFUL
FAMILY TIME OCCURS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA. FAMILY
SEPARATION INFLICTS PROFOUND
DAMAGE ON CHILDREN AND PARENTS.
CHILDREN OFTEN EXPERIENCE FEAR,
ANXIETY, SADNESS, ANGER, AND
CONFUSION. VISITATION IS NOT
ONLY THE LINCHPIN OF SUCCESSFUL
FAMILY REUNIFICATION, BUT ALSO A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR MITIGATING
TRAUMA. BY ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN IN CARE CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY KNOW AND LOVE THE MOST.
THEIR PARENTS. UNFORTUNATELY,
QUALITY FAMILY TIME IS NOT
HAPPENING FOR MANY FOSTER
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
BECAUSE UNDER CURRENT LAW, THERE
ARE ALMOST NO GUIDELINES FOR
COURTS REGARDING VISITATION. AS
A RESULT, COURTS OFTEN DEFAULT
TO SUPERVISED VISITATION ORDERS,
WHICH ARE OFTEN UNNECESSARILY
RESTRICTIVE, DIFFICULT TO
SCHEDULE, UNCOMFORTABLE AND
UNNATURAL FOR FAMILIES, AND
COSTLY FOR THE DEPARTMENT. IN
2020, THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION ON
CHILDREN, YOUTH AND FAMILIES
PUBLISHED OFFICIAL GUIDANCE
STATING THAT FAMILY TIME SHOULD
BE PRESUMED UNSUPERVISED, ABSENT
AN IDENTIFIED PRESENT DANGER OF
HARM, WITH THE MOST RECENT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, THE
LANGUAGE OF AB 2752 MIRRORS THIS
FEDERAL GUIDANCE AND WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE ADOPTED THESE
STANDARDS. THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE
ALSO MAKES CLEAR THAT THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE OF PARENT CHILD
VISITATION TO SHOULD BE TO
FACILITATE FAMILY TIME. IT IS
NOT TO ASSESS OR IMPROVE
PARENTING SKILLS. NEVERTHELESS,
THERE IS NOTHING IN OUR BILL
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT THE
DEPARTMENT FROM SCHEDULING TIME.
IN ADDITION TO A VISIT TO
OBSERVE AND ASSESS PARENT CHILD
INTERACTIONS OR THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT THE DEPARTMENT IN AN
APPROPRIATE CASE FROM
RECOMMENDING COACHING OR OTHER
SERVICES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WITNESS, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS DAVE SCHUSTER AND I'M
A FORMER PARENT IN THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. AND I'M
CURRENTLY EMPLOYED AS DAX,
MENTOR PARENT PROGRAM MANAGER.
I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WITH VISITATION AND
ITS IMPACT ON MY FAMILY, WHICH
UNDERSCORES WHY VOTING AYE ON AB
2752 IS SO IMPORTANT. WE WERE
TOLD VISITS WOULD BE MONITORED
FOR A TIME TO ASSESS THE SAFETY.
FOR MY DAUGHTER. THIS WAS
COMPLETELY UNWARRANTED AND THE
TRAUMA FROM THIS EXPERIENCE
STILL HAUNTS HER. OUR VISITS
WERE DONE IN AN OLD OFFICE
BUILDING, BROKEN TOYS WITH
BROKEN TOYS AND BOOKS WITH PAGES
MISSING. WE FELT WE COULDN'T
COMPLAIN. WE WERE FINALLY ABLE
TO HUG OUR CHILD, AND WE DIDN'T
WANT TO RISK THAT IN ANY WAY.
SOME OF THE OFFICES HAD WINDOWS,
NOT SURE IF THIS WAS A GOOD
THING, BECAUSE IT WAS A CONSTANT
REMINDER OF WHAT WE USED TO DO
AS A FAMILY AND FEARED WE WOULD
NEVER DO AGAIN. I WOULD VISIT MY
SEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER TWO
TIMES A WEEK FOR TWO HOURS PER
VISIT. THE MOTHER VISITED THE
SAME, KEEPING A VERY ACTIVE
SEVEN YEAR OLD CHILD OCCUPIED
FOR EIGHT HOURS, A WEEK WITH
LIMITED SPACE AND ACTIVITIES,
WAS AN UNFAIR AND RIDICULOUS
TEST OF PARENTING MY DAUGHTER
WAS MOST UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
MONITORS OF THE VISIT. THEY SAT
IN THE DOORWAY WITH THE
COMPUTER, TYPING EVERY WORD THAT
WAS SAID BETWEEN US. THIS MADE
HER VERY UNCOMFORTABLE AND
HELPED HER TO WITHDRAW. SHE
WOULD WHISPER TO ME, WHY ARE
THEY SITTING THERE? JUST TO BE
TOLD, YOU CANNOT WHISPER. YOU
NEED TO SPEAK UP, SO SHE JUST
WOULDN'T TALK AT ALL. I HAVE
NEVER FELT SO POWERLESS AND
SHAMEFUL AND RIDDLED WITH GUILT
SINCE WE WERE THERE BECAUSE OF
OUR ACTIONS AND OUR ADDICTIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY, MY CHILD PAID THE
PRICE FOR THAT AND STILL
CONTINUES TO, DESPITE TESTING,
CLEAN AND COMPLETING, COMPLYING
WITH OUR CASE PLAN. SUPERVISED
VISITATION CONTINUED FOR SEVEN
MONTHS AT ANY POINT, MY PARENTS,
WHO WERE MY DAUGHTER, WAS PLACED
WITH, COULD SUPERVISE OUR VISIT
IN THEIR HOME OR AT A NEARBY
PARK. THESE SUGGESTIONS WERE
ALWAYS DISREGARDED AND TOLD BY
THE DEPARTMENT. IS NOT YET TIME.
LET'S CHANGE THAT VOTE. I ON AB
2752 AND PROTECT CHILD'S RIGHT
TO QUALITY FAMILY TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2752, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR POSITION AND YOUR
AFFILIATION. SEEING NO ONE
COMING FORWARD, LET'S NOW TURN
TO THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2752, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. YOU MAY
SIT DOWN OR SPEAK FOR THE MIC.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
SENATORS, MY NAME IS AMANDA
KIRCHNER. I'M WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE STILL IN AN OPPOSED
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS TODAY.
WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE ASKED
FOR, AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS BILL, AS WE HAVE
BEEN FOR QUITE SOME TIME, I DO
WANT TO NOTE FOR THE PANEL THAT
SUPERVISED VISITATION IS NOT A
PUNISHMENT FOR OUR PARENTS WHEN
WE ARE REMOVING A CHILD, WE ARE
DOING SO BECAUSE THERE IS A
THREAT TO THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR
SAFETY, THEIR EMOTIONAL
WELL-BEING. AND SO WE DO NOT
TAKE THAT LIGHTLY TO HAVE A
DEFAULT OF UNSUPERVISED
VISITATION AT THE VERY START OF
A CASE WHERE WE ARE STILL TRYING
TO ASSESS PARENTING SKILLS,
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN THE PARENT
AND CHILD, OTHER ALLEGATIONS
THAT MIGHT BE AMENDED INTO THE
COMPLAINT, WE FEEL IS A VERY
BROAD STEP. AND THE STANDARD
THAT'S OUTLINED RIGHT NOW IN THE
BILL, WE THINK IS JUST A LITTLE
BIT TOO HIGH. I WANT TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE THAT CAME FROM ONE OF
OUR CHILD WELFARE DIRECTORS.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE PARENTS
HAVE SO FEW PARENTING SKILLS
THAT THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY AN
IDENTIFIABLE DANGER, BUT TO
ACTUALLY HAVE THEM BE THERE
UNSUPERVISED WITH THE CHILD
WITHOUT SOME SORT OF GUIDANCE OR
OTHER SORT OF NAVIGATION WITH
THE SOCIAL WORKER. WE HAVE FOUND
ACTUALLY HELPS ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PARENT,
THE SOCIAL WORKER. IT HELPS
TEACH THOSE SKILLS AND IT HELPS
CREATE TRUST BETWEEN THEM, WHICH
WE KNOW IS CRITICAL FOR THEM IN
HELPING CREATE AND FINISH THEIR
CASE PLANS. AND EVENTUALLY
REUNIFY. AND SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE
JUST THAT STANDARD ADJUSTED DOWN
A LITTLE BIT. WE HAVE SOME
OUTSTANDING, AMENDMENTS AS I
TALKED ABOUT, BUT AT THE MOMENT
WE ARE STILL IN OPPOSITION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
IS THERE A MOTION? SENATOR ROTH
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES THANK
YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, MADAM SECRETARY, IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 11, AB 2752.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES. UMBERG HI, I WILK NÓ
WILK NÓ ALLEN ASHBY CABALLERO.
DURAZZO. LAIRD MILO. ROTH. ROTH
I STERN. WAHAB. 2 TO 1. ALL
RIGHT, 2 TO 1. WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT THE VERY PATIENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO. YOU'VE
BEEN HERE FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMENZÓ. OH, I'M
SORRY, YOU'RE PRESENTING ANOTHER
BILL. I AM FALSE START. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO. SO ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. YEAH YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT, I BELIEVE AB 2244. IS
THAT RIGHT? CORRECT. OKAY OKAY,
LET'S FILE, NUMBER 46 FOR THOSE
WHO ARE FOLLOWING AT HOME WITH
YOUR PLAYBOOK THERE. YES, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHIL TING, AB 2244. FIRST
OF ALL, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
TING, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB 2244 WOULD
PROHIBIT THE USE OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED BIPHENOL BPA
IN PAPER RECEIPTS BY JANUARY
2025 AND ALL INTENTIONALLY ADDED
BIPHENOL CHEMICALS AND PAPER
RECEIPTS BY JANUARY 2026.
RECEIPTS GENERATE MILLIONS OF
POUND OF WEIGHT, POUNDS OF WASTE
AND BILLIONS OF POUNDS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE A YEAR. THIS
NON-RECYCLABLE RECEIPT WASTE
CONTAMINATES RECYCLABLE PAPER
MATERIALS AND IS EXTREMELY
HARMFUL TO HUMAN HEALTH.
HANDLING RECEIPTS ON A DAILY
BASIS CAUSES HIGH EXPOSURE TO
BPA AND BPPS, WHICH ARE BOTH
LINKED TO CANCER AND OTHER
HEALTH ISSUES. PROHIBITING THE
USE OF BIPHENOL CHEMICALS WILL
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS BY
ELIMINATING TOXIC CONTAMINATION
IN PAPER WASTE AND MAXIMIZE
MAXIMIZE OUR ABILITY TO RECYCLE
PAPER PRODUCTS. IT'S CRITICAL
THAT BOTH BUSINESSES AND
MANUFACTURERS MAKE THE SWITCH TO
SAFER ALTERNATIVES. IF PAPER
RECEIPTS TO HELP BETTER PROTECT
OUR CASHIERS AND CONSUMERS.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2244, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S TURN NOW TO OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2244,
PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH, LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. IS THERE A MOTION? SENATOR
ASHBY MOVES THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS FILE, ITEM NUMBER 46, AB
2244. MOTION IS TO PASS. IS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG I UMBERG.
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE LAIRD.
NHIÀU. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN.
WATT. 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO. PUT THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THE LONG SUFFERING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, CARILLO AND I.
SEE ALSO LONG SUFFERING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG HERE. YOU'RE AFTER
YOU'RE NEXT IN LINE. SO. AB
2371, FILE ITEM NUMBER 12. IS
THAT RIGHT? THAT IS CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT, CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE TEAM FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. SENATORS ELECTRIC FENCES
ARE PROVEN TO PROVIDE AN
EFFECTIVE AND SAFE DETERRENT FOR
BUSINESSES SEEKING TO PROTECT
LARGE AND HEAVY PRODUCTS THAT
MUST BE STORED OUTDOORS.
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION, AS WELL AS
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS, HAVE
ENSURED THAT THESE FENCES ARE
SAFE. IN FACT, DESPITE THE
THOUSANDS OF FENCES INSTALLED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN AN INJURY, MUCH
LESS A FATALITY, CAUSED BY ONE
OF THESE FENCES. THESE FENCES
DO, HOWEVER, SERVE AS A
DETERRENT AND AN EFFECTIVE ALARM
SYSTEM, PARTICULARLY FOR
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE EQUIPPED
EQUIPMENT OR INVENTORY THAT MUST
BE STORED OUTDOORS WHEN THEIR
EXISTING LAW AND ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCE MAY ONLY BE
INSTALLED AND OPERATED INSIDE
THE EXTERIOR FENCE OR WALL ON A
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY, A PERSON
CAN ONLY COME INTO CONTACT WITH
THE ELECTRIFIED SECURITY FENCE
IF AND ONLY IF HE OR SHE COMMITS
TRESPASS AND BREACHES THE FENCE
OR WALL. SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE EMBRACED EXISTING LAWS THAT
GOVERNS THE INSTALLATION OF
OPERATIONAL STANDARDS OF
SECURITY, ALARM SYSTEMS, AND
WORK QUICKLY WITH BUSINESSES AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE DELAYED PERMIT
APPLICATIONS FOR YEARS WHEN
ISSUING PERMITS TO INSTALL SUCH
SECURITY SYSTEMS. CURRENTLY,
THERE ARE ALMOST 400 BUSINESSES
WAITING FOR THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ISSUE APPROVAL,
AND MOST CONCERNING THESE
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN WAITING ON
AVERAGE FOR MORE THAN ONE YEAR
AND STILL DON'T HAVE APPROVAL
YET. HB 2371 ADDRESSES THIS BY
REQUIRING THAT THE LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THAT OF OTHER SECURITY
ALARM SYSTEMS, AND REINFORCES
EXISTING LAW THAT REQUIRES THE
SECURITY FENCES AND INSTALLING
LABEL IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT WILL
BE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ANYONE TO ACCIDENTALLY COME INTO
CONTACT WITH ONE. FOR THE PAST
EIGHT YEARS, AND HAVE MORE THAN
1000 PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, INCLUDING PUBLIC AGENCIES
SUCH AS CAL FIRE AND CITY PUBLIC
WORKS DEPARTMENTS. ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCING BASICALLY
FENCES INSIDE A FENCE HAVE BEEN
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY SECURING
PROPERTIES AND EMPLOYEES WITHOUT
INCIDENTS. UNDER OUR BILL, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALSO RETAIN THE
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO MAKE LOCAL
ZONING DECISIONS THAT DICTATE
WHERE THESE TYPE OF SYSTEMS CAN
BE USED. FOR EXAMPLE, YOU CANNOT
PUT AN ELECTRIFIED FENCE ON A
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY YOU NEED ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS DOCTOR
MARK CROLL, PROFESSOR EMERITUS
OF CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO, AND
LARS FREIBERG, A HARD WORKING
LOCAL BUSINESS OWNER. ALSO HERE
IS KEITH KENNEDY WITH AMAROK TO
BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. PARTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE ACCEPTED,
YOU'RE GOING TO BASICALLY ACCEPT
THOSE IN THE NECK, PUT THOSE IN
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE. IS THAT
RIGHT? THAT IS CORRECT, SIR. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. FIRST WITNESS, MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS DOCTOR
MARK KROLL. I'M A BIOMEDICAL
SCIENTIST WITH A SPECIALTY IN
BIOELECTRICITY, WITH A SPECIAL
FOCUS ON THE EFFECTS OF
ELECTRICITY ON HUMANS AND
ANIMALS. I'M AS CHAIRMAN CARILLO
MARKED AS CONGRESSMAN CARRILLO
MENTIONED, I AM A PROFESSOR
EMERITUS OF BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERING AT CAL STATE POLY
POLYTECH, AND I PRESENTLY
ADJUNCT FULL PROFESSOR OF
BIOMEDICAL ENGINEERING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA. I ALSO
SIT ON SEVERAL NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL COMMITTEES THAT
SET ELECTRICAL SAFETY STANDARDS
FOR THE UNITED STATES AND FOR
THE WORLD ELECTRICAL SAFETY,
SECURITY FENCES THAT CONFORM TO
CALIFORNIA CIVIL CODE 835 ARE
NOT CAPABLE OF HARMING HUMANS OR
ANIMALS. THE SHOCKS ARE TOO
SHORT TO AFFECT THE HEART OR TO
CAUSE INJURY. THE BEST ANALOGY
IS TO A STATIC SHOCK, WHICH CAN
BE ANNOYING BUT HAS NEVER BEEN
HARMFUL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING MY TESTIMONY, AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT WITNESS, MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
I'M LARS FREIBERG. I AM THE
OWNER OF SALINAS VALLEY FORD IN
SALINAS. I HAVE WORKED, I HAVE
WORKED AT OUR FAMILY OWNED
DEALERSHIP SINCE 1981. I STARTED
WASHING CARS, WORKED MY WAY
THROUGH ALL JOB FUNCTIONS OF THE
BUSINESS UNTIL FINALLY BUYING MY
FATHER OUT AND NOW RUNNING AND
MANAGING ALL OPERATIONS OF THE
FACILITY. THE TWO FACILITIES WE
HAD TWO FACILITIES IN SALINAS.
ONE WAS SELLING AND SERVICING
LIGHT TRUCKS AND CARS IN NORTH
SALINAS, THE OTHER WAS IN THE
SOUTH PART OF TOWN, A COMMERCIAL
AREA. AND THAT WAS SELLING AND
SERVICING LARGE COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS, SEMIS, MOTORHOMES. IN
THE SUMMER OF 2020, WE HAD A LOT
OF CRIME BREAK INS THROUGH OUR
CYCLONE FENCE TO OUR PROPERTY,
INCLUDING THEFT AND BURGLARY OF
OUR CUSTOMERS VEHICLES WAITING
TO BE SERVICED, TOOLS EQUIPMENT
WAS TAKEN OUT OF COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS AS THEY WERE PARKED
OUTSIDE WAITING. IT WAS JUST A
CONSTANT, CONSTANT EFFECT ON OUR
NEW VEHICLES WAITING TO BE SOLD
AND CUSTOMERS VEHICLES WAITING
TO BE SERVICED, IN THE SUMMER OF
2020, WE I SUBMITTED A CITY
PERMIT APPLICATION FOR AN
ELECTRIC SECURITY FENCE TO
SURROUND OUR PROPERTY, AS OTHERS
WERE DOING IN MY AREA OF MY TOWN
DURING THE FIFTH MONTH OF
WAITING FOR THE CITY TO APPROVE
THE PERMIT, TRAGEDY STRUCK MY
DEALERSHIP EARLY ONE MORNING IN
THE EARLY MORNING OF JANUARY
13TH, 2021. MY PROPERTY'S
PERIMETER FENCE WAS BREACHED
AGAIN BY A CRIMINAL. THIS PERSON
THEN BROKE INTO THE BUILDING
ITSELF AND STARTED A MOTORHOME
ON FIRE THAT WAS INSIDE THE
SERVICE FACILITY, AND BY THE
TIME I GOT THERE AT 7 A.M, THE
BUILDING WAS COMPLETELY CONSUMED
IN FIRE. $1 MILLION OF PARTS
INVENTORY WAS DESTROYED, 11
CUSTOMERS VEHICLES INSIDE WERE
DESTROYED. I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO WRAP IT UP. OKAY, HAD AB 2371
BEEN A LAW IN 2021? I BELIEVE
THAT THIS WOULD NOT HAVE
DESTROYED MY BUSINESS BY ARSON.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
APPROVE THIS CRIME PREVENTION
SECURITY TECHNOLOGY TO PROTECT
OUR BUSINESSES, EMPLOYEES, AND
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, AND I'M SORRY FOR YOUR
PROPERTY LOSS, ALL RIGHT, THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2371, PLEASE
APPROACH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS AND LEE AUGUSTINE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF
THE BILL IN SUPPORT DUE TO THE
NEED FOR CRIME PREVENTION. I'M
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF COPART
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY
PERRY, AARON REED AND
ASSOCIATES, ON BEHALF OF PORAC
AND CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TIM TAYLOR WITH THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. RYAN.
ELAINE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS. CAMERON DIMITRI, ON
BEHALF OF THE SECURITY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, GRACE
COPLIN ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MICHAEL CAPRIO
WITH REPUBLIC SERVICES HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
NAOMI PIGEON ON BEHALF OF THE
SELF STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
CAL CHAMBER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
NICK CHAPPIE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANTHONY
BUTLER TORRES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OTHER THAN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHES THE
MICROPHONE. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2371, PLEASE APPROACH. YOU
MAY SIT DOWN OR YOU MAY USE THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. BRADY, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES, WE ARE GOING
TO GO NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE
AFTER THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ARE ACCEPTED. WANTED TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND THEIR
STAFF, AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS ONE. AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE LANGUAGE IN PRINT.
SO THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTY. THANK
YOU. MARK NEUBERGER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES, I WANT
TO ECHO CAL CITY'S COMMENTS.
WE'RE MOVING TO NEUTRAL AS WELL.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, ANYONE
ELSE NEUTRAL OR OTHERWISE,
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE? LET'S COME BACK.
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR, I HAVE A
QUESTION. YES. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR
REACHING OUT EARLY ON, I HAVE
SOME PROBABLY CLARIFICATIONS,
BUT I COULDN'T REMEMBER THE
ANSWERS TO THEM, WILL THIS
REMOVE THE PERMIT OR APPROVAL
REQUIRED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT?
NO. THEY WILL STILL NEED TO GO
THROUGH A PERMITTING PROCESS.
YOU STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
PERMIT. OKAY, AND I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THAT, WELL, THE
QUESTION IS IF THE PROPERTY IS
DEVELOPED RESIDENTIAL AFTER THE
CITY APPROVES AND AFTER YOU DO
THE FENCE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHAT HAPPENS THEN IN THAT
SITUATION? WE KNOW THEY CAN'T
BEFOREHAND, BUT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE WHAT ARE
CALLED DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS.
BUT CITY PLANNER BY PROFESSION
WORKING THE PROFESSION FOR ABOUT
20 YEARS. THERE ARE DEVELOPMENT
STANDARDS THAT CAN BE APPLIED
TO, IN THESE CASES, THERE WOULD
BE REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS BLOCK
FENCING, TO SEPARATE THE USES
NOT ONLY FOR THIS PARTICULAR
INTENT, BUT ALSO FOR NOISE
ATTENUATION. ALSO, IN CITIES,
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THOSE
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS, WHERE A
DEVELOPMENT COMES IN ADJACENT TO
A ALREADY DEVELOPED PROPERTY,
THE DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS ARE
APPLIED ACCORDING TO THEIR
STANDARDS, AND THEY HAVE THE
TOTAL CONTROL TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT. THIS, AGAIN, WILL JUST
ALLOW THIS TYPE OF SECURITY
SYSTEMS TO BE PROCESSED IN A
FASTER MANNER. AS YOU HEARD MY
TESTIMONY AND THEY'RE HERE TO
TESTIFY, SOME PERMITS ARE TAKING
MORE THAN A YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
GO THROUGH THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. THIS WILL JUST SIMPLY
IS TRYING TO ACCELERATE IN THAT
PROCESS SO THAT INSTANCES LIKE
THE PRIMARY WITNESS MENTIONED OF
HAVING TO LOSE, A FAMILY
INVESTMENT IS VERY TRAGIC. THIS
IS TO DETER THESE INCIDENTS FROM
HAPPENING. OKAY. AND, ONE MORE
QUESTION IS, WHY DO YOU HAVE AN
URGENCY, WELL, I THINK THAT WE
ALL KNOW THE, CRIME THAT WE ARE
FACING. THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
MAYBE EVEN THE NATION. THIS IS,
IN MY VIEW, TO ACCELERATE
PROTECTING THESE BUSINESSES, SO
THAT THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
BUT IF THE PRIMARY WITNESSES
WANT TO ADD ON OR ALSO, MR.
KEITH CAN I GO WITH MARK IF IT'S
OKAY WITH THE CHAIR, OKAY. DOES
THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION,
SENATOR? I THINK THAT PRETTY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. THANK THANK
YOU, SENATOR. I'LL JUST, I LOOK
FORWARD, I'LL BE SUPPORTING. I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU COMING TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. COMMITTEE
NEXT. IT WILL BE NEXT IN YOUR
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. IS THERE
A MOTION? SENATOR WILK MOVES THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AGAIN, THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO GIVE OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES THE ABILITY TO
MORE EASILY ACCESS A TOOL TO
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY PROTECT
THEIR PROPERTY AND LIVELIHOOD.
FOR THIS REASON, THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY OVER 100 BUSINESSES
AND INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS, AS
WELL AS LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
FIRST RESPONDERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WILK, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 12, AB 2371.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT UMBERG I
WILK I WILK I ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY
I CABALLERO TO RUSSELL TO
RUSSELL I LAIRD. MILO ROTH. ROTH
I STERN. WAHAB 5 TO 0 I ZERO.
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. AND I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO QUITE A LONG TIME
TODAY, BUT AT LEAST IT'S HOT.
SO, ESPECIALLY UP HERE, AND I
KNOW THE SERGEANTS ARE WORKING
ON THAT, SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS TO MAKE THE ROOM A
LITTLE BIT COOLER. ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG, FILE
NUMBER 16, AB 2047. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
SENATORS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 247 52 YEARS AGO, AN EFFORT
WAS LED BY TWO CONGRESSWOMEN TO
UPDATE THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT TO
INCLUDE A CLAUSE WITH 37 WORDS
AT THE TIME, TITLE NINE WAS SEEN
AS THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
EDUCATION LEGISLATION. TITLE
NINE IS MORE THAN SIMPLY
ASSURING THAT WOMEN HAVE ACCESS
TO SPORTS. TITLE NINE IS WHAT
LED TO WOMEN BEING DOCTORS,
LAWYERS, AND HAVING EQUAL ACCESS
TO EDUCATION UNDER THE LAW. WE
ARE HERE TODAY TO FULFILL THAT
PROMISE MADE BY CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS ALL THOSE MANY YEARS
AGO. WE ARE HERE TO CREATE A
STRUCTURE BY WHICH OUR
INSTITUTIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS AND TO
RESTORE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY WHEN
DISCRIMINATORY INCIDENTS OCCUR
ON CAMPUS. ASSEMBLY BILL 2047
WILL REQUIRE BOTH THE CSU AND
THE UC TO ESTABLISH A SYSTEM
WIDE CIVIL RIGHTS OFFICE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING BEST
PRACTICES AND TO ENSURE EACH
CAMPUS WITHIN THE CSU AND UC ARE
ADHERING TO THE POLICIES SET
FORTH BY THE OFFICE. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2047 WILL ALSO REQUIRE EACH
CAMPUS TO ESTABLISH A TITLE NINE
OFFICE, AND WILL ESTABLISH IN
LAW THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF EACH
OFFICE TO ADDRESS AND TO PREVENT
THE REOCCURRENCE OF SEX
DISCRIMINATION ON CAMPUS
INCIDENTS, INCLUDING INCIDENTS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THE
CALL TO ACTION REPORT RELEASED
BY THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED A LACK
OF COHERENT PROCESSES ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS, DESPITE ALREADY HAVING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS SEX DISCRIMINATION
CASES. THE MEASURE WILL PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL LAYER OF GUIDANCE
AND REQUIREMENTS BASED ON
EXISTING BEST PRACTICES FROM THE
US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FIRST WITNESS. NO WITNESS. OKAY,
ALL RIGHT, THOSE IN SUPPORT OF,
2047 AB 2047, PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION, AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. JACOB
B¢O, ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND STRONG
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MAGGIE WHITE,
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. THOSE OPPOSED
TO AB 2047, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMENTS SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IS THERE A MOTION?
SENATOR I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GROSSO. THIS IS BILL ITEM NUMBER
16, THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
UMBERG. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE ALLEN. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. DURAZO
DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD. NHIÀU ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. STERN WAHAB. WE HAVE
5 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS MISSING FIVE
ZERO. PUT THAT ON CALL. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT FILE NUMBER 17, AB
2048. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG. YOU'RE
RIGHT IN THE RIGHT PLACE. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
THE BILL PRESENTED JUST
PRESENTED FOCUSED ON THE CSU AND
THE UC SYSTEM. THIS BILL,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2048, ADDRESSES
OUR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS DETAILED IN THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE'S REPORT, A CALL TO
ACTION. THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DOES NOT HAVE A SYSTEM
WIDE APPROACH TO ADJUST TO
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
INSTEAD, THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RELY ON LOCAL GOVERNING BOARDS
TO ADOPT POLICIES THAT ALIGN
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
THIS RESULTS IN A DECENTRALIZED
SYSTEM COMPRISED OF 72 DIFFERENT
VERSIONS. AS TO HOW TO ADDRESS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, TO PROVIDE SYSTEMIC
REFORM AND SYSTEM WIDE
OVERSIGHT, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL REQUIRE A UNIQUE
SYSTEM THAT ALIGNS WITH THEIR
UNIQUE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2048 REQUIRES
ESTABLISHES A WORKING GROUP OF
STUDENTS, FACULTY, STAFF, AND
ADMINISTRATORS WHO WILL WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO EXAMINE
EXISTING PRACTICES AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENTS
AS TO HOW OUR CAMPUSES ARE
DETECTING, ADDRESSING, AND
PREVENTING SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
THIS WORKING GROUP WILL SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
ITS FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
BY FEBRUARY 1ST OF 2026. I'VE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PROVIDE A
SOLUTION THAT BOTH HONORS THE
UNIQUE STRUCTURE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING REFORM TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS, FACULTY AND STAFF
FEEL SAFE ON OUR CAMPUSES. THIS
WORKING GROUP CONCEPT CAME
DIRECTLY FROM INDIVIDUALS THAT
MY OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOUSEKEEPING MEASURE, AFTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG, IF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
HERE, SHE WILL BE NEXT, THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON, RIGHT
NOW WE ARE MISSING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN GARCIA AND
GRAYSON. ALL RIGHT, I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOUR TESTIMONY,
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO YOU
HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT? AB
2048 SEEING. ALL RIGHT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2048,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, AND YOUR POSITION.
JACOB ROWE, ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
AGAIN IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO. GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2048,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING. LET'S
TURN IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. SENATOR BARRASSO IS
INTERESTED IN MOVING THE BILL.
SHE IS OKAY. GOOD. SENATOR ALSO
MOVES THE BILL, WE'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS BILL ITEM 17,
AB 2048. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WILK.
WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. CAVALLERO DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD NHIÀU. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. WAHAB. YOU HAVE 5 TO 0
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. PUT THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU. SO, MEMBER
FONG. ALL RIGHT, NOW WE HAVE NO
AUTHORS THAT ARE PRESENT IN
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NONE. SO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, GARCIA AND GRAYSON.
OH. HERE COMES US. ALL RIGHT.
PERFECT ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO.
YEAH. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YOU.
YES, YES, WE AIM TO PLEASE HERE.
RIGHT. OKAY FILE NUMBER 39, AB
2743. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2743. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER AND THE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
STAFF FOR THEIR EXTENSIVE
FEEDBACK AND TIME SPENT ON THIS
BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT OF ADDING A SUNSET OF
JANUARY 1ST, 2031, WHILE
CONTINUING TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
TO ADDRESSING THE DATA
COLLECTION. AB 2743 HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND PROVIDES
AN APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENT AND
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS
FOR PEER TO PEER CAR SHARING
PLATFORMS. THIS BILL REFLECTS
MONTHS OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND GOOD FAITH
ATTEMPTS TO MITIGATE THEIR
CONCERNS AND PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CLARITY ON THE BILL'S INTENT,
SAID FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITIES
IN 2025 TO 45 K, 90 K FOR BODILY
INJURY AND 15 K FOR PROPERTY
DAMAGE INCREASED THREE TIMES FOR
LIMIT FOR 2035, REQUIRING NEW
ROBUST CONSUMER DISCLOSURES AND
CREATE NEW PENALTY PROVISIONS.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES THE
SAVINGS CLAUSE LANGUAGE
REQUESTED BY THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA, AB 2743
SEEKS TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN REGULATION AND GROWTH,
ENSURING THAT PEER TO PEER CAR
SHARING REMAINS VIABLE AND
BENEFICIAL FOR BOTH USERS AND
PROVIDERS. WITH ME TODAY TO
SUPPORT TO TESTIFY IN, SUPPORT
OF AB 2743 ARE LARISSA CESPEDES
ON BEHALF OF TURO AND ANDREA BO
ON BEHALF OR JUST IT MIGHT JUST
BE ME BECAUSE A BIT OUT OF
ORDER, BUT GO AHEAD. YEAH, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
ATTENTION TO THIS BILL, WHICH IS
SO CRITICAL FOR PEER TO PEER CAR
COMPANIES LIKE TURO. TORO IS A
COMPANY HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER 300
EMPLOYEES. HI, TIM. NO WORRIES,
AND WE HAVE OVER 20,000 GUESTS
THAT CURRENTLY PUT THEIR CAR ON
THEIR PLATFORM, WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL HOPEFULLY STRIKES A GOOD
BALANCE BETWEEN ADDING CONSUMER
PROTECTION. BY BUT ALSO WRITING
THE FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
LIMITS THAT ARE UNIQUE TO PEER
TO PEER CAR COMPANIES, WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING A DIALOG
ON THIS ISSUE, PARTICULARLY WITH
REGARDS TO THE DATA THAT SHOULD
BE USED TO INFORM WHAT THE NEXT
SET OF RATES WILL BE IN 2031,
WITH THE AMENDMENT THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS, IS ACCEPTING
. AND SO YOU WILL SEE US BACK
HERE ON A BILL, AND THAT WE WILL
BRING ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
BACK TO THE TABLE AGAIN, THE
INSURERS WHO ACTUALLY HAVE THE
CLAIMS DATA THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, THE INSURANCE,
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
COMMITTEE STAFF, OF COURSE, THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF HERE, THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS TIMOTHY BURR, AND I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING TECHNET.
TECHNET IS DIVERSE. MEMBERSHIP
INCLUDES A DYNAMIC AMERICAN
BUSINESSES RANGING FROM STARTUPS
TO THE MOST ICONIC COMPANIES ON
THE PLANET. AND REPRESENTS OVER
5 MILLION EMPLOYEES AND
COUNTLESS CUSTOMERS. WE ARE HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2743 AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO
FOR HER WORK ON THIS POLICY AND
THIS BILL. WE FULLY AGREE WITH
THE TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY THE
PRIOR WITNESS, AND JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE AB 2743 INCLUDES
ROBUST CONSUMER NOTICES AND
PENALTY PROVISIONS ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIANS WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THESE PEER TO PEER CAR
SHARING SERVICES AND INNOVATIONS
REMAIN PROTECTED AND WELL
INFORMED WHEN DRIVING IN
CALIFORNIA, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I'M SORRY. AB 2743.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JAMIE HUFF, ON BEHALF OF
THE CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. ROBERT SINGLETON WITH
CHAMBER OF PROGRESS, STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF PEER TO PEER CAR
SHARING PARTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHER THAN
SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
TAKE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB, 20. EXCUSE ME.
2743. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
AFTERNOON, NANCY PAVARINI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS. BUT
THE BILL AS PROCEEDING AS, AS
CURRENTLY AMENDED, DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE OR
ANYONE ELSE TO HELP DETERMINE
WHAT THESE RATES SHOULD BE. AND
WE FEEL THAT IT'S INCUMBENT UPON
THE SPONSORS, IF THEY DO WANT TO
CHANGE THE INSURANCE TO HAVE
THAT DATA SO THAT YOU ALL CAN
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID WHEN WE
SPONSORED A BILL TO INCREASE THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS.
A FEW YEARS AGO. SO WE FEEL
THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT DATA IS
ESSENTIAL AND IT'S CURRENTLY NOT
IN THE BILL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS JUST RAN OVER FROM
THE SWING SPACE. ROBERT HERRERA
WITH THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
HEARD OR DIDN'T HEAR, WHICH JUST
NOTE THAT THIS DATA ISSUE SHOULD
BE SOLVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE IN FIVE MINUTES. WE
JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY IT'S
STILL LINGERING. HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSORS. BUT THAT'S
THE KEY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE RUNNING INTO
THE ROOM. ALL RIGHT, QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THIS
SENATOR RUSSELL. YEAH, I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION. HELLO, SIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THERE'S A THE
DIFFERENCES IN, YOU KNOW,
INSURANCE FOR YOUR PERSONAL, YOU
KNOW, YOUR PERSONAL USE OF A OF
A CAR. AND THEN THERE'S, LIKE,
WHAT YOU PAY LIKE A CAB. AND
THEN NOW, IN THIS CASE, A
DIFFERENT WAY OF GETTING AROUND
IS HAVE YOU, COMPARED THE, THE
COSTS AND THE LIABILITY LEVELS
WITH TAXIS AND CAB DRIVERS? I
MEAN, HOW DOES THAT ALL COMPARE
WITH THIS? IS IT IF IT'S OKAY
THROUGH THE CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO
TAKE THAT QUESTION, SENATOR, A
VERY GOOD QUESTION. AND YOU'RE
HITTING ON A REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE PEER TO
PEER BUSINESS MODEL AND LET'S
SAY A RIDESHARING BUSINESS
MODEL. SO A RIDESHARING IS MORE
ANALOGOUS OR COMPARISON COMPARED
TO THE TAXI SITUATION THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, WHERE,
THERE'S A DRIVER AND SOMEBODY'S
RIDING IN THE CAR IN THE PEER TO
PEER BUSINESS MODEL, THIS IS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT. THIS IS
WHERE YOU ARE ACTUALLY PUTTING
YOUR OWN CAR ON A PLATFORM. IT'S
OKAY WHERE YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR
CAR ON A PLATFORM FOR SOMEBODY
ELSE TO USE. YOU'RE NOT ACTUALLY
IN THE CAR. IT'S A VERY YOU
KNOW, WE ARE MORE COMPARABLE TO
A RENT THE RENTAL CAR INDUSTRY
WHERE THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO
MANDATES LIKE THIS. AND IT IS A
UNIQUE SITUATION BECAUSE BACK IN
2010, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVE
JONES CREATED THE STATUTE THAT
THE PEER TO PEER BUSINESS,
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS CURRENTLY
OPERATING UNDER. AND SO IN THIS
INSTANCE, YOU HAVE THE INSURANCE
THAT THE, PERSON THAT'S
BORROWING THE CAR. SO IF I WAS
TO BORROW YOUR VEHICLE AND I WAS
IN AN ACCIDENT, MY INSURANCE MAY
COVER IT. BUT IF FOR SOME REASON
I HAD A LAPSE IN MY INSURANCE OR
I CURRENTLY DIDN'T HAVE VALID
INSURANCE, THEN THE PEER TO PEER
CAR SHARING PLATFORM. INSURANCE
WOULD COVER THAT ACCIDENT. AND
SO IT'S AN EXTRA LEVEL OF
PROTECTION FOR ALL OF THE
CONSUMERS OR PARTIES INVOLVED IN
A POTENTIAL ACCIDENT INVOLVING
THAT VEHICLE. OKAY. AND DO YOU
HAVE ANY PARTICULAR RESPONSE TO
THE OPPOSITION ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP BY THE TWO SPEAKERS?
I ASKED, WOULD THIS BE ASKED TO
THE DATA? YES. SO WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN HAVING EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS AS TO THAT. THE
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW WITH OBTAINING
THE DATA IS THAT IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE TO OBTAIN IT, BECAUSE
WHENEVER SOMEONE'S INVOLVED IN A
CAR ACCIDENT, THEY DON'T, PUT
DOWN IF THEY WERE USING A PEER
TO PEER CAR SERVICE OR WHETHER
IT WAS A CAR RENTAL, IF THEY
WERE USING SOMEONE ELSE'S
VEHICLE. SO RIGHT NOW IT'S HARD
TO OBTAIN THAT DATA, WE ALL
AGREE WE NEED TO OBTAIN THAT
DATA, AND SO THAT'S WHY THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE. AND IF I NEED TO CARRY
A BILL, NEXT YEAR, I'M WILLING
TO CARRY A BILL, TO HELP WITH
THIS, BUT I DON'T KNOW IF, IF MY
WITNESS WANTS TO TESTIFY
FURTHER. HAPPY TO WEIGH IN. WE
CAN COMPLETELY AGREE THAT DATA
SHOULD INFORM WHAT THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LIMITS SHOULD BE
FOR PEER TO PEER. WE ATTEMPTED
TO TRY AND SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF, AND WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE DATA
SPECIFIC TO OUR INSURANCE
PROVIDER. HOWEVER, THERE ARE
INSTANCES WHERE THERE ARE
ACCIDENTS WHERE THE TRAVELER'S
INSURANCE, WHO WE CONTRACT WITH
DOESN'T ACTUALLY COME INTO PLAY.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RUNNING
INTO THE DATA GAP. AND AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAYS, WHEN AN
ACCIDENT IS REPORTED OR THERE'S
A CLAIM FILED WITH THE WITH AN
INSURER, THE INSURER DATA THAT
THEY COLLECT IS SIMPLY THAT YOU
ARE DRIVING A VEHICLE THAT WAS
NOT YOUR OWN. THEY DON'T SPECIFY
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WERE DRIVING
YOUR MOTHER'S VEHICLE, YOUR
FRIEND'S VEHICLE, A RENTAL CAR
VEHICLE OR TURO VEHICLE. AND SO
WE REALLY NEED THEIR PARTNERSHIP
IN ORDER TO GET THIS DATA. AND
ALSO THE DEPARTMENT'S
PARTNERSHIP. SO WE HAVE TO
CREATE A NEW SYSTEM. IT SOUNDS
VERY SIMPLE. I WISH IT WAS.
OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
RUNNING ANOTHER BILL. BUT, WE
ARE VERY COMMITTED TO SOLVING
THIS ISSUE AND ADDRESSING THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS, CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED AND ALSO THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION. AND IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN DO
BEFORE THE FINAL VOTE TO KEEP
GOING IN THAT DIRECTION?
BECAUSE, I MEAN, THERE'S STILL
MY CONCERNS. I'M JUST, YOU KNOW,
IS ANOTHER STEP THAT YOU COULD
TAKE IN THAT SAME DIRECTION AS
FAR AS YOUR COMMITMENT. WELL, I
THINK, ONE OF THE SIGNALS OF
THAT COMMITMENT IS MOVING UP IN
THE AMENDMENT THAT THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTED WAS MOVING UP THIS,
DEADLINE TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
FROM 2035 TO 2031. AND SO, THAT
WAS WHAT WAS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE BY ALL MEANS, WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE BREAK. AND I'LL TELL
YOU THIS, ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'VE BEEN FACING IS JUST
GETTING THE ATTENTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND INSURERS, WHO ARE
FOCUSED ON A MUCH BIGGER CRISIS.
YOU KNOW, FOR OUR MY CLIENT,
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, LIFE
CHANGING, IMPORTANT ISSUE. BUT
THERE'S ANOTHER INSURANCE CRISIS
THAT'S GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW THAT IS TAKING UP ALL
OF THEIR TIME, AND THE ONE
UNFORTUNATE THING WE UNDERSTAND,
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
INSURANCE COMMITTEE, DEPARTMENT
STAFF, IS THAT THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT ARE WORKING ON THAT ISSUE
WOULD ALSO BE WORKING ON OUR
ISSUE. SO THIS IS NOT A LACK OF
TRYING. AND I COMMIT TO YOU AND
OUR CLIENT WOULD WILL COMMIT TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ON THIS.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. I KNOW YOU ALSO HAVE MY
COMMITMENT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS CONCERNS SEEING
NONE. IS THERE A MOTION SENATOR
ASHBY MOVES THE BILL? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AS YOU NOTED, THE,
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO
CHANGE THE TEN YEAR SUNSET TO A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET. I AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THAT THAT IF WE'RE
IN THE BUSINESS OF BASICALLY
REGULATING INSURANCE RATES,
WHICH, BY THE WAY, WE SHOULD NOT
BE, THEN WE DO NEED THE DATA TO
KNOW WHAT'S APPROPRIATE. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
WE WILL BE OUT OF THIS BUSINESS,
THAT THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
WILL BE IN THIS WORLD, BUT
HAVING SAID THAT, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FLEXIBILITY. AND, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH, I'M SORRY YOU DIDN'T CLOSE.
GO AHEAD. CLOSE. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OKAY. THIS IS CHIEF
COUNSEL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU. THIS IS AB 2743. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. UMBERG A UMBERG I
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. AYE LAIRD. NHIÀU. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. STERN. WAHAB YOU HAVE
6 TO 0 MEMBERS MISSING. ALL
RIGHTY, WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
SIX ZERO. PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
YES, WE'RE GOING TO GO IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER. NOW WE'RE
BACK TO SORT OF REGULAR ORDER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN IS UP
NEXT AFTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, WHO I DON'T BELIEVE IS
HERE. AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
SO, MEMBER FRIEDMAN, FILE NUMBER
18, AB 2297. AND FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, WE ARE MOVING RIGHT
ALONG. WE'RE ALREADY HALFWAY
DONE. IT'S ONLY 358. SO YEAH.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, MEDICAL
DEBT IS UNFORTUNATELY STILL A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF BANKRUPTCY
, POVERTY AND RACIAL
INEQUALITIES IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
A THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS REPORT
HAVING MEDICAL DEBT AND HOSPITAL
DEBT ALONE MAKES UP 70% OF ALL
MEDICAL DEBT. IN 2006,
CALIFORNIA CREATED THE HOSPITAL
FAIR PRICING ACT TO PROTECT
PATIENTS. MANY OF YOU WILL
RECALL OUR RECENT UPDATES TO THE
ACT IN 2021, INCLUDING MY BILL
AB TEN 1020. WHILE THE PATIENT
PROTECTIONS WE PUT INTO LAW ARE
WORKING, WE'RE ALSO LEARNING OF
AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR CODE. AB 2297
DOES THE FOLLOWING. IT DEFINES
CHARITY CARE, DISTINGUISHING IT
FROM DISCOUNTED CARE OR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. IT
CLARIFIES THAT HOSPITALS MUST
REVIEW APPLICATIONS FOR CHARITY
CARE OR DISCOUNTED CARE WITHOUT
ARBITRARY DEADLINES. IT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF LIENS ON
PROPERTY TO COLLECT UNPAID
MEDICAL BILLS FROM FINANCIALLY
ELIGIBLE PATIENTS. IN OTHER
WORDS, LOWER INCOME PATIENTS,
AND IT ELIMINATES THE
CONSIDERATION OF ASSETS FROM
ELIGIBILITY CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT MEDI-CAL RULES, SO THAT
LOW INCOME SENIORS FOR INSTANCE,
AREN'T FORCED TO SELL. MAYBE AN
APARTMENT THAT THEY'VE USED AS A
RENTAL AND PLAN TO USE FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT FOR THEIR ONLY SOURCE
OF INCOME. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE PATIENT
PROTECTIONS APPLY ONLY TO
UNINSURED AND UNDERINSURED
PATIENTS WITH AN INCOME UNDER
400% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE
. FOR PATIENTS WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES, MEDICAL DEBT CAN BE
DEVASTATING, PUTTING THEM AT
RISK OF HOUSING INSTABILITY AND
FINANCIAL RUIN. WE STILL,
UNFORTUNATELY, HAVE SITUATIONS
WHERE PATIENTS ARE RELEASED FROM
HOSPITALS, LOW INCOME PATIENTS
WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO GET CHARITY
CARE. THEY EITHER ARE NOT TOLD
OR THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THEIR
ABILITY TO RECEIVE DISCOUNTED
CARE OR CHARITY CARE. THEY'RE AT
A PLACE IN THEIR LIVES AND THEIR
TREATMENT WHERE THEY'RE JUST NOT
CAPABLE OF MAKING THESE
DECISIONS. AND MANY OF US HAVE
HAD THAT EXPERIENCE LEAVING THE
HOSPITAL AND BEING REALLY SICK.
AND YET THEY MAY COME BACK
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER TO TRY TO
APPLY FOR THAT CARE, ONLY TO BE
TOLD THAT SORRY, THAT PARTICULAR
HOSPITAL HAS A TWO MONTH LIMIT,
AND AFTER THAT YOU JUST YOU HAVE
TO THEY WON'T GIVE YOU THE
CHARITY CARE. THAT'S
INCONCEIVABLE. IT'S
INCONCEIVABLE IN THE STATE THAT
WE STILL HAVE MEDICAL
BANKRUPTCY, THAT PEOPLE STILL
LOSE THEIR HOMES AND PROPERTIES
TO MEDICAL DEBT MEMBERS. NOBODY
CHOOSES TO GO INTO THE HOSPITAL
FOR THESE KINDS OF PROCEDURES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE SICK. WE DON'T
WANT TO DISCOURAGE THEM FROM
GETTING THE TREATMENT THEY NEED.
AB 2297 INCREASES PROTECTIONS
FOR THESE VULNERABLE PATIENTS,
AND I WOULD REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS LINDA HèA FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER OF LAW AND
POVERTY. AND TED MEN FROM FROM
THE LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. FIRST
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON, LINDA
HèA WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY, PROUD CO-SPONSORS
OF AB 2297, WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED MEDICAL DEBT RELIEF
BY PROHIBITING THE USE OF HOME
LIENS IN THE COLLECTION OF
UNPAID HOSPITAL BILLS FROM
FINANCIALLY QUALIFIED PATIENTS.
HOSPITALS ARE CURRENTLY
PROHIBITED FROM PLACING LIENS ON
A PATIENT'S HOME, BUT DEBT
COLLECTORS ARE ALLOWED TO PLACE
LIENS TO COLLECT UNPAID HOSPITAL
BILLS. HOME LIENS ARE
AGGRESSIVELY USED, AS SEEN FROM
CLIENT STORIES AND OUR RESEARCH.
A REVIEW OF ASSESSOR DATA FOUND
THAT IN LA COUNTY ALONE, OVER
140 PROPERTY LIENS WERE PLACED
IN 2023 DUE TO MEDICAL DEBT. IN
ADDITION, THE BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE ASSET CONSIDERATION IN
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
DETERMINATION EXCEPT IF NEEDED
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW,
SIMPLIFY THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE APPLICATION PROCESS,
AND HELP PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
SAVINGS FROM BEING DEPLETED WHEN
SEEKING CARE. CALIFORNIANS NEED
THEIR SAVINGS TO PREVENT POVERTY
IN RETIREMENT AND OLDER AGE,
ACCORDING TO A 2019 REPORT.
NEARLY HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE SECTOR WORKERS HAVE NO
RETIREMENT ASSETS AT ALL.
FINALLY, THE BILL WOULD CLARIFY
THAT HOSPITALS MUST REVIEW
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE ELIGIBILITY
AT ANY TIME SO THAT PATIENTS ARE
NOT DENIED FOR MISSING ARBITRARY
DEADLINE SET BY HOSPITALS.
ALTHOUGH HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED
TO NOTIFY PATIENTS OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. WE HAVE CLIENTS
SEEKING HELP, UNINFORMED THAT
THIS ASSISTANCE IS EVEN
AVAILABLE. THIS BILL PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS TED MUMFORD AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY AT THE LEGAL SERVICES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE A
NONPROFIT LAW FIRM, AND WE
REPRESENT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIVING IN 32 COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE. MY TEAM AT LESNICK, AS WE
CALL OURSELVES, REPRESENTS THOSE
WHO ARE WHO ARE OFTEN FACING
MEDICAL DEBT ISSUES. AND WE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS EVERY YEAR. WE
REGULARLY SEE ISSUES WITH THE
EXISTING HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING
ACT, AND I'VE GOT JUST THREE
EXAMPLES OF A HOST OF CASES. I
COULD TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHERE
THE EXISTING HOSPITAL FAIR
PRICING ACT FAILS TO DO, WHAT
ITS GOAL IS SET OUT TO. THE
FIRST IS A SINGLE MOTHER THAT I
REPRESENTED, WHOSE INFANT SON
WENT TO THE E.R. AND WHOSE
ABUSER WAS HIDING HER MAIL FROM
HER SUCH THAT SHE DID NOT GET
THE MEDICAL BILLS FOR HER INFANT
SON'S MEDICAL VISIT. SHE WAS
THEN SUED ON THAT MEDICAL DEBT
AND DIDN'T FIND OUT ABOUT IT
UNTIL HER TAX RETURNS WERE BEING
INTERCEPTED BY THE HOSPITAL. WE
HELPED TO APPLY FOR CHARITY
CARE, BUT THE HOSPITAL DENIED
THAT APPLICATION BECAUSE IT WAS
PAST THEIR ARBITRARY INTERNAL
DEADLINE. THE SECOND CLIENT THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT IS A RETIRED LOW
INCOME COUPLE WHO WOULD HAVE
BEEN ELIGIBLE FOR CHARITY CARE
WHEN THEY WENT TO THE ER TEN
YEARS AGO, BUT AT THE TIME THEY
WEREN'T TOLD ABOUT IT IN THE
HOSPITAL, TOLD THEM THAT THEY
HAD TO SIGN OVER A HOME LIEN TO
CONTINUE GETTING MEDICAL CARE
FROM THE HOSPITAL. THEY THEN, AS
PART OF THAT SAME AGREEMENT,
PAID $100 A MONTH EVERY SINGLE
MONTH, DILIGENTLY UNTIL THE
PANDEMIC TOOK THEIR JOB AWAY.
AND THEY WERE THEN FORCED NOT TO
MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS ANYMORE. AND
THE HOSPITAL SUED THEM ON THAT
DEBT. WE THEN THEY THEN CAME TO
US AND WE HELPED THEM APPLY FOR
CHARITY CARE, WHICH SHOULD HAVE
COVERED THAT BILL. BUT AGAIN,
THE HOSPITAL DENIED THAT
APPLICATION BECAUSE IT WAS PAST
THE HOSPITAL'S DEADLINE. THE
FINAL EXAMPLE I'LL GIVE IS OF A
LOW INCOME FATHER OF TWO WHO WAS
HOMELESS AT THE TIME. HE WENT TO
THE ER AND THEN YEARS LATER,
WHEN HE NOW HAS A FAMILY AND A
JOB, HE FOUND OUT THAT THIS
HOSPITAL BILL EXISTED BECAUSE HE
HIS WAGES WERE BEING GARNISHED
BASED ON A LAWSUIT THAT HE WAS
NEVER INFORMED OF. WE HELPED HIM
APPLY FOR CHARITY CARE AGAIN.
ANOTHER PERSON WHO IS NOW
ELIGIBLE WOULD HAVE ALSO BEEN
ELIGIBLE AT THE TIME, AND HE WAS
DENIED BECAUSE IT WAS PAST THE
HOSPITAL'S DEADLINE. IF YOU
COULD WRAP IT UP, THANK YOU.
YES, AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT IN EACH OF THESE CASES,
THESE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD BE
MADE TO THIS BILL, WOULD, WOULD
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SORRY YOU DID
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS, RIGHT? YES.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. OKAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2297,
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS. SO YOU
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'LL WRITE THEM
LATER. VERY WILLING TO ACCEPT.
AYE. WE ARE THE GREAT OFFENDERS
HERE. SO. RIGHT. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THAT WAS FAKED. YOU OUT.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. YEAH, I SAID
YES. RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. AUBRY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE,
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JENNIFER ROBLES
WITH HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2297.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACH.
MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 2297, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALRIGHTY. PLEASE. YOU MAY USE
THE MICROPHONE OR THE TABLE,
WHICHEVER YOU CHOOSE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HERE WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. HOWEVER
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN THUS FAR TO
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS ON OUR REMAINING
CONCERN. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE ELSE,
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE. Þ SENATOR
CABALLERO, I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION IN REGARDS TO THE
CONCERN EXPRESSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
IS THERE ANY RESOLUTION WITH THE
ISSUE THAT THAT THEY RAISED,
WHICH IS, REGULATION BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN REGARDS TO
DEBT, LINDA HèA WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY, WE
DID TAKE AMENDMENTS LAST WEEK,
THAT WOULD, ALLOW, ASSET
CONSIDERATION FOR MEDICARE
PATIENTS IF FEDERALLY REQUIRED.
OKAY. AND THAT WAS THEIR ISSUE,
AS I UNDERSTOOD IT, I WAS TRYING
TO I, I STAY AWAY FROM FEDERAL
STUFF SO THEY CAN SPEAK MORE TO
IT. I THINK THEY ALSO WANT TO
INCLUDE OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAMS
IN OUR REVIEW OF, CURRENT
GUIDANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IT, WE HAVE NOT SEEN
THAT EXPANSION NEEDED, OTHER
FEDERAL PROGRAMS INCLUDE
MEDI-CAL AND MEDI-CAL HAS
ALREADY ELIMINATED THE ASSET,
CONSIDERATION FROM ELIGIBILITY.
I APPRECIATE THAT. I THINK YOUR
BILL IS A GREAT BILL. I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WEREN'T DOING SOMETHING THAT
THEN PUT THEM IN DANGER OF
WHATEVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL DO WHEN YOU VIOLATE THEIR
ASSET ISSUES. SO, AS LONG AS IT
WORKS, I'M THEN IT LOOKS TO ME
LIKE IT'S BEEN TAKEN CARE OF.
KIND OF. YEAH, WELL, WE'LL SEE.
IN ANY CASE, I YOU'RE I THINK
YOUR BILL IS REALLY IMPORTANT,
I'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS TO
SENIORS WHEN THERE'S MEDICAL
ISSUES. AND USUALLY THE MEDICAL
ISSUES HAPPEN LATE IN LIFE AND
THEY LEAVE ONE OF THE SPOUSES
SAD SADDLED WITH INCREDIBLE
DEBT, THAT THAT MANY TIMES ENDS
UP BEING RESOLVED AS A REVERSE
MORTGAGE, WHICH IS THE ABSOLUTE
WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN TO
SENIORS AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
SO I WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN YOU'RE
READY. SENATOR CABALLERO HAS
MOVED THE BILL OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS. AND SENIOR WOMEN
ARE THE FASTEST GROWING GROUP OF
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS IN LOS
ANGELES, AND I DON'T HAVE A
DIRECT CONNECTION, BUT I HAVE
ALSO SEEN, YOU KNOW, THE HUSBAND
DIES, SHE SPENDS ALL THE MONEY
TAKING CARE OF HIM. AND THEN
THERE'S NOTHING LEFT. AND TO
HAVE A HOSPITAL THEN COME AFTER
HER OR PUT A LIEN ON THE HOME
IS, IS REALLY, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
OUTRAGEOUS IN THIS DAY AND AGE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MISSUS, FILE ITEM NUMBER 18, AB
2297. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. BURKE
Ã UMBERG. I WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
GRASSO I LAIRD. NHIÀU ROTH. ROTH
I STERN. WAHAB 4 TO 0 FOUR ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT BILL AB 2925
FILE NUMBER 19. THE NEXT AFTER
THAT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA,
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE HAMAS TERROR
ATTACK ON OCTOBER 7TH, JEWISH
AND PRO-ISRAEL STUDENTS ARE
FEELING PRESSURED TO HIDE THEIR
IDENTITIES ON CAMPUS BECAUSE
THEY FEEL UNSAFE. I HAVE HEARD
DIRECTLY FROM AT LEAST ONE
JEWISH PROFESSOR THAT HE IS
CONVINCED HE'S GOING TO LOSE HIS
JOB BECAUSE HE IS A ZIONIST AND
SUPPORTS THE STATE OF ISRAEL'S
RIGHT TO RIGHT TO EXIST. AND
MANY TIMES THESE STUDENTS AND
THESE PROFESSORS FEEL THAT THERE
IS NO ONE, YOU KNOW, PERHAPS
REPRESENTED IN THE COLLEGES THAT
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS.
ACCORDING TO THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE, THERE HAS BEEN A 2,000%
INCREASE IN ANTI-SEMITIC
INCIDENCES ON CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
CAMPUSES FOLLOWING THE OCTOBER
7TH COMPARED TO A YEAR AGO. OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE ASKING US WHAT
IS BEING DONE TO ASSURE THAT
JEWISH STUDENTS CAN ATTEND
CLASSES AND EXIST IN THE
ACADEMIC SETTING, FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION. WE ARE ANSWERING
THIS DIFFICULT QUESTION THROUGH
AB 2925, WHICH IS NOT SPECIFIC
TO ANTI-SEMITISM, I MIGHT ADD.
BUT WHAT IT DOES DO IS IT
REQUIRES THAT IF A COLLEGE
CAMPUS OFFERS A DEI TRAINING, TO
TRY TO ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION ON
THEIR CAMPUSES, THAT THEY CAN
MAKE THAT AS EXPANSIVE AS THEY
WANT, BUT THAT THEY NEED TO
INCLUDE AS PART OF ANY ANTI
DISCRIMINATION TRAINING OR
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TRAINING THAT'S ALREADY OFFERED
IN THE INSTITUTION. THE FIVE
MOST TARGETED GROUPS IN THE
STATE, CURRENT LAW SAYS THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE A RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS, FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT.
AND OF COURSE, NO ONE CAN FOCUS
ON THEIR EDUCATION IF THEY DON'T
FEEL SAFE ON THEIR CAMPUS. AND
WE BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY, MY
COAUTHORS AND MYSELF, THAT OUR
UNIVERSITIES NEED TO DO A LOT
MORE TO MEET THIS MOMENT, TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS FEEL
SAFE AND INCLUDED. NOW
UNFORTUNATELY, ALTHOUGH THERE IS
WIDESPREAD DEI TRAINING ON OUR
CAMPUSES, THERE IS NO STANDARD
AS TO WHAT THAT MEANS OR WHAT
GROUPS NEED TO BE INCLUDED. BUT
IF CURRENT LAW SAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGES HAVE AN
AFFIRMATIVE OBLIGATION TO COMBAT
RACISM, SEXISM, AND OTHER FORMS
OF BIAS, THEN LET'S ENSURE THAT
HATEFUL ACTS OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST ANY GROUPS, INCLUDING
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY, IS NOT
LEFT OUT, AND THAT EDUCATIONAL
TRAINING, IF IT'S ALREADY BEING
DONE ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES,
TESTIFYING AND SUPPORT THIS
MORNING IS CLIFF BURG WITH THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IT'S A PRIORITY BILL
FOR THE JEWISH CAUCUS. ONE, I
THINK, OF 4 OR 5 PRIORITY BILLS.
AND I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL. IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO MY COMMUNITY, AND
WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. AND
JOINING ME IS MY JOINT AUTHOR,
SENATOR LOWENSTEIN, TO SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ALSO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THE BILL, THANK YOU.
AND I'LL JUST BE VERY BRIEF. I
THINK THAT WAS VERY SUCCINCT, AS
A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF THE
BILL, I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FOR BEING A
CHAMPION ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AND IT IS INDEED
UNFORTUNATE. THERE NEEDS TO BE
LEGISLATION ADDRESSING RISING
DISCRIMINATION ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. BUT OUR COMMUNITY IS
HURTING AND WE NEED TO STEP UP.
AND THIS IS UNIQUE TO THIS TIME.
BUT THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE
PHENOMENA. WE GO THROUGH
INFLECTION PERIODS IN OUR
HISTORY WHERE SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING ON A GLOBAL SCALE THAT
RESULTS IN INCREASED
DISCRIMINATION WE SEE
DOMESTICALLY. SO AFTER 911, WE
FELT THAT AGAINST THE MUSLIM,
COMMUNITY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES ON A GREAT SCALE. AFTER
CORONAVIRUS HIT ALL OF US,
CERTAINLY REMEMBER THE INTENSE
LEVELS OF ASIAN HATE THAT WAS
FELT. AND RIGHT NOW IT IS THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY THAT IS
SPEAKING OUT. AND, THE
PALESTINIAN MUSLIM AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES AND AGAINST
ISLAMOPHOBIA ARE, ARE, ARE
FEELING THESE PHENOMENA AT
INTENSE LEVELS. AND WHAT WE SEE
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE TWO
THINGS A THAT EVERYBODY IS IN
FAVOR OF PROTECTING FREE SPEECH,
AND B THAT WE NEED GREATER
LEVELS OF SENSITIVITY TOWARDS
OTHERS THAT ARE IN PAIN AND
SPEAKING OUT, OR JUST TRYING TO
LIVE THROUGH THESE INFLECTION
PERIODS. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT, IS NOT TO
PRIORITIZE ANYONE OVER THE OTHER
, BUT SIMPLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN WE ARE GOING THROUGH THESE
PERIODS, THE GROUPS THAT ARE
FEELING THEM ARE GOING TO BE
COVERED, AND WITH THAT, I'LL
PASS IT OFF TO MR. BERG. THANK
THANK YOU, CLIFF BERG, MR.
CHAIRMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA, THE LARGEST
SINGLE STATE COALITION OF JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NATION, IS
PLEASED TO BE A CO-SPONSOR OF AB
2925 WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS. THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
COLLEGE CAMPUSES INCLUDE
TRAINING TO COMBAT AND ADDRESS
ANTI-SEMITISM AS PART OF THEIR
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION TRAINING OR
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION
TRAINING THAT IS OFFERED BY THE
INSTITUTION. JPAC IS A COALITION
OF OVER 30 LEADING JEWISH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE AS THE VOICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S JEWISH COMMUNITY TO
THE STATE CAPITOL, WE ADVOCATE
IN SACRAMENTO ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY'S CONCERNS AND
BROADLY SHARED VALUES. OUR
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDE
JEWISH FEDERATIONS, JEWISH
COMMUNITY RELATIONS COUNCILS,
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICES AGENCIES,
AND MANY, MANY OTHERS.
UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE FIVE
MONTHS FOLLOWING THE HAMAS
TERROR ATTACKS ON OCTOBER 7TH,
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE
REPORTED A 2000 INCREASE OF
INCIDENTS OF ANTISEMITISM THAT
THE ASSEMBLYWOMAN REFERRED TO.
THIS IS CONTRIBUTING TO A
GROWING FEELING AMONGST THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY THAT
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS HOME TO THE
THIRD LARGEST JEWISH POPULATION
IN THE WORLD, IS BECOMING UNSAFE
FOR JEWISH STUDENTS AND UNSAFE
FOR JEWISH FAMILIES ON OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. IT'S NOW BEEN
WELL DOCUMENTED THAT STATE
INSTITUTIONS, AS WELL AS PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS ARE FAILING TO
PROTECT JEWISH STUDENTS.
ANTISEMITISM IS A FORM OF HATE
AND DISCRIMINATION THAT IS NO
LESS DANGEROUS THAN OTHER FORMS
AND NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
STUDENTS, REGARDLESS OF
IDENTITY, SHOULD NOT FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE OR AFRAID OF
WALKING ON THEIR OWN CAMPUSES,
THIS BILL, WHILE CLEARLY OUR
PRIORITY, IS ADDRESSING THE
GROWING SURGE OF ANTI-SEMITISM,
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT
SINGLING OUT ONE PARTICULAR
GROUP OR, FORM OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION OVER OTHERS. AS
THE AUTHOR POINTED OUT, THIS
BILL UTILIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S LIST OF, HATE TARGETED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WAS SUGGESTED
BY THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR CONSTITUTIONAL
REASONS. BUT WE REMAIN CONCERNED
NOT ONLY ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM,
BUT ABOUT ISLAMOPHOBIA. THE BILL
INCLUDES A ISLAMOPHOBIA WITHIN
THE DEFINITION OF RELIGION AND
SPELLS IT OUT RIGHT ALONGSIDE
ANTI-SEMITISM. SO NO FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA, NO STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FACE
HARASSMENT. ON OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. THEY SHOULD FEEL SAFE.
WE THINK THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE IN GETTING
CALIFORNIA MOVED IN THAT
DIRECTION. AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. OKAY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT, MR. BERG. ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT CAN NOW ADD THEIR MEET
TO TESTIMONY NAME ORGANIZATION.
IF YOU HAVE ONE. AND YOUR
POSITION, JESSICA DUONG WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ALLEVIATE OUR
CONCERNS AND GET US TO THE
SUPPORT POSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WERE YOU WAITING FOR
YOUR WALK UP MUSIC? IS THAT WHAT
WAS GOING ON? I'M STILL WAITING,
GOOD AFTERNOON, MAGGIE WHITE,
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET A LETTER IN
ON TIME, BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. OH,
THERE'S ONE. OH, PLEASE. I'M
SORRY SIR. YEAH YOU CAME AND
TESTIFIED IN EDUCATION. I SHOULD
HAVE REMEMBERED. NO PROBLEM.
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS. GOOD
MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON NOW,
CHAIR. AND, SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS OMAR
AL-TAMIMI. I'M A SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE COUNCIL OF
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS. OR
CARE, CALIFORNIA. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF CARE CALIFORNIA TO
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION, NOT TO THE INTENT OF
THE BILL, BUT RATHER HOW IT WILL
BE IMPLEMENTED, UNLESS AMENDED
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
DESPITE AB 2925 STATED INTENT TO
ADDRESS THE RISE OF HATE
MOTIVATED INCIDENTS ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES SINCE OCTOBER SEVENTH,
AB 2925 FAILS TO ADDRESS THE
UNPRECEDENTED SPIKE IN CASES OF
ISLAMOPHOBIA TAKING PLACE ON
UNIVERSITY AND COLLEGE CAMPUSES
SINCE THEN. SINCE OCTOBER 7TH,
THERE HAS NOT ONLY BEEN A RISE
IN ANTI-SEMITISM, WHICH THE BILL
ADDRESSES, BUT ALSO AN
UNPRECEDENTED SPIKE IN
ISLAMOPHOBIA. CARE HAS RECEIVED
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
NATIONWIDE IN 2023 THAN EVER
RECORDED IN OUR 30 YEAR HISTORY.
DESPITE THIS, RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL REMOVED THE
REQUIREMENT THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTES INCLUDE
TRAINING ON ISLAMOPHOBIA WITHIN
ALREADY EXISTING
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION AND DEI
TRAINING. FURTHERMORE, DESPITE
THE UNPRECEDENTED RISE IN
ISLAMOPHOBIA ACROSS THE STATE
AND COUNTRY, NO MUSLIM
ORGANIZATION NOR LEADERS,
INCLUDING CARE, WERE CONSULTED
IN THE DRAFTING OF THE BILL IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE MUSLIM
PERSPECTIVE AND EXPERIENCE WAS
CONSIDERED RELYING SOLELY ON ONE
SET OF DATA FROM THE AG. ANNUAL
HATE CRIMES REPORT DOES NOT
PROVIDE AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF THE HATE AND
DISCRIMINATION FACED BY THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY AND OTHER
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. THIS
IS A FACT NOTED IN BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY. JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ANALYZES THE AG REPORT
ON WHICH THIS BILL SOLELY
RELIES. ONLY INCLUDES HATE
CRIMES REPORTED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, OF WHICH THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY HAS HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPORTED DUE TO MISTRUST
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. AS A RESULT
OF DECADES OF POLICE
SURVEILLANCE POST NINE OVER 11,
THIS WAS A FACT EVEN NOTED BY
THE BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN HIS
RECENT OPEN LETTER TO THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY. FURTHERMORE, THE AG
REPORT DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR
HARASSMENT, DISCRIMINATION, AND
OTHER INCIDENTS PROHIBITED BY
LAW THAT DO NOT RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF HATE CRIMES. IT DOES
NOT PROVIDE SPECIFIC DATA ON
HATE ON COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES, AND DOES NOT PROVIDE
THE MOST UP TO DATE INFORMATION
ON WHICH GROUPS ARE CURRENTLY
FACING HATE, AS NOTED IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, THE TOOL DOES NOT
PROVIDE CONTEXT FOR THE RATE OF
REPORTED INCIDENTS MOTIVATED BY
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST A
PARTICULAR GROUP. IN TERMS OF
THE GROUP POPULATION AS A WHOLE.
NOR DOES IT SET FORTH THE NUMBER
OF REPORTED INCIDENTS THAT WERE
VERIFIED OR RESULTED IN A
CONVICTION. GIVEN THE RECORD
RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA, WE FEEL
THAT ANY ANTI DISCRIMINATION
TRAINING MUST INCLUDE AND
ADDRESS THE GLARING SPIKE IN
ISLAMOPHOBIA. WE'VE SPOKEN TO
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE REGARDING
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS. AND, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE WE'VE EVEN
RECOMMENDED SOME AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THEM, ONE OF WHICH IS TO
INCLUDE, TRAINING WITHIN THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO THE TOP
THREE MOST TARGETED RELIGIOUS
GROUPS, IN ADDITION TO OR IN
PLACE OF THE TOP FIVE MOST
TARGETED GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA AS
A WHOLE. AS A WHOLE, THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD BE CONTENT
NEUTRAL, AND STILL ADDRESS BOTH
THE RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
ANTI-SEMITISM ON CAMPUSES. IT
WILL KEEP THE CURRENT. THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS KEEPING THE
CURRENT DEFINITION OF
NATIONALITY FOUND IN THE EQUITY
IN HIGHER EDUCATION ACT. THAT
WILL NOT HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INFRINGING ON THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF
STUDENTS, POTENTIALLY,
UNFORTUNATELY, AS AT THIS POINT,
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE DECIDED NOT
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
PROPOSED AMENDMENT. WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE BILL
CONTINUES TO IGNORE THE MUSLIM
PERSPECTIVE AS WE TRY, IN GOOD
FAITH, TO PROPOSE REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS WHILE WE APPRECIATE
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL'S
INTENT TO ADDRESS THE RECENT
RISE IN HATE ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, THERE'S A CLEAR GAP IN
THE BILL'S INTENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION, AND AS SUCH, YOU
KNOW, WE FEEL THAT SUBSTANTIVE
SUBSTANTIVELY INCLUDES FAILS TO
INCLUDE MUSLIMS OR ADDRESS THE
RISE IN ISLAMOPHOBIA IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. WE HOPE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. BUT UNTIL THEN, WITH
RESPECT, WE WILL REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ANY ANY
OTHER, SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO
ADD ME TO COMMENTS, SEEING NONE
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SENATOR
DURAZZO, THANK YOU FOR RAISING
THE ISSUES THAT THAT YOU HAVE.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE'VE HAD SO MANY TIMES
WHEN RACISM AND SEXISM HAS JUST
BEEN TAKEN OVER AND, AND, LED SO
MUCH HATE AND VIOLENCE, I JUST,
NOBODY'S BROUGHT THIS UP, BUT
ONE OF MY, QUESTIONS IS HOW DO
YOU, STRENGTHEN THE EXISTING LAW
WHEN IT'S FOCUSED ON A SPECIFIC,
YOU KNOW, GROUP OF, SECTORS OF
OUR COMMUNITY? I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHICH EXISTING LAW
THE, THE CURRENT EXISTING LAW.
SO THERE'S NO LAW THAT REQUIRES
DEI TRAINING AT ALL OR
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION, WHATEVER
THE LAW IS. I'M JUST SAYING.
YEAH. SO THAT RIGHT NOW THE
COLLEGES CAN DO A DEI TRAINING
OR NOT DO IT. SO THERE'S NO LAW
THAT REQUIRES IT. OKAY. SO THEY
HAVE TO PREVENT DISCRIMINATION
ON CAMPUS. SO IF YOU'RE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ON CAMPUS,
YOU CAN CERTAINLY BRING A
LAWSUIT, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
THERE ARE DIFFERENT MECHANISMS
WITHIN HIGHER EDUCATION THAT
PEOPLE CAN, YOU KNOW, THAT
STUDENTS CAN RAISE ISSUES AROUND
DISCRIMINATION. SO THERE'S THAT
KIND OF LAW, BUT THERE'S NO LAW
THAT PRESCRIPTIVELY TELLS
UNIVERSITIES. YOU HAVE TO TRAIN
YOUR PROFESSORS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
DIFFERENT ETHNIC GROUPS OR THAT
YOU. AND THEN THAT'S WHY DEI
KIND OF STARTED, BECAUSE I THINK
THE COLLEGES SAW A NEED TO
OFFER, TRAINING SOMETIMES TO
THEIR PROFESSORS, TRAININGS TO
STUDENTS, YOU KNOW, ANTI-BIAS
TRAININGS. BUT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE DEVELOPED ON
THEIR OWN. THERE IS NO LAW THAT
I'M AWARE OF ARE REQUIRING THEM
TO DO ANY OF THAT. AND SO AND
THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE THIS IS
A RELATIVELY NEW WAY OF
ADDRESSING DISCRIMINATION ON
CAMPUSES AND IMPLICIT BIAS.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY WE'RE SEEING
THIS VERY UNEQUAL KIND OF,
TRAINING ACROSS THE STATE
UNIVERSITIES DOING THIS
DIFFERENTLY. I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
WHAT'S BEING OFFERED IN THE
ISLAMOPHOBIA SPACE. I HOPE THAT
UNIVERSITIES ARE TRAINING TO
THAT. I HAVE YET TO FIND ANY OF
THESE TRAININGS THAT COVER
ANTISEMITISM. YOU KNOW, DESPITE
THIS SORT OF INCREDIBLE MOMENT
WHERE WE'RE SEEING THIS, YOU
KNOW, HUGE SPIKE IN
ANTISEMITISM, IT MAY BE OUT
THERE. I JUST HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
NOBODY HAS CALLED AND SAID, HEY,
WE OFFER. YOU KNOW, WE ROUTINELY
WHEN WE DO OUR
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION TRAINING,
WE'RE ALSO TEACHING OUR
PROFESSORS. WE'RE TEACHING THEM
ABOUT ANTI-SEMITISM AS PART OF
OUR DEI. WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT YET.
SO IT'S WE'RE TRYING TO NOW PUT
SOME GUARDRAILS AROUND THIS AND
SAY, HEY, IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
OFFERING THESE, YOU CAN MAKE IT
AS EXPANSIVE AS YOU WANT. AND
CERTAINLY SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THAT THEY
WANT TO PROTECT. THEY MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT DYNAMICS IN TERMS OF,
YOU KNOW, IMMIGRATION TRENDS OR
WHATEVER, BUT WE'RE SAYING YOU
SHOULD ALSO BE INCLUDING AND
WE'VE JUST, YOU KNOW, WE PICKED
SORT OF AN ARBITRARY NUMBER
FIVE, THE TOP FIVE GROUPS THAT
WE KNOW ARE BEING TARGETED FOR
DISCRIMINATION AND HATRED RIGHT
NOW ON OUR CAMPUSES. AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK THIS IS
THE BEGINNING OF PROBABLY
PUTTING SOME LAWS AND GUARDRAILS
AROUND THESE KINDS OF TRAININGS.
YEAH. AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED WAS THERE ARE
DIFFERENT TIMES WHEN SEPTEMBER
11TH HAPPENED, WHATEVER, YOU
KNOW, DISCRIMINATION RESULTED
FROM SEPTEMBER 11TH WON'T BE
LISTED. THAT GROUP WON'T BE
LISTED IN A IN A IN A TOP FIVE,
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING IN REAL
TIME, YOU KNOW, SO THE LIST
THAT'S REFERRED TO IS FIVE. THE
FIVE TOP, BUT IT GOES BACK A
YEAR OR TWO YEARS WHATEVER AND
DOESN'T REALLY ADDRESS THE
CURRENT SITUATION. AND THAT
COULD BE TRUE. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF EXAMPLES OF THAT. AND YOU
GAVE TWO OF THE BEST. SO HOW DO
WE HANDLE THAT WHEN IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE THAT PARTICULAR
GROUP IS NOT NECESSARILY GOING
TO BE ON THE TOP FIVE LIST, BUT
SOME VERY REAL HORRIBLE VIOLENT
THINGS COULD BE GOING ON. SURE.
WELL THERE'S THE DATA IS ONLY
COMPILED THAT WE'RE USING YEAR
TO YEAR. THERE IS NO COMP. I
MEAN, I WOULD SAY THAT IF A
UNIVERSITY BELIEVES THAT THERE'S
DISCRIMINATION HAPPENING ON
THEIR CAMPUS, IF AS HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA, THEY
HAVE STUDENTS GOING TO THEM AND
PROFESSORS GOING TO THEM AND
SAYING, I FEEL THAT I'M BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OR I FEEL
UNSAFE, WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD IMMEDIATELY
START TO INCORPORATE THAT ANTI
DISCRIMINATION TRAINING INTO
THEIR PROGRAMS. THE REASON WE'RE
DOING THIS BILL IS THAT HAS NOT
HAPPENED. WE HAVEN'T SEEN THEM.
FOR INSTANCE, TURN AROUND AND
START OFFERING
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION. I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE ISLAMOPHOBIA
PIECE. I'M HOPING THAT THAT
GIVEN THAT THAT'S ON THE RISE,
THEY DO OFFER ISLAMOPHOBIA. YOU
KNOW, ANTI DISCRIMINATION
TRAINING IN THEIR EXISTING
PROGRAMS. BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
NOT HAD ANY WORD. AND AGAIN I
DON'T I'M NOT MONITORING EVERY
CAMPUS, BUT I HAVE YET TO SEE
ONE OF THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME TO ME SAY, HEY, I'M REALLY
GLAD THEY'VE JUST STARTED
OFFERING THIS REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING ON ON
ANTI-SEMITISM ON THIS CAMPUS.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN
THIS RISE. SO I AGREE WITH YOU.
THEY SHOULD BE RESPONDING IF
THEY IF THEY HAVE COMPLAINTS
COMING TO THEM. BUT THE REASON
WE'VE INTRODUCED THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE AS FAR AS WE'VE SEEN,
THAT JUST HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING.
SENATOR, IF I COULD LOWENTHAL GO
AHEAD. IF I COULD, I THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION THAT
YOU ASKED. AND THE TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS, IS THAT SENSITIVITY
TRAININGS TAKE A BIT OF TIME.
ACTUALLY TO BE PUT TOGETHER, AND
THERE ARE GOING TO BE BASED ON A
REACTION OF WHAT'S SEEN AND THE
INPUT, FOR EXAMPLE, THE INPUT OF
THE GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION, I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND VERY CRITICAL. HOW
YOU HAVE DIFFERING PERSPECTIVES
OF INCIDENTS THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE RIGHT NOW IN COLLEGE
CAMPUSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON THE UNIVERSITIES TO DEVELOP
THIS TRAINING, AND THAT IS GOING
TO TAKE A BIT OF TIME TO CREATE
A TRAINING CURRICULUM AROUND
THAT. JUST AS ANY DEI TRAINING
TAKES A BIT OF TIME. SO IT'S NOT
YOU WOULD NEVER HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE SOMETHING'S GOING TO COME
IN REAL TIME AND YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO GET IT IN REAL TIME.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE
WHILE FOR THEM TO COMPILE THAT,
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT I
THINK THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT, THAT THE
METRICS WE HAVE ARE IMPERFECT TO
LOOK AT THIS, AND IT WOULD BE
GOOD IF WE HAD A, YOU KNOW, IF
THERE WAS A BETTER KIND OF LIST
OF GROUPS THAT ARE NOT ONLY THE
TARGET OF HATRED AND HATE
INCIDENCES, BUT GROUPS THAT ALSO
HAVE JUST FACED SORT OF ARE
FACING SYSTEMIC DISCRIMINATION
IN THE COMMUNITIES. I MEAN,
THERE ARE SOME WAYS OF TRACKING
THAT, BUT THEY'RE SORT OF IN
DIFFERENT PLACES AND DIFFERENT
BUCKETS. SO BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S THERE SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
UNIVERSITIES THAT THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING WE SHOULD HAVE TO
NECESSARILY PRESCRIBE IN LAW.
THEY SHOULD BE ACTIVELY IF
YOU'RE DOING DEI TRAINING, I
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO BE ACTIVELY
LOOKING AT THE GROUPS THAT ARE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
EXPERIENCING YOU KNOW, HATRED
AND TO BE RESPONDING ACCORDINGLY
. WE AND MY JOINT AUTHOR IS
CORRECT. IT DOES TAKE A WHILE TO
DEVELOP THESE TRAININGS. IT'S,
YOU KNOW, YOU NEED PEOPLE THAT
HAVE AN EXPERTISE IN THE SUBJECT
AND HISTORY. YOU KNOW, SOMETHING
LIKE ANTI-SEMITISM. YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS OF
YEARS OF HISTORY THAT YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND AND YOU
KNOW WHAT? THAT WHAT IT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE. BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES WHAT I'VE FOUND IS THAT
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT
ANTI-SEMITISM IS AND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE, AND THEY'LL EVEN
ARGUE WITH JEWS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT SOMETHING IS ANTI-SEMITIC,
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE. AND IF OUR SCHOOLS
ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY
, YOU KNOW, THEY SHOULDN'T NEED
US NECESSARILY TO COME UP WITH A
LIST. THEY SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND INCORPORATING ALL
THE DIFFERENT KINDS OF HATRED
AND DISCRIMINATION. WE KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES INTO
THEIR ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAM AND
INTO THEIR DEI PROGRAMS.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
HAS THERE BEEN Ó SENATOR STERN
SORRY, I DID HAVE A QUESTION AND
IT MAY BE FOR THE OPPOSITION AS
OPPOSED TO THE AUTHORS. BUT I, I
NOTICED I MEAN, I WAS DOING MY
RESEARCH ON THE BILL BEFORE YOU
GUYS. YOU ALL CAME BEFORE
COMMITTEE. I DID NOTICE THAT, IN
A NUMBER OF THE DEI TRAININGS
OFFERED ACROSS THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS, THAT ISLAMOPHOBIA WAS
EXPRESSLY ADDRESSED. I'M LOOKING
HERE AT A RECENT ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL EVENT FOR CALIFORNIA
FACULTY, BY THE ISLAMIC NETWORKS
GROUP AT UC SAN DIEGO. I SEE
HERE, ISLAMOPHOBIA TRAINING.
THAT'S BUILT INTO THE CORE,
THAT'S IN THE OFFICE OF EQUITY,
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AT UCSD.
I SEE ANOTHER ONE AT UC DAVIS,
THAT LOOKED ENCOURAGING AND
LOOKED LIKE EXACTLY THE KINDS OF
THINGS, YOU'RE, YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR HERE. AND ALSO, I WAS
LOOKING AT THE UK'S RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE INVESTMENT
OF $7 MILLION IN A CIVIL RIGHTS
OFFICE THAT WOULD THAT EXPRESSLY
CALLED OUT ISLAMOPHOBIA, AMONGST
OTHER, CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUES,
INCLUDING ANTI-SEMITISM, AS A
NOT JUST AS TALK AND AS SORT OF
TRAINING POINT, BUT REALLY AS
SOMETHING WHERE THERE'S GOING TO
BE ENFORCEMENT. SO WHAT I'M WHAT
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING HERE IS
SETTING ASIDE THE BILL FOR A
SECOND. DO YOU SEE A GAP IN THE
DEI TRAINING, IF I MAY, THROUGH
THE CHAIR, AS THE OPPOSITION, IS
THERE A GAP IN DEI TRAINING
YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW? ARE
CAMPUSES NOT ADDRESSING
ISLAMOPHOBIA IN DEI TRAINING
THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF? SO I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN TO ONE OF THOSE
TRAININGS PROVIDED BY ING. AND
USUALLY THEY COVER
ANTI-SEMITISM, ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
SO ON. BUT I THINK THAT WITH
THOSE, IT'S NOT THE UNIVERSITY
NECESSARILY PUTTING THEM ON, BUT
BRINGING IN CONSULTANTS WHO WILL
TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES. IF WE
ARE TO CODIFY SOME KIND OF
PROGRAM THAT INCLUDES
ANTI-SEMITISM, ISLAMOPHOBIA AND
SO ON THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY, I
THINK IT WOULD JUST BE A
DIFFERENT KIND OF PROGRAM. SO,
SO A PROGRAM LIKE THAT, WOULD BE
VERY GENERAL AND BRINGING
OUTSIDE GROUPS. BUT IF IT WERE
THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDING A
YEARLY TRAININGS OR SO ON TO
STUDENTS, KIND OF LIKE WHAT'S
PROPOSED IN THE BILL, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S, YOU KNOW, I
DON'T KNOW IF I MISUNDERSTOOD
THAT, BUT NO, I MEAN, I THINK
YOU'RE GETTING AT IT. I DON'T
THINK THE BILL ACTUALLY REQUIRES
ANY DEI TRAININGS THAT WAS
REMOVED IN ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. I THINK IT JUST MAKES
SURE THAT WHATEVER DEI TRAININGS
ARE OCCURRING DOES NOT
INADVERTENTLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST TARGETED GROUPS. SO IT
DOESN'T FORECLOSE THE WAY I READ
IT, THE ANALYSIS STATES THAT IT
DOESN'T FORECLOSE THE
POSSIBILITY OF, YOU KNOW, BEYOND
ISLAMOPHOBIA OR ANTI-SEMITISM OR
WHATEVER THE ISSUE MAY BE. IT
STILL ALLOWS ALL THOSE
UNIVERSITY TRAININGS TO KEEP
OCCURRING. AND IT DOESN'T, SORT
OF CONSTRAIN I THINK IT IT JUST
MAKES SURE THAT NO ONE'S LEFT
BEHIND, I GUESS, IS HOW I READ
IT. SO I'M JUST WONDERING, FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE OR BASED ON
YOUR KNOWLEDGE HERE OF HOW THE
SYSTEM IS CURRENTLY WORKING, ARE
THERE ANY DEI TRAININGS ON ANY
UC OR CSU CAMPUSES THAT DO NOT
ADDRESS ISLAMOPHOBIA TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE? SORRY, CAN YOU
REPHRASE THAT QUESTION? SO JUST
ARE THERE ANY EVERY DEI TRAINING
I'VE, I'VE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
PUBLICLY AND I MAY NOT BE AWARE
OF ALL OF THEM, INCLUDES
ISLAMOPHOBIA AS A AS A KEY
COMPONENT. LIKE I JUST
MENTIONED, A FEW I KNOW I TALKED
TO, CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE, WHICH
IS IN MY BACKYARD, HAS SOME VERY
NEAR AND DEAR MUSLIM FRIENDS
THERE, INCLUDING IN THE FACULTY,
IT'S SQUARELY ADDRESSED THERE.
SO I'M JUST ARE THERE ANY
INSTANCES WHERE YOU FEEL LIKE
THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY OR
ISLAMOPHOBIA IS CURRENTLY NOT IN
A DEI TRAINING BEING OFFERED IN
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA?
SO I'M NOT I HAVEN'T AUDITED ALL
THE TRAININGS AVAILABLE, AND I
CAN I CAN GO LOOK AND KIND OF
GET BACK TO YOU ON WITH THAT
QUESTION. AND FOLLOW UP, BUT
WHAT I THINK OUR CONCERN IS, IS,
IS KIND OF TO SENATOR RAZA'S
COMMENT AROUND MUSLIMS RIGHT
NOW, IF WE WERE TO GO JUST OFF
OF THE AG'S REPORT OF THE TOP
FIVE, GROUPS, ISLAMOPHOBIA
WOULDN'T BE INCLUDED. AND IT
LIKELY, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
THE AG REPORT I CHECKED LAST WAS
2022. SO IF WE WERE TO IMPLEMENT
TRAINING JUST BASED OFF THE LAST
YEAR, IT WOULDN'T BE IMPLEMENTED
UNTIL 2025, 2026, WHENEVER THAT
TRAINING WOULD BE DEVELOPED BY
THE UNIVERSITY. AFTER THE REPORT
HAD ALREADY BEEN PUBLISHED. SO
THAT'S OUR OUR MAIN CONCERN. I
WANT TO BE PRECISE ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE YOU SAY
WOULDN'T BE INCLUDED, BUT THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT HOW THE BILL READS.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, BECAUSE IT'S
WOULDN'T BE ALLOWED TO BE
EXCLUDED. THE BILL ONLY PREVENTS
CERTAIN GROUPS FROM BEING
EXCLUDED. SO IT'S NOT THAT,
LGBTQ COMMUNITY, MUSLIM
COMMUNITY, JEWISH COMMUNITY. IF
THINGS GOT REALLY GOOD OUT THERE
FOR THE JEWISH COMMUNITY AND
ANTI-SEMITISM DROPPED AND THEY
WERE NO LONGER IN THE TOP FIVE
AND THEY WERE OFF, IT'S STILL IT
JUST WOULD IT WOULDN'T, REMOVE
THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR INCLUSION.
IT WOULD JUST IT WOULD CHANGE
WHO WE MAKE SURE DOESN'T GET
LEFT BEHIND. AND I THINK WHAT
I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
AUTHORS, AT LEAST, IS THAT THEY
HAVEN'T FOUND A SINGLE INSTANCE
IN ANY DEI TRAINING ON THE
CAMPUSES, AND THERE MAY BE SOME,
WHERE ANTI-SEMITISM WAS SQUARELY
ADDRESSED. SO I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT LOOK,
BUT IT'S A CONCERN ABOUT WHO WE
DON'T WANT TO GET LEFT BEHIND
VERSUS WHO'S GOING TO GET
EXCLUDED AND WHO WON'T, BECAUSE
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO BE IN
THIS TOGETHER. AND, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT THREE YEAR OLD GIRL IN
TEXAS THIS LAST WEEK, WHAT
HAPPENS TO FRIENDS OF MINE WHO
WEAR HIJAB IN LOS ANGELES, IT'S
AWFUL. OUT THERE. AND I DON'T
WANT TO DIMINISH THE SERIOUSNESS
OF IT. I'M JUST I'M TRYING TO
GET TO THE TO THE FACTS THAT
BILL AND I, I REALLY I STRUGGLE
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND THIS
SORT OF JUST I WANT TO GET
ACCURATE ABOUT WHAT THE NATURE
OF THE OPPOSITION IS, BECAUSE
THIS BILL WOULD NOT EXCLUDE THE
ISLAMOPHOBIA FROM DEI TRAINING
AND IN FACT MENTIONS
ISLAMOPHOBIA EXPLICITLY IN THE
BILL. IT JUST WOULD PREVENT
THOSE TOP FIVE FROM BEING
EXCLUDED. SO I HOPE THAT. DOES
THAT GET YOU FURTHER ALONG? DOES
THAT HELP? THAT HELPS, I THINK
OUR CONCERN IS THIS WHEN WE
DIRECT UNIVERSITIES AND, YOU
KNOW, I THINK YOUR POINT IS, IS
NOT, YOU KNOW, IGNORED OR NOT
TAKEN, IT'S ACTUALLY A GREAT
POINT, BUT I THINK THAT WHEN,
YOU KNOW, OUR POSITION WOULD BE
OR OUR CONCERN IS THAT WHEN YOU
DIRECT UNIVERSITIES TO IMPLEMENT
TRAINING FOR FIVE GROUPS,
THEY'RE GOING TO STOP AT FIVE
GROUPS. MOST LIKELY. OR IF WE
WERE TO ENUNCIATE THREE GROUPS,
NOT NECESSARILY. BUT IF YOU WERE
TO SAY THREE GROUPS, THEN THEY'D
FOCUS ON THOSE THREE GROUPS AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY IT
DOESN'T EXCLUDE, BUT CONSIDERING
YOU KNOW, THE PAST EIGHT MONTHS,
SEVEN MONTHS OF JUST INCREASED
TENSION AND DISCRIMINATION ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES, WE'D BE MORE
COMFORTABLE INCLUDING THOSE WITH
WITH THAT AMENDMENT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN. SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU, I WAS WATCHING YOUR
PRESENTATION EARLIER, AND I JUST
WANTED TO UNDERSTAND FROM THE
AUTHOR IN THE MOST LAYMAN WAY,
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE WHAT THIS
BILL REALLY DOES? WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS IT TELLS UNIVERSITIES
THAT IF THEY'RE OFFERING DEI
TRAINING, DISCRIMINATION
TRAINING, THAT THEY SHOULD ALSO
INCLUDE THE GROUPS THAT WE KNOW
ARE AT LEAST I MEAN, IT'S THE
BEST LIST WE COULD FIND, WE
AGREE IT'S NOT A PERFECT LIST,
BUT THE LIST THAT WE WENT BY IS
THE AGS LIST OF HATE CRIMES. AND
DISCRIMINATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
MAJOR GROUPS ARE NOT BEING LEFT
OUT OF TRAINING. YOU KNOW, JUST
LIKE THE DEI TRAINING IS
SUPPOSED TO ADDRESS IMPLICIT
BIAS, WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE TRAINERS THEMSELVES
DON'T BRING THEIR IMPLICIT BIAS
IN AND EXCLUDE GROUPS THAT WE
KNOW ARE THE TARGET OF MAJOR
AND, YOU KNOW, MAJOR
DISCRIMINATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THERE ARE MANY
GROUPS THAT THAT ARE THE TARGETS
OF DISCRIMINATION, AND, SO IF
YOU MAKE IT INTO THAT TOP FIVE
LIST, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
REALLY WIDESPREAD, YOU KNOW,
DISCRIMINATION AND HATRED IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WHO'S IN THE TOP
FIVE FOR RIGHT NOW? I'M NOT SURE
THAT THAT LIST. WOULD YOU LET ME
ASK MY STAFF TO BRING UP THE
LIST? WHEN I REMEMBER, I THINK
IT WAS BLACK LGBT. OH, SORRY.
IT'S RIGHT HERE, RIGHT NOW.
IT'S, YOUR YOUR BLACK COMMUNITY.
HISPANIC, LATINO, ASIAN, JEWISH
AND GAY MALE. AND THIS IS FROM
2022. THIS WHEN'S THE LAST DATA?
YEAH. 2022. OKAY. AND SO WE'RE
IN 2024 RIGHT NOW. AND LET'S SAY
THAT LET'S SAY THIS GOES INTO
EFFECT. AND WE'RE IN THE YEAR
2027 RIGHT. DOES THAT TOP FIVE
ROTATE. YEAH IT CHANGES OVER
TIME I DON'T KNOW I COULDN'T
TELL YOU HOW OFTEN IT'S CHANGED
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS. BUT IT
CERTAINLY CHANGES. AND AGAIN WE
ARE NOT TELLING THE UNIVERSITIES
ANYWHERE IN THIS BILL TO NOT DO
ANY OF THE TRAINING THEY'RE
CURRENTLY DOING. BUT IF YOU'RE
DOING A WHOLE BUNCH OF TRAINING
AND YOU'RE MISSING ONE OF THESE
GROUPS, I THINK THERE'S A
PROBLEM THERE. YEAH, I
UNDERSTOOD COMPLETELY. NOW, WE
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION. AND
WHERE DID THE OPPOSITION GO? AND
THE ONE THING THAT YOU GUYS
WANTED TO ADD WAS SPECIFICALLY
WHAT? SO, I THINK THE MAIN
AMENDMENT IS TO ALSO INCLUDE TOP
THE RELIGIOUS GROUPS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IF WE
LIMITED IT, TOP FIVE
ISLAMOPHOBIA WOULD BE EXCLUDED
FROM THAT TOP FIVE LIST, FOR
GOING OFF THE, YOU KNOW, THE
POPULATION OF THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, ESTIMATED TO BE
AROUND ONE AND A HALF TO 2
MILLION. OKAY. AND I BELIEVE
THAT I'VE HAD MEETINGS WITH,
JPAC IN THE PAST, AND I BELIEVE
THAT THEIR NUMBER. DO YOU GUYS
KNOW THE POPULATION SIZE OF THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY AS WELL IN
CALIFORNIA? YOU KNOW.
APPROXIMATELY 1.2 MILLION,
ROUGHLY THE SAME. OKAY IT LOOKS
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT THE SAME. LET'S
DO LET'S DO THIS IN QUESTION
ANSWER FORMAT. SO GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, AND ONE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF BILLS AND OBVIOUSLY THE
JEWISH CAUCUS HAS PRIORITIZED A
HANDFUL OF BILLS THAT THEY MOVE
FORWARD, WHICH I'M VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF. AND I VOTED FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THEM. AND, YOU KNOW,
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DISCRIMINATION AND I THINK, I
HATE TO SAY THAT THE DATA, THE
FACT THAT IT'S FROM 2022 IS
OUTDATED, SINCE WE'RE TWO YEARS
OUT ALREADY, AND WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING A LOT OF ISSUES ON OUR
CAMPUSES, AND I GENUINELY DO
VALUE FREEDOM OF SPEECH. I, I
THINK THAT IT'S A CORE TENET OF
BEING AN AMERICAN AND ESPECIALLY
AT THAT AGE RANGE WHERE, PEOPLE
WANT TO STAND UP FOR WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IN, WITH THAT SAID, I AM
ASKING AND WONDERING IF YOU
WOULD BE OPEN TO INCLUDING THE
TOP THREE RELIGIOUS GROUPS,
BECAUSE I WILL SAY IN MY
DISTRICT, WE HAVE BEEN SEEING A
UPTICK IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST,
YOU KNOW, I WILL SAY UPTICK IN
INDOPHOBIA. WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER
OF BUSINESSES BEING ROBBED AND
HARASSED. WE'VE ALSO SEEN, I
BELIEVE, EVEN WHEN JPAC VISITED
MY OFFICE, THEY HIGHLIGHTED THAT
SOME THINGS THAT WERE HAPPENING
IN, NOT NECESSARILY MY DISTRICT,
EXACTLY, BUT THE BORDERING AREAS
OF THE BAY AREA, AND I WANT TO
KNOW, WOULD YOU GUYS BE WILLING
TO TAKE SOME TYPE OF LANGUAGE OR
AMENDMENT TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS HERE? I THINK THAT'S
THE EASIEST RESOLUTION TO BE
INCLUSIVE. YEAH. LET US TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS, YOU KNOW, THE
THING ABOUT THE FIRST OF ALL, I
JUST FOUND OUT THEY I ONLY
LOOKED AT THIS BECAUSE STAFF IS
TEXTING ME SOME INFORMATION. THE
LIST IS BEING UPDATED THIS
SUMMER JUST SO THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS, I FUNDAMENTALLY AM NOT
AGAINST DOING THAT. I WANT TO
JUST MAKE UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO MEAN, WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO BROADEN THIS NOW TO
SEVEN GROUPS, FOR INSTANCE, YOU
KNOW, BECAUSE THIS IS IN FLUX,
FOR INSTANCE, AGE COULD CREEP
INTO THIS LIST, YOU KNOW, LIKE
IT'S NOT JUST. NO. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND I'M
ACTUALLY VERY OPEN TO THE FLUID
ASPECT OF WHAT IS BEING
REPORTED. BUT I ALSO, JUST AS A
MINORITY IN THIS BUILDING AS THE
ONLY MUSLIM IN THE SENATE, I
PERSONALLY THINK THAT THERE ARE
THINGS BEING LEFT OFF THE TABLE
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS, AND
I'VE HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS.
I'VE SHARED IT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES JUST THIS PAST WEEK.
I GET AN ANONYMOUS LETTER THAT
SAYS F HAMAS FREEDOM FOREVER
SHARIA, NEVER WITH A TARGET
DIRECTED SPECIFICALLY TO ME. AND
IN MY REPORTING THAT TO ONE OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS AGENCIES NOT
NECESSARILY, AND THE REASON WHY
I THINK SO MANY PEOPLE DON'T
REPORT IT, WHETHER IT'S THE
SIKHS THAT WEAR THE TERMINALS
THAT ARE IGNORANTLY MISTAKEN AS
A MUSLIM OR THE WOMEN THAT WEAR
THE HIJAB OR THE JEWISH MEN,
RIGHT, THAT ARE MORE
IDENTIFIABLE, OR ANY OF THOSE
THINGS IS BECAUSE THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THAT TAKE IT ON THE
CHIN EVERY DAY, RIGHT? PEOPLE
WILL WALK PAST THEM. WE SEE OUR
ASIAN COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT
THAT LITERALLY CANNOT HIDE WHO
THEY ARE. IT'S VISIBLE. AND
WE'VE SEEN AN UPTICK IN ASIAN
HATE, AND WE CONSISTENTLY SEE
THIS. AND YET AT THE SAME TIME,
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
NOT THAT INTEGRATED INTO
AMERICAN SOCIETY THAT DO NOT
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
REPORT IT, THAT DO NOT GET
COUNTED IN SOME OF THESE
TRADITIONAL SURVEYS THAT HAVE
BEEN HISTORIC FOR DECADES.
RIGHT, THERE ARE ALSO PEOPLE WHO
ARE ASHAMED THAT THEY ARE BEING
TARGETED OR WANT TO SAY IT'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THIS, BECAUSE WE LIVE
IN AMERICA, RIGHT? AND EVERY
SINGLE DAY THERE ARE PEOPLE
GETTING ATTACKED AND HARASSED. I
THINK. AND I WANT TO BE AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE. AND I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH, MANY,
MANY DIFFERENT MEMBERS HERE. AND
I DO VALUE THE WORK THAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING. IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO TRAIN IN THE MOST
INCLUSIVE WAY WITH THE MOST UP
TO DATE DATA. AND I DON'T THINK
ASKING FOR THESE THREE
CONSIDERATIONS TO BE INCLUDED.
AND SO I'M ASKING AS A
COLLEAGUE, IF YOU WOULD TAKE
THAT AMENDMENT, NOT NECESSARILY
HERE, BUT AND MAYBE HERE, BUT
EVEN IN A PROCESS. AND IF YOU
WOULD COMMIT TO THAT. WELL,
LOOK, I CONCEPTUALLY I'M GOOD
WITH IT AND I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE. IT'S NOT GOING TO HELP
WITH THE REPORTING ISSUE. YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE ARE I THINK I THINK
THAT ONE THING THAT WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT MOVING FORWARD INTO
THE FUTURE IS THE LIST THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS REALLY
REPORTABLE SORT OF HATE CRIMES,
BUT IT DOESN'T COUNT A LOT OF
SORT OF LATENT DISCRIMINATION
THAT DOESN'T END UP IN THAT
LIST. SO I'M NOT ARGUING ABOUT
THAT. I'M JUST SAYING THAT I
THINK THAT DEVELOPING SORT OF
MORE COMPREHENSIVE LISTS THAT
LOOK NOT JUST AT SORT OF HATE
CRIMES, BUT ALSO INCORPORATE
DISCRIMINATION, INCORPORATE, YOU
KNOW, SOME OF THE ISSUES YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT DON'T FILTER
THEIR WAY UP INTO AN AGS LIST IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT. I WANT TO JUST
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT I WANT TO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE BEFORE I
COMMIT THAT THE COMMITTEES DON'T
COME BACK AS THEY HAVE IN
SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEES AND HAD
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES WITH
THINGS LIKE WE'VE WE STARTED OUT
IN A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT PLACE,
AND EVERY COMMITTEE BROUGHT UP
SOME ISSUES THAT WERE
CONSTITUTIONAL. I DON'T WANT TO
RUN INTO ANYTHING LIKE THAT 100.
AND I HIGHLY DOUBT THAT ANYBODY
IS GOING TO BE ALARMED THAT WE
ARE INCLUDING GROUPS THAT HAVE
NOT HISTORICALLY SPOKEN FOR
THEMSELVES OR HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED, AND WE AS A BODY, TRY
TO BE INCLUSIVE FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT NECESSARILY SPEAK UP
FOR THEMSELVES, WHO DO NOT HAVE
REPRESENTATION, WHO DO NOT. AND
I THINK THAT THIS IS A FAIR
ASSESSMENT TO BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE THIS. IT IS
LITERALLY ADDING A COMMA, RIGHT?
NO, BUT BUT IT WOULD, IT WOULD
BE ADDING IT WOULD BE HAVING THE
FIVE GROUPS ON HERE AND THEN
PLUS THE THREE TOP RELIGIONS,
UNLESS THEY WERE ALREADY
INCORPORATED. SO ALL I'M
POINTING OUT IS THAT YOU COULD
GO FROM 5 TO 7, REQUIRE GROUPS
AND KEEP IN MIND THAT THIS
TRAINING IS ALSO AND I'M NOT
SAYING NO, I JUST WANT EVERYONE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
EARLY PUSHBACK WE GOT WAS JUST
THE SCOPE OF THE TRAINING THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED WHENEVER THEY
DO TRAINING, AND WE DID ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS WE HAD TO TAKE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WAS TO ACTUALLY
ALLOW FOR SOME OF THE TRAININGS
TO NOT INCLUDE THIS, BECAUSE
THERE ARE VERY SPECIFIC
TRAININGS ABOUT THINGS LIKE
HANDICAPS, YOU KNOW, PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES. I UNDERSTAND ALL
THAT WOULD LET HER FINISH HER
ANSWER. OKAY GO AHEAD. YEAH. SO
I'M JUST SAYING I JUST WANT TO
BE I'M I'M, I'M, I WANT TO SAY
YES. I'M NERVOUS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO NOW HAVE THE UCS COME
BACK AND SAY, BECAUSE IT'S GONE
FROM 5 TO 7, IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE,
IT'S TOO HARD TO IMPLEMENT OR,
YOU KNOW, THE COST IS GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT A PROBES NOW
IS GOING TO SAY. IT'S JUST
UNMANAGEABLE FOR THEM TO OFFER
THAT MUCH TRAINING. SO I JUST I
WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF ALL THAT.
SO I WILL MAKE I WILL COMMIT TO
IF WE DON'T RUN INTO ANY OF
THAT, SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
REALLY KILL THE BILL IN
APPROPRIATIONS OR BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. I, YOU KNOW, I
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT.
AND I CAN CERTAINLY COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT,
BECAUSE I DO AGREE THAT
RELIGIONS MAY, BY THEIR VERY
NATURE, JUST NOT RISE TO THE
LEVEL, BECAUSE THERE TEND TO BE
A DIFFERENT KIND OF
DISCRIMINATION. AND I WANT TO
INCLUDE THAT. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT, THAT THEY'RE IN
THERE. SO CONCEPTUALLY, YES,
LET'S JUST MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY WORKABLE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SOME SENATOR WAHAB.
YEAH. SO I APPRECIATE ALL THAT.
AND OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT TRYING TO
TANK ANYBODY'S BILL THAT IS NOT
EVEN AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
THAT'S NOT MY JOB. I DON'T DO
THAT. I DO WANT TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE. AND I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS ALWAYS VERY SKEWED
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT HISTORICALLY
REPRESENTED. RIGHT. AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE IN, YOU KNOW, THE
21ST CENTURY AND WE HAVE, LIKE
MYSELF, THE FIRST MUSLIM, THE
FIRST AFGHAN IN THE SENATE.
RIGHT. WE HAVE TO GO. AND I
ALWAYS SAY THIS, EVEN WITH LAST
YEAR'S THE LAST BILL, WE HAVE TO
GO FURTHER AND DEEPER INTO
COMMUNITIES. THE MORE DIVERSE WE
BECOME ASKING FOR THIS IS NOT A
BIG ASK, RIGHT? IF WE ARE TRULY
TRYING TO BE INCLUSIVE, IF WE
ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS, THAT
EDUCATE INDIVIDUALS, THAT WE ARE
EDUCATING PEOPLE NOT TO BE
BIASED, NOT TO CAUSE HARM, NOT
TO DO THESE THINGS. I WOULD LOVE
TO KNOW WHICH CSU OR UC COMES UP
AND SAYS, I DON'T WANT TO TRAIN
THIS PARTICULAR
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION EFFORT.
RIGHT? SO I RESPECT YOUR CONCERN
AND I WILL SAY THAT I'M A LITTLE
DISTURBED THAT IT'S GONE THROUGH
THIS MANY COMMITTEES WITHOUT
THIS PIECE IN IT. AND THE REASON
WHY IS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD TO
JUST BE INCLUDED IN THE
CONVERSATION. AND RIGHT NOW WE
ARE SEEING SUCH A DIVIDE IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS. AND AT
LEAST WHERE I'M FROM, IN THE BAY
AREA, WE TRY AS VERY HARD TO BE
AS INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE, AND I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S A LOT TO
ASK FOR. OBVIOUSLY, WE'RE GOING
TO FIGURE OUT THE BUDGETARY
COSTS IN A PROBES, BUT I THINK
THAT THIS IS GENUINELY NEEDED. I
HEAR YOU THAT YOU WILL COMMIT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE TO GET THIS
DONE. THAT IS ALL I'M ASKING
FOR. AND I HOPE THAT, INAPPROPES
WE SEE THAT MOVE FORWARD.
ALRIGHTY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT COMMENT IN YOUR
CLOSE? JUST I, I TOTALLY AGREE
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S I THINK
THAT, WE'RE AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE
JUST SEEING RISING SORT OF
INTOLERANCE IN GENERAL. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE UNIVERSITY
STEPPING UP AND CREATING THESE
PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW, IT'S THE
UNIVERSITIES TOOK IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO CREATE DEI
PROGRAMS TO TRAIN ON
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION AND IMPLICIT
BIAS. AND, AND IT'S DIFFERENT
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE. YOU
KNOW, IN MY DISTRICT, WE HAVE A
REALLY LARGE, COMMUNITY OF
ARMENIAN AMERICANS, WE SEE, YOU
KNOW, ISSUES AROUND THAT
POPULATION THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO SEE PROBABLY IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. SO YOU WOULD
EXPECT THE UNIVERSITIES THERE
TO, YOU KNOW, ACT ACCORDINGLY,
SO I THINK IT'S A BALANCE OF
BEING, LIKE YOU SAID,
PRESCRIPTIVE ENOUGH TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT LEAVING GROUPS
OUT, YOU KNOW, AND GIVING THEM
THAT GUIDANCE, WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE DOING THE BILL AND ALSO
ALLOWING ENOUGH LATITUDE SO
WHERE THEY CAN, YOU KNOW,
RESPOND TO WHAT THEY NEED TO IN
TERMS OF LIKE LOCAL CONDITIONS
AND LOCAL POPULATIONS. AND, YOU
KNOW, IT'S MESSY STUFF IN A WAY,
TO TRY TO PUT THAT CULTURE
CHANGE INTO A LAW. YOU KNOW, IN
SOME WAYS WE'RE TRYING TO SORT
OF GUIDE THEM HERE, LIKE, HEY,
YOU'RE MISSING GROUPS, YOU'RE
MISSING, YOU KNOW, MAYBE MUSLIM
STUDENTS, YOU KNOW, IN SOME
PLACES YOU'RE MISSING THIS, THIS
TRAINING TO KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ATTEMPT TO DO HERE. SO WE AGREE
WE WANT TO MAKE THIS AS
PROTECTIVE AS WE CAN AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE GROUPS THAT NEED
THAT NEED THIS TRAINING, THAT
NEED PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, KIND OF WHAT THEY'RE
FACING ARE INCLUDED. SO I THINK
THAT THERE'S A WAY OF WORDING
THIS, THAT, THAT MAKES SURE
THAT, LIKE YOU SAID, THAT IT
GOES DEEP ENOUGH AND, YOU KNOW,
LET'S WORK. I'LL WORK WITH YOU
ON THE LANGUAGE, YOU KNOW, TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY. OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? SEEING
NONE, HAS THERE BEEN A MOTION
SENATOR CABALLERO MOVES THE
BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADD,
WOULD I LIKE TO DO WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? OH, I WILL
ACCEPT THAT AS MY CLOSE. AND
THANKS FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION. I THINK THIS BILL I
MEAN, I HONESTLY DO BELIEVE THIS
BILL HAS GOTTEN BETTER AND
BETTER AS IT'S MOVED THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOWENTHAL. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 19
AB2925. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG
I UMBERG. AYE WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. Dð.
GRASSO RUSSO. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE NHIÀU. ROTH. ROTH AYE.
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WAHAB. AYE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
7 TO 0 SEVEN ZERO. WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NEXT, WE
HAVE SOME MEMBER GARCIA, THEN
GRAYSON, THEN HANEY. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO I'VE
DONE THE MATH HERE FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO ARE WATCHING IN YOUR
OFFICES AND LISTENING AND THE
MATH INDICATES THAT IF WE STAY
ON THIS PACE, WILL BE DONE AT 11
MINUTES AFTER TEN TONIGHT. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO STOP FOR A DINNER
BREAK FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, THERE WILL BE FOOD
AVAILABLE, BUT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO RECESS FOR DINNER, SO. ALL
RIGHT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
MISTER CHAIR. WELL, IT WON'T BE
MY FAULT THAT YOU'RE NOT
STOPPING FOR DINNER, BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO BE QUICK, THIS BILL IS
A STUDY BILL THAT FOCUSES ON THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVIEW OF THE
RIVAS Ã. THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION, IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE, TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE ISSUE OF DISQUALIFICATION
AND RECUSAL OF JUDICIAL OFFICERS
FOR PREJUDICE AND CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. YEAH. CHAIR
MEMBERS, MARVIN PINEDA IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2125 ON BEHALF OF
THE WILLIAM C VELASQUEZ
INSTITUTE AND ASIAN LAW
ALLIANCE. I WOULD ALSO MAKE A
SHORT, THE STUDY EVALUATES THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CURRENT
MECHANISM IN ELIMINATING BIAS.
THE PREVALENCE OF JUDGES
PRESIDING OVER CASES WHERE
ETHICAL STANDARDS SUGGEST THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN. THEY SHOULD
HAVE RECUSED THEMSELVES, THE
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE STUDY WILL GUIDE FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE AND JUDICIAL REFORMS
, HELPING TO BUILD MORE
TRANSPARENT, ACCOUNTABLE AND
TRUSTWORTHY JUDICIARY SYSTEM. WE
RESPECTFULLY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2125, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR. WELL, WE'VE GOT TWO
WITNESSES. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON. ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON
BEHALF OF LA COOPERATIVA
CAMPESINA DE CALIFORNIA, LOS
AMIGOS DE LA COMUNIDAD, AND AS A
PROXY FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
OPPORTUNITY CENTER, INLAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
AND FIRST AID FOUNDATION. ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2125, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OR THE
TABLE SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BILL AND I
MOVE IT. SENATOR WILK HAS MOVED
THE BILL. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. NO, SIR. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S THAT WAS AMONG THE
BEST CLOSES TODAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY.
DINNER? YEAH. WE'LL HAVE DINNER.
MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL, IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS AB 2125,
FILE ITEM NUMBER 21. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILK
AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO. GRASSO. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. MILO ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN WAHAB. WAHHAB. AYE
YOU GOT 7 TO 0 MEMBERS. WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I SEE SOME IMMIGRATION
WHO'S BEEN WAITING VERY
PATIENTLY AFTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON WILL HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. IF HE APPEARS,
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN FOR
THREE BILLS. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS, I WILL RIVAL
MY COLLEAGUE WHO JUST PRESENTED.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2017. IT
WILL HELP PREVENT WHAT WE CALL
FEE CREEP IN THE BANKING
INDUSTRY BY PROHIBITING STATE
CHARTERED FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
FROM CHARGING A NON-SUFFICIENT
FUND OR NSF FEE TO A CONSUMER
FOR A TRANSACTION DECLINED
INSTANTANEOUSLY OR NEAR
INSTANTANEOUSLY. I AM PLEASED TO
SHARE THAT THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE HAS FORMALLY TAKEN
A NEUTRAL POSITION ON THE BILL,
AND THERE IS NO LONGER ANY
OPPOSITION ON FILE. THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY IN STATE LAW A RULE
PROPOSED BY THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU, WE
KNOW AS CFPB IN JANUARY, IN
ORDER TO PROACTIVELY SET
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
FROM ABUSIVE PRACTICES AND BY
PROHIBITING A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION FROM CHARGING A
CONSUMER AN NSF FEE. WHEN THE
CONSUMERS ATTEMPT TO INITIATE A
TRANSACTION THAT IS DECLINED
INSTANTANEOUSLY OR NEAR
INSTANTANEOUSLY DUE TO NON
NON-SUFFICIENT FUNDS, AB 2017
WILL REIN IN JUNK FEES AND
PROTECT FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS FROM CHARGES THEY
CANNOT AFFORD. AND I DO BELIEVE
MY WITNESS IS MIA. SO THAT IS
IT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WELL,
YOU'VE DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB.
ALL RIGHT. SO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2017, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BRIAN
AUGUSTA, ON BEHALF OF REYES
ECONOMY AND THE HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH. LET'S TALK TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 22
AB 2017, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING, BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. BILL AND I MOVE IT.
SENATOR WILK HAS MOVED THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, THAT WAS
MY CLOSE. ALL RIGHT. YOU BEAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA, SO. ALL
RIGHT, MADAM SECRETARY, IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YES, THIS
IS AB 2017, FILE ITEM NUMBER 22.
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS IS A
MOTION UMBERG A UMBERG. AYE.
WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. MILO ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN WAHAB. 6 TO 0.
MEMBERS MISSING SIX ZERO. PUT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NORMALLY WE WOULD GO TO
MR. HANEY OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN, BUT THEY'RE NOT HERE. SO
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL.
IT'S YOUR LUCKY DAY. LET'S HOPE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL, FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE FOLLOWING
AT HOME, IT'S 5 A.M, NUMBER 32
AB 3172. FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. I'M VERY PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 3172. THIS IS A BIG
BILL BY ANY MEASURE. LET ME
START OUT BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND TO THANK YOU AND TO
YOUR STAFF FOR THE TIME AND
INCREDIBLE, INCREDIBLY
THOUGHTFUL WORK. STRENGTHENING
THE LEGISLATION TO GET US TO
THIS POINT. I HOPE YOU WILL ALL
AGREE WITH ME THAT THE NUMBER
ONE JOB OF GOVERNMENT IS TO
PROTECT ITS CITIZENS, AND IT'S
OUR CULTURE IN CALIFORNIA TO
APPLY ADDITIONAL FOCUS ON OUR
MOST VULNERABLE, OUR CHILDREN.
MOREOVER, WE ARE FAILING OUR
CHILDREN AND DERELICT IN OUR
MISSION WHEN WE KNOWINGLY ALLOW
HARM TO COME TO THEM UNDER OUR
WATCH. AB 3172 IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD. IT WILL HELP
HOLD SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HARM. THEY
CAUSED TO CHILDREN AND TEENAGERS
IN OUR GREAT STATE. QUITE
SIMPLY, WE'RE ASKING SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES TO DO WHAT WE
ASK OF EVERY OTHER CONSUMER
PRODUCT COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVEN HARM
THEY CAUSE TO CHILDREN. THIS, OF
COURSE, ISN'T A NEW CONCEPT. IN
FACT, WE ALREADY DO THIS FOR
COMPANIES THAT MAKE TOYS, THAT
MAKE HELMETS, THAT MAKE
SEATBELTS, THAT MAKE SLEEPING
BAGS, CAR SEATS, BICYCLES,
SCOOTERS, AND ON AND ON AND ON.
ANECDOTALLY, THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT EVERY SINGLE PARENT I'VE
COME ACROSS IS FRUSTRATED WITH
EVERY PARENT, EVERY PERSON IN
THIS BODY THAT I'VE TALKED TO
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, AND
IT'S DRIVEN BY DATA. THIS ISSUE
IS MAGNIFIED BY THE TRULY
ALARMING DROP IN CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. AND PARTICULARLY IN
GIRLS. AND IT'S GETTING WORSE.
WE CANNOT SIT IDLY BY WHILE WE
WATCH DRAMATIC, UNPRECEDENTED
RISES IN ANXIETY, DEPRESSION,
EATING DISORDERS AND SUICIDE BY
CHILDREN. SUICIDE WHICH IS UP
60% IN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE SINCE
2011. HOW CAN WE SIT BY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SPENDING AN AVERAGE
BRACE YOURSELVES OF FIVE HOURS
PER DAY ON SOCIAL MEDIA. IS
THERE ANY OTHER ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE SEND OUR KIDS INTO WITHOUT
CLEARLY UNDERSTANDING THE SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED TO US AS
THEIR CUSTODIANS? ANYTHING.
THINK ABOUT THE PROTECTIONS WE
HAVE WITH OUR KIDS FOR EVERY
OTHER ENVIRONMENT. I MUST MAKE
MYSELF PERFECTLY CLEAR. I'M NOT
AGAINST SOCIAL MEDIA AT ALL. AND
LIKE ALL OF YOU IN THIS CHAMBER,
USE SOCIAL MEDIA AS A POWERFUL
COMMUNICATIONS VEHICLE. AS A
PARENT, I SEE THE POSITIVE
EFFECT SOME SOCIAL MEDIA TOOLS
HAVE ON CONNECTING YOUNG PEOPLE.
I JUST WANT SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO MUCH MORE
VIGOROUSLY STEP UP TO THE PLATE
AND BE RESPONSIBLE PARTNERS THAT
TAKE SAFETY AND WELL-BEING OF
OUR CHILDREN AS SERIOUS AS THEY
DO THEIR PROFITS. THE ISSUES
RAISED IN AB 3172 ARE NOT NEW,
BUT THE DEMAND FOR RELIEF IS
GETTING LOUDER AND LOUDER BY THE
DAY. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
CALIFORNIA, MULTIPLE OTHER
STATES AND IMPORTANT TO NOTE,
BOTH BLUE AND RED STATES AND
MANY OF OUR ALLIES OVERSEAS HAVE
LONG SOUGHT WAYS TO HOLD SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
NEGATIVE IMPACTS THEIR PLATFORMS
ARE HAVING ON THE WELL-BEING OF
CHILDREN AND TEENS. NOW, THE
OPPOSITION MAY HAVE SAID MANY
THINGS TO SCARE YOU FROM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
DOES NOT DO THIS BILL WOULD
WOULD IMPOSE SPECIFIC FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY ON LARGE SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES ONLY IF THEIR
NEGLIGENCE HAS BEEN PROVEN IN
COURT. THIS ISN'T ABOUT LIMITING
KIDS EXPRESSION OR ACCESS
WHATSOEVER. NOTHING. NOTHING IN
THIS BILL DICTATES CONTENT.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL RESTRICTS
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM USING THE
INTERNET OR ANY PARTICULAR
PLATFORM. AND NOTHING IN THIS
BILL CHANGES CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERLYING STANDARDS FOR WHAT
CONSTITUTES NEGLIGENCE. NOTHING.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
STANDARD OF LIABILITY AT ALL.
ALL COMPANIES ALREADY OWE AN AN
ORDINARY DUTY OF CARE TO ALL
USERS OF THEIR PRODUCTS. THIS
BILL MERELY ASSIGNS SPECIFIC
DAMAGES. IF A SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY IS FOUND TO HAVE
VIOLATED EXISTING NEGLIGENCE LAW
UNDER 1714 A AND THE BREACH OF
ORDINARY CARE AND SKILL TO A
CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF 18. IN
ADDITION, I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE OF ENSURING
THERE IS AN INCENTIVE FOR SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO DESIGN
BETTER, SAFER PRODUCTS FOR YOUTH
FROM THE OUTSET. SPECIFICALLY
THE AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT ARE
HARMED BY PLATFORMS AREN'T
DENIED WHATEVER REDRESS CAN BE
FOUND IN THE COURT OF LAW, WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME ADDING
HEIGHTENED PENALTIES IN THIS
BILL TO ACTIONS BROUGHT BY
PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. IN OTHER
WORDS, THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION CREATED
IN THIS BILL. THE NET EFFECT OF
AB 3172 WILL UNDOUBTEDLY MAKE
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES MORE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE WAY THEY
DESIGN AND OPERATE THEIR
PLATFORMS, AND THE EFFECT THAT
WILL HAVE ON OUR KIDS TO FOCUS
ON SAFETY MEASURES AND WELLNESS,
RATHER THAN ON ADDICTION. I'M SO
PROUD TO SAY THAT THIS BILL
MOVED WITH OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGH BOTH
PRIVACY AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEES. IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
. AND THANK THESE MEMBERS THEN
AND TO ALL OF YOU TODAY FOR YOUR
VERY THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO THIS
LEGISLATION. INDEED, WE HAVE
REACHED A WATERSHED MOMENT IN
TIME, MY COLLEAGUES. THIS IS OUR
MOMENT TO STAND UP FOR
CHILDREN'S TEENS AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITH ME TODAY IS
NICOLE ROCHA OF COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
MISS ROCHA. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD. I USED TO SAY GOOD
MORNING. AND THEN IT WAS
AFTERNOON, AND NOW IT'S EVENING.
GOOD EVENING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
NICOLE ROCHA. HERE ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE MEDIA. EVERY PERSON
IN CALIFORNIA HAS AN OBLIGATION
TO AVOID REASONABLY FORESEEABLE
HARM TO OTHERS. THIS IS THE
COMMON LAW TORT OF NEGLIGENCE,
AND IT'S CODIFIED IN THE CIVIL
CODE. SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES ARE
ALREADY SUBJECT TO THIS STATUTE,
AND THEY ARE LITIGATING THESE
CASES UNDER THE SECTION IN BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL COURTS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE ACTUAL
DAMAGES THAT PLAINTIFFS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PROVE IN THESE
CASES HAVE NOT BEEN HIGH ENOUGH
TO DEFER HARMFUL BEHAVIOR BY
SOME OF THE MOST PROFITABLE
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD. AB 3172
IS SIMPLE. IT BUILDS UPON
EXISTING LAW AND CREATES
STATUTORY DAMAGES FOR SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES WHO HAVE
BREACHED THE ORDINARY STANDARD
OF CARE OR HARM CHILDREN BY
THEIR NEGLIGENCE. THE OPPOSITION
TODAY WILL ARGUE THAT ORDINARY
CARE IN THIS CONTEXT IS ILL
DEFINED, MAKING IT INAPPROPRIATE
TO SUBJECT THEM TO INCREASED
PENALTIES. THEY WILL ARGUE THAT
THIS BILL IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CONTENT MODERATION, AND THAT THE
BILL IS PREEMPTED BY SECTION
230. THESE ARGUMENTS ARE NOTHING
MORE THAN A RED HERRING BY AN
INDUSTRY SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR LIABILITY REMAINS
DISPROPORTIONATELY SMALL
COMPARED TO THEIR PROFITS. THE
STANDARD OF ORDINARY CARE FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES EXISTS
UNDER CURRENT LAW. THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE IT. SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES FAIL TO MEET THIS
STANDARD WHEN THEY HAVE REASON
TO KNOW THAT THEIR PRODUCTS ARE
HARMFUL, BUT DON'T MITIGATE
THOSE HARMS. WHISTLEBLOWERS
FRANCES HAUGEN AND ARTURO BÉJAR
HAVE SHOWN THAT THESE COMPANIES
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THEIR
PRODUCTS HARM KIDS, INCLUDING
INCREASED RISK OF DEPRESSION,
ANXIETY AND SUICIDE, AND CHANGES
TO SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ROLLED
OUT OVERSEAS IN RESPONSE TO
DEMANDS THAT THEY MITIGATE HARM.
SHOW THAT THESE COMPANIES KNOW
EXACTLY HOW TO PROTECT KIDS, BUT
WON'T DO IT UNLESS FORCED TO DO
SO. THE OPPOSITION WILL ARGUE
THAT THIS BILL IS CONTENT
MODERATION, AND IT WILL
ULTIMATELY SUBJECT KIDS TO
SURVEILLANCE AND SHRINK THE
UNIVERSE OF INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO THEM. BUT THIS BILL
DOES NOT REGULATE CONTENT
NOTIFICATIONS. ENDLESS SCROLL
FRIENDS, SUGGESTIONS, LIKES.
THESE ARE ALL BUSINESS
DECISIONS, NOT CONTENT. THEY ARE
FEATURES DESIGNED BY PLATFORMS
LOOKING TO MAXIMIZE CONSUMER
ATTENTION. AND WE KNOW THAT IT
IS OFTEN THE ADDICTION TO SOCIAL
MEDIA THAT IS HARMFUL AND NOT
THE CONTENT ITSELF. WHICH BRINGS
ME TO SECTION 230, SECTION 230
PROVIDES SPECIFIED IMMUNITY FOR
PUBLISHERS OF THIRD PARTY
CONTENT. IT DOES NOT PROVIDE
IMMUNITY FOR ALL BUSINESS
DECISIONS. IN RECENT CASES
BROUGHT UNDER THE EXISTING
STATUTE. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
SUPPLEMENT PLATFORMS, HAVE
RAISED THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
SECTION 230 AS DEFENSES I WILL
WRAP UP VERY SHORTLY. THANK YOU.
SHOULD THIS BILL BECOME LAW,
THAT PROCESS WOULD NOT CHANGE.
CLAIMS BASED ON THE PUBLISHING
OF THIRD PARTY CONTENT WOULD
LIKELY BE BARRED BY FIRST
AMENDMENT OR SECTION 230. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. CLAIMS BASED ON
NEGLIGENCE WOULD BE PERMITTED TO
GO FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. MR.
CHAIR, ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MIKEY HOFI,
ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE MEDIA
AND THE CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, OTHERS, IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE ELSE APPROACHED MIGRANT,
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO, AB
3172, PLEASE HAVE A SEAT. EXCUSE
ME. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, JASON SCHMELTZER HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF TECHNET, I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO START IN THE
SAME PLACE THAT THE AUTHOR DID,
WITH A THANK YOU, WE'VE
REQUESTED SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL, AND
HIM AND HIS STAFF HAD HAVE
GRANTED EVERY ONE. THEY'VE HAD
AN OPEN DOOR POLICY. AND WE JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE
THEIR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
POSITIONS. AND I KNOW VARIOUS
RED LINES ON THIS BILL AND OTHER
BILL FROM VARIOUS OPPONENTS. SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT, WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE. WE DO
THINK THAT THAT IS AN
IMPROVEMENT TO THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT DOESN'T REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION, AND WE DO HAVE
SOME REMAINING POINTS OF
CONTENTION. FIRST, WE JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY TECHNET AND OUR
MEMBERS AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR'S
GOAL OF PROTECTING CHILDREN
ONLINE. OUR MEMBERS HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THESE EFFORTS, CREATING NEW
POLICIES, TOOLS. FEATURES FOR
USERS AND THEIR PARENTS TO
EXERCISE GREATER CONTROL OVER
THEIR ONLINE ENVIRONMENT. AND I
THINK THOSE THOSE EFFORTS
EXISTED, FRANKLY, BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE WAS INTERESTED IN
THIS SUBJECT. WE ARE, HOWEVER,
OPPOSED TO THE BILL FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS. THE STATED
GOAL IN THE BILL IS TO
INCENTIVIZE PLATFORMS TO CHANGE
HOW THEY OPERATE. WE ASSUME THAT
THE REFERENCING OPERATIONS
RELATED TO USER CONTENT AND
FEATURES PLATFORMS USED TO
ORGANIZE CONTENT THAT'S BASED
OFF OF PAST HEARINGS. AND
FRANKLY, WHAT'S IN THE ANALYSIS,
ALTHOUGH I THINK WE STIPULATE TO
SOME OF THE DISTINCTIONS MADE BY
BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
ON THAT FRONT. BUT THE BILL
DOESN'T TARGET ANYTHING
PRECISELY. IT SIMPLY
ACKNOWLEDGES A PLATFORM'S
GENERAL DUTY OF CARE AND THEN
SETS HIGH STATUTORY PENALTIES
FOR FAILURE TO MEET THAT DUTY.
WE READ THOSE PENALTIES IN THE
BILL TO APPLY TO ALL CLAIMS
AGAINST A SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM
BY A MINOR, INCLUDING, FOR
INSTANCE, A CLAIM BY A CHILD
THAT TRIPS AND FALLS DURING A
TOUR OF COMPANY HEADQUARTERS OR
A CHILD INJURED IN A CAR
ACCIDENT WITH A PLATFORM
EMPLOYEE. WE DON'T THINK THAT
THIS IS THE AUTHOR'S INTENT,
ALTHOUGH WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE COMPLICATIONS OF DRAFTING A
BILL TO BE SPECIFIC TO CONTENT
AND CONTENT, DELIVERING
FEATURES. IF THE INTENT IS TO
APPLY THESE PENALTIES TO CLAIMS
FOCUSED ON CONTENT AND CONTENT
DELIVERING FEATURES, THE SPONSOR
WAS RIGHT. WE DO THINK THAT
THOSE CLAIMS ARE BARRED BY
SECTION 230 AND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL CREATES A STRONG INCENTIVE
FOR PLAINTIFFS TO SUE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS ON THE BASIS OF
USER GENERATED CONTENT. ALL
RIGHT. AND I WILL I WILL
ABSOLUTELY WRAP IT UP, HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS AND OTHERS
OPPOSED TO AB 3172, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. ROANOKE
WITH CAL CHAMBER RESPECTFULLY
ALSO OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. JAMIE. JACK RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. NAOMI PEDRO,
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. CAMERON
DIMITRI, WITH NETCHOICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, ROBERT SINGLETON, CHAMBER
OF PROGRESS. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. BRANDON.
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE SEEING. YES, SENATOR
CABALLERO, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I THINK THAT, THAT WHAT
YOU'VE DONE WITH THE BILL IN
TERMS OF REALLY FOCUSING ON ITS
PRODUCTS LIABILITY AS AS A BASE
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. IT'S,
SOMETIMES HARD BECAUSE YOU GET
INTO CONTENT AND, AND THEN
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF ISSUES
RELATED TO THAT, I DON'T THINK
YOU INTENDED TO INCLUDE KIDS
SLIPPING ON A TOUR, AND SO MY
GUESS IS THAT'S EASILY
REMEDIABLE, BUT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY, AND
I'LL MOVE IT. MOVE THE BILL WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT. I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE. SENATOR
CABALLERO HAS MOVED THE BILL.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE. ALL RIGHT, SO,
MEMBER LOWENTHAL, PLEASE CLOSE.
YOU KNOW, I, I WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE THINGS. FIRST OF ALL,
WHILE I HAVE DEEP ADMIRATION FOR
TECHNET, THE SLIP AND FALL
ANALOGY WOULD BE A REALLY TOUGH
ONE. IF PUBLIC PROSECUTORS ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
BRINGING THIS FORWARD, I THINK
THEY'D HAVE A VERY SHORT CAREER
AS PUBLIC PROSECUTOR IF THAT'S
THE THAT'S THOSE ARE THE CASES
THAT THEY'RE BRINGING FORWARD. I
IT IS IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF
US IN THIS STATE THAT TECH IS
SUCCESSFUL. SO MANY OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE BASED IN OUR STATE
AND ARE WOVEN INTO THE FABRIC OF
OUR ECONOMY. AND WE'RE PROUD
THAT WE HAVE THE INNOVATORS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THAT
THESE COMPANIES HAVE BEEN BORN
IN OUR STATE, AND THE BEST
THINKERS AND INNOVATORS ARE
LOCATED HERE. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES AND WHAT SO MANY
LEGISLATORS ARE WORKING ON, AND
WE'LL BE WORKING ON FOR THE NEXT
FEW YEARS, IS GETTING THESE
COMPANIES TO FOCUS ON SAFETY SO
THAT THEY CAN ACHIEVE EVEN MORE
AND BE MORE SUCCESSFUL, BE MORE
PROFITABLE. I WOULD BE HAPPY FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN, AS I'M NOT JUST
HERE AS A LEGISLATOR, I'M HERE
AS A DAD. I'VE GOT THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN AND I HAVE A LABORATORY
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT IN
FRONT OF ME. AND ALSO WITH
RESPECT TO THE OPPOSITION AS IT
RELATES TO, YOU KNOW, THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING ON
TRYING TO MAKE THINGS SAFE. I
CAN TELL YOU, JUST FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AND FROM EVERY SINGLE
PARENT THAT I SPEAK WITH, IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE AND THAT IS WHY WE
HAVE THE ALARMING RATES OF
MENTAL HEALTH IN OUR CHILDREN
TODAY. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
32 AB 3172. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED. UMBERG Ã
UMBERG. AYE. WILK AYE. WILK.
AYE. ALLEN. ASHBY CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO Dð.
RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE
MILO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE STERN.
STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 8
TO 0. 8 TO 0. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL. AND, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM. EXCUSE ME, MR.
VICE CHAIR, FOR TAKING CONTROL,
WE'LL BE BACK. WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
WE'LL BE BACK SHORTLY.
ALRIGHT. I'M YOU'RE GOING TO LET
MR. VALENCIA GO FIRST? SENATOR
SAID OKAY. WELL, I'M THE CHAIR.
HE'S NOT THE CHAIR. BUT
ASSEMBLYWOMAN IRWIN IS
GRACIOUSLY ALLOWED YOU TO JUMP
HER SO WE CAN DO THAT. SO WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM 48 AB
3025. AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. WITH THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SIR. WHEN I STARTED AS
MEMBERS. EXCUSE ME, SENATORS, I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS BILL AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AB 3225 ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE THEIR
NEGOTIATED RETIREMENT BENEFITS,
EVEN IF CERTAIN COMPENSATION IS
DISALLOWED. DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION UNDERMINES THE
PROMISE OF A SECURE RETIREMENT
AND JEOPARDIZES THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR COUNTY RETIREMENT SYSTEMS.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS
DOUG SUBURBS, THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS, AND THEN ALSO
JENNIFER ROE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE,
ORANGE COUNTY, I HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS. DOUG SUBERS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS, CPF
IS PLEASED TO CO-SPONSOR AB
3025. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
WITH REGARD TO THE ANALYSIS
DISCUSSION ON THE LIMITATION OF
ACCESS TO INFORMATION UNDER THE
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT. WE DO THINK
THAT LIMITATION IS APPROPRIATE
TO PROTECT THE INFORMATION OF A
RETIREE, SURVIVOR OR
BENEFICIARY. AS NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR, THIS MEASURE WILL CREATE
A CLEAR PROCESS TO ADDRESS
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION
IDENTIFIED ON OR AFTER JANUARY
1ST, 2024. THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
MEASURE IS SIMILAR TO PRIOR
POLICIES ENACTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION AT
CALPERS AND CALSTRS. DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION IS WHEN A PAY ITEM
INCLUDED IN AN EMPLOYEE'S
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION IS
DETERMINED TO BE NON PENSIONABLE
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THAT
EMPLOYEE. FOR A RETIREE, WHEN
DISALLOWED COMPENSATION IS
IDENTIFIED, THEY ARE NOTIFIED OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCE UNTIL THEY'VE
BEEN OVERPAID AND HAVE TO DO A
REDUCTION IN THEIR RETIREMENT
ALLOWANCE. FOR A FIREFIGHTER,
THAT CAN BE DEVASTATING. FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE'D RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE BEFORE YOU
START. IF WE COULD HOLD, IF WE
COULD HOLD IT DOWN HERE. SO WE
ALL COULD HEAR AND PAY DEFERENCE
TO THOSE TESTIFYING, THAT'D BE
GOOD. SORRY ABOUT THAT. YES.
IT'S OKAY. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS JENNIFER
ROE, WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FRATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE, ONE
OF THE CO-SPONSORS, IN SUPPORT
OF AB 3025, WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WRITES A SIGNIFICANT WRONG
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR RETIREES
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THE AUTHOR, AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
OTHERS IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT?
THEY'D LIKE TO COME UP AND DO ME
TWO TESTIMONY, MR. CHAIR MEMBER
SHANE LEVINE ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY, SACRAMENTO
COUNTY, SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, AND
THE LONG BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SIR.
SEEING NO OTHERS, ANYBODY HERE
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO OTHERS.
PULLED BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS SOMEBODY?
YEAH. WELL, PLEASE, PLEASE,
PLEASE. CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND I
APOLOGIZE. CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MOVE THE
BILL. OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH. ANY QUESTIONS?
SEEING NONE, LET'S CALL THE ROLL
ANY. YOU DID SAID YOU'RE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS. CORRECT. I DID,
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES.
GREAT I SUPPOSE YOU COULD CLOSE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A YES VOTE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 48, AB
3025. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. UMBERG WILK. HI WILK. I
ALLEN ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO
I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I. LAIRD
NHIÀU. ROTH ROTH I STERN. STERN
I WAHAB. WAHHAB I 6 TO 0. WE
HAVE SIX VOTES AND WE'LL WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
SAINT ERWIN, WHO WAS SO KIND TO
LET MR. VALENCIA GO. AND DO YOU
WANT DO YOU WANT TO TAKE HIM AND
FILE AN ORDER OR DO YOU. YES.
WELL, 2013, FIRST IS THAT FILE.
THAT IS FILE ORDER. OKAY. SO
FIRST UP, FILE ITEM 24 AB 2013
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION DO PASS,
DO PASS. SO WITH THAT THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD EVENING MEMBERS,
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2013
WHICH REQUIRES DEVELOPERS OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SYSTEMS
AND SERVICES TO DISCLOSE HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR TRAINING DATA. AI HAS
BECOME NEARLY UNAVOIDABLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S DAILY LIVES.
HOWEVER, CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IN
AI HAS NOT GROWN AT THE SAME
RAPID PACE AS INDUSTRY ADOPTION.
MANY CONSUMERS HAVE VALID
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THESE AI
SYSTEMS AND SERVICES ARE CREATED
, AND IF THEY TRULY ARE BETTER
THAN WHAT THEY SEEK TO REPLACE.
TO BUILD CONSUMER CONFIDENCE, WE
NEED TO START WITH THE
FOUNDATION OF AI MODELS, AND
THAT IS THE SELECTION OF
TRAINING DATA. MY HOPE IS THAT
WITH THIS INFORMATION AND LIKELY
SOME ASSISTANCE FROM CIVIL
SOCIETY GROUPS, WE CAN BRIDGE
THE GAP IN UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN
CONSUMERS AND DEVELOPERS. WE
REMAIN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THE MOST RECENT SET
OF AMENDMENTS WE TOOK WERE THE
RESULT OF ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
A NUMBER OF THEIR CONCERNS. MY
STAFF AND I CONTINUE TO BUILD
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL AMONGST OPPOSITION, AS
WE BELIEVE THE BILL IN PRINT HAS
ALREADY ADDRESSED MANY OF THEIR
STATED CONCERNS. SPECIFICALLY,
THE BILL DOES NOT IMPLICATE AI
SYSTEMS OR SERVICES DEVELOPED
FOR INTERNAL USE OR SYSTEMS OR
SERVICES DEVELOPED FOR PRIVATE
PARTY AND NOT OFFERED TO THE
PUBLIC. I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
CHANGES MADE IN ASSEMBLY,
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
TO HAVE A DISCLOSURE BE A HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY PROVIDES AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY, AMPLE FLEXIBILITY
TO ADDRESS ANY TRADE SECRET OR
CONFIDENTIALITY CONCERNS. NOW, I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
PRIMARY WITNESS, JAY JASMIA OF
THE TRANSPARENCY COALITION. I
THANK YOU, SIR. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. MY NAME IS JAY JAY
AND I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL 2013 AS THE
CO-FOUNDER OF TRANSPARENCY
COALITION. WE'RE A SEATTLE BASED
NONPROFIT WHICH ADVOCATES FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY IN
GENERATIVE AI. I HAVE A PHD,
WHICH I COMPLETED IN 1996.
PLEASE DON'T HOLD THAT AGAINST
ME. I'M CURRENTLY ALSO AN
AFFILIATE PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF ELECTRICAL AND
COMPUTER ENGINEERING FOR 30
YEARS, I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING AI AND DIGITAL MEDIA
APPLICATIONS AT A VARIETY OF
SMALL AND LARGE ORGANIZATIONS.
IN MY CAPACITY AS A SCIENTIST,
TECHNICAL LEADER, CTO, AND CEO,
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
STANDARDS IN THEIR LANGUAGE OF
TRUSTWORTHY AI GLOSSARY HAS
DEFINED TRANSPARENCY AS A
PROPERTY OF A SYSTEM TO IMPLY
OPENNESS AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
CURRENTLY, WE ARE SEEING NEITHER
OPENNESS NOR ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
THE LARGEST DEVELOPERS OF
GENERATIVE AI MODELS, AND THEY
ARE SETTING THE PRECEDENT FOR
EVERYONE ELSE, ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO POTENTIAL PRIVACY,
COPYRIGHT, AND CONSUMER HARM. WE
AT TCI ARE FIRMLY SUPPORTIVE OF
AB 2013, CHAMPIONED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. WE THINK IT WILL
HELP BRING MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS TO
GENERATIVE AI INPUTS. IT WILL
PROVIDE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH CRITICAL INSIGHT INTO THE
SOURCE OR OWNER OF A DATA SET.
THE TIME PERIOD IN WHICH THE
DATA SET WAS ACQUIRED, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE PROVENANCE AND
LICENSES UNDER WHICH THE DATA
WAS OBTAINED, INCLUDING FOR
COPYRIGHTED, PERSONAL OR
AGGREGATED CONSUMER DATA. YOU
WILL HEAR THAT WE CAN'T DO THIS
BECAUSE TRAINING DATA IS A TRADE
SECRET. THIS IN OUR OPINION, IS
A FALSE NARRATIVE. WE AS
CITIZENS KNOW MORE ABOUT WHAT
GOES INTO THIS PACK OF GUM THAN
WE DO ABOUT OUR AI MODELS.
GENERATIVE AI MODELS ARE LARGELY
BUILT USING THE SAME DATA, AND
THERE ARE DIFFERENT BECAUSE OF
ALL THE INGENUITY EMPLOYED IN
TRAINING THEM, THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF THESE
PROPRIETARY METHODS. AND ASK
YOURSELF IF TRAINING DATA IS
SUCH A SECRET, WHY DOES THE
INDUSTRY INSIST ON LOUDLY
ANNOUNCING EVERY SINGLE
LICENSING DEAL? THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER IN SAFEGUARDING ITS
CITIZENRY, WHILE STILL
EMPOWERING THE TECH INDUSTRY TO
GROW AND THRIVE. I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PASS AB 2013 AND
SEND IT TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU SARAH. DO
WE HAVE ANY MEAT TO TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM? COME UP. NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE ONE.
AND YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ELMER LAZARD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. AND THAT
WAS ON TIME DELIVERY THIS TIME.
GOOD JOB. IS THAT IT? NOW DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPONENTS IN THE ROOM?
YOU MAY COME UP AND SIT HERE OR
YOU MAY DO IT FROM THE
MICROPHONE THERE, WHEREVER
YOU'RE MOST COMFORTABLE. THANK
YOU. MR. VICE CHAIR MEMBERS RON
DELORME WITH CAL CHAMBER
RESPECTFULLY IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF FOR GIVING US SO MUCH
TIME AND BEING WILLING TO ENGAGE
WITH US ON THE AMENDMENTS WE
HAVE REQUESTED. I WILL SAY WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN,
ESPECIALLY MOST RECENTLY. SO FOR
PURPOSES OF TODAY, I'M GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT JUST A COUPLE ISSUES
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO TALK
TO THE AUTHOR ABOUT. TO TAKE A
QUICK STEP BACK, THOUGH, FIRST,
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES PLACE GREAT
VALUE ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRANSPARENCY. IT'S HOW WE
MAINTAIN THE TRUST OF OUR
COMPANIES AND CLIENT CUSTOMERS
AND CLIENTELE. ENSURE THE
SUCCESS AND UPTAKE OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AT A HIGH LEVEL.
ONE OF OUR MAJOR CONCERNS HAS TO
DO WITH THE WORKABILITY FROM A
COMPLIANCE PERSPECTIVE. TO THAT
END, WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
BILL APPLIES TO ALL AI SYSTEMS
AND MODELS, NOT JUST HIGH RISK,
MEANING THAT EVEN A TECHNOLOGY
AS LOW RISK AS AUTOCORRECT COULD
BE SCOPED IN WHICH WE DON'T
THINK IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR. BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT HER INTENT IS TO CAPTURE
MORE THAN JUST HIGH RISK. SO OUR
HOPE IS TO BE ABLE TO FIND A
MIDDLE GROUND WITH HER, AND WE
ARE WORKING ON THAT. COMPOUNDING
THE PROBLEM IS ALSO THE ISSUE OF
RETROACTIVITY BETWEEN THOSE TWO
ELEMENTS. THE BILL WOULD BE
WHOLLY UNMANAGEABLE. OUR HOPE IS
TO ALSO THEN LAND ON A LIMITED
LOOKBACK PERIOD. AND FINALLY, WE
ARE ACTIVELY DISCUSSING WITH
MEMBERS A COUPLE OF OTHER
CHANGES IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
DISCLOSURES, IN THE LINES OF
SOME OF THE CHANGES THAT SHE HAS
MADE MORE RECENTLY, ADDING SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO THE REQUIREMENTS.
WE DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF THE
CHANGES WE'RE ASKING FOR WILL
UNDERMINE THE UTILITY OF THE
BILL. IT WILL JUST STRIKE A
BETTER BALANCE, AND FOR THAT, WE
ARE AGAIN GRATEFUL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THANK THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. HELLO.
GOOD EVENING, TODD O'BOYLE FROM
THE CHAMBER OF PROGRESS, SENIOR
DIRECTOR THERE OF TECHNOLOGY
POLICY. WE'RE A TRADE, TRADE. A
TECHNOLOGY TRADE ASSOCIATION
COMMITTED TO BUILDING A MORE
INCLUSIVE FUTURE, WHERE ALL OF
US BENEFIT FROM TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCE WHILE OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDE COMPANIES LIKE GOOGLE
AND MIDJOURNEY, OUR PARTNERS DO
NOT HAVE A VOTE OR A VETO ON OUR
POSITIONS, WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ADOPTED, LIKE TECHNOLOGIES,
WE DO RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB 2013. IN ADDITION TO
MY COLLEAGUES, POINTS THAT SHE
JUST MADE, I'LL ADD A COUPLE
VERY QUICKLY, WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT REQUIRING DEVELOPERS TO
DISCLOSE DATA USED TO TRAIN
THEIR ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
SYSTEMS AND SERVICES ON THEIR
WEBSITE WOULD STIFLE COMPETITION
IN THE DIGITAL MARKETPLACE. A
HEALTHY, COMPETITIVE DIGITAL
MARKETPLACE IS ESSENTIAL TO
PROMOTE QUALITY SERVICES TO
CONSUMERS AND DRIVE INNOVATION.
THIS DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT
RISKS REVEALING IMPORTANT
BUSINESS INFORMATION AND
STRATEGIES, EVEN WHEN DEVELOPERS
SPECIFICALLY NOTE THAT THE DATA
SETS ARE PROTECTED INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. ADDITIONALLY, THE
LANGUAGE, BUT NOT LIMITED TO IN
SUCH REQUIREMENTS, MAKES THE
EXPECTATIONS PLACED ON
DEVELOPERS VERY UNCLEAR, ONE
MORE INNOVATION THRIVES IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE
EXPERIMENTATION IS ENCOURAGED.
WE SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY, BUT THE
MANDATES CONTEMPLATED IN THIS
BILL WOULD FORCE DISCLOSURE OF
ESSENTIAL BUSINESS INTELLIGENCE
AND TRADE SECRETS TO COMPETITORS
AND CUSTOMERS, STIFLE INNOVATION
THE ENTIRE AI ECOSYSTEM TO
ILLUSTRATE OUR CONCERNS, THIS
BILL WOULD AMOUNT TO REQUIRING A
CHEF TO POST HER RECIPES ONLINE
EACH TIME SHE DEVELOPS A NEW
DISH, AND HOW THE DISH VARIES
FROM ITERATION TO ITERATION. SO
DISCOURAGED RESTAURATEURS FROM
OPENING UP SHOP IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES A ROAD MAP
TO COMPETITORS OR MAY ENCOURAGE
THEM TO MOVE ELSEWHERE. INSTEAD,
CONSIDER THE VALUABLE CONSUMER
ENHANCING, TRANSPARENT CONSUMER
INFORMING TRANSPARENCY THAT WE
GET FROM NUTRITION LABELS,
INGREDIENTS AND PERCENTAGES AND
SO ON. NOT A STEP BY STEP
RECIPE. WE'D ENCOURAGE YOU A
SIMILAR APPROACH HERE ROUNDED
PERCENTAGES OF THINGS LIKE THE
LANGUAGE OF THE SOURCE MATERIAL
USED COULD PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
AND HELPFUL TRANSPARENCY INSTEAD
OF IT. THE POINT BY POINT
DISCLOSURES CONTEMPLATED IN
SECTIONS A ONE THROUGH 12. THE
SPECIAL SAUCES WERE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
2013. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION THAT WANTS TO ADD ME
TO TESTIMONY, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. NAOMI PADRONA, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CHAMBER AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JOSE TORRES CASILLAS WITH,
TECHNET ALSO ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH CHAMBER AND IN,
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
EVENING. CAMERON DIMITRI, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION,
ECHOING THE COMMENTS OF THE
CHAMBER. THANKS. OKAY. THANK
YOU. PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. NO. NO
QUESTIONS. OKAY. I'LL JUST DO
SOME CLOSING COMMENTS. I THINK
WE AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY AND THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE SOMEBODY WITH
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND BACKGROUND
HERE AT THIS TIME, BECAUSE THESE
ARE BIG ISSUES. AND YOU'RE
WILLING TO STEP UP AND DO IT.
AND I THINK YOU'VE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB. SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. TODAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
STERN. SO WITH THAT, YOU MAY
CLOSE. JUST, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT
. THIS IS CALL THE ROLL FILE,
ITEM NUMBER 24, AB 2013. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS UMBERG WILK I
WILK I ALLEN ASHBY CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I RUSSELL RUSSELL. I
LAIRD. MILO ROTH. ROTH I STERN.
STERN I WAHAB. WAHHAB I 6 TO 0
SIX ZERO. WE WILL, LEAVE THAT
VOTE OPEN FOR OUR FELLOW
MEMBERS. NOW WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 25 AB 2420,
AND THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
IS. FOR 26, 26, 24, 26. I AM
SORRY, Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
. I SEE YOU CHANGED OUT
WITNESSES AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY, PLEASE PROCEED. ALL
RIGHT. I'M PLEASED, PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 2426. ONE OF THE
CONSUMER GOES ONLINE TO PURCHASE
A MOVIE AND BOOK OR A VIDEO GAME
. THEY FREQUENTLY ARE PRESENTED
WITH THE OPTION TO BUY THAT
DIGITAL GOOD IN COMPLETING THE
TRANSACTION, CONSUMERS ARE LED
TO BELIEVE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
OWN A COPY OF THE PURCHASED
DIGITAL GOOD, SIMILAR TO WHEN
THEY PURCHASE A DVD OR PAPERBACK
BOOK. IN REALITY, THOUGH, THE
CONSUMER HAS ONLY RECEIVED A
DIGITAL LICENSE THAT THE SELLER
CAN REVOKE AT ANY POINT IN TIME,
THE CONSUMER IS ONLY TOLD OF
THIS DEEP WITHIN THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF THEIR PURCHASE. AT
FACE VALUE, THIS IS BLATANTLY
DECEPTIVE. THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION IS FAR WORSE. THE
NATURE OF THESE TRANSACTIONS
MAKES THE CONSUMER, MAKES EACH
CONSUMER'S LICENSE TO VIEW THEIR
PRODUCT DEPENDENT ON THE SELLER
ENTIRELY. THAT MEANS FOR
EXAMPLE, IF THE SELLER OF A
MOVIE LOSES THEIR RIGHT TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THAT MOVIE, SO DO ALL THE
CONSUMERS WHO PURCHASE THAT
MOVIE ONLINE. AT TIMES,
CONSUMERS HAVE LOST ACCESS TO
THEIR PURCHASES ENTIRELY WITHOUT
REFUNDS. ALL BEING TOLD THAT
THEY BOUGHT THE DIGITAL GOOD IN
THE FIRST PLACE. AB 2426
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE OF
MISINFORMATION BY REQUIRING THE
SELLERS OF DIGITAL GOODS TO
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
THESE TRANSACTIONS. THE BILL
OFFERS SELLERS A VARIETY OF WAYS
TO COMPLY IF THEY STILL WISH TO
LABEL THEIR TRANSACTIONS A
PURCHASE, THEY CAN RECEIVE AN
AFFIRMATIVE ACKNOWLEDGMENT FROM
THE CONSUMER, INDICATING THEY
ARE ONLY RECEIVING A LICENSE TO
THE DIGITAL GOOD, OR THEY CAN
OFFER A DISCLOSURE TO THE
CONSUMER, TELLING THEM PRIOR TO
THE PURCHASE THEY ARE ONLY
RECEIVING A LICENSE TO VIEW THE
DIGITAL GOOD AND PROVIDING A
LINK TO THE TERMS. OR. THIRD,
THEY CAN CHOOSE TO ALLOW THE
DIGITAL GOOD TO BE DOWNLOADED AT
THE TIME OF PURCHASE, OR THE
SELLERS CAN OPT OUT BY TELLING
CONSUMERS THEY ARE BUYING THE
DIGITAL GOOD ENTIRELY, SO WE
HAVE AS YOU CAN SEE, WE HAVE
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY BASED ON
THE INITIAL OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THERE ARE MANY WAYS TO,
ACTUALLY COMPLY WITH THE BILL.
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY OF THESE
PURCHASES WILL HELP CONSUMERS
TRULY UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF
THEIR DIGITAL PURCHASES
PURCHASES. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE ENGAGED IN A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITIONS. AND AGAIN, THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE BILL ARE IN
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE RAISED. I AM
CONTINUING, I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS WELL. THANK YOU. AND I HAVE
NO WITNESS. THIS IS MY STAFF WHO
DID ALL THE HARD WORK ON THE
BILL. WELL, CONGRATULATIONS FOR
HAVING A JOB AS A GREAT MEMBER.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT LIKE TO
COME UP AND ADD ME TO TESTIMONY
AND SUPPORT, SEEING NONE,
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS
TO Ó OUR FRIEND TIM LYNCH, COME
ON UP. DO YOU WANT TO DO
PRIMARY? SURE RECOGNIZING THE
TIME. TIM LYNCH, ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTERTAINMENT SOFTWARE
ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS THE VIDEO
GAME INDUSTRY AND DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMENTS, SHE AND HER STAFF HAVE
BEEN EXCEEDINGLY GENEROUS WITH
THEIR TIME AND HAVE MOVED THE
BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THERE ARE A FEW REMAINING ISSUES
WE'RE TRYING TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE ON AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
ONE IS RELATED TO CLARIFYING THE
ROLE OF AN ADVERTISING OR
MARKETING CAMPAIGN. WE ADVERTISE
THE GAME, NOT THE MEDIUM IN
WHICH IT'S PROVIDED. SO WE WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT'S STILL
ACCEPTABLE AND RELATED IS THE
TRANSACTION AND WHERE THAT
OCCURS. MANY GAMES OR SOME GAMES
ARE SOLD THROUGH THIRD PARTY
PLATFORMS. WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THE CONSUMER IS GETTING THE
DISCLOSURE AT THE POINT OF
TRANSACTION OR THE RIGHT PLACE,
AND WE'RE NOT HELD TO ACCOUNT
FOR A DIGITAL MARKETPLACE WHERE
WE HAVE NO CONTROL. AND THEN
FINALLY, VIDEO GAMES ARE A
LITTLE UNIQUE BECAUSE THERE ARE
TRANSACTIONS IN SOME GAMES THAT
OCCUR IN GAME. SO THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH EMBEDDING
THAT, AND THEN ALSO SOME
CONSUMER EXPERIENTIAL ISSUES. IF
YOU'RE HAVING TO HALT GAMEPLAY
TO AFFIRMATIVELY CLICK OR READ
OR LINK TO A DISCLOSURE. SO
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THANK
THEM FOR THEIR WORK. THANK YOU
SIR. ANY ADDITIONAL ME TO
OPPOSITION OR YOU WANT TO DO
MORE THAN THAT? YOU CAN IF YOU
LIKE. IT'S KIND OF YOU. MR. YOU
ARE LONDON CALLING. LONDON
CALLING. YEAH KARL LONDON HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA,
WE SIMILARLY HAVE HAD A GOOD
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH THIS
AUTHOR AND STAFF ON THIS. WE DO
HAVE A MAIN CONCERN THAT MR.
LYNCH OUTLINED. I'LL JUST
REITERATE IT. MUSIC IS SOLD ON A
MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS, AND OFTENTIMES WHILE
WE HAVE AGREEMENTS WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SELLING MUSIC FOR
UNDER A COPYRIGHT AGREEMENT OR A
RIGHTS AGREEMENT, WE HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER WHAT THEY DO ON
THEIR PARTICULAR WEBSITE AND HOW
THEY SELL IT. WE DON'T WANT TO
BE HELD LIABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO
DON'T COMPLY WITH THIS NEW LAW.
IF IT GOES THROUGH, WHEN WE'RE
NOT AT ALL RESPONSIBLE OR EVEN
INVOLVED IN THAT TRANSACTION,
OTHER THAN WE'VE PROVIDED THAT
THROUGH A RIGHTS AGREEMENT,
WE'VE ASKED THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER THAT AS AN AMENDMENT.
WE'VE OFFERED AN AMENDMENT.
WE'RE HOPEFUL WE CAN GET THAT
DONE. BUT RIGHT NOW I HAVE TO
STAY CONCERNED OR OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OKAY. AT THIS POINT,
ME TO TESTIMONY. OKAY. CAMERON
DIMITRI, ON BEHALF OF SO RARE
AND DAPPER LABS, WE'RE IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. THANKS
FOR WORKING WITH US. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WAHAB. NO
COMMENTS. NO QUESTIONS. OKAY.
WITH THAT, LET'S GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL. DID SHE CLOSE? OH
YEAH. YOU SHOULD CLOSE, I GUESS.
ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW WHAT? BECAUSE
SOME OF THE STUFF THAT THEY SAID
THAT THEY HAVE CONCERNS WITH
SEEMS LIKE SOME A LOT OF THAT I
THINK IS FIXABLE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE SUMMER BREAK.
SO ARE YOU GOING TO TAHITI. ARE
YOU GOING TO ARE YOU GOING TO
STAY HERE AND GET THIS ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE? THE BEST BILL
POSSIBLE? WE ARE, WE ARE VERY
CLOSE ON THESE ISSUES. SO FOR
INSTANCE, WITH THE THIRD PARTY,
THERE IS ALREADY WITH THE THIRD
PARTY SELLER, THERE'S ALREADY A
CONTRACT BETWEEN THE BUSINESSES
THAT WE THINK THIS CAN BE. THE
DISCLOSURE CAN BE PART OF THE
CONTRACT. AND THEN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON INSIDE A
VIDEO GAME, AND I DIDN'T REALIZE
I WAS GOING TO GET THIS DEEP
INTO IT, THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WOULD REQUIRE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT, BUT OTHER THINGS
LIKE YOU'RE PURCHASING
ADDITIONAL COINS AND THEY RUN
OUT THAT WOULDN'T REQUIRE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT. SO WE ARE
DEFINITELY WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION TO GET THIS RIGHT. I
GOT TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I'M
GLAD THAT THAT THAT TECHNOLOGY
DID NOT EXIST WHILE I WAS
FUNDING MY KIDS, BECAUSE I HEAR
THEY MAKE A LOT OF MONEY DOING
ALL THAT STUFF MID GAME. YOU MAY
STILL YOU CAN CLOSE IN ADDITION
TO THAT IF YOU LIKE. IF YOU'RE
WE ARE WE ARE. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THESE LAST FINAL
ISSUES, LIKE I SAID, TO GET IT
RIGHT. GREAT. GOOD GOOD STAFF,
GOOD WITNESS. ALL RIGHT. WITH
THAT, LET'S CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM 25 AB 2426. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG WILK Ã
WILK. AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE
DURAZZO. LAIRD NILO. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0 5 TO 0. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON. AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO YOUR FINAL BILL OF THE
EVENING, AB 24, WHICH IS AB
2492. AND THE RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR IS TO PASS AS
APPROPRIATION. AND IF FOR THOSE
INTERESTED, SENATOR WAHAB, THE
VICE CHAIR, HAS THE SAME
RECOMMENDATION WITH THAT. OKAY,
SO I WILL MAKE THIS VERY QUICK.
AB 2492 IS A BILL RELATED TO
PROVIDING SUPPORTS TO STUDENTS,
STAFF AND FACULTY DURING TITLE
NINE PROCEEDINGS AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND THIS IS PART OF
THE TITLE NINE PACKAGE. IT IS
ALREADY DONE AT MOST OF THE UCS,
AND WE WANT TO START, MAKING
SURE THAT IT HAPPENS AT THE CAL
STATES TO THIS BILL WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE OF A
YOUNG WOMAN, TWO YOUNG WOMEN IN
OUR DISTRICT THAT WERE, PLAYING
COLLEGE SPORTS AND TOOK THEIR
OWN LIVES BECAUSE OF A
DISCIPLINARY HEARING. SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT, THEY DO HAVE
SUPPORTS IN THEIR, IN THE AS
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS. AND I HAVE NO
WITNESSES. OKAY. IS THERE ANY
MEAT TO TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM?
LOOKS LIKE WE GOT ONE HERE. MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS. DOUG SUBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I THINK
WE CAN TAKE THIS LONG. I THINK
I'M GOING TO MAKE YOU HUM OR
SING YOUR OWN WALKUP SONG SO WE
KNOW WHAT KIND OF TASTE YOU HAVE
IN MUSIC. THE LONG NIGHT
APOLOGIES. GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD JOB. OKAY.
ANYONE IN THE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. I'M GOING
TO ACKNOWLEDGE SENATOR CABALLERO
SEEING NO QUESTIONS. LET'S CALL
THE ROLL. SHE GETS CLOSE. OH,
YOU GET NO. COME ON, LET'S GET
IT GOING. WE ARE, JUST ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. EXCELLENT. PLEASE
THIS IS FILE ITEM 26, AB 2492.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG WILK. AYE.
WILK AYE. ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO LAIRD. NHIÀU ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN STERN. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0. OKAY. FIVE
ZERO. AND WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN
SO MEMBERS CAN ADD ON. THANK
YOU. CONGRATULATIONS TRIFECTA.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE SITTING IN THE
FRONT ROW. ASSEMBLYMAN HANEY, SO
THIS WOULD BE FILE ITEM 23, AB
2182, AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS
Dð PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
. ALL RIGHT, START WHENEVER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, AB 2182
IS CRUCIAL LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ENSURE EQUITABLE PAY FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BY ADDRESSING SEVERAL
SHORTCOMINGS OF CURRENT
PREVAILING WAGE LAW AND
ENFORCEMENT. FIRST, THE BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT WORKERS RECEIVE
THE CURRENT PREVAILING WAGES ON
PROJECTS REGARDLESS OF WHEN A
PROJECT WAS ANNOUNCED FOR A BID
RIGHT NOW, WORKERS ARE FORCED TO
TAKE THE PREVAILING WAGE FOR
WHEN THE PROJECT WAS FIRST
ANNOUNCED, EVEN IF THAT IS YEARS
BEFORE THE PROJECT ACTUALLY
BREAKS GROUND, OR IF THERE WAS A
LOWER WAGE IN PLACE. THIS
ADJUSTMENT IS ESSENTIAL TO
MAINTAIN EQUITY WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE WORKERS ARE
RECEIVING ADEQUATE WAGES.
SECOND, THE LAW WILL STRENGTHEN
THE BILL WILL STRENGTHEN THE
ABILITY OF THE STATE TO ENFORCE
PREVAILING WAGE LAWS AND WILL
PROVIDE STATUTORY ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY FOR THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO REQUEST
CERTIFIED PAYROLL INFORMATION.
LASTLY, THIS BILL WILL UPDATE
ANNUAL IZATION PAYMENTS TO ALIGN
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS SO THAT WORKERS ARE
PROPERLY COMPENSATED FOR THEIR
WORK. I WANT TO LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OPPOSITION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS ADOPTED IN
THIS COMMITTEE CLARIFY THAT AN
AWARDING BODY CONTRACT OR A
SUBCONTRACTOR SHALL NOT BE
LIABLE FOR ANY VIOLATIONS OF
SAFETY STANDARDS CAUSED BY JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES.
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS FROM THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION, AND THEY
HAVE REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF LAUSD
AND THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES, AS IT MOVES FORWARD TO
SEE IF WE CAN ADDRESS ANY
FURTHER CONCERNS WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS KEITH DUNN, ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE, ON THE ON
BEHALF OF THE TRADES. AND HE IS
ABLE TO ADDRESS ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SIR. MR.
DUNN, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. I
WILL BE QUICKER THAN THAT. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. KEITH DUNN, ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES, I WOULD
TELL YOU THIS IS A PRIORITY BILL
FOR THE STATE TRADES. I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH LA UNIFIED. I
BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BE,
REMOVING THEIR OPPOSITION. WE'VE
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS FROM THEM.
SO WE'VE BEEN MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT, WITH THAT, I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND JUST
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WELL DONE.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO
ADD ME TO TESTIMONY NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME. ELMER LAZARD, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN DOING THIS LONG
ENOUGH THAT NOT THAT DON WILCOX
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF CARPENTERS, IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU, MR. WILCOX, GREG
LEWIS, PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL 761 AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SIR ANDRÉS POSADA
WITH THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMPLIANCE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, SEEING NO
ONE ELSE. ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE PRIMARY? YEAH YOU CAN,
WHEREVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. YOU
CAN DO THERE. YOU FEEL A LITTLE
PRESSURE? PLEASE SIT. NEXT. ME
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GREAT.
GOOD EVENING. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
MELANIE PARENT. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE THE STATEWIDE OR THE LARGEST
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CONTRACTORS, BOTH
UNION NONUNION WITH ABOUT A
THOUSAND MEMBERS, I'LL TRY TO BE
BRIEF. HERE WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 282, WHICH WOULD EXPAND
THE REQUIREMENTS ON PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS FOR CONTRACTORS, WE DO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
TO THE AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR
TAKING RECENT AMENDMENTS ABOUT
ACCESS TO JOB SITES. THERE'S
STILL A LITTLE MORE WORK TO BE
DONE THERE, AND WE ARE PLEASED
WITH THE CONVERSATIONS. WE'LL
CONTINUE FORTH ON THAT, OUR
PRIMARY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM WITH
THIS BILL AT THIS POINT IS
REGARDING THE PREVAILING WAGE
PROVISIONS ON THE IN THE BILL
REGARDING PREVAILING WAGE
INCREASES THROUGHOUT A PROJECT,
WHEN A CONTRACTOR IS BIDDING A
PROJECT, THEY'RE PUTTING IN
THEIR THEIR BIDDING, THAT
PREVAILING WAGE RAGE, AS THERE'S
UNCERTAIN COSTS THAT CAN COME IN
FROM THIS PREVAILING WAGE RATE.
EXCUSE ME? PREVAILING WAGE RATE
INCREASES THROUGHOUT THE
PROJECT. CONTRACTOR DOESN'T
FULLY KNOW WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE
GOING TO BE. SO IF THAT IS NOW
GOING TO BE A REQUIREMENT IN
FORCE IN THIS STATUTE, WE'LL BE
LOOKING FOR THAT. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY THAT THE AWARDING ENTITY
CAN GO AND REIMBURSE THOSE COSTS
TO THE CONTRACTOR, SO GETTING
SOME CERTAINTY AROUND THAT, IF
WE'RE ABLE TO GO AND GET THAT
INTO STATUTE THAT THE AWARDING
BODY WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONTRACT CHANGE ORDERS TO GO AND
MAKE SURE THAT THE CONTRACTOR IS
ABLE TO GET THEIR FUNDS, THE
ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD EXPRESS
IN THIS IS JUST THAT OUR SMALLER
CONTRACTORS ARE TAKING A BRUNT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE EXPANSION
OF PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. WE
WANT TO INCREASE THE DIVERSITY
OF THE CONTRACTOR POOL AND THE
AMOUNT OF CONTRACTORS BIDDING ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. THIS BILL
IS NOT NECESSARILY HELPING THAT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT ADDITIONAL
WAYS THAT WE CAN GO LOOK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN GET MORE CONTRACTORS
ONTO THESE PROJECTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BELIEVE WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ME TWO TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. YES. WE SIDE WITH
THE AGC, SO I WON'T REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT SHE STATED. BUT
YES, REFLECTING WITH THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION AS WELL.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. SEEING
NO ONE ELSE, WE WILL PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. GO AHEAD.
DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION? GO
AHEAD, A QUESTION. I HAVE, ONE
OF MY WATER DISTRICTS. I'M NOT
SURE IF THE THEY MAY NOT BE HERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T
HAVE A BIG LOBBYING CORP. BUT I
NOTICED THAT CAYUGAS IS OPPOSED
AS WELL. SOME OF THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WAS THE LAUSD
AMENDMENT THAT YOU'RE WORKING
ON. IS THAT GOING TO HELP SOLVE
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS TOO? CAN
YOU JUST ONE OF YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THAT? JUST A SO FROM LA
USD, WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE COMPLIANT WITH
ACCESS, OF ANY LRMC EMPLOYEES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE COMPLIANT
WITH SAFETY REGULATIONS ABOUT
HAVING WORKERS AT SCHOOLS. SO WE
ARE TAKING LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NO ONE WHO'S
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE AT A SCHOOL,
HAVING ACCESS TO SCHOOL WHEN
KIDS ARE THERE AND ARE AT ANY
TIME, BUT ESPECIALLY WHEN
CHILDREN ARE PRESENT. SO THAT'S
THE SCHOOL PIECE. OTHERS I CAN
SPEAK TO, IF YOU LIKE THE WHAT
I'M AWARE OF WITH REGARDS TO
OPPOSITION, AND MISS PERONE
MENTIONED IT IN HER OPPOSITION
ABOUT HAVING CERTAINTY OF COSTS.
AND WHAT I WOULD TELL YOU IS
THAT PREVAILING WAGE IS PRETTY
CERTAIN THESE ARE ALL PREVAILING
WAGE JOBS. AND WHAT WE'RE WE
BELIEVE IS A PROBLEM IS WE ARE
FLOATING LOANS ON WAGES FOR
WORKERS WHO ARE DUE A PREVAILING
WAGE. NO ONE DISAGREES THAT
THESE ARE PREVAILING WAGE PUBLIC
WORKS. THE CONTENTION IS WHETHER
OR NOT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
NOT REPRESENTED SHOULD BE PAID
THE CURRENT RATE, OR IF THE JOB
GOES LONGER, THEY'RE STUCK AT
THE WAGE WITHOUT THAT RAISE,
WHICH EVERYONE ELSE IS
ACCUSTOMED TO GETTING AND
RECEIVING, WE BELIEVE THAT'S NOT
FAIR. WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING PUBLIC WORKS
ON THE BACKS OF WORKERS WHO ARE
Dð THE PREVAILING WAGE. AND
AGAIN, NO ONE DISAGREES THAT
THESE ARE PREVAILING WAGE JOBS.
IT'S JUST WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD BE ADJUSTED. AND WHAT I
WOULD TELL YOU, I'M PRETTY
FAMILIAR WITH THE CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS IS THAT WE HAVE NO
PROBLEM WHEN MATERIALS COSTS GO
UP. IT'S A ROUTINE FUNCTION OF
CHANGE ORDER. AND I THINK IT'S
DISINGENUOUS TO SUGGEST THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEING REIMBURSED FOR
CHANGES IN MATERIALS, I THINK
THAT IT'S NOT A STRETCH TO GET
THE SAME REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
WAGES. AND THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW THAT'S
BEING APPLIED UNDER ALTERNATIVE
DELIVERY. AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT IN THE LAST 15 YEARS, I'VE
PROBABLY DONE ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE BILL THAT DEALS WITH
PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE PROJECT
DELIVERY TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
AND IT'S NEVER BEEN CONTEMPLATED
THAT WE WOULD BUILD THOSE JOBS
ON THE BACKS OF WORKERS. THOSE
ARE PUBLIC JOBS WITH PREVAILING
WAGES, AND THEY SHOULD BE PAID.
THE PREVAILING WAGE WEIGHT WHEN
AND IF IT CHANGES. AND IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS CHANGE, IT COULD
CHANGE, BUT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS.
AND IT'S SOMEWHAT PREDICTABLE.
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW, GOING 20 BUCKS MORE AN
HOUR. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SMALL
CHANGES MOSTLY. AND IT DOES ADD
UP ON LARGER JOBS, BUT IT'S
PRETTY PREDICTABLE. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT JUST LIKE A
MATERIAL COST THAT GOES UP AT
ANY TIME WITHIN A CONSTRUCTION
JOB, PUBLIC AGENCIES ACCOUNT FOR
THAT. AND I THINK THEY SHOULD
ACCOUNT FOR THE PEOPLE, THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE BUILDING
CAREERS AND LIVES AND BUILDING
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEM HERE
IN CALIFORNIA MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE. YEAH. SO I APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK. AND I KNOW THAT THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AREN'T HERE,
JUST CONTRACTORS. RIGHT. SO,
MAYBE THAT SAYS IT. ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
STERN. OTHER QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE, IS THERE
A MOTION? Þ, YOU MOVED THE BILL
ALREADY? OKAY. THANK YOU. THAT
WAS A SECRET MOTION. I WASN'T
HERE, ALL RIGHT, OKAY. SENATOR
WAHAB HAS MOVED THE BILL. MADAM,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES
THANK. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND I'LL MAKE A NOTE
OF LOOKING INTO THOSE CONCERNS
FROM YOUR WATER DISTRICT AND THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS IS ABOUT
FAIRNESS. WE WOULDN'T PAY
SOMEBODY A MINIMUM WAGE FROM
FIVE YEARS AGO. WE SHOULDN'T PAY
THEM A PREVAILING WAGE FROM FIVE
YEARS AGO EITHER. AND WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WAHAB. MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 23, AB 2182. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE. WILK ALLEN. ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. NIELLO. NIELLO NO.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN STERN.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 7 TO 1
SEVEN ONE. PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT,
ACCORDING TO MY PLAYBOOK, IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. FILE NUMBER
30. AND THEN, FILE NUMBER 37,
SOME MEMBER ORTEGA. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, UNDER CURRENT LAW,
WHEN A LANDLORD TAKES A TENANT
INTO THE EVICTION PROCESS, THE
COURT RECORD IS MÁS. UNLESS
LANDLORD PREVAILS WITHIN 60
DAYS, IF THE TENANT PREVAILS OR
THE CASE WAS DRAWN, THEN THE
RECORD REMAINS MÁS. IF A
LANDLORD PREVAILS, THEN THE
RECORD MAY BE RELEASED AND THE
TENANT WILL LIKELY END UP WITH A
MARK ON THEIR CREDIT SCORE. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THIS PROTECTION.
EXISTING LAW PROTECTION TO
MOBILE HOME PARK TENANTS.
FINDING A HOME TO RENT CAN BE
DIFFICULT ENOUGH FOR PEOPLE. WE
DON'T NEED TO MAKE IT HARDER
WHEN THE PERSON HASN'T DONE
ANYTHING TO WARRANT BEING PUT ON
A TENANT BLACKLIST. AND WITH ME
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS BRYAN
AUGUSTA, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FUND. GOOD AFTERNOON.
EVENING. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BRYAN AUGUSTA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND ALSO
OUR CO-SPONSORS, THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. THIS
EXTENDS IMPORTANT TENANT
PROTECTIONS TO MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS WHO WERE LEFT OUT OF
THE LAW ORIGINALLY. AND WE WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2304,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
OPPOSITION. GOOD EVENING, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CATHERINE
CHARLES ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE, LET'S NOW TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2304, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OR THE
TABLE. SEEING NOBODY
APPROACHING. I DON'T THINK.
THERE WE GO, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. YES, SENATOR
CABALLERO, SENATOR CABALLERO
MOVES THE BILL. SENATOR LAIRD,
I'M SORRY, I HAVE A SORT OF A
LAYPERSON'S QUESTION WHEN IT
APPLIES TO MOBILE HOME RENTS. IS
THAT SOMEBODY THAT RENTS A
MOBILE HOME FROM SOMEBODY ELSE,
OR IS THAT A MOBILE HOME WHERE
THE OWNER OWNS THE MOBILE HOME
AND IS RENTING THE SPACE
UNDERNEATH? SO IT APPLIES TO
ANYBODY WHO IS RENTING THE
SPACE, EVEN IF THEY OWN THE
MOBILE HOME, IF THEY OWN THE
STRUCTURE. BUT THEY'RE RENTING
THE SPACE. YES. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? SEEING
NONE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AFTER I VOTE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT,
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS FINAL ITEM 30 AB 20
304. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK ALLEN ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZO
LAIRD. LAIRD I NEELO. NO. NEELO.
NO. ROTH ROTH I STERN, A STERN I
WAHAB. WAHAB I RUSSELL I. ALL
RIGHT, 7 TO 1, 7 TO 1. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL. I SEE
I DO NOT SEE. YES, I DO SEE.
OKAY. SOME MEMBER ORTEGA. THIS
IS FILM NUMBER 37 AB 2705. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATORS AND MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2705,
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS TIME TO RECOVER
UNPAID WAGES FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO WAGE THEFT ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS UNDER EXISTING
LAW. WHEN THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FINDS A VIOLATION OF PREVAILING
WAGE REQUIREMENTS ON A PROJECT,
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS 18
MONTHS TO DETERMINE THE AMOUNT
OF FINES AND PENALTIES TO BE
ASSESSED, BUT ONLY SIX MONTHS TO
SUE THE COMPANY. THAT BONDED THE
PROJECT. THIS INCONSISTENCY IN
THE TWO STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
MEANS THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
COULD BE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
ASSESSMENT AND RUN OUT OF TIME
TO RECOVER THE WAGES OWED TO THE
WORKERS FROM THE BONDING
COMPANY. WORKERS SHOULD NOT
SUFFER A POTENTIAL SIGNIFICANT
LOSS IN WAGES DUE TO AN
UNINTENTIONAL UNINTENTIONAL
INCONSISTENCY IN THE LAW. AB
2705 SIMPLY ALIGNS THE TWO
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS, SO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS UP TO 18
MONTHS TO BOTH MAKE THE
ASSESSMENT AND SUE THE BONDING
COMPANY TO RECOVER WAGES. I
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES TODAY.
I HAVE MY, MEGAN LANE, OUR CHIEF
LABOR CONSULTANT, FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIRST WITNESS DON'T HAVE
ANY WITNESSES. JUST YOU'RE IT.
YOU'RE THE WITNESS. OKAY, GREAT.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
YEAH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
KEITH DUNN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
GREG LEWIS, PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL 761, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANDRÉS
POSADA, ON BEHALF OF THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO, Ã. THIS BILL
2705 AB 2705 PLEASE APPROACH.
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR WAHAB HAS
MOVED THE BILL. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. EXCELLENT
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY OR MADAM CHIEF
COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AB 2705 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ORTEGA BEALL.
ITEM NUMBER 37. THE MOTION DO
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. UMBERG A UMBERG. AYE
WILK ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZZO DURAZZO.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE NILO A
NILO AYE. ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN.
STERN AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE YOU
HAVE 8 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. EIGHT ZERO. PUT THAT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ HERE. SO, COME ON UP.
ALL RIGHT, LET ME, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO, SENATOR WILK. HE
MUST HAVE REALLY BEEN FLYING
THROUGH THE FILE WHILE I WAS
GONE. HE HE DOES NOT MESS
AROUND. APPARENTLY AND SO MY
PREDICTION IS WAY OFF. I THINK
UNLESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ
GOES FOR A COUPLE HOURS HERE. SO
LET ME JUST, GO THROUGH, NEXT
WILL BE, SOME MEMBER THREE OF
US. THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SCHIAVO, AND THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. AND THEN WE WILL
HAVE BEEN COMPLETE. SO IF YOU'RE
WITHIN THE SOUND OF MY VOICE,
YOU MAY WANT TO COME ON DOWN TO
SENATE JUDICIARY HERE. OKAY SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 1843. FIRST, I WANT TO THANK
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF,
FOR YOUR WORK AND ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL TODAY. I WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. THIS
BILL WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
AND EXPAND THE MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO OUR EMS WORKERS IN
THE PRIVATE AMBULANCE COMPANIES
WITH OVER 35 YEARS WORKING IN
THE EMS SERVICES, I KNOW
FIRSTHAND THE DIFFICULTIES OF
BEING A FIRST RESPONDER AND
ENCOUNTERING TRAUMATIC INCIDENTS
DAILY. WE ARE CONSISTENTLY
EXPOSED TO DEATHS, SEVERE
INJURIES AND LIFE THREATENING
CONDITIONS WHILE ALL WHILE
WORKING LONG AND IRREGULAR
HOURS. THIS COMBINATION OF
FACTORS CREATES STRESSFUL WORK
AND HOME ENVIRONMENTS. IN 2018,
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION 11,
WHICH PROVIDED PRIVATE EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES UP TO TEN
EMPLOYER PAID MENTAL HEALTH
SESSIONS THROUGH AN EAP KNOWN AS
AS AN EAP. HOWEVER, THESE
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN INADEQUATE
OR DIFFICULT TO ACCESS. FOR
EXAMPLE, EMS WORKERS CANNOT
ACCESS PROVIDERS WHO SPECIALIZE
IN THEIR FIRST RESPONDER RELATED
ISSUES. AS A RESULT, THESE
WORKERS ARE OFTEN USING THEIR
LIMITED EAP SESSIONS JUST TO
FIND THE APPROPRIATE PROVIDER TO
SERVE THEIR NEEDS. ADDITIONALLY,
THE AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION FOUND THAT 15 TO 20
SESSIONS ARE NEEDED FOR OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS TO BEGIN
RECOVERING FROM DIAGNOSED PTSD
INCURRED ON THE JOB TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF EAP
SESSIONS AND ALLOW OUR EMS
WORKERS TO BE TREATED BY
PROVIDERS FAMILIAR WITH THEIR
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY AND ITS
CHALLENGES. PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES FACE CHALLENGES IN
SCHEDULING APPOINTMENTS WITH
PROVIDERS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
APPOINTMENTS TO BE SCHEDULED
WITHIN 48 HOURS UPON REQUEST,
ENSURING PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE TIMELY CARE.
AB 1843 WOULD ALSO REQUIRE PEER
TO PEER SUPPORT SERVICES TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES. PEER TO PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES ARE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM IN WHICH TRAINED
COLLEAGUES OFFER EMOTIONAL AND
SOCIAL SUPPORT TO THEIR PEERS.
UNFORTUNATELY, A 2016 SURVEY BY
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF EMTS
FOUND THAT ONLY 28% OF AGENCIES
NATIONWIDE ADOPTED PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS WITH AB 1843. OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WILL HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO ADDRESS THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS TO RECOVER, SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE EMERGENCY CARE THEY
NEED AND DESERVE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS AMBER
STOHR, A FIRST RESPONDER
REPRESENTING THE UNITED STEEL
WORKERS OF DISTRICT 12. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AMBER AND JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS AMBER STOHR.
I AM A 15 YEAR EMT, SECRETARY
TREASURER OF LOCAL 12 911 AND A
STAFF REP WITH US W IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY LOCAL
MEMBERS AND OUR SIBLINGS OF UAW
LOCAL 1853, IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. EVERY DAY OUR
MEMBERS LEAVE FOR WORK NOT
KNOWING WHAT TYPE OF SITUATION
WILL BE ENCOUNTERED THAT DAY.
THE ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT
THE DEDICATION AND CARE WE
PROVIDE WITHIN MULTIPLE
COMMUNITIES CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. AS FIRST RESPONDERS, IT
IS OUR PRIVILEGE TO SERVE OUR
PATIENTS WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
CARE. UNFORTUNATELY, THAT THE
CARE THAT MAY BE NEEDED BY US IS
NOT GIVEN THE SAME CONSIDERATION
NOR COMMITMENT, AND IS THE
REASON WHY I AM HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB 1843, TO
ENSURE THE ACCESS AND FOLLOW
THROUGH TO RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND EFFECTIVE EAP PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION RESPONSIBILITY IS
ACHIEVED. AB 1843 PROVIDES A
CRITICAL PATHWAY TO THESE MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES. CURRENTLY, WE
HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAVE, AFTER
MONTHS OF FOLLOW UP, UNABLE TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT OR RECEIVE
ANY EAP ASSISTANCE. REPEATEDLY,
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD BY PROGRAM
FACILITATORS THERE ISN'T ANYONE
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND TO FOLLOW
UP MONTHLY ON THEIR OWN TO NO
AVAIL. IT DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF
AN EAP IF THE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDED ISN'T THERE FOR MONTHS ON
END OR AT ALL. WHILE PERFORMING
A JOB THAT DAILY PLACES WORKERS
DIRECTLY INTO VOLATILE AND
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS, THE PTSD
EFFECTS AND IMPACTS ARE VERY
REAL, AS IS THE CARE NEEDED THAT
CARE SHOULD AND MUST BE PROVIDED
BY SOMEONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE IN
TRAUMA AND TRAUMA COUNSELING.
RESPONDING TO CRITICAL INCIDENTS
IS WHAT WE DO EACH DAY. PUTTING
OURSELVES AT RISK WITHOUT ANY
THOUGHT OTHER THAN SAVING LIVES.
TODAY, WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT AB
1843 TO ENSURE OUR MEMBERS CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT THEY NEED TO
POTENTIALLY SAVE THEIR OWN LIVES
WHILE EXPERIENCING THEIR MOST
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE OR YOUR AYE VOTE IN BEHALF
OF ALL FIRST RESPONDERS WHO NEED
THIS FOR THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING. THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR
AUTHORIZING THIS CRUCIAL BILL.
AND THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 1843,
PLEASE APPROACH. GOOD EVENING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
BENEFIT TRUST FUND, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED OR IN SUPPORT. I'M
SORRY. IT'S LATE. YEAH. GOOD
EVENING, CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE
O'MALLEY WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA
ON BEHALF OF OUR LOCAL
AFFILIATE, THE UNITED EMS
WORKERS, LOCAL 4911 IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO, AB 1843,
PLEASE APPROACH HERE. WE GO.
COME ON UP TO THE TABLE. GOOD
EVENING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN
LONG. I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M SEAN HENSCHEL HERE.
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN MEDICAL
RESPONSE, CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
PROVIDER OF EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
SERVICES. EMR IS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB 1843, THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF THE CONCERN IS THIS
CALL FOR THE INCREASE OF EAP
VISITS FROM 10 TO 20, AN
EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO SERVE IMMEDIATE AND
SHORT TERM ISSUES AND TO TRIAGE
REFERRALS WHEN APPROPRIATE TO
SPECIALIZED LONG TERM CARE. THIS
MORE APPROPRIATE LONG TERM
MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE IS BEING
PROVIDED UNDER EXISTING HEALTH
INSURANCE, AS IS REQUIRED BY
2018. PROP 11. THE CURRENT
UTILIZATION OF EAP IS BELOW 3%
OF THE 3% OF EMPLOYEES THAT USE
EAP SERVICES. THE AVERAGE
UTILIZATION IS 4.5 VISITS. THE
LOW VISIT UTILIZATION
DEMONSTRATES THAT THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE BEING REFERRED TO
LONG TERM TREATMENT BEFORE
MAXING OUT ON THEIR EAP
SESSIONS, SO WE KNOW EAP
BENEFITS ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED FOR SHORT TERM
IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND REFERRAL. WE
KNOW THIS BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
OWN HR BENEFITS WEBSITE
DESCRIBES IT IN THE SAME WAY.
SHORT TERM AND REFERRAL. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT PTSD IS NOT AT ALL A
SHORT TERM ISSUE. SO WHY THE
REDUNDANCY? WHY DOES THIS
INCREASE ACCESS IN ANY WAY
DESPITE THESE LOW UTILIZATION
RATES? THE AUTHOR HAS PREVIOUSLY
STATED THAT THE INCREASE IS
WARRANTED JUST IN CASE A PATIENT
NEEDS MORE THAN TEN SESSIONS.
WELL, THE COST OF THE INCREASED
EAP IS NOT THE CONCERN.
REQUIRING AN EMPLOYER TO GIVE
DOUBLE COVERAGE IS A PROBLEM. IF
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS IMPORTANT,
THE INCREASE ONLY DELAYS THE
APPROPRIATE LONG TERM CARE.
RESPECTFULLY SEVERAL PARTS OF
THIS BILL ARE VERY WELL
INTENTIONED. HOWEVER, UNTIL THIS
SHORT TERM INTENDED USE FOR EAP
FOR WHAT IS CLEARLY A LONG TERM
ISSUE IS RESOLVED, EMR MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS OPPOSED TO
AB 1843. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
MOTIONS. DO I SEE A MOTION? DO I
HEAR SENATOR DURAZZO HAS MOVED
THE BILL? ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ? WELL, WITH
THAT, SENATORS, I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY I
DO THESE TYPES OF BILLS FOR
THESE TYPES OF WORKERS. THE
PRIVATE SECTOR EMS WORKERS ARE A
VERY UNIQUE CLASS OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WORK DAY IN AND DAY OUT, 24
OVER SEVEN, PROVIDING, CARE AND
TREATMENT TO THOSE THAT ARE SICK
AND INJURED. WE ALWAYS ADVOCATE
FOR A LOT OF OTHER GROUP OF
EMPLOYERS OR EMPLOYEES, SUCH AS
FAST FOOD WORKERS, JANITORS,
ETC. AND I THINK THIS IS JUST
ONE CLASSIFICATION OF EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE OFTEN OVERLOOKED WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT BETTER WORKING
CONDITIONS AND RESOURCES FOR
THEM, BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN, THESE
ARE DEALING WITH THE WORST OF
THE WORST. WHY SHOULDN'T WE BE
ABLE TO OFFER AT LEAST TEN MORE
SESSIONS IF NEEDED? AND THE FACT
THAT, CURRENTLY THIS DOESN'T
EVEN COVER PART TIME EMPLOYEES.
SO THAT'S PROBABLY ONE WAY, ONE
REASON WHY YOU SEE A LOW,
UTILIZATION RATE, AS THE
OPPOSITION REFERS TO, BECAUSE
ONCE AGAIN, THAT CLASSIFICATION
OF PART TIME WORKERS ARE NOT
EVEN GIVEN THIS OPPORTUNITY. SO
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YEAH. THIS
IS BILL ITEM 43, AB 1843. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. UMBERG A UMBERG. AYE.
WILK WILK. AYE ALLEN. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. DURAZZO
DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD NILO. HI.
NEAL. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB. 7 TO
0. MEMBERS MISSING SEVEN ZERO.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
SO I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHIAVO
HERE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHIAVO,
AFTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHIAVO,
THEN WE WOULD HAVE GOING IN FILE
ORDER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF
US. AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. NOW, I MAY HAVE CREATED A
FALSE IMPRESSION. I WASN'T
ANTICIPATING THAT SENATOR WILK
WOULD FLY THROUGH THE FIRE LIKE
HE DID IN MY ABSENCE. SO TO THE
EXTENT I CREATED A FALSE
IMPRESSION THAT WE WOULD BE
GOING UNTIL 11 MINUTES AFTER TEN
TONIGHT, I DID NOT ANTICIPATE
SENATOR WILK. SO, WE'RE GOING TO
GET DONE LONG BEFORE THAT. SO
FOLKS THAT ARE LISTENING, ONE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NEED TO
PRESENT THEMSELVES AND TWO, WITH
RESPECT TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE
OF US AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER,
THEY WOULD BE WELCOME TO COME
DOWN. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SOME MEMBERS CHAU, ITEM
NUMBER 44, AB 2135. WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. CHAIR AND Ã SENATORS. SO
WAGE THEFT AFFECTS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS EVERY YEAR
IN NEARLY EVERY FIELD. AND FOR
FAMILIES LIVING TO PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK, WAGE THEFT MAKES
BALANCING BALANCING BUDGETS
IMPOSSIBLE. UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE
SAME INDIVIDUALS OFTEN DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO SEEK
JUSTICE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. BAD ACTORS ALSO CREATED
DISADVANTAGE FOR HONEST
CONTRACTORS LIVING UP TO THE
HIGH STANDARDS WE HOLD IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PUBLIC WORKS, AND
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
INVESTIGATIONS AND LABOR
VIOLATIONS ON PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS IS CREATING SITUATIONS
WHERE NOT ONLY WORKERS
COMPLAINTS ARE CLOSED
PREMATURELY, BUT BAD ACTORS CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. AB 2135
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS AND ENSURE
JUSTICE IS SERVED. WE ALL WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT CONTRACTORS IN
THE ECOSYSTEM, THE CONTRACTOR
ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS BOTH GOOD
ACTORS AND WORKERS AND PROVIDING
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER MORE TIME
TO INVESTIGATE CASES WILL HELP
TO DO THAT. I AM JOINED TODAY BY
GREG LEWIS, BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
SEVEN, 61, AND ANDRES POSADA,
DIRECTOR OF THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMPLIANCE COUNCIL, TO TESTIFY
AS WELL. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
OKAY. THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
GREG LEWIS. I'M THE BUSINESS
MANAGER FOR THE PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL 761,
REPRESENTING OVER 1000 MEMBERS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. I CAME
HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO STAND
WITH WORKING FAMILIES AND VOTE
YES ON AB 2135. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
WORKING ON PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
ARE PAID APPROPRIATELY PER THE
CURRENT PREVAILING WAGE LAWS.
ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS HAS IMPACTED
WORKERS IS A PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT. IN MY HOMETOWN OF SANTA
CLARITA. IT WAS A SENIOR CENTER.
PREVAILING WAGE VIOLATIONS WERE
FOUND ON SEVERAL CONTRACTORS ON
THAT JOB, INCLUDING NOT
SUBMITTING THE REQUIRED FORMS,
NOT HIRING APPRENTICES,
INCORRECT JOURNEYMEN TO
APPRENTICE RATIOS,
MISCLASSIFYING WORKERS, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, FAILURE TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGES. CASES AGAINST
THESE CONTRACTORS WERE OPENED
WITH THE DLC IN EARLY 2020, AND
WERE UNDER INVESTIGATION UNTIL
THEY REACHED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IN 2023, AND THE
CASES WERE SIMPLY CLOSED. SO THE
PEOPLE WORKING ON THE JOB,
DIGGING DITCHES, GETTING DIRTY,
INSTALLING PIPE, FIRE
SPRINKLERS, AIR CONDITIONING,
TOILETS AND EVERYTHING ELSE WERE
NOT APPROPRIATELY PAID FOR THEIR
WORK AND THE CONTRACTORS SIMPLY
GOT AWAY WITH THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS HAPPENS ALL
TOO OFTEN, AFFECTING UNION AND
NONUNION WORKERS ALIKE. WITH
TODAY'S COST OF LIVING, THE LAST
THING WE CAN ACCEPT IS FOR
WORKERS TO GET RIPPED OFF, THIS
IS NOT A VICTIMLESS CRIME. THESE
ARE CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLING TO
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS AND
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WHEN
WORKERS GET RIPPED OFF, WE ALL
PAY THAT PRICE. PAY A PRICE FOR
THAT, THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL THAT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
WORKERS GET PAID THE MONEY THAT
THEY'VE EARNED, THAT AWARDING
AGENCIES AND TAXPAYERS ARE
GETTING WHAT THEY PAID FOR. AND
IT WILL ALSO HOLD BAD
CONTRACTORS ACCOUNTABLE. THAT'S
WHY I'M ASKING YOU TO VOTE YES
ON AB 2135. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. SECOND
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ANDRES POSADA AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMPLIANCE COUNCIL.
WE ARE A JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION COMMITTEE THAT
MONITORS COMPLIANCE WITH THE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
APPLICABLE TO PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS. I HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FIELD FOR OVER 15 YEARS,
AND I HAVE BEEN THE HEAD OF THIS
DEPARTMENT FOR SIX, AND
THROUGHOUT THIS TIME WE HAVE
BEEN PARTNERING ACTIVELY WITH
THE DIR, SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT BY CO-HOSTING
OUTREACH EDUCATIONAL EVENTS THAT
ARE FREE AND OPEN TO THE PUBLIC,
TO CONTRACTORS, TO AWARDING
AGENCIES. ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
BUT WE'RE ALSO CONTINUOUSLY
SUBMITTING COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE
TO DO THAT HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
LABOR COMPLIANCE VIOLATIONS.
HOWEVER, FOR THE LAST FOUR
YEARS, MY AGENCY, AS WELL AS
MANY OTHER AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, HAVE EXPERIENCED A
BIG PROBLEM. AND THAT IS THAT 25
ON AVERAGE OF OUR COMPLAINTS
HAVE REACHED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS WHILE IN THE HANDS
OF THE DLS. IT IS IMPORTANT HERE
TO SAY THAT THESE COMPLAINTS
HAVE BEEN SENT WITH AMPLE TIME
AND IN SOME CASES BEFORE THE
PROJECT IS EVEN COMPLETED. SO
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ROUGHLY TWO YEARS IN
ADVANCE SINCE THE DLS IS THE
LAST LINE OF DEFENSE WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECT THE WORKERS
RIGHTS ON PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS,
THE CLOSURE OF THESE CASES DUE
TO REACHING THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IS DETRIMENTAL, HAS
BIG PROBLEMS AND BAD EFFECTS ON
WORKERS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
EXPLOITATION AND UNFAIR
TREATMENT. THIS PRETTY MUCH
LEAVING THEM HOPELESS. IT ALSO
PERPETUATES A CYCLE OF
INJUSTICE, ALLOWING UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS TO ESCAPE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. FURTHERMORE, THE
CLOSURE OF THESE CASES
UNDERMINES PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
THE ENFORCEMENT OF LABOR LAWS.
NOW, WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE
EXTENSIVE CASE BACKLOG THAT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND
BY EXTENSION, THE DLS, HAS
EXPERIENCED DUE TO BEING BEING
SHORT STAFFED. AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE ACTIVELY TRYING TO
RECRUIT PEOPLE AND IMPROVE THEIR
ENFORCING MECHANISMS, THIS
PROCESS WILL TAKE TIME. MOST
LIKELY IT WILL TAKE. IF YOU'D
WRAP IT UP. ALL RIGHT, YOU URGE
AND I VOTE I THINK. YES, ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
KEITH DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL, ASKING FOR A AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. HOMER LAZARD,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
LISTENING TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2135,
PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED, LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. IS THERE
A MOTION, SENATOR? SENATOR WAHAB
MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? WE DO LIKE SAYING
THAT, SO THANK YOU SO MUCH, YOU
KNOW, WE THINK THAT 25% IS WAY
TOO MANY THAT ARE HITTING UP
AGAINST THIS, STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS. AND, YOU KNOW,
THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS
AND LIVES ON THE LINE. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE TIME
TO BE ABLE TO SEEK JUSTICE AND
GET A DECISION EITHER WAY, BUT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET A
DECISION. SO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THE MEASURE HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WAHAB. MADAM
CHIEF COUNSEL, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YES. THIS IS FILE ITEM 44
AB 2135. THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WILK ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO
DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD. NILO
NILO. NO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE STERN.
STERN. AYE. HOB WAHAB. AYE. IT'S
5 TO 1 WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
FIVE. ONE. WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THAT ON CALL ALL RIGHT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER 45, AB 2863. AMENDS.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GAVEL
. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS. I ACCEPT
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS. THE
SUBSCRIPTION ECONOMY IS
PROJECTED TO BE A $1.5 TRILLION
MARKET BY 2025. WHILE AUTOMATIC
SUBSCRIPTIONS RENEWALS CAN OFFER
CONVENIENCE IN TOO MANY
INSTANCES, CONSUMERS ARE BEING
BILLED FOR SERVICES THEY NO
LONGER WANT. 2022 RESEARCH FOUND
THAT, ON AVERAGE, 42% OF
CONSUMERS FORGOT THEY WERE STILL
PAYING FOR A SUBSCRIPTION THEY
NO LONGER USED IN ADDITION, THE
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATED THAT
CONSUMERS UNDERESTIMATED THEIR
MONTHLY SPENDING ON SUBSCRIPTION
BY $133 A MONTH. I SUSPECT THAT
ALL THE PERSONAL STORIES OF
INTENSE FRUSTRATION ATTEMPTING
TO CANCEL UNWANTED AUTO RENEWAL
SERVICES, WHETHER GYM MEMBERSHIP
, STREAMING SERVICES, ONLINE
PUBLICATIONS, APPS AND COMPUTER
SOFTWARE, THE LIST OF SERVICES
IS ENDLESS AND THE FRUSTRATION
GROWS. WE HAVE HEARD IT IN EVERY
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN,
AND I HAVE CERTAINLY MY OWN. IF
YOU ARE LUCKY ENOUGH TO FIND A
CUSTOMER SERVICE NUMBER TO CALL,
THEN YOU STILL HAVE TO BE EVEN
MORE LUCKY TO NEGOTIATE THE
PHONE TREE MAZE AND ACTUALLY
CONNECTING WITH A LIVE PERSON
WITHOUT THE CALL. SUDDENLY
SOMEHOW BEING DROPPED, FORCING
YOU TO START ALL OVER. WE KNOW
THAT THESE SYSTEMS ARE DESIGNED
TO KEEP CONSUMERS LOCKED INTO
PLANS, PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY NOTES THAT
THIS BILL SEEKS TO BOLSTER THE
PROTECTIONS AROUND AUTOMATICALLY
RENEWING OFFERS, WHICH CAN BE
CONVENIENT FOR BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS ALIKE, BUT CAN ALSO BE
MISLEADING AND PREDATORY FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL. MANY OF THESE
CHARGES ARE RELATIVELY SMALL
SUMS, BUT THEY ADD UP FOR FOLKS
WHOM YOU KNOW, RESOURCES ARE
TIGHT. THAT $133 ADDITIONAL
MONTHLY COST CAN BE BURDENSOME.
I AM NOT AGAINST BUSINESS BEING
SUCCESSFUL. I FRANKLY APPRECIATE
IN SOME INSTANCES THE
CONVENIENCE OF AN AUTO RENEW.
HOWEVER, I IF I DECIDE TO END A
SERVICE, IT SHOULD BE AS EASY TO
CANCEL AS IT WAS TO SIGN UP. AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT AB 2863
SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH, WHICH IS
MAKE IT AS EASY FOR CONSUMERS TO
UNSUBSCRIBE OR CANCEL AS IT IS
TO SIGN UP. REQUIRE AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT FOR AN AUTOMATIC
RENEWAL. PROVIDE NOTICE OF AN
AMOUNT OR RANGE OF THE COST TO
THE CONSUMER, AND PROHIBIT
BUSINESSES FROM OBSTRUCTING OR
DELAYING THE REQUEST TO CANCEL.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK PUT INTO
THE ANALYSIS. I THINK AS SOME
SUMMARIZED, THE ISSUE EXACTLY
RIGHT. AND HERE FOR ME TODAY
FROM THE CONSUMER FEDERATION,
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER FEDERATION
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ROBERT
HARRELL, AS WELL AS DOUGLAS
ALLEN, WHO'S ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
ALL RIGHTY. MR. HARRELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WELL, ACTUALLY, GOOD
EVENING, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS, ROBERT HARRELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, CONSUMER
FEDERATION, CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US AND A VERY
THOROUGH AND ACCURATE ANALYSIS,
THE AUTHOR DID A GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING IT. IT'S LATE. I'LL
BE FAIRLY BRIEF. EVERYONE HAS
THEIR STORY IN THIS AREA. THERE
IS THE CONTEXT HERE IS THAT THE
FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION, HAS A
PROPOSED RULE IN THIS IN THIS
SPACE AND WRIT LARGE CFC FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS HAS DONE A LOT OF
WORK IN JUNK AND HIDDEN FEES.
AND WHAT HAPPENS FOR FAR TOO
MANY CONSUMERS IS THAT THESE
WIND UP BEING KIND OF MASSIVE
JUNK AND HIDDEN FEES, I'LL JUST
READ BRIEFLY IF IT'S OKAY. FROM
TWO DOCUMENTS JUST RECENTLY,
WITHIN THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS,
THE FEDERAL TRADE COMMISSION HAS
EITHER TAKEN ACTION OR RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS THAT EVEN GO FURTHER
INTO DETAIL. ONE WAS A LAWSUIT
FILED AGAINST ADOBE. I'LL JUST
READ TWO PARAGRAPHS FROM THAT,
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR
FOR THIS IS FROM THE FTC
COMPLAINT, A LAWSUIT, QUOTE, FOR
YEARS, ADOBE HAS HARMED
CONSUMERS BY ENROLLING THEM IN
ITS DEFAULT MOST LUCRATIVE
SUBSCRIPTION PLAN WITHOUT
CLEARLY DISCLOSING IMPORTANT
PLAN TERMS. ADOBE FAILS TO
ADEQUATELY DISCLOSE TO CONSUMERS
THAT BY SIGNING UP FOR THE
ANNUAL PAID MONTHLY SUBSCRIPTION
PLAN ÁP PLAN, THEY ARE AGREEING
TO A YEAR LONG COMMITMENT AND A
HEFTY EARLY TERMINATION FEE THAT
CAN AMOUNT TO HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS. ADOBE CLEARLY DISCLOSES
THE EARLY TERMINATION FEE ONLY
WHEN SUBSCRIBERS ATTEMPT TO
CANCEL TURNING THE STEALTH ETF
INTO A POWERFUL RETENTION TOOL
THAT, REDACTED BY TRAPPING
CONSUMERS IN SUBSCRIPTIONS THEY
NO LONGER WANT DURING
ENROLLMENT. ADOBE HIDES MATERIAL
TERMS OF ITS APM PLAN IN FINE
PRINT AND BEHIND OPTIONAL TEXT
BOXES AND HYPERLINKS, PROVIDING
DISCLOSURES THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
GO UNNOTICED AND THAT MOST
CONSUMERS NEVER SEE. ADOBE THEN
DETERS CANCELLATIONS BY
EMPLOYING AN ONEROUS AND
COMPLICATED CANCELLATION PROCESS
. AS PART OF THIS CONVOLUTED
PROCESS, ADOBE AMBUSHES
SUBSCRIBERS WITH THE PREVIOUSLY
OBSCURED EARLY TERMINATION FEE
WHEN THEY ATTEMPT TO CANCEL.
THROUGH THESE PRACTICES, ADOBE
HAS VIOLATED LAWS. THANK YOU, SO
YOU URGE AND I VOTE URGE AND I
VOTE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'LL MAKE THIS QUICK.
DOUGLAS ALLEN, ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ. WE ARE A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AUTO RENEW TASK
FORCE, THE MAIN ENFORCEMENT ARM
IN CALIFORNIA OF THE AUTO RENEW
LAW, WE SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE
OF THE VERY NEEDED, NEW 17 6024
THAT REQUIRES THE AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT TO THE AUTO RENEW TERMS
THEMSELVES. WE ACTUALLY ENFORCE
THAT AGAINST THOSE WHO HAVE
HIDDEN THOSE WHICH THEY'RE VERY
ARTFUL AT DOING WITHIN A BUNCH
OF OTHER TEXTS AND ON DIFFERENT
PAGES, BY REQUIRING AFFIRMATIVE
CONSENT AS PART OF THE REMEDY IN
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. AND WE'VE
NEVER HAD A PROBLEM WITH A
COMPANY COMPLYING WITH THAT
PROVISION. WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
THE CANCELLATION. THE NEW 17 602
Â BECAUSE, WE HAVE ADVISED IN
THE PAST THAT, THE CANCELLATION
NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO BE
IMMEDIATELY EFFECTUATED BY THE
CONSUMER, REQUIRING ANY
ADDITIONAL OFFERS OR
EXPLANATIONS WE HAVE FOUND
REQUIRES ONLINE AS MANY AS 21
ADDITIONAL SCREENS THAT A
CONSUMER HAS TO NAVIGATE, AND
TURNING DOWN NEW OFFERS AND
GETTING EXPLANATIONS. WE HAVE
ALSO, IN TELEPHONE CONTACTS, OUR
INVESTIGATOR IN ONE CASE WENT
THROUGH THREE LEVELS OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE BEFORE THEY WERE TOLD,
WELL, YOU CAN'T CANCEL HERE. YOU
HAVE TO CALL ANOTHER NUMBER. SO
IT IT HAS BEEN ABUSED. WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. WE WOULD LIKE
THAT AMENDED. WE'RE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THAT FOR FROM FUTURE
ACTION. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE APPROACH MR. CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS DAN FELIZARDO ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING. DANNY CANDLE KAISER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? I'M GUESSING, MR.
MØT, THAT YOU'RE NOT HERE IN
SUPPORT. JUST A GUESS. JUST
GETTING READY. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
GOOD. I'M GLAD YOU'RE QUICK TO
THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU,
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. ROBERT,
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
I WILL ENDEAVOR TO BE AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE, THANK STAFF FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS. AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR
THE WORK AND TIME ON THIS BILL.
I APPRECIATE THE AMENDS TAKEN, I
ONLY FLAG THREE ISSUES QUICKLY.
ONE, THE FIRST PROVISION ON THE
AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT OBLIGATION.
WE VIEW AS EXTRAORDINARILY,
SURPRISINGLY COSTLY FOR OUR
MEMBERS, PARTICULARLY SMALLER
MEMBERS, LIKE NEWSPAPERS.
ACTUALLY WHO HAVE CALLED ME
ABOUT IT TO DO. BUT WE DO NOT
VIEW IT AS SIGNIFICANTLY
BENEFICIAL CONSUMERS ON OUR
VIEW. SECOND, WE HAVE CONCERNS
AROUND CONSISTENCY WITH THE FTC
RULEMAKING, AS PHRASED, WE'RE
AFRAID OF DIFFERENT TEXTS COMING
OUT THERE. AND THIRD, WE WISH
THE DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
AMENDMENT WERE SLIGHTLY LONGER.
12 MONTHS, NOT SIX FOR
IMPLEMENTATION TIME, I WOULD
TALK ABOUT THE ADOBE ISSUE. THE
BRIEF ANSWER IS, THOUGH I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THEM, THAT HAS
HAPPENED. THE FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT THERE IS HAPPENING
UNDER WHAT IS CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARD, MEANING
WE DON'T NEED TO CHANGE THE LAW
TO HAVE THAT IMPLEMENTATION AND
THAT ENFORCEMENT, WHICH IS
APPROPRIATE. BUT WE DON'T NEED
THIS CHANGE FOR IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. MOULTRIE. ALL
RIGHT, OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
GOOD EVENING, JOSE TORRES.
GARCIA'S WITH TECHNET. I JUST
REITERATING WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CHAMBERS SAID IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. JAMIE.
ELSIE. JACK RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
. THANKS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. STEPHANIE ESTRADA, ON
BEHALF OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AND
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RYAN, ELAINE, WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS ABOUT. YES, SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO I
WAS CONTACTED BY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE BLACK CHAMBER FOR THE
STATE, AND HE HAD THE FOLLOWING
QUESTION, WHICH I JUST I THINK I
SHOULD JUST READ IT TO YOU
BECAUSE, I'LL MAKE IT EASIER. SO
BASICALLY, HE IS SAYING THAT HE
WROTE AN OP ED ABOUT THIS. SO
MAYBE YOU READ THAT AND WOULD
HAVE MORE CONTEXT OR CONTEXT FOR
IT, BUT BELIEVES THAT THE DOUBLE
CONSENT IS A PROBLEM FOR HIM,
PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. HE SAYS IT WOULD
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT REDESIGN OF
WEBSITE USER INTERFACES AND
CUSTOMER CONTACTS, AND THAT
BUSINESSES WOULD NEED TO
REDESIGN USER INTERFACES FOR NEW
CUSTOMERS AND FOR EXISTING
CUSTOMERS. THEY MAY NEED TO
REDESIGN THEIR AUTO RENEWAL
PROCESS TO INSERT THE SEPARATE
CONSENT OR CONTACT ALL EXISTING
CUSTOMERS TO OBTAIN THAT SECOND
SEPARATE CONTACT. THIS WILL COST
LARGE COMPANIES MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, BUT FOR HIM, MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY, IT WILL CREATE
BIG COSTS FOR SMALLER BUSINESSES
. HE NAMES COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS
AND I KNOW HE'S VERY CLOSE TO
THE COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS, WHICH
IS PROBABLY WHY I GOT THIS
MESSAGE AND THAT THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO MAKE IT IN THOSE
MARGINS. SO I HAVE A REALLY
POPULAR NEWSPAPER HERE CALLED
THE OBSERVER. I'M SURE THEY'RE
INVOLVED IN THIS CONVERSATION.
CAN YOU EITHER COMMIT TO DEALING
WITH THOSE CONCERNS FOR THESE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
PARTICULARLY THE NEWSPAPER
GROUPS OR TELL ME HOW YOU'RE
ALREADY DEALING WITH THAT? YEAH,
WE'VE DEFINITELY BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH NEWSPAPERS.
CERTAINLY. I AM A FAN AS WELL
AND THINK THAT LOCAL NEWS IS
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT IN THIS
DAY AND AGE. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO WORK WITH
THEM AS MUCH AS WE CAN, I'M NOT
SURE. I MEAN, I THINK THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS IN THIS
BILL THAT WILL REQUIRE
REDESIGNS. AND SO I'M NOT SURE
WHY THERE'S LIKE, ZEROING IN ON
THIS ONE THING THAT WILL MAKE IT
REALLY CLEAR FOR CONSUMERS WHAT
THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR, BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR CONSUMERS,
THIS IS, YOU KNOW, AGAIN,
THERE'S AN FTC PROCESS THAT'S
GOING THROUGH THIS IS BASED ON
GUIDELINES FROM THE FEDS. AND SO
WE THINK IT'S KIND OF IN LINE ON
WHAT'S MOVING, NATIONALLY. AND,
YOU KNOW, THE OTHER THING I WILL
SAY IS THAT, THIS IS THIS IS
HAPPENING EVEN IF THIS BILL WERE
NOT TO GO THROUGH THIS IS
HAPPENING. THERE'S SO MUCH
FRUSTRATION IN THIS SPACE, SUCH
OVERWHELMING FRUSTRATION BY
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES ABOUT
THIS. THERE ARE ACTUALLY
COMPANIES THAT NOW YOU CAN PAY
TO GET YOU OUT OF SUBSCRIPTIONS.
THERE IS A NEW EMERGING MARKET
AROUND THIS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
SO FRUSTRATED, AND ALSO MY OWN
BANK NOW TELLS ME I DON'T KNOW
IF OTHER PEOPLE HAVE BANKS THAT
DO THIS, BUT MY BANK HAS A NEW
FEATURE WHERE IT TELLS ME WHAT
I'M GOING TO BE CHARGED IN THE
COMING MONTH, AND I CAN
UNSUBSCRIBE THROUGH MY BANK. SO,
YOU KNOW, IF THIS WERE NOT SUCH
A BROAD PROBLEM, THEN YOU KNOW,
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD HAVE
THESE KINDS OF THINGS HAPPENING.
AND I'LL LEAVE IT TO WITNESSES
TO ADD ANY OTHER IMPORTANT
DETAILS, IF I MAY. I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCERN, BUT AND WE'RE
SENSITIVE TO THAT. BUT IT IS A
VERY SIMPLE PROCESS TO CREATE A
SIMPLE LITTLE CHECKBOX THAT HAS
THE AUTO RENEW DISCLOSURES
DISPLAYED RIGHT BEFORE YOU ENTER
INTO THE TRANSACTION. IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A LOT OF REDESIGN. WE'VE
NEVER AND I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
NOW FOR OVER TEN YEARS. WE HAVE
NEVER HAD ANYBODY COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE COST. IT IS SIMPLY A QUICK
REDESIGN. WE ALL GO ONLINE AND
WE ALL SEE SEPARATE CHECK BOXES
TO CERTAIN PRIVACY CONDITIONS,
TERMS AND CONDITIONS, ALL KINDS
OF THINGS. IT IS AN EASY DESIGN.
SHOPIFY CAN DO IT AND THE
PRODUCT THEY SELL AS A SERVICE
TO CUSTOMERS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. AND SOME OF THE OTHER
MAJOR PROVIDERS. SO IT HASN'T
THAT IS NOT THE PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE CONFRONTED IN ENFORCEMENT.
THE PROBLEM IS JUST THE
RESISTANCE TO BEING FORCED TO
ACTUALLY DISCLOSE THE AUTO
RENEW. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT I HEAR THE CONCERNS
FROM A LOT OF THESE TECH
COMPANIES AND, YOU KNOW,
REPRESENTING SILICON VALLEY. I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S
LITERALLY ONE PIECE OF CODE THAT
NEEDS TO BE WRITTEN. AND USUALLY
EVEN ON THE SIGN UP, IT'S A
CHECKBOX, AS YOU STATED, TO OPT
OUT OR OPT IN, DEPENDING ON, YOU
KNOW, HOW THEY DESIGN IT AND
EVERYTHING ELSE IS AUTOMATED.
LITERALLY EVERYTHING. THE LISTS
OF WHO, WHAT DAY, WHAT MONTH,
WHEN DID THEY SIGN UP, HOW MUCH,
WHAT TYPE OF SUBSCRIPTION THEY
HAVE. WHETHER IT'S A STUDENT,
WHETHER IT'S A DISCOUNT, WHETHER
IT YOU NAME IT, THEY HAVE IT.
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT A
LOT OF THESE APPS AND WE'VE BEEN
UTILIZING AND PURCHASING THINGS
ONLINE MORE AND MORE REGULARLY
VERSUS, YOU KNOW, TYPING IN OUR
CREDIT CARD EVERYTHING. IF MY
FATHER'S USING APPLE PAY, IT IS
CLEARLY TRENDING VERY WELL. AND
VERY POSITIVELY. AND THE
CONCERNS I HAVE IS THAT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND I WILL SAY
MICROSOFT AND ADOBE ARE TWO OF
THE BIGGEST LEADERS, IN REGARDS
TO CHANGING DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MODELS. RIGHT? SO MICROSOFT IN
PARTICULAR IS REALLY LED THE
CHARGE ON SUBSCRIPTION MODELS.
RIGHT? AND I'VE WORKED IN THIS
FIELD, I KNOW IT VERY, VERY WELL
, AND IT'S REALLY NOT FAIR TO
THE END USER. IT'S NOT EASY AT
ALL TO UNSUBSCRIBE. AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY, I WILL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. I HAD A MEETING LAST
WEEK WITH THE GLOBAL CHIEF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS OFFICER OF
STARBUCKS, AND I COMPLAINED TO
HIM, AND YOU GUYS KNOW ME. I
WILL MAKE THE COMPLAINT VERY
DIRECT. THAT I ORDERED A CUP OF
COFFEE AND THIS IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THAN THE EXAMPLE YOU
GAVE, BUT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS AND TO THEY DIDN'T MAKE MY
CUP OF COFFEE FOR OVER AN HOUR,
AND I ASKED FOR A REFUND. I'LL
JUST TAKE IT ON THE ROAD. I'LL
GO TO ANOTHER STARBUCKS THAT'S
LESS BUSY. THEY SAID YOU HAVE TO
DO IT ONLINE. AND I SAID, OKAY,
EVEN THOUGH I ORDERED ON THE APP
AND I'VE BEEN A MOBILE APP USER
SINCE 2014, SO I LOVE MY
STARBUCKS. RIGHT? AND, IT TOOK
OVER 45 MINUTES TO GET A REFUND
ON $10. AND I'M GONNA BE HONEST,
IT WASN'T ABOUT THE $10. I KIND
OF CHANNELED MY FATHER, AND IT
BECAME THE PRINCIPLE OF THE
MATTER, WHICH I'M SURE YOU GUYS
ALL HAVE FAMILIARITY WITH, AND I
TOLD HIM THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE
THIS CUMBERSOME TO GET A REFUND.
LET ALONE WHEN YOU ARE CHARGED.
AND FOR AN ADOBE SUBSCRIPTION,
THE WAY THAT THEY HAVE MOVED,
IT'S NEARLY 300. IT COULD BE
MORE, IT COULD BE $500 AND MUCH
MORE, FOR A YEAR SUBSCRIPTION,
IF NOT THE 1999 A MONTH. AND I
SAY THIS BECAUSE I KNOW THE
PRICES, BECAUSE I USE ADOBE
PRODUCTS. AND IT'S NOT EASY. YOU
DON'T EVEN KNOW. OKAY. SO THEY
ALSO KEEP YOUR CONTENT IN THE
CLOUD. AND SO IF YOU DON'T PAY,
YOU LOSE YOUR CONTENT. IT COULD
BE A YEAR. IT COULD BE FIVE
YEARS WORTH OF WORK. SO I
ACTUALLY GENUINELY DO APPRECIATE
THIS. I THINK THAT THIS IS, YOU
KNOW, WE NEED MORE LAWS AROUND
THIS. TO YOUR POINT, WHERE WE
DON'T NEED NECESSARILY LAWS TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD BECAUSE, IT
COULD BE DONE, WE KNOW THAT IF
WE DON'T PUSH THESE LAWS, PEOPLE
WON'T DO IT OUT OF THE KINDNESS
OF THEIR HEART. THEY'RE TRYING
TO MAKE A BUCK OFF THIS. SO I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING. I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT BOTH OF YOU GUYS
ARE HERE TO PRESENT IN IN UNISON
, AND I WILL MOVE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR BILL.
SENATOR RUSSELL, I'M SORRY. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE ASSEMBLY,
MEMBER OF YOUR WITNESSES COULD
YOU JUST SPEND ANOTHER MINUTE OR
SO ON THIS, DOUBLE CONSENT ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP? SENATOR,
I'LL BE BRIEF, I THINK THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS THAT WHAT WHAT
SOMETIMES GET CHARACTERIZED AS
DOUBLE CONSENT FOR CONSUMERS IS
THAT THEY THINK THEY'RE SIGNING
UP FOR X, AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SIGNING UP FOR X, Y, Z AB. THIS
IS STREWN THROUGHOUT ALL THE
COMPLAINTS I CAN READ YOU, BUT I
WON'T. SOME OF THE ADOBE
COMPLAINT WHERE LITERALLY
CONSUMERS SAY I HAVE TRIED
FOREVER TO TRY TO GET OUT OF
THIS THING, AND I DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT I SIGNED UP FOR ALL THESE
THINGS. I JUST SIGNED UP FOR
THIS THING, NOT THESE OTHER
THINGS. I WE CALL THAT NEGATIVE
BUNDLING. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SEEING. AND I'LL LET THE DA'S
OFFICE TO SPEAK TO THAT AS WELL.
THAT'S I THINK THE ISSUE THAT
SOMETIMES GETS PUN INTENDED,
BUNDLED INTO DOUBLE CONSENT,
THAT'S SEPARATE AND DISTINCT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. SO CONSUMERS
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE AGREEING
TO AND WHAT THEY'RE SIGNING UP
FOR AND WHAT THEY'RE NOT
AGREEING TO. YEAH, THAT'S THE
MOST COMMON WAY THAT'S EXPRESSED
IS WE HAVE AN OFFER OF A FREE
WIDGET. AND YOU JUST BUT YOU
DON'T REALIZE THAT IN ORDER TO
GET THAT FREE WIDGET OR THE
DISCOUNT ON THE WIDGET, YOU'RE
SIGNING UP FOR A YEAR'S WORTH OF
WIDGETS, ALL AT A NEW PRICE. SO
THERE THE COMPANY IS LITERALLY
ASKING YOU FOR DOUBLE CONSENT.
THEY'RE ASKING YOU NOT ONLY TO
BUY THAT WIDGET TODAY AND PUSH
THAT RED BUTTON THAT SAYS YOU
AGREE, BUT THEY'RE ALSO ASKING
YOU TO CONTINUE TO LET THEM SELL
YOU FOR THE NEXT 12 MONTHS. THE
SAME WIDGET. ALL WE'RE ASKING IS
YOU AFFIRMATIVELY CONSENT TO
THAT EXTRA 12 MONTHS. THAT'S
WHAT THE ENFORCEMENT IS ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROSSO. ALL RIGHT. IT'S BEEN
MOVED, I BELIEVE, BY SENATOR
WAHAB. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS WILL
ENABLE ME TO CANCEL MY BOY'S
LIFE SUBSCRIPTION THEY'VE HAD
SINCE 1965. SO I'M GOING TO WORK
ON THAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. RIGHT.
OKAY. YES YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN I
VOTE. I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THIS IS AB 2863 FILE ITEM 45.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED. UMBERG A UMBERG I WILK
I WILK I ALLEN ASHBY. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO NILO I ROTH.
STERN. STERN I WAHAB. WAHHAB I.
YOU HAVE 8 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING EIGHT ZERO. WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SUMMER SCHIAVO. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US. ALL RIGHT.
AND THEN WE WILL CONCLUDE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AND AS
THE BIBLE SAYS, THE FIRST SHALL
BE LAST AND THE LAST SHALL BE
FIRST. WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
BIBLE NEXT WEEK. SO, YEAH, YOU
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING. WELL YEAH.
BIG MISTAKE. SO ALL RIGHT, SOME
MEMBER RIVAS FILE NUMBER 41 AB
2738. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS. AB 2738 STRENGTHENS
THE ENFORCEMENT TO PROTECT STAGE
PRODUCTION WORKERS BY HOLDING
PUBLIC VENUES ACCOUNTABLE AND
INCREASING CONTRACT TRANSPARENCY
TO VERIFY THAT PRODUCTION
COMPANIES HIRE TRAINED WORKERS.
ADDITIONALLY, IT EXPANDS THE
EXISTING AUTHORITY OF LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES TO ENFORCE THE
LIVE EVENT SAFETY LAW AND OTHER
LABOR LAWS TO REDUCE THE BACKLOG
AT STATE AGENCIES. LASTLY, IT
MAKES A SMALL CHANGE TO AB 594
FROM LAST YEAR THAT REQUIRES,
RATHER THAN ALLOWS A COURT TO
AWARD REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S FEES
TO THE PUBLIC PROSECUTOR IF THEY
WIN THE CASE, SO THAT LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE ADEQUATELY,
ADEQUATELY FUNDED FOR
ENFORCEMENT. WE NEED TO ALLOW
LOCAL PROSECUTORS TO RECOVER
FEES BECAUSE THERE'S AN UNLEVEL
PLAYING FIELD FOR A LARGE
DEFENDANT AGAINST SMALLER
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT FROM OUR
LARGE CITIES TO GO AFTER LABOR
VIOLATIONS. WITHOUT PUBLIC
COUNSEL, THEY WILL BE AT A
SEVERE DISADVANTAGE. THEY'RE
TAKING A GAMBLE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO SUCCEED AND RECOVER
ATTORNEY FEES. THIS IS SIMPLY
TRYING TO EMPOWER PUBLIC SECTOR
PROSECUTORS TO ENFORCE LABOR
VIOLATIONS, TO REDUCE THE BURDEN
ON THE STATE. TODAY, I HAVE OUR
SPONSOR, SARAH FOX, REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
AS MY WITNESS. THANK YOU, MISS
FLOCKS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS SARAH FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION,
WE'RE A PROUD CO-SPONSOR WITH
AOC OF THIS BILL, AND THIS BILL
REALLY HELPS ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S LABOR LAW. AND
WORKER SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
CRISIS, IT EXPANDS THE AUTHORITY
OF FIVE NINE, FOUR TO LIVE
EVENTS, SET SAFETY. THESE ARE
EXISTING LAWS THAT IT HELPS
ENFORCE, IT ALSO HELPS FUND
LOCAL PUBLIC LAW ENFORCEMENT BY
MANDATING AWARDS OF ATTORNEY'S
FEES. THIS HELPS BOTH SUPPORT
AND INCENTIVIZE LOCAL PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS TO DO LABOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT, TAKING THE BURDEN
OFF OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
AND CAL OSHA. I ALSO WANT TO
START BY ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS, WHO ARE
GOING TO COME UP AFTER ME,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE CONCERNS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT MANDATING THE
AWARD OF ATTORNEY'S FEES TO
PREVAILING PARTIES. BUT THIS
BILL APPLIES SPECIFICALLY TO
PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. THIS IS THE
LOCAL CITY ATTORNEY'S, THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S AND THE
COUNTY COUNCILS. THESE ARE THE
OFFICES THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO GO AND ENFORCE LABOR LAW.
THESE ARE NOT PRIVATE ATTORNEYS.
THESE ARE THE ATTORNEYS WHO WORK
FOR GOVERNMENT THAT WE WANT TO
EMPOWER IN THIS BILL. AND AFTER
FIVE, NINE, FOUR PASSED, THERE'S
A TON OF INTEREST. WE'VE HEARD
FROM ORANGE COUNTY, NAPA SOLANO,
FRESNO, LONG BEACH, CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO WANT TO
EXPAND THE ABILITY OF THEIR CITY
ATTORNEYS TO ENFORCE LABOR LAW.
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO SEE THE
VIOLATIONS. THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ARE ABLE TO TAKE ON THESE CASES
WITHOUT COST TO THE STATE, AND
SO THESE FEES, MANDATORY
ATTORNEY'S FEES ARE NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THEIR WORK AND TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO TAKE THESE
CASES. WE ACTUALLY WANT TO
PREVENT ANY HAVING TO CONTRACT
OUT TO PRIVATE ATTORNEYS,
BECAUSE IF THEY CAN HAVE THAT
STEADY, THEY KNOW THAT THEY WILL
GET ATTORNEY'S FEES. THEY HAVE
AN INCENTIVE TO KEEP IT IN
HOUSE. AND YOU URGE AND I VOTE,
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
WITNESSES? NO. OKAY IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2738, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION, YOU CAN
GET READY TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD EVENING, CHRIS
MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS APPROACHING. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OR OR
THE TABLE, WHICHEVER YOU CHOOSE.. ASHLEY
HOFFMAN FROM THE CAL CHAMBER,
OUR OPPOSITION IS THAT WHEN
ATTORNEY'S FEES PROVISION, THERE
WERE AMENDMENTS TAKEN LAST YEAR
TO AB 594 TO CHANGE IT FROM A
MAY AWARD. SO COURT DISCRETION
OR SORRY FROM SHALL AWARD TO MAY
AWARD WITH GIVING COURT
DISCRETION. AND THIS REVERSES
THAT AMENDMENT SO THAT IS WHERE
OUR OPPOSITION IS LIMITED TO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE
BROMANCE ENDED QUICKLY. YEAH
RIGHT. JAMIE FROM C JACK
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, ANTHONY AUGUSTINE, ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED FOR THE
SAME REASON AS CAL CHAMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH
SAYING NO ONE APPROACHED. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS BY SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE.
SENATOR ALLEN MOVES THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT. SO RIVAS, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT, MADAM SECRETARY, IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ALLEN. IF
YOU'D CALL THE ROLL, THIS IS
FILE ITEM 41 AB 2738. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG I UMBERG I
WILK ALLEN. ALLEN. I ASHBY
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. LAIRD I.
LAIRD. AYE. NEELO. NO MILO. NO.
ROTH. ROTH I. STERN. STERN. AYE.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE RUSSELL. AYE. 7
TO 1. SEVEN ONE. WE'LL PUT THAT
BACK ON CALL. I THINK THAT WAS
IT. I THINK THAT'S THE LAST
BILL. SO WEBER. OH, SORRY. THANK
YOU. YEAH. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
SO, SO FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
LISTENING IN YOUR OFFICES, THIS
IS THE LAST BILL. THIS IS
AMAZING THAT WE ARE DONE. I KNOW
. YEAH, THAT'S TRUE. YOU'RE
RIGHT. I SHOULDN'T JINX THINGS.
ALL RIGHT, SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER IS GOING TO PRESENT. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE CONVERSATION AND
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER'S
BILL. AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. I'M HOPING ONE
TIME WE'VE GOT A VERY LONG ROLL
TO GO THROUGH. SO SOME MEMBER
WEBER, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB 82. AB 82
WOULD BAN THE SALES OF DIET
PILLS TO MINORS UNLESS
PRESCRIBED BY A PHYSICIAN. THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH AN ID CHECK
FOR THE SALE OF DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND DRUGS TO PREVENT
MINORS FROM PURCHASING WITHOUT
THEIR PARENTS OR DOCTOR'S
APPROVAL. WHILE CALIFORNIA IS AT
THE FOREFRONT OF REGULATIONS
CONCERNING WEIGHT LOSS, DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS AND DIET PILLS, WE
DO NOT PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
THESE PRODUCTS TO MINORS.
DESPITE WELL DOCUMENTED DANGERS.
DANGERS. EXCUSE ME? TEEN
TEENAGERS ARE ESPECIALLY
TARGETED BY THESE DIET PILLS AS
SELF-IMAGE ISSUES ARE PREVALENT
IN THE ADOLESCENT PERIOD. EATING
DISORDERS ARE A SERIOUS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEM AFFECTING PEOPLE
OF ALL RACES, AGES, AND GENDERS,
BUT IT IS ESPECIALLY TROUBLING
FOR OUR YOUNG YOUTH. THIS BILL
IS NEEDED SO THAT PARENTS MAY BE
AWARE OF THE PRODUCTS THEIR
CHILDREN ARE TAKING, AND TO
PREVENT TEENS FROM LOOKING FOR A
QUICK WAY TO LOSE WEIGHT FROM
CONSUMING PRODUCTS WITH UNKNOWN
OR MISLABELED INGREDIENTS. YOUR
VOTE TODAY WILL ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE WORKING TO PREVENT OUR
ALREADY VULNERABLE YOUTH FROM
UNNECESSARY HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
EATING DISORDERS ASSOCIATED WITH
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS AND OVER
THE COUNTER DIET PILLS. MY
WITNESS TODAY IS NIRAV ZUBIATE,
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT FROM THE
SACRAMENTO AREA, AND MY OTHER
WITNESS, DOCTOR SONIA FRAUSTO
FROM TEN ACRES PHARMACY.
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO LEAVE
ALREADY. THANK YOU. IS IT MR.
SUBBAIAH? SUBBAIAH SABAT? GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING, HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS SENATE-TV SUBBAIAH. I'M
A HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR FROM
SACRAMENTO. FROM SACRAMENTO AS
WELL AS A YOUTH ADVOCATE AT THE
STRATEGIC TRAINING INITIATIVE
FOR THE PREVENTION OF EATING
DISORDERS, BASED AT THE HARVARD
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCES
WITH WITNESSING FIRSTHAND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF DIET PILLS ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF MY CLOSE
FRIENDS AND MY PEERS, AS WELL AS
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL 82, WHICH WOULD
BAN THE SALE OF DECEPTIVE
OVER-THE-COUNTER DIET PILLS AND
WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS TO
MINORS IN OUR SOCIETY, THE
PRESSURE TO CONFORM TO BODY
IMAGE IDEALS IS OVERWHELMING,
ESPECIALLY FOR TEENAGERS
THROUGHOUT MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
EARLY HIGH SCHOOL, I TOO
STRUGGLED WITH ACCEPTING MY BODY
AS A RESULT OF MY WEIGHT. I
GRAPPLED WITH MY OWN MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND TRIED HARD TO
CHANGE WHO I WAS IN THE PURSUIT
OF ACCEPTANCE BY MY PEERS. MANY
OF MY PEERS ALSO FACED
SELF-ESTEEM ISSUES, ESPECIALLY
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
WHICH ONLY EXACERBATED THESE
PROBLEMS. IN RECENT YEARS, THE
RISE OF TOXIC GYM CULTURE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA HAVE INCREASED IN
PREVALENCE, ONLY FEEDING INTO
HARMFUL BEAUTY IDEALS. CHILDREN
ARE CONVINCED THAT THEY NEED TO
ACHIEVE AN UNATTAINABLE BODY,
AND OFTEN TURN TO THE DECEPTIVE
CLAIMS TOUTED BY WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENT COMPANIES. PAIRED
WITH THE PROMOTION OF STRICT
DIET PLANS, CHILDREN ULTIMATELY
DEVELOP POOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
BODY IMAGE ISSUES. IT IS
HEARTBREAKING TO SEE SOME OF MY
CLOSE FRIENDS SKIPPING MEALS ON
A DAILY BASIS AND CONSUMING DIET
PILLS IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS,
NOT KNOWING THE CONSEQUENCES
THAT IT HAS ON THEM. AT SEVERAL
POINTS, I CONSIDERED TAKING
SUPPLEMENTS SO I COULD ACHIEVE A
SO-CALLED BETTER BODY, AND AT
TIMES MY PEERS WHO WERE UNAWARE
OF POTENTIAL RISKS EVEN
ENCOURAGED ME TO TAKE DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS. THIS IS A SIMILAR
STORY FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIAN YOUTH WHO LACK THIS
VITAL KNOWLEDGE, AND AS A RESULT
, TURNED TO DIET PILLS AS A WAY
OF QUICKLY SOLVING THEIR ISSUES
AND ACHIEVING A CERTAIN BODY
TYPE. THESE ARE THE CHILDREN WHO
URGENTLY NEED PROTECTION FROM
THE DECEPTIVE WEIGHT LOSS
INDUSTRY. AB 82 IS CRUCIAL TO
SHIELD THE YOUTH OF CALIFORNIA
FROM THESE DANGEROUS DIET PILLS
AND WEIGHT LOSS SUPPLEMENTS BY
PREVENTING THESE COMPANIES FROM
PROFITING OFF OF AND EXPLOITING
THE INSECURITIES OF CHILDREN.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
LISTEN TO MY CONCERNS, AND I
HOPE THAT MY EFFORTS WILL
INSPIRE FURTHER ACTION TO KEEP
DIET PILLS OUT OF KIDS HANDS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB 82.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU, MR.
ZUBIATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE. THANK YOU FOR COMING
FORWARD LIKE YOU'VE DONE. THAT
BODES WELL FOR YOUR FUTURE. SO
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. I THINK I
DO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
WELL, I'M LOSING CONTROL HERE.
WE'RE LOSING CONTROL AT THE END
OF THE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
ALL RIGHT? OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OKAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WEBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHER
WITNESSES ALL RIGHT. OTHERS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH.
GOOD EVENING. ROBERT HARRELL
WITH THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE NOT REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS, BUT HAVING
WORKED ON THIS ISSUE, WE WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO SB 82, EXCUSE
ME, AB 82, PLEASE APPROACH.
SEEING NO ONE APPROACH. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR STERN, SENATOR WAHAB,
SENATOR STERN, YES. THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BACK TO US,
AND, YOU KNOW, AS A PREVIOUS
AUTHOR, BUT APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE HELM AND FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. I WENT
THROUGH SIMILAR STUFF IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND TOOK ALL KINDS OF
LIKE, I MYSELF TOOK WEIRD
THINGS. I WAS TRYING TO BE AN
ATHLETE AND, LIKE, GET BUFF AND
THEN LOSE WEIGHT. AND I HAD A
FRIEND, ACTUALLY, WHO WAS THE
CAPTAIN OF MY WATER POLO TEAM
AND, WENT THROUGH A REAL
STRUGGLE WITH ANOREXIA AND
BULIMIA, AND IT WAS AWFUL TO
SORT OF BE JUST SEE IT, CRUSH
HIM. AND ANYWAY, I WISH THIS
BILL HAD BEEN THERE THEN. MY
ONLY QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR IS
JUST CDF. HOW DO YOU GET OVER
THE VETO MESSAGE? YOU THINK
YOU'RE IN GOOD SHAPE? JUST
WANTED A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW WE CAN GET OVER THE HUMP
THAT THE GOVERNOR LAID OUT.
YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO, AS
YOU ALLUDED TO, THIS IS A VERY
SIMILAR LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED IN 2022 THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID VETO, IN HIS VETO MESSAGE,
HE DID DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO CONVENE A WORK
GROUP AND DEVELOP POLICY,
SUGGESTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR CONCERN. AND THIS IS
ACTUALLY A TWO YEAR BILL BECAUSE
WE HELD IT WAITING FOR THE WORK
GROUP TO COME OUT WITH THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND IT FINALLY
CAME OUT THIS FEBRUARY. AND WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED SOME OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. THANK YOU, SENATOR WAHAB,
THANK YOU. I DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR WITNESS
FOR SPEAKING UP, I GENUINELY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH CONVERSATIONS REGARDING,
YOUNG BOYS AND MEN SPECIFICALLY
WITH BODY ISSUES, IT IS JUST AS
DEBILITATING AS IT IS FOR A LOT
OF YOUNG WOMEN WHO TYPICALLY GET
A LOT MORE ATTENTION FOR THE
ISSUE, AND I APPRECIATE SENATOR
STERN FOR SHARING YOUR SPECIFIC
THOUGHTS AS WELL, BECAUSE, THIS
IS LARGELY, VERY MUCH STILL
TABOO TO TALK ABOUT, AND SO I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I THINK
THAT IT'S QUITE SICKENING TO SEE
HOW MUCH WE PUT PRESSURE ON SO
MANY OTHER INDUSTRIES, AND TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THAT THESE TYPES OF
THINGS ARE SOLD OVER THE COUNTER
TO KIDS IS, QUITE FRANKLY,
DISGUSTING, SO WITH THAT, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL AND I APPRECIATE
IT AGAIN. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR WAHAB HAS MOVED THE
BILL. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK MY WITNESS. THIS
IS THE SECOND TIME THAT HE'S
COME TO PRESENT, AND IT'S NOT
EASY TELLING YOUR STORY, OPENING
UP, BEING VULNERABLE TO A GROUP
OF STRANGERS, BUT HE UNDERSTANDS
THE EXTREME IMPORTANCE AND THE
IMPACT THAT IT HAD ON HIM AND
ALSO HIS PEERS, AND TRYING TO
MAKE THE FUTURE BETTER SO THAT
THOSE WHO ARE YOUNGER WILL NOT
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
SAME ISSUES THAT HE AND HIS
FRIENDS HAD TO DEAL WITH. SO I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE HIM BEING
HERE, YOU KNOW, DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS, WEIGHT LOSS
SUPPLEMENTS IS BECOMING EVEN
MORE COMMON. AND A BIGGER
PROBLEM. AND THE FACT THAT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, WE DO NOT HAVE
AGE RESTRICTION ON THEM IS
EXTREMELY CONCERNING, AS A
MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG BOYS THAT
ARE GROWING UP, BUT ALSO A
PROVIDER WHO HAS MANAGED
PATIENTS WHO HAVE EATING
DISORDERS, AND I KNOW THE SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS CONDITION.
THIS BILL IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB 82. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 49, AB 82. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS BILL, NUMBER GÂY.
WILK WILK. AYE ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
RUSSELL Dð. RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE NEELO. ROTH ROTH.
AYE. STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 10 TO 0. TEN ZERO.
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. CONGRATULATIONS. ALL
RIGHT. SO HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO. WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL. ONE TIME. WE
GOT A FULL COMPLEMENT OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE. SO
EVERYBODY HANG TIGHT. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH. WE GOT A
LOT OF BILLS TO GO THROUGH. SO
LET'S TRY IT. LET'S. MADAM
SECRETARY, ARE WE READY? I'M
READY. ALL RIGHT. LET'S ROLL
OKAY. CONSENT FIRST. YES. I'M
SORRY. FIRST. YES, YES. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CHAIR VOTING.
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB 886,
CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALLEN. AYE
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 9
TO 2. NINE TWO. BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 2586.
CHAIR VOTING AYE TOS ON CONSENT.
THREE'S ON CONSENT. THREE'S ON
CONSENT. TWO IS NOT. YOU GUYS
GOT THE WRONG GOT THE WRONG
NUMBERS ON YOUR THING. I'M SORRY
. OKAY. I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT.
WHERE ARE WE, MADAM SECRETARY?
LET'S LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE
CLEAR ON THE RECORD. SO. SO WE
HAD TO ADD A BILL YESTERDAY, SO
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
I WAS TOLD TO PUT IT IN THE
FILE. BUT IT'S FILE ITEM 50, AND
I PUT EXTRA AGENDAS. OKAY. SO
I'M USING THE IPAD, SO THE ITEM
THAT YOU SAID THAT WAS ITEM
NUMBER ONE WAS THAT THE DODD
BILL? NO NO. THAT'S 50. NO,
BILL'S ALREADY OUT. AND FILE
NUMBER ONE IS AB 886. SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IS, MADAM
SECRETARY, I KNOW YOU'RE DOING
IT ALREADY, BUT WHY DON'T YOU
READ THE BILL NUMBER AND THE
AUTHOR AND THEN CALL THE ROLL SO
THAT WE'RE RIGHT? OKAY, OKAY,
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. PEOPLE ALWAYS
WALK UP AND THAT'S WHY. AB 2586.
ALVAREZ CHAIR VOTING AYE. WILK.
NO WILK. NO. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
LAIRD A. LAIRD. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
ROTH I HAVE A HOB. I 9 TO 2 NINE
TWO. BILLS OUT. AB 2543, WE NEED
A MOTION ON THIS BILL. MOVE. THE
BILL MOVES THE BILL BY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARAMBULA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO.
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO DURAZZO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE MILO. NO. MILO. NO.
ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN A STERN.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 92292.
BILLS OUT AB 460. CHAIR VOTING
AYE WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD A LAIRD. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. STERN. STERN.
AYE WAHAB. WAHHAB. AYE. 11 TO 0
11 ZERO. BILLS OUT. NOT NOW. BE
YOU GO FORWARD. OKAY AB 18.
SORRY. DID WE SAY THAT AB AB
1846 IS OUT NEXT IS FILE NUMBER.
HOLD ON. NO NO, NO. HASN'T BEEN
DONE 60. NO. DID WE SAY 460 WAS
OUT 11 TO 0 FOUR. 60 IS 11 ZERO
OKAY. LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON AB
1846 AB 1846 BAUER-KAHAN UMBERG
VOTING AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE. LAIRD A LAIRD.
AYE. ROTH A ROTH. AYE. STERN.
STERN AYE. WAHAB. WAHHAB. AYE.
11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT AB
2837. BAUER-KAHAN CHAIR VOTING
AYE. WILK NÓ. WILK. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. LAIRD A. LAIRD. AYE. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE STERN. STERN. AYE.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 9 TO 2 NINE
TWO. BILLS OUT. AB 2877.
BAUER-KAHAN. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
WILK. NO, I MEAN I SORRY. OKAY.
WILK. AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT
AB 2642 BERMAN. CHAIR VOTING AYE
. WILK NÓ WILK. NO ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD A.
LAIRD. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WAHAB. AYE 9 TO 2. NINE TWO.
BILLS OUT. FILE OR SORRY? AB
2715. BURNER. IS THAT HOW YOU
SAY IT? CHAIR VOTING. AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
STERN. A. STERN. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
BILLS OUT AB 2752. CALDERON,
CHAIR VOTING AYE ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE. DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD
A. LAIRD. AYE. MILO. NO. MILO
NO. STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 8 TO 2. EIGHT. TWO.
BILLS OUT. AB 2371 BY ONE.
CARILLO. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD.
AYE. MILO. MILO AYE. STERN.
STERN. AYE WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 11
TO 0 SEVEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE
OR SORRY. AB 2677. CHEN. CHAIR
VOTING CHAIR. NOT YET HAVING
VOTED. UMBERG. AYE AYE. WILK.
AYE WILK. AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
ASHBY. IS THIS 2677? YES. YES
ASHBY. AYE. DURAZO LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE MILO. MILO. AYE ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN AB 2677. CHEN OKAY.
WAHAB WAHAB. NO. 8 TO 1. 8 TO 1.
BILLS OUT. AB 2047. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MIKE FONG. THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. NEELO 2047. YES
MILO. AYE STERN. STERN. AYE
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 11 TO 0.
EVANSVILLE BEARS OUT AB 2048 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FONG. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. NILA. NILA. AYE.
STERN STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB
AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILL IS
OUT AB 2297 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. CHAIR VOTING AYE. WILK
AYE. WILK. AYE ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE LAIRD A.
LAIRD. AYE. MILO NO. MILO. NO.
STERN STERN. AYE. WAHAB A WAHAB.
I MADE A MISTAKE ON THAT ONE.
YES, I DO OKAY. WILK. WILK. AYE.
WILK. AYE TO NO. THREE 9 TO 2
NINE TWO. BILLS OUT. AB 2925 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FRIEDMAN. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE.
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. MILO I MILO. AYE. 11 TO 0
11 ZERO. BILLS OUT AB 2125 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GARCIA. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE MILO AGAIN
2125. YES. MILO. AYE STERN.
STERN. AYE 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
BILLS OUT AB 2017 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. CHAIR VOTING AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. MILO MILO. AYE. STERN A
STERN AYE. WAHAB. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT
AB 2182 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. CHAIR VOTING AYE. WILK
NOT VOTING ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE 9 TO 1 NINE
ONE. BILLS OUT AB 2013 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. CHAIR NOT
YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG AYE.
UMBERG AYE. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. MILO NO. MILO. NO. 10 TO 1.
TEN ONE. BILLS OUT AB 2426 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IRWIN. CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. ALLEN AYE.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
DURAZO. DURAZO AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. MILO 25. YEA OKAY.
10 TO 0. TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. AB
2492 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN.
CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG A UMBERG AYE. ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD A
LAIRD. AYE. MILO. MILO AYE. 11
TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT. AB 2288
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. KALRA. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD A.
LAIRD AYE. MILO. MILO. AYE
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE. 11 TO 0. 11 ZERO. BILL IS
OUT. AB 2773 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
11 ZERO 20 773. YES, IT'S
CURRENTLY 2 TO 1. CHAIR AB 2773
CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE. DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD
LAIRD. AYE. MILO. 27. 73. YES.
NOW MILO. NO. STERN A STERN.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE 9 TO 2. NINE. TWO. BILLS OUT
. AB 2304 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
LEE CHAIR VOTING AYE. WILK. NO.
WILK NO. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE 9 TO 2 NINE
TWO. BILLS OUT. AB 3172 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LOWENTHAL.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. MILO AYE.
NHIÀU. AYE. 11 TO 0. 11 ZERO.
BILLS OUT. AB 2095 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. THIS BILL
WAS ORIGINALLY ON CONSENT BUT
PULLED A CHAIR, NOT YET HAVING
VOTED. UMBERG AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALLEN AYE.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
LAIRD A. LAIRD. AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE STERN. STERN. AYE WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
BILLS OUT AB 2705 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ORTEGA. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. 11
TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT AB 2743
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PACHECO
CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. MILO I'M
SORRY. 2743 39 2743. YES MILO.
AYE. STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB 10
TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILL IS OUT. AB
2738 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF
US. CHAIR. VOTING AYE. WILK NÓ.
WILK. NØ. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO OKAY. 8 TO 2 EIGHT
TWO. BILL IS OUT. THAT'S OKAY. I
MEANT TO NOT VOTE, BUT BECAUSE I
DIDN'T VOTE IN FRONT OF HER. NOW
I VOTED NO. AND I DIDN'T WANT TO
DO THAT BEHIND HER BACK. I MEANT
TO NOT VOTE. YEAH, YOU CAN GO
FROM NO TO NOT VOTING. AYE. AND
THAT'S IT. YEAH. NO, I WAS NOT
VOTING TO BEGIN WITH THE FIRST
TIME AROUND. AND THEN I GOT
CONFUSED AND I SAID, NO, I DON'T
MIND BEING A NO, BUT I WAS NOT
VOTING IN FRONT OF HER. YOU SEE,
IT'S JUST AWKWARD. OKAY? IF WE
CAN'T DO IT, YOU WANT TO SWITCH
YOUR VOTE? I WOULD LIKE TO, IF
THAT'S OKAY. I'M SORRY. HE CAN
DO A NO TO AN AYE. AND THAT'S
IT. OR WE WOULD HAVE TO. ALL
RIGHT. THAT'S FINE. GET
RECONSIDERATION. NO, NO. YEAH.
THAT'S OKAY OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
SHE'LL WATCH THE HEARING AND SEE
THAT YOU'RE. YEAH I'LL HEAR
ABOUT IT. I'LL TELL HER THAT YOU
DIDN'T MEAN. OKAY. AB 1843 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD
A. LAIRD. AYE. WAHAB. 10 TO 0.
TEN ZERO. YES OKAY. TEN. WAHAB.
AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO. BILLS OUT.
AB 2135. CHAIR VOTING AYE. WILK
NOT VOTING. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO YES.
CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE
9 TO 1 NINE ONE. BILLS OUT AB
2863. CHAIR VOTING AYE. ALLEN
AYE. ALLEN AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. ROTH A ROTH AYE. 11 TO 0 11
ZERO. BILLS OUT AB 2244. CHAIR
VOTING AYE ALLEN. ALLEN AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. MILO. VOTING STERN.
SORRY. 2244 ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TÍNH YES. STERN. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE EXACTLY 10 TO 0 TEN
ZERO. BILLS OUT AB 3025 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA. CHAIR
NOT YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG. AYE
UMBERG AYE. ALLEN. OKAY ASHBY.
ASHBY AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
MILO AYE. NHIÀU. AYE 123456789
1010 TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT.
THAT'S LEADERSHIP BEN AND, THE
LAST ONE FILE ITEM. OH, NO. WE
DID THAT ONE. WE'RE DONE. DON'T
GO ANYWHERE. DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
MARGIE THERE'S A WHAT'S WHAT'S
CONFUSING? HOLD ON, HOLD ON,
HOLD ON. WE'RE JUST GOING TO
DEAL WITH A COUPLE OF MATTERS
HERE. YES. YOU VOTED AYE. SO.
WE'RE DONE. HOLD ON. SENATOR
NEIL.
SENATOR, LET ME RECOGNIZE
SENATOR YELLOW. OKAY WHEN WE
WERE HEARING THAT BILL, I
ARTICULATED AT THE TIME THAT I
WAS GOING TO ABSTAIN BECAUSE THE
BILL, AFFECTS ME, AND IT
INVOLVES LICENSING THAT I'M
INVOLVED WITH. I SAID AT THE
TIME WHEN WE WENT THROUGH AND WE
DIDN'T VOTE, THEN I GUESS WE
DIDN'T HAVE A QUORUM. WE WENT
THROUGH AGAIN JUST NOW. I WAS
LOOKING AT ANOTHER SHEET AND I
VOTED IN THE AFFIRMATIVE WHEN I
HAD ALREADY SAID THAT I WAS
GOING TO ABSTAIN. SO WHAT'S THE
PARLIAMENTARY HANG ON FOR ONE
SECOND HERE. OKAY LET'S ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION. BERNIE SAID, AND
OH YEAH, THAT IS OVER. SO IT'S.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO RECESS
FOR JUST A MOMENT HERE.
ASSUMING THAT THERE IS A MOTION
ON RECONSIDERATION OF TWO BILLS.
OF TWO BILLS, WE'RE GOING TO.
WE'RE GOING TO REVOTE FIRST.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SO LET'S.
MADAM SECRETARY, WHICH BILLS ARE
WE GOING TO RECONSIDER HERE? AB
2677 ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN OKAY,
LET'S DO THAT ONE FIRST. OKAY.
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'RE
GOING TO DO WE'RE GOING TO
RECONSIDER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN'S BILL AB 2677. NO
OBJECTION. I SEE. NO OBJECTION.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S REDO THE VOTE.
OKAY MOTION AGAIN. WE NEED A
MOTION. SENATOR ASHBY MOVES THE
BILL. OKAY, AB 2677 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS UMBERG. I UMBERG I WILK I
WILK I ALLEN, I ALLEN I ASHBY I
ASHBY I CABALLERO CABALLERO I
GRASSO. NOPE. NO I DON'T THINK
SHE IS. YOU WERE YOU WERE NOT
VOTING BEFORE SENATOR RUSSO DO
YOU. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. NOT VOTING
OKAY. ALL RIGHT OKAY. IT'S AN NÓ
NOT VOTING ON YOU GUYS. ALL
RIGHT? OKAY. NEXT PERSON. WEIRD.
WEIRD. I, NELLO. OKAY ROTH, ROTH
I STERN. NO. WAHAB. NO. 7 TO 1,
7 TO 1. THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY.
WHAT'S THE OTHER ONE, THE MOTION
ON THE NEXT ONE, WHICH WAS
SENATOR WILKES. WHAT WAS THE
BILL? DO YOU REMEMBER? IT WAS
RIVAS BILL. THREE OF US BILL,
WHICH IS FILE NUMBER 41, AB
2738, CONCERNING LABOR CODE,
ALTERNATIVE ENFORCEMENT. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE NEED A MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON AB 2738.
SENATOR ASHBY HAS MOVED THE BILL
FOR RECONSIDERATION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING TO
RECONSIDER. AB 2738, NO
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB 2738, FILE NUMBER 41, THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. A UMBERG I WILK
NOT VOTING. ALAN. I ALLEN I
ASHBY I ASHBY I CABALLERO THRASO
THRASO I LAIRD. LAIRD I NILO NØ.
NILO NO. ROTH ROTH I STERN A
STERN I WAHAB WAHAB I. 8 TO 1, 8
TO 1. THE BILL IS OUT, FOR NEXT
TUESDAY. WE'RE GOING TO MEET
HERE AT 930. WE'RE GOING TO MEET
IN ROOM 113 ONE. I'M SORRY.
ROUTE 113 ACROSS THE HALL, 9:30
A.M. AND THEN AT 130, WE'RE
GOING TO MEET IN THE SWING SPACE
AND SOME OTHER SPACES
DESIGNATED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL. 930 OVER HERE. GREAT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR THANKS.